GOOD MORNING THE- ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE IS
READY TO BEGIN. ONE OF MY MIKE
IS ON. BOB LET'S BEGIN WITH THE-
QUORUM CALL. HERE YOUR- YEAH.
HOWEVER YEAH YEAH YEAH WHAT
PART OF THANK YOU BOB. EXCUSE
ME. CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW. OKAY
THANK YOU ARE WE JUST BEGUN THE
UP ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE- DAY SECRETARY
COMMITTEE JUST CALLED THE ROLE
WE A QUORUM IS PRESENT. I WILL
NOW READ A POLICY STATEMENT- ON
OUR NEW PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND
HEARING LOGISTICS. WELL WHAT TO
THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
HEARING TO START I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ALL OF THE STAFF- THAT
HAVE MADE OUR RETURN TO THE
CAPITAL TO HEAR BILLS POSSIBLE.
DUE TO CURRENT STAY AT HOME
ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE AND
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITAL SO WE ARE THE ONLY
WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER. TO WATCH AND TO
PUT IN A IN PERSON WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTION FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM TODAY IN
THE ROOM RIGHT NOW WE ARE
HAVING A PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
PERSON HEARING. IN THIS SPACE
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF MEMBERS A
MINIMAL. CONTINGENT OF STAFF
LIMITED NOW. PUBLIC AND MEDIA
SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF
SPACING THEY'RE ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL. FOR THOSE
HERE TODAY IN THE HEARING IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON
THE BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
AND I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
TO PROFOUND AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT CATCH REFORM. BUT TO
PORTANTINO'S DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING WILL RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON LEAD
TO CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USE TO ONE PERSON AT A
TIME. FOR W. WE ARE WITNESSES.
IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM. WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS BE. W. WE ARE WHICH ARE
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL
THESE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE. OF THE HEARING ROOM
AND ALSO AS QUESTIONS OF THOSE
WERE. FOR IN WITNESSES WE WILL
ALSO YOU BE A AT TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO FIVE NINE I MEAN
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN LET ME
SAY THAT AGAIN EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND I HAVE HERE THE
ACCESS CODE IT HAS A BUNCH AT
FIRST SO IF THERE'S A NUMBER
PLEASE GET IT TO ME BECAUSE
IT'S NOT ON THE SHEET. ARE YOU
CAN ALSO FOR THIS NUMBER. ON
THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
WEBER WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING
AND PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WE'LL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN Q. BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A BILL.
IF YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMARTPHONES TO REDUCE TO SOUND
DISTORTION. WE ALSO. PLEASE
ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE
MAIN WITNESS WITNESSED
WITNESSES PROVIDEDTESTIMONY
FOR OR AGAINST THE BILL. YOUR
ROOMMATE ON A LIVE LINE IT WILL
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF INTO YOUR
CALL ON TO SPEAK. IT OR HAVING
A PROBLEM. WITH WITH ANY. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATE IT PHONE SERVICE
YOU CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT.
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE AND
I NEED THAT NUMBER TO. ASK
YEARS **** ASKARIS ASKARIS AND
MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY
TO HELP LET ME GO BACK. TO THE
ACCESS CODE. FOR CALLING IN THE
CALL IN NUMBER TO DIAL IN AT AS
A WITNESS IS. 877-692-8957 ANY
EXCESS CLOTHES IS JUST AS LONG
AND CONFUSING. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO TWO ZERO TWO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. AND
THEN THE CALL IN TO THE
COMMITTEE. IT'S NINE ONE THREE
ONE NINE AND I STILL HAVEN'T
GOTTEN A NUMBER YET BUT I'LL
GET BY. THANK YOU FOR HERE
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US
AS WE IMPLEMENT MET THIS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO MINDFUL
AND RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL FACE.
BUT IN PARTICULAR HOW
CHALLENGING THIS ISN'T THIS IS
OUR- FIRST MEDIA PUBLIC SAFETY
AND US TO. BE ABLE TO STILL A
FEW GLITCHES IN THE SYSTEM AS
YOU CAN SEE BUT WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SHORT.
EVERYONE AND THAT RUN THIS MOVE
THE COMMITTEE MEETING AS
POSSIBLE. WITH THAT. I WOULD
LIKE TO PRESENT THAT CAN SECOND
WITH HER. BOB. AS OUR PRACTICE
I WILL READ OFF THE PROPOSED
CONSENT CANNOT WHICH WAS MOVED
AND SECONDED BY BAUER QUE HAN
AND SANTIAGO OR SANTIAGO
EMBARKATION. ITEM NUMBER TWO ON
THE LIST AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
BIGELOW- PEACE OFFICERS DUTY
SHERIFF'S ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWO SIX ZERO SIX CERVANTES-
CRIMINAL JUSTICE CERTIFIED
RELEASED FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB TWO TO THREE SIX GABRIEL
PEACE OFFICER TRAINING HATE
CRIMES. ITEM NUMBER AND AB TWO
FIVE FIVE FOUR GIPSON
CORRECTIONAL PERSONNEL PEER
SUPPORT. ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY ONE
JONES SAWYER JUVENILE COURT
RECORDS ACCESS. ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
ONE JONES SAWYER PEACE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA SCIENCE CENTER IN
EXPOSITION PARK. ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB THREE ZERO FOUR
THREE JONES SAWYER CORRECTION
CORRECTIONS CONFIDENTIAL CALLS.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY THREE LACKEY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS
INFORMATION CART ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO AB THREE ZERO NINE
NINE RAMOS. ADMITTED JUSTICE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ASSISTANCE WITH
TRIBAL ISSUES. AP AT ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE AB TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY ONE BLOCK OF RUBIO
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTER'S.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX A. B.
TWO SIX NINE NINE SANTIAGO
FIREARMS AND SAFE HAND GUNS WE
ARE THE FIRST IN A SECTION SEC
MA'AM SECTOR YOU MAY CALL THE
ROLL. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
JONES SAWYER HI JOHN SO YOU'RE
AYE LACKEY. CAN BARRY CAN I
DEEP FRYING DEEP I COM AUGER.
KAMAGRA I CARILLO YEAH I SAN
DIEGO SAN DIEGO I WICKS WICKS I.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN
ADOPTED AS MANY OF YOU KNOW WHO
REGULAR COME TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE MEETING WE
GENERALLY HAVE THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS GO LAST BUT BECAUSE
THIS IS A NEW SYSTEM WE'RE
GOING TO GO IN ALPHABETICAL
ORDER SO THAT ONE WE CAN KEEP
TRACK OF WHERE WE'RE GOING OR
NOT GOING OUT OF ORDER. BUT
MOST IMPORTANT PEOPLE FROM THE
OUTSIDE CAN STAY ON TRACK AND
KEEP UP WITH US WITH THAT SAID-
ART THE LOOK AT MEMBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER QUE IN WILL
PRESENT THE FIRST BILL AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY. MAY BEGIN.
YEAH FIRST HOME TODAY I AM
BECAUSE I ON AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE EACH YEAR SINCE
REALIGNMENT WAS ENACTED
APPROPRIATIONS IN THE STATE
BUDGET HAVE PROVIDED MONEY FOR
COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT DIVERSE
APPROACHES FOR SUPERVILLE GEN
AND WE HAVE THE BILL. AND
REHABILITATION AIM SURPLUS
RECIDIVISM. THAT APPROACH AND
CORRESPONDING SPENDING PLANS
ARE CREATED BY EACH INDIVIDUAL
COUNTIES COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
PARTNERSHIPS THIS EASY PEAS ARE
MADE UP OF THE CHEAPER
PROBATION SHERIFF'S DA'S PT AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. WE HAVE
SENT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
COUNTIES FOR THESE PROGRAMS AND
AS WE HAVE DISCUSSED MANY TIMES
IN THIS COMEDIAN IS THE CHAIR
HAS SO ELOQUENTLY ADVOCATED FOR
OVER THE YEARS. WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE SPENDING
DOLLARS SMART. AND THAT MEANS
THAT WE NEED DATA TO MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS SO THIS BILL AIMS TO
PROVIDE THAT. TODAY WE CAN MAKE
GOOD DECISIONS AS WE LOOK TO
CUT OUR BUDGET AND SPEND ON THE
PROGRAMS THAT WORK. WITH THAT I
WILL TURN IT OVER TO MY FIRST
WITNESS MISS WENDY STILL WHO
HAS OVER THIRTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE AS A CRIMINOLOGIST
DEALING WITH RECIDIVISM
PROGRAMS DELIVERY TODAY
INCARCERATED. SO I WILL LAST A
MODERATOR TO CONNECT THIS WITH
BOTH WINDY STILLS FIRST
CRIMINOLOGIST BY PHONE AND IN
MARGOT GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION BY THOUGHT.
REMINDER OPENED. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN JONES SAWYER AND
MEMBERS THIS IS WHEN THE SCALE
AND I AM CURRENTLY TO KEEP
PROVISIONAL THIRD ALAMEDA
COUNTY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2483% OF THEM AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL- I AM
TESTIFYING TODAY AS A
CRIMINOLOGIST AND ALSO AN
INDIVIDUAL OVER FORTY YEARS.
AND BY THE- REHABILITATE
EXECUTIVE OVERSIGHT AS PRO AND
THIRTEEN A AS A LEGISLATIVE
APPOINTEE ON THE SCENE
CALIFORNIA NATION OVERSIGHT
BOARD AND CHAIR OF THE TCP AND
TO COUNTY FOR OVER TEN YEAR
BEGINNING WITH SB SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT TWENTY TEN AND CONTINUING.
AB OH NINE PROPOSITION SEVEN AT
OUTLOOK MENTIONED THE
LEGISLATURE HAS INVESTED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND FUNDING
LOCAL COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY RELYING BUT THERE
HAS NOT BEEN ADEQUATE RESEARCH-
BUT BUT THE- OTHER THING THAT'S
WHAT HAS YEAH. EACH OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT EIGHT. RELY LET'S
TRY. INCLUDING WHAT OF
REASONABLE. AND RESETTLEMENT
THEM REDUCTION PROGRAMS THAT
WERE CREATED A LOOKING. HERMAN
THE EFFICACY OF THE JAIL
REGRETTABLE FROM REDUCTION
PROGRAM IT IS ESSENTIAL TO
CREATE A STATEWIDE REPOSITORIES
AND REQUIRE THAT EACH COUNTY
SHERIFF REPORT ON THE IS WITH
THAT ARE THAT THE REDUCTION
PROGRAM ANY JURISDICTION AND
THE ASSOCIATED OUTCOME AB ONE
OH NINE HAS EXPANDED THE
MISSION OF JAILS IN CALIFORNIA.
INMATES ARE NO LONGER. YOUR
TURN AROUND. AND NEED FOR LOCAL
PRESENT. OTHER AMPLE ROLE
PROBATE FILE WHICH HAVE BEEN
ENDED THE AMOUNT OF TIME
INMATES ARE SERVING A JAIL
CREATING PROGRAMS THE JAILS
THAT WORK WILL NOT ONLY REDUCE
RECIDIVISM IT CAN ALSO PREVENT
FUTURE VICTIMIZATION. AND
GENERATIONAL CYCLE OF THE
CORPORATION A FEW OF THE
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS INCLUDE
INTENSIVE COGNITIVE
RESTRUCTURING. PROGRAM DOESN'T
JUST ORDER TREATMENT GENDER
WITHOUT THAT ANGER MANAGEMENT.
IF I WAS. ALIVE AND MANY OTHER
STATEWIDE PROGRAMS THAT OUTCOME
DATA IS ESSENTIAL TO CREATE A
LOCAL DETENTION. CENTER DOWN
THAT DOES NOT THE CARD BATES IT
COMBINES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HELP INMATES CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY OF. THEIR LIVES.
TRACK HAS BECOME THE NEXT
STANDARDS FOR MAKING RELATED TO
CRACK PRO AND NOT. WORK COUNTY
SHARE A HIS SUPPLY DATE. ON
WITH REDUCTION. THE PROGRAM
WITH LITTLE WILL ALLOW SHARE UP
FROM THE VERY COUNTIES AND LIKE.
A UTILIZED THE DATA TO INVEST
IN PROGRAMS THAT WORK AND
PROVIDE A RETURN ON INVESTMENT
OF THE PUBLIC HAVE TO PAY YOUR
BILL AND ASK THEM FOR. THEY
OTHER. YEAH THANK YOU. MARGOT
GEORGE OPERATOR. GOOD MORNING
MARCO GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS OF CREATION WE
SUPPORT AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
THREE BECAUSE IT IS A
COMMONSENSE PROPOSAL TO
DETERMINE WHETHER TO
REHABILITATION MONEY SPENT ON
PROGRAMS BY THE SHERIFFS AND
COUNTY JAIL AS WELL SENATE.
UNDER CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
SAFETY RELIGNMENT AB ONE OH
NINE AND SUBSEQUENT LEGISLATION
THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUAL SENATE
TO PRESENT WERE LEFT THE FENCES
WERE TRANSFERRED TO COUNTY JAIL
IN THE STATE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY.
THE COUNTIES WERE GIVEN STATE
FUN THING TO DEAL WITH THE
INCREASED NUMBER OF OFFENDERS
AND DISCRETION TO DEVELOP THEIR
OPEN REHABILITATION AND- THE
HOPE WAS THAT AB ONE OWN NINE
WOULD BOTH REDUCE PRISON
OVERCROWDING. AND REDUCE A
STUDY 64% WE SHOULD BUT THERE'S
SOME GREAT. NOW IN SOME
COUNTIES SURE UTILIZED THE
FUNDS IN OPPORTUNITIES PROVIDED
BY REALIGNMENT TO EXPAND AND
CREATE AN ADVOCATE OF
PROGRAMMING AND APPLY EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICE. MORE RE
ALIGNMENT I USED TO URGE MY
POINT CLIENTS TO GET IN A
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROGRAM CALLED
THE DEUCE PROGRAMS AS SANTA
RITA JAIL AND MEET A COUNTY.
BECAUSE I BELIEVED IT WOULD GO
TO HELP THEM RECOVER FROM
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND THE JUDGES
WERE INCLINED TO READ. SOME OF
IT THANKS SUCCESSFULLY.
COMPLETED THE PROGRAM. NONE OF
US KNEW IF THE PROGRAM WORK.
BUT IT SEEMED LIKE A GOOD IDEA.
IT SEEMS LIKE IN THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY WE SHOULD HAVE
THE DATA. WE ASK VOTE FOR AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE BUT
BECAUSE BY REQUIRING ALL SURE
STATE BY TO COMPILE THE DATA
THE PUBLIC WILL LEARN WHAT
WORKS TO MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES
SAFER. HELPING OUR CLIENTS TO
RE INTEGRATE INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND YOU WILL HAVE
THE IMPORTANT INFORMATION TO
ALLOCATE SCARCE RESOURCE THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE. ANY OTHER REMAINING
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MODERATOR.
PLAYER BY MISTER CHAIR ARE YOU
ASKING FOR THE ME TO USE THE ME
TO USE YES. THANK YOU YEAH IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. LINE EIGHTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS THE
ETHICAL READ I'M UP IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ARE THERE WE DO HAVE TO
PAY MORE IN THE QUEUE YES NAME
AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE. BY
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
DANA PULLED OUT ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER FOR ITS ON.
LINE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I APOLOGIZE THAT LINE
DISCONNECTED IF THERE ARE ANY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. ALL
ONE ONE. THE OPERATOR. ONE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. CHOOSE. AND ONE
HUNDRED THE STATE YOU'RE BY MY
NAME ARE ALOT MORRISON I WORK
FOR ONE JUSTICE THE STATE BY
LEGALLY SUPPORT CENTER WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PASSAGE OF
AB EIGHTY TWO EIGHT. TWENTY
OTHER HUMAN RIGHT OF A
LIBERTIES ABOUT. THANK YOU. NO
FOR THE LANDING GEAR. THANK YOU
FOR A- MODERATOR WILL NOW LIKE
TO HEAR FROM COREY CELL ZILLOW
SHARES TO STATE SHERIFF'S. BY
PHONE. IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS COREY CELLS- HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION-
UNFORTUNATELY- IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION A. B. TWO FOUR EIGHT
THREE SHERIFF'S ACROSS THE
STATE PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING TO
JAIL INMATES WITH THE DESIRE TO
ENHANCE FORMALLY INCARCERATED
PERSONS RE ENTRY INTO SOCIETY
AND TO REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD
PEOPLE RE OFFEND UNFORTUNATELY
BILL AS IT SAID THIS IS MEGAN
BURDENSOME DATA COLLECTION
REQUIREMENTS WITHOUT ANY
GUARANTEE OF FUNDING TO COVER
THE BILL'S COSTS. ME TO FOUR
EIGHTY THREE REQUIRED REPORT
DATA ON EACH OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM PROGRAMS PAPER IN
NEEDS IN THEIR COUNTY JAIL
FACILITIES AND QUOTE THE SCOPE
OF WHAT IS SOUGHT BY ONE
HOWEVER UNCLEAR YIELD. BUT RISK.
DEAL ADDITIONALLY THE BILL'S
DEATH OF REPETTIVE ON COULD BE
INTERPRETED AS A COUNTY JAILS
ASCERTAIN FROM COURTS OTHER
JAILS OR STATE PRISONS
POTENTIAL INCLUDING SUCH
ENTITIES AND OTHER STATES
INFORMATION AS TO SUBSEQUENT
CONVICTIONS. REQUIRING SUCH
WOULD BE VERY EXPENSIVE A
PROBLEM EXACERBATED BY THE FACT
THE BILL PROVIDES NO FUNDING
FOR ITS REQUIREMENTS AGAIN
SHERIFFS IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SEE
THE VIRTUE AND PROVIDING
PROGRAMMING AND REDUCING
RECIDIVISM UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO
THE BILL'S AMBIGUOUS LANGUAGE
AND LACK OF FUNDING CSSA MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
FORTY THREE THANK. THANK YOU
MISTER TELL. OTHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THEN
LET'S GO TO MEET TO. MISTER
MODERATOR IN OPPOSITION TO- AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES THANK YOU
BUT- YEAH IF YOU'RE FOR THE
SENATE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THAN THEIR AT THIS
TIME. NO ONE IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU UP. WAS
DROPPER RAIDER ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SCENE. NINE YOU MAY BE
THE AUTHOR MAY BE PRESENT
CLOSING ARGUMENTS IN IF YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS ANYTHING THAT
WAS BROUGHT UP BY THE
OPPOSITION WE WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR THAT YES I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION WE TRIED FOR MONTHS
IT DIDN'T HEAR IT UNTIL THE
LAST YEAR THAT THEY OPPOSE THE
BILL WE LOOK FOR TO TALKING
ABOUT. THE VEGAS SEE AN ADDRESS
MESSES WOMEN ARE ABOUT IT'S MY
POSITION THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
START LOOKING AT THE DATA TO
FIGURE OUT WHICH OF PROGRAMS
ARE WORKING AND FUND PROGRAMS
SPECIFICALLY SHARE WITH CARE
THE GOAL OF USING RECIDIVISM IN
SO DOING REDUCING. CRIMES AND
INCREASING. RESPECT THANK YOU
AND DONE I THINK AL ON THE
SAME PAGE IT COMES HAVING
BETTER PROGRAMS FOR RECIDIVISM
AT AND I THINK I THINK I KNOW
ESPECIALLY IN THIS IN ITS HARSH
ECONOMIC TIME- IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND I KNOW YOU'VE
ALREADY DONE SOME OF THE NITTY
AUTHORS ALREADY DONE SOME OF
THE PRELIMINARY INVESTIGATION
ON HOW TO FUND THIS AND MAKE
SURE THAT NOT ONLY THAT. SEC
PERSPECTIVE IT GETS DONE. WE
ENSURE THAT EVEN DURING THESE
TRYING TIMES DELEGATES BUT IN
SOME WICKS I THINK THIS COULD
BE SOME SAVINGS IN THE LONG RUN
AND SO THE TWO CHAIRS OF
RECOMMENDED AND HI BECAUSE YOU
WERE WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION- TO ENSURE THAT
THAT ONLY DOES THAT. DO WE HAVE
TO GET THE DATA BUT- ART I KNOW
YOU SHOULD WE BOTH OF A SHARE.
OF IS JUST AS IMPORTANT AS THE
ACTUAL BILL. A GAS ATTACK SO WE
HAD A FIRST IN A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY COULD YOU CALL. ON AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE
BARRICADE HAND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER ARE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
I BAUER-KAHAN BARRICADE HAND I
DEEP DEEP I COM AUGER. KAMAGRA
I CARILLO CARILLO AYE SANTIAGO
SAN DIEGO I WICKS WICKS I. THE
MEASURE PUT PASSAGE. I WILL NOW
GO ON TO FOUGHT. ITEM ORDER
NUMBER THREE BONTA AB. THIRTY
TWO TWENTY EIGHT. THE BILL OF
FARE. A THERE'S BEEN A FIRST
AND A SECOND ON A. B. THIRTY
TWO TWENTY EIGHT PRIVATE
DETENTION FACILITIES. YOU MAY
BEGIN MISTER BONTA. YOU ARE ON
YOUR OWN. EVERYBODY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT
PROVIDES ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT IN FOR PROFIT PRIVATE
DETENTION FACILITIES IN OUR
STATE THE BILL DOES THIS BY
REQUIRING PRIVATE OPERATORS TO
ADHERE TO THE MINIMUM STANDARDS
AGREED TO. OPERATIONS CON AT
LEGAL MECHANISM VIOLATIONS OF
ANDERS IT ALSO EMPOWERS THE
OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
TO CONVENE A WORKING GROUP TO
ADDRESS THE NEED FOR OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN THESE
FACILITIES PARTICULARLY IN THE
WAKE IT COVERED NINETEEN I WANT
TO PORT SPEC THIS BILL BUT IT
WAS. ADDRESS THE EMERGENCY AND
CRISIS THAT WE HAVE INSIDE SOME
OUR DETENTION FACILITIES
INCLUDING. THE THAT CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY HOME THE LARGEST
OUTBREAK OF COVER NINETEEN IN
ANY PRIVATE CIVIL DETENTION
FACILITY IN THE COUNTRY WITH
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS AT THE OTAY. MESA
DETENTION FACILITY HAVE YOU
BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH COVERED
NINETEEN- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WE HOLD OUR PRIVATE
ATTENTION FACILITIES TO AT. A
FAIR AND SUFFICIENT STANDARD
AND THAT WE ARE PROTECTING THE
HEALTH SAFETY WELFARE OF
CALIFORNIANS INSIDE THOSE
FACILITIES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE WITH ME- OVER THE
PHONE TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT
ARE HAMID. YEAH I'VE DONE
PONDERED ATTORNEY WITH
IMMIGRATION DEFENSE ADVOCATES
AND YOU NEEDS CHAU SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY AT THE ACLU NATIONAL
PRISON PROJECT. BUT THE MARKET
VIEW. PLEASE GET OUR- WITNESSES.
THE COME ON. THANK YOU BOTH
LINES ARE OPEN AND I MAY
CONTINUE. IT IS IT IS TO MEET
FIRST YES THAT'S CORRECT YEAH
YAZDANI YOUR LINE TO BUILD OUT.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF IMMIGRANT DEFENSE ADVOCATES
A SPONSOR FOR THIS BILL TODAY
AND THAT MADE 90% OF THE FIVE
THOUSAND IMMIGRANTS IN
DETENTION IN CALIFORNIA ARE
HELD IN FOR PROFIT FACILITIES.
VIOLATIONS OF MINIMUM STANDARDS
IN THE FACILITY INCLUDING
DEATHS HAVE RESULTED NO
MEANINGFUL CONSEQUENCES FOR
THOSE WHO OPERATE THEM. A
TWENTY SEVENTEEN REPORT BY NPR
ON THE ON A LONG TO DETENTION
FACILITY WHICH IS OWNED BY THE
GEO GROUP. FOUND THAT IT WAS
MORE LIKELY THAN PROBLEMS OF
MEDICAL CARE OPPORTUNITY
CONTRIBUTED. INJURIES INCLUDING
BONE DEFORMITIES AND RETAIN THE
DEATHS. DESPITE THESE FINDINGS
YIELD CONTRACT WITH I WAS
RECENTLY. THAT EXPAND TO HOLD
MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED DETAINEES. NOW DURING
THE CALL BUT NINETEEN OUTBREAK
THERE'D BEEN DISTURBING REPORTS
ABOUT VIOLENCE AND ABUSE
AGAINST DETAINEES AS WELL THE
COMPLETE FAILURE TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE MEDICAL CARE FOR THOSE
INSIDE. JUST YESTERDAY IT WAS
ANNOUNCED THAT THE SEVENTY FOUR
YEAR OLD MAN COMMITTED SUICIDE.
IN THE MESA VERDE. FACILITY
OWNED BY GEO THIS FALL THE
DEATH. OF ANOTHER MEDICALLY MAN
DOT FROM KOBE NINETEEN AT THE
OKAY MAKES A THE TENSION BUT IN
DIEGO. OPERATED BY CA CIVIC.
LEFT IN THE DEVICES. OR PROP
OPERATORS WILL BE EVERYTHING
CAN HAS AND- ABOUT THE SPREAD
OF COPING NINE AND AFTER. AND
WE KNOW THEIR DUTY IT TO THE-
AND NOT THE PUBLIC. THAT IS WE
NEED A CLEAR. FOR CANADA THAT
IMPACT ONE THING THEY DO CARE.
THEIR BOTTOM LINE. IF AND WHEN
THERE IS A LARGE OUT IN THE U.
YOU. WE CAN ANTICIPATE. OF
DISEASE INTO THE THREE CAN. THE
FACILITY. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
CRITICALLY ILL DETAIN WILL BE
SET TO LOCAL. BANKING OVERWHELM
THE MEDI RESOURCE AND IN
COMMUTER HEALTH. THAT IS WHY
GOD WAS ONE OF THE WORKING ON
THE- WAS SO CRITICAL PUBLIC.
FAR I WANT TO. WITH AN EX FROM
A MAY TEMPLATE. SIGNED BY FOR
THREE IN. THE PAIN AND TIME
MAKE A- GRIEVING THE LOSS OF
YOUR CARLOS ESCOBAR MEJIA. A
FIFTY SEVEN. YEAR OLD MAN WHO
STEP FORWARD THAT I MEAN I
THINK BEFORE DIED. OF COLD AT
NIGHT ENOUGH PROFIT FACILITY.
WE NEED EVERYONE. TO KNOW THAT
HERE AT MAKE THE TEN CENTER.
EIGHT YOU GET BIG. THE ONLY
THAT YOU. FROM STAFF. IF
TYLENOL IBUPROFEN MUSIC. NOT
MISTER AT. BUT HE WAS SO SICK
THAT YOU COMPARED GET UP. THE
BIG PINEY MOVE HIM. OUT AND PA.
INSTEAD OF TAKING HIM TO THE-
KNOWING WOULD DIE. AND AT A
HIGHER RISK THEY TOOK HIM NEXT
DOOR TO HELP. WELL ALL THE COOL
NIGHT. IT ENDED. WERE FURTHER
EXPOSED HIM TO THE- NEXT AND IF
WE CAN. WE CAN STATE. FINALLY
WHEN NO LONGER BREED WAS TAKEN
A HOT. BY THAT TIME. TOO MUCH
TIME IN. IN TO A- DUE TO THE
GROWTH MAY. IN BLATANT THAT.
FOR SHOWN BY CORPS CIVIC AND
MEDIC STAFF. FELLOW DETAINEE
TOO MANY OF US FRIEND. YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. GREAT THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING AT- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAMEIS UNESCO I'M A
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE
ACLU NATIONAL PRISON PROJECT IN
WASHINGTON DC AND THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR HEARING MY
TESTIMONY TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY
EIGHT IS A CRITICAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT'S NEED TO HOLD
PRIVATE PRISON. CORPORATIONS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE TREATMENT
OF PEOPLE HELD IN THEIR
CUSTODY. THIS IS PARTICULARLY
TRUE IN LIGHT OF THE THREAT
POSED TO PEOPLE HOLD AND
PRIVATE PRISON CAMP. PRIVATE
PRISONS DURING THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AS WE ALL
KNOW COVERT NINETEEN IS CAUSING
A UNIQUE CORRECT THE LIVES OF
PEOPLE HELD IN PRISONS JAILS
AND DETENTION FACILITIES. THE
PHONE SYSTEM THING AND GOOD
HYGIENE THAT'S NEEDED TO
PROTECT PEOPLE FROM CONTRACTING
FOR THE NINETEEN IS INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT IN A CORRECTIONAL OR
DETENTION SETTING IF. THEN THE
NURSING HOMES THE MEAT PACKING
PLANTS. AND THE DESCRIPTION TO
HAPPEN THE FLIGHT OF THE COVER
NINETEEN OUTBREAKS. IN
RECOGNITION OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AUTHORITIES LIKE THE
CENTER TODAY. CONTROL PREVENT
HAVE RIGHT RECOMMENDED BASIC
RECALLS. IT OPENS. FACEMASK AND
CLEANING. THE PEOPLE HOW IN
THESE FACILITIES. BUT DESPITE
THE FOR. PRIVATE PRISON COME
AND HOW. HAVE UNIQUELY FAILED
TO PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
PROTECTION THE PEOPLE HELD IN
THAT CAPACITY. AND OKAY MADE
THE DETENTION CENTER NEAR SAN
DIEGO NOW ONE OF THE LARGEST
OUTBREAKS OF CODE NINETEEN AND
THE STATE AND ONE PERSON HAVE
ALREADY DIED. CORD CIVIC THE
PRIVATE PRISON COMPANY THAT
RUNS THE FACILITY REFUSE TO
PROVIDE FACEMASK DETAINEES
UNLESS THEY FIND. LIABILITY
WAIVER FORMS. ONLY A- FACT WE
SHIP WITH THE PRESS THE COURTS
OF IT ACTUALLY DOES CONTINUE
THIS PRACTICE. THREE PRIVATE
PRISON COME ARE THIS OF SOME OF
THE LARGE COVER NINETEEN AT
BREAKS IN THE COUNTRY. EIGHT T.
A. B. THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT
WILL PROVIDE ACCOUNTABILITY TO
THE PRIVATE PRISON COMPANIES
THAT HAVE PROFITED MIGHTILY
FROM LOCKING PEOPLE UP BUT HAVE
CUT CORNERS ON THE MOST BASIC
OF HUMAN NEEDS ALL OF WHICH ARE
CRITICAL TO THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
INCUSTODY THIS BILL PROVIDES A
TITLE CAN ABILITY TO THOSE WHO
ARE HARMED BY THE FAILURE A
PRIVATE PRISON COMPANIES TO
COMPLY WITH THE BASIC MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS THAT THAT THEY'RE
ALREADY OF OBLIGATED TO FOLLOW
UNDER THE TERMS OF THE CONTRACT.
FOR TOO LONG. THE BOY THAT THE
KIND OF BILL FOR THE REPEAT
FAILURE PROVIDE THE REQUIRE
CARE WILL CONTINUING TO BUILD A
PROFIT WE MUST COUNTY EQUATION
IN FAVOR OF THOSE FEW OF FACE
LONG TERM DISABILITY AND HONEST
BECAUSE OF THESE CORPORATIONS
FAILURE TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
PEOPLE IN THEIR CARE. OR ALL
THESE REASONS WE ENCOURAGE YOUR
VOTE IN FAVOR THE BILL AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOT THERE
ANY OTHER MODERATOR MEN OF
SUPPORT WITNESSES A NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU IF YOU
ARE IF YOUR POSITION IN SUPPORT
IN A PRESS ONE THENZERO WE'LL
GO FIRST TO LINE SIXTY SIX ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN SIXTY. SORRY THIS IS A
RIGHT NOT HANDLE A LOT OF WHO
ARE IN A CHRISTIAN TRAINING
WITH DOLLARS STREET COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BOB MARKELL YORKSHIRE
LINES OPEN. THANK YOU MARCO
GEORGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE THIRTEEN ONE ONE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE RESPONSE
IS A CHIRLA OF THE COALITION
REMAIN AMERICAN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHRIS. NINE ONE ONE
ONE ONE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND THERE IS THERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BY ONE FOURTEEN
ONE ONE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IT ALSO WITH THE YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION PASSED DIRECTLY
IMPACTED MEMBERS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY TWO SIX
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES. YOU CAN HAVE
A THING WITH THE COMP ON
AMERICAN ISLAMIC RELATIONS CARE
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE TWO TWO
EIGHT. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
TWENTY ONE TWO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING JIM WHEN
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE FRENCH
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU JIM. LINE FORTY THREE FOUR
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT
ONE BUT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE OH SIX ONE ZERO
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING ALEXANDER WOULD ON WHAT
THE WIDENING GROUP WORK WITHIN
THE NEXT IN CALIFORNIA AND
TRUMP REPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE TWELVE ONE ONE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
KERRY MEMBERS SOVIET SO LEAST
SHANDI HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE ONE
ONE SEVEN ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORNING EVERYONE
THIS IS ALEX MEN THINK OF THE
SAN DIEGO BRANCH OF WEB LOOKING
FOR BETH ON BEHALF OF MANY
PEOPLE WITH TOUCH WITH
CURRENTLY DETAINED OKAY I MEAN
FOR THE PENSIONS CENTER WENT
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR. I AM THIRTY
SEVEN THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALEXANDER LEGAL DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
FOR IMMIGRANTS OFFICE WE WORK
WITH THE TEAM WITH INDIVIDUAL
CONTAINED AT THE YUBA COUNTY
JAIL IN AMERICA. AND THEN MADE
A DETENTION FACILITY IN
BAKERSFIELD THEY WEREN'T STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWO TWO
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE ONE SEVEN ONE HUNDRED
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS GREGORY SAID-
WITH INITIATE JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I AM EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHT FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DAN AYKROYD ARE NOW ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
TWO FOUR TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE PERSON ON THE HALF OF THE
TIME THEY SPEND DETENTION
RESISTANCE IN ROOM LOOKING FOR
OLD FRIENDS WHO WERE DETAINED
AT. THE DETENTION CENTER CARLA-
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HOT
LINE ONE OR TWO ONE ZERO TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE MISTER
MEMBERS RANGE SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
ALL CONFRONT SUPPORT. OKAY
THANK YOU. HM AND ONE TWENTY
ONE OF. ONE TWO ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE ONE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SORRY FOR
THE CONFUSION ONE LAST TIME ONE
TWENTY ONE ONE TWO ONE. THE
CHAIRS ARE LOOKING TO MOVE ON.
GREAT OF WERE NOW HERE FROM THE
WELL I APOLOGIZE TO THE NEXT
LINE I STILL HAVE ABOUT TEN AND
Q. OKAY. HE'D THERE DOES NOT
RESPONSE THERE VERY GOOD THANK
YOU LINE ONE OF FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE WATER IN A LAND.
THANK. LINE ONE OF FOUR LINE
ONE ALSO ORDER LINE IS OPEN.
CALLER ON ONE ZERO FOUR ARE YOU
THERE. WILL MOVE THE LINE ONE
TWENTY TWO ONE TWO TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MANY
WILL PROVIDE A SPEND A GREAT
LEGAL DEFENSE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LINE ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS ARIELLE OUT
MARTIN I'M A SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH ONE JUSTICE AND
I'M IN STRONG WORK ON DOCTORS
AND INSTRUCT THE PART OF EIGHTY
THREE TWO TWO EIGHT. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE TWENTY THREE ONE TWO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THE FEDEX AND THE
MANAGING ATTORNEY AT
PHILADELPHIA THAT RUSSIA WE
PROVIDE IMMIGRATION REMOVAL
DEFENSE SERVICES INDIVIDUALS AT
THE MET THE VERITY DETENTION
CENTER AND WEREN'T STRONG THE
CARD BILL. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
ZERO NINE ONE ON NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ALL ARE ON ONE OH NINE
DID YOU WANT TO SHARE YOUR
POSITION. SOME OF THE LINE ONE
ON ONE ONE ZERO ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JAN THAT
I'M A FORMER SENIOR PATROL
AGENT AND A FORMER INTELLIGENCE
AGENT WITH UNITED STATES BORDER
PATROL IN TRAINING THE
CALIFORNIA. AND I'M CONSIDERED
THAT. WATER POLICIES AND I IN
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY
SEVEN ONE TO SEVEN NO LINES
OPEN. IN A KELLY ON BEHALF OF
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY NANCY O'MALLEY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWO TWO
EIGHT. THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE
LEFT AT THE MICROPHONE JUST A
MOMENT. LINE ONE TWENTY FIVE
ONE TWO FIVE YOUR LINE GOOD
MORNING ONE OF THE A MY NAME IS
BRIAN B. R. THAT THE DIRECT
WHA ON YOUR ARE YOU THINK
DOCTOR DOCTOR. THANK YOU YOU.
NO FOR THE LINE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE YOU MAY
CLOSE MISTER BONTA I'M SORRY
COREY I AM SO SORRY I SAID IT
THIS IS ALL NEW TO ME.
DEFINITELY WANT TO HEAR FROM
COREY ST STILL OUT CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION BY
PHONE. MISTER MODERATOR COULD
YOU PLEASE LET HIM AND- AS MUCH
TIME AS YOU WALK CHORUS EXITS I
ALMOST SKIPPED YOU. PROBLEM IS
DANGER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED I AM AND IF YOU'RE
IN MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR- COREY SO GO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION ARE OPPOSITION. TO
THE BILL IS NOT IN REFERENCE TO
THE LANGUAGE THAT- REFERENCES
SPECIFICALLY PRIVATE DETENTION
FACILITIES WE HAVE NO POSITION
ON THAT LANGUAGE OUR CONCERN
WITH THE BILL IS MERELY
CREATION. THE CALIFORNIA
DETENTION STANDARDS AND SAFETY
WORKING GROUP IN IS UP TO ALL
DETENTION FACILITIES WHICH
WOULD INCLUDE COUNTY JAILS WE
DIDN'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL UNTIL THE MAY SEVENTH
AMENDMENTS. WHICH WILL. THE
WORKING TO JAIL SO JUST IN
REGARD TO THAT I WOULD NOTE
THAT EXISTING LAW ESTABLISHES
THE MORE STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS ON CHARGES IT WITH.
ESTABLISHING MINIMUM STANDARDS
FOR LOCAL CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES AND REQUIRES A BOARD
TO CONDUCT AT LEAST BY ANY-
INSPECTIONS OF LOCAL DETENTION
FACILITIES. THE BSD SEE IS ALSO
CHARGED WITH EVELOPING
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
IMPROVEMENT OF. JUSTICE AND IN
ADDITION TO THE BSE SEE MANY
ENTITIES OF DIRECT OR INDIRECT
RECITE. JAIL PUTTING. THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL COUNTY GRAND
JURY THE COURTS JUST TO NAME A
FEW. AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT
AGAIN JUST IN REFERENCE TO THE
WORKING GROUP PROVISION CREATES
DUPLICATIVE PROCESSES. AND IN
SO DOING GREAT TO WORKING GROUP
THAT FAILS TO SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDE THE BSE SCENE. OR JAIL
OR OTHER CORRECTIONAL
PROFESSIONALS IN ITS
MEMBERSHIP. FOR THESE REASONS
IN THOSE STATED ABOVE WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB THREE
TWO TWO EIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. YOU'RE WELCOME ARE THERE
ANY OTHER. WITNESSES AND-
OPPOSITION NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. YOUR POSITION
EVAN IS IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS OE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE ZERO PLEASE. BLINDS IN
KIANA TELEPHONE SIR. OKAY NOW
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE YOU MAY CLOSE MR
BONTA AND IF YOU COULD. THANK
YOU MISTER HAS A FEW THE
CONCERNED. YEAH THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION BROUGHT UP HAPPY
TO- AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY
THE- CALIFORNIA SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION. MENTIONED THE
POTENTIAL FOR OVERLAP OF THE
PROPOSED WORKGROUP IT IN THIS
BILL THAT I WITH THE BSE SEAT.
THERE IS A NARROW POTENTIAL
OVERLAP BUT WE THINK THERE ARE
DIFFERENT UNIVERSES THAT ARE-
WORKGROUP WOULD COVER FOR
EXAMPLE TO BE SEC DOESN'T COVER
A FOR PROFIT PRIVATE- DETENTION
FACILITIES OF ANY TYPE WHETHER
PIECE SO IMMIGRATION FACILITIES
OR FOR PRIVATE PRISONS. REALLY
THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL
TO PROVIDE COUNT ABILITY
OVERSIGHT ASSURANCES OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND WELFARE-
PROVISIONS TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS SO- TO THAT AND
THERE IS THERE IS NOT OVERLAP
SO WE THINK THAT THE OVERLAP IS
FINE AT THAT. AND WE SO IT'S
IMPORTANT HAVE A MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL WORKGROUP WITH
SOCIAL SIR IS THE PUBLIC HEALTH
TOURNEY GENERAL THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL OTHERS TO WORK TOGETHER
TO IDENTIFY A MAP AND A PATHWAY
FORWARD TO. PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS SO- I DID RECEIVE
THEIR LETTER I APPRECIATE THEIR
CONCERN- I THINK THE OVERLAP IS.
PERHAPS THE NOT A SIGNIFICANT.
IS NOT SUPER SIGNIFICANT AND
THEY ALSO ARE AS AS MENTIONED
CLEARLY BY THE REPRESENTATIVE
THEY ARE NOT OPPOSING THE
ACCOUNTABILITY COMPONENT THAT
THEY'RE NOT A SILENT ON THAT
IT'S JUST THE WORKGROUP PEACE
SO I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH THEM
FOR. IT IS FOR A MEMBER OF THE
BEAST YES SEE SEE TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE WORK GROUP-
CONTEMPLATED BY A. B. THIRTY
TWO TWENTY EIGHT SO THERE ARE
PATHWAYS TO WORK TOGETHER- TO
BE DUPLICATIVE AND- TO. WORK IN
HARMONY I DON'T JUST END BY
SAYING WE HAVE A DEEPENING
CRISIS IN A FOR PROFIT PRIVATE
FACILITIES WHETHER BE STILL
IMMIGRATION TENSION OR FOR
PROFIT PRIVATE PRISONS IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT IT
IS OUR JOB WITH OUR POLICE
POWERS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO PROTECT THE HEALTH SAFETY
AND WELFARE OF CALIFORNIANS
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
THAT WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
NOT TO SHIP YOUR CONSIDERATION
TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER BONTA
AND- JUST SO. FOR YOUR
INFORMATION BOTH THE- THE
MEMBERS WOULD COMMITTEE. OF THE
OPPOSITION AND A PROPONENTS IN
AND TO THE AUTHOR. OF I JUST
RECENTLY HAD AUDIT DONE.
OBVIOUSLY SEE LOOKING AT SOME
OTHER PROGRAMS. ONE IS A
GLARING THINGS THAT WE NOTICED
IS. THEY BELIEVE THAT. HAVE THE
AUTHORITY OR THEY WEREN'T GIVEN
INSTRUCTIONS. FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES SO
BASICALLY. THEY WENT IN
GATHERED INFORMATION. BUT THEY
DID NOT DO ANY ANALYSIS BECAUSE
THEY SAID THEY WEREN'T SUPPOSED
TO DO THAT AND- JUST POST TO
GATHER. AND SO IN IN THAT
SPIRIT. WITH WORKING WITH THE
ASSURE DEPARTMENT IN THE SEC.
AT THE GROUP REALLY WISE TO
INCLUDE SO THAT. ARE FOR
EXAMPLE IF THERE ARE SUPPOSED
TO CERTAIN THINGS. THAT THEY
ARE THEY'RE DOING IT BUT MORE.
NOT ONLY DID. TO FORCE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE. DOING ALL.
OF THE OTHER PARTS OF THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND OTHER
JAILS. BECAUSE THERE MAY BE
SOME OVERLAP BUT EVEN WITH THAT
OVERLAP THE SEC STILL MAY NOT
BE DOING THEIR JOB IF YOU GET
WHERE I'M GOING- AND SO WITH
WITH THAT I LIKE THE PART ABOUT
GETTING SPECIFIC INFORMATION
THAT WE CAN PULL TOGETHER AND
THEN USE THAT DATA TO ON HOW TO
KEEP IT PRIVATE PRISON AND
IMMIGRATION AND IN CENTER BUT
MOST IMPORTANT WHAT IS OUR ROLE
BUT HOW CAN WE BE POSTED APPLE.
AND I THINK THAT WOULD AS WELL
AS WE MOVE FORWARD ON HOW WE
DEAL WITH NOW IMMIGRATION
CENTERS BUT JUST PRIVATE
FACILITIES IN GENERAL AND HOW
TO MAKE THEM SAFER AND YOUR
WORK TRYING TO DO IS PUT THE
DATE FORMATION SO YOU BRING
SOME FAT. WE HOPE. SWIFTLY ON
MAKING SURE THAT EVERY ONCE.
AND SO I RECOMMEND YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT I ALSO COMMEND
YOU FOR WANTING TO WORK. WITH
THE OPPOSITION ON WHERE THE
OVERLAP IS OF I'M WANTED DEAD
BELIEVING REDUNDANCY I'VE
WORKED ON BILLS I WORKED IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHERE. WE HAVE
REDUNDANT OPERATIONS AND IN
THIS TIME A RECESSION. IS
REALLY GOOD THAT IF YOU COULD
FIND THAT BRING YOU SOME
SAVINGS. HE SAID IT AGAIN IT
BOTH HE WORKING WITH THE
SHERIFF TO BE SEC AND FIND SOME
WAYS WHAT ARE SOME REDUNDANCY
IF WE CAN SAVE SOME MONEY. THAT
WOULD BE. GREAT NOW LIKE FOR
THE BILL BUT I THINK FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA- SO WITH THAT AND
THE SURPRISE SUPPORT OF THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION. OF THOSE CHERISHED.
AN AYE VOTE. ON AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT BONTA AT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JOHN SO YOU'RE AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY NO BARRICADE
HAN. BARRICADE HAND I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I
CARILLO CARILLO I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I THAT MEASURES OUT
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF. WE
NOW WILL HAVE MISSED CARILLO AB
THIRTY FIFTY TWO I WILL ALSO
ANOTHER BIT OF HOUSEKEEPING
MISS CREEL WILL BE SUBSTITUTING
FOR MR ASSEMBLY MEMBER BILL
QUIRK FOR TODAY'S HEARING ONLY.
EVERY COMMITTEE MEMBER THAT
SHOWED UP TODAY FOR PRACTICING
SAFE DISTANCING BUT MORE
IMPORTANT. WARNING SOME TYPE OF
FACIAL SHIELD MASK TODAY AT THE
HERE. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
MADE AGAIN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME 2% AB THIRTY
FIFTY TWO WHICH WILL RIGHT
FULLY COMPENSATE PEOPLE WHO
WERE INVOLUNTARILY STERILIZE
UNDER CALIFORNIA'S PREVIOUS
EUGENICS LAWS AND IN WOMEN
STATES PRESENCE AFTER NINETEEN
FIFTY NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE BY
CREATING THE FOR STERILIZATION
COMPENSATION PROGRAM. IN
NINETEEN OH NINE CALIFORNIA
APPROVED LEGISLATION
AUTHORIZING MEDICAL
SUPERINTENDENTS OF STATE HOMES
AND HOSPITALS TO STERILIZE
PATIENTS THEY SEEMED. IT FOR
REPRODUCTION LET ME SAY THAT
AGAIN. THEY SEEMED UNFIT FOR
REPRODUCTION. THE STATE WENT ON
TO ADMINISTER THE MOST ADVANCED
EUGENICS STERILIZATION PROGRAM
IN THE NATION. STERILIZING OF
MORE THAN TWENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN THE UNITED STATES.
THOUGH THE STATE'S EUGENIC LAWS
WERE REPEALED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE A LATER STATE
AUDIT REVEALED A HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR MORE WOMEN WERE
STERILIZED DURING LABOR. AND
DELIVERY WITHOUT PROPER CONSENT
WHILE INCARCERATED IN
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S PRISONS FROM
TWO THOUSAND SIX TILL TWO
THOUSAND TEN. AN ADDITIONAL ONE
HUNDRED WOMEN WERE
INVOLUNTARILY STERILIZED. IN
PRISON DURING LABOR AND
DELIVERY DATING BACK TO THE
LATE NINETEEN NINETIES AS WELL
AS A SMALL NUMBER OF FORCED
STERILIZATIONS PERFORMED DURING
OTHER SURGERIES. EUGENICS
STERILIZATION PROGRAMS ARE NOW
RECOGNIZED AS A MAJOR HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATION. IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE GOVERNOR GRAY
DAVIS AND THE STATE SENATE
SEPARATELY APOLOGIZE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S EUGENICS
STERILIZATION PROGRAM. ANY FORM
OF ADDRESS HOWEVER DID NOT
ACCOMPANY THEIR APOLOGIES AB
FIFTY TWO WHAT I'D MATERIAL
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THIS AND
JUSTICE BY ESTABLISHING. A
PROGRAM TO COMPENSATE CONFIRM
SURVIVORS WHO WERE STERILISED
IN CALIFORNIA STATE
INSTITUTIONS AND PRESENCE. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHEN THE BILL
WILL GO INTO EFFECT THAT WILL
BE AN ESTIMATED FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE STERILIZED
INDIVIDUAL STERILIZED UNDER
EUGENIC LAWS. AND TO EARN FIFTY
SURVIVORS OF PRISON
STERILIZATION ABUSE. TODAY YOU
WILL HEAR FROM CARLY A MYERS
WITH ABILITY RIGHTS EDUCATION
AND DEFENSE FUND AND KELLY
DILLON WHO WILL BE ABLE TO
SPEAK ON THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
BILL FIRST. THANK THANK YOU
MODERATE WE HAVE KELLY DILLON
CARLY MYERS KELLY FIRST. WHAT
IS. AND. YOU WILL EITHER OPEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I WOULD SAY
THAT DILUTES THE PAST BECAUSE
IT'S LONG OVERDUE IN PASSING
THE BARBER THAT MARK THOUGH WHO
WERE STERILIZED AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY FOUR ONE OF COURSE YOU
RATED AT CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL
WOMEN'S FACILITY. THIS BILL THE
ONE WHO FOR AND THE LIVE WELL
OF THE HAVE BEEN SPEAKING BUT I
KNOW OVERTHE YEARS HEY MARCEL
FOR EIGHTEEN IN THE LIGHT OF
THE CALL THE PANDEMIC THE
CAPTAIN OF THIS BILL IS THE
EVIDENCE THE CALIFORNIA HAVE
THE WILLINGNESS TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE MEDICAL AND JEFF. THE
MEDICAL PRACTICES IN THE LACK
OF WITH FOR YOU LIKE THAT
PEOPLE OF COLOR HAVE SUFFERED
AT THE HANDS OF THE PEOPLE. WHO
WERE SUPPOSED TO FIRST THIRTY
OR EITHER PROTECTING. THE
ACTUAL FINANCIAL COMPENSATION
JEFF THE BARBER'S WILL BE
SEATED ONLY A HUMBLE PEACE
OFFERING THERE SHOULD BE HANDY.
WHAT THE SINCERE APOLOGY FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IF YOU
DIDN'T GET THE GUARD DESPITE
THE PACKAGE DEAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MS MYERS. HI GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS CURRENTLY
MYERS AND I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY
AT THE DISABILITY RIGHTS
EDUCATION AND DEFENSE FUND I
NATIONAL DISABILITY ALIVE
POLICY CENTER THAT PUSH TAX IN
BANDS OF THE CIVIL AND HUMAN
RIGHTS PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
AT THE ORGANIZATION CAN LET IT
COME OUT IN A QUALITY IN ALL
ASPECTS OF LIFE WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB THIRTY FIFTY TWO AND
THE LEGAL PLAY A VITAL ROLE IN
ADVANCING DISABILITY RACIAL AND
BE PRODUCTIVE JACKET. BETWEEN
NINETEEN OH NINE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FORCIBLY STERILIZED
DEGREES TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES. BASED ON
YOUTH GUIDED ASSUMPTIONS AND
BIAS HE'S ABOUT DISABILITY
INDIVIDUALS WERE LABELED QUOTE
UNFIT TO REPRODUCE. AND THEY
WERE SUMMARILY STERILIZED.
DISABLED PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
DISABLED WOMEN OVER THE GROUP'S
PRIMARILY TARGETED BY THE
PAYMENT LOT. CALIFORNIA FAIRLY
ABUSE IT HAVE BEEN PACKAGE
COUNTLESS LIVE. BUT THE TWO
YOUNG WOMEN WHO WORK FOR THE
AIRLINE STATE AND- WANTED YOU
TO SHARE THEIR LOVED ONES
EXPERIENCES WITH YOU TODAY.
FRANCO WITH A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD
GIRL WHO LIVED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. MARY CAME LOOK
MEXICAN AMERICAN FAMILY AND WAS
ADMITTED TO THE PACIFIC COLONY.
IN NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR. A
DOCTOR DIAGNOSED HER WITH CLOSE
PEOPLE MINDEDNESS AND SOCIAL
MEDIA AND STERILIZED HER
WITHOUT HER CONSENT. MERRY
STERILIZATION AFFECTING HER
ENTIRE LIFE PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS WERE HARMED HER
HUSBAND LEFT HER WHEN HE FOUND
OUT THAT SHE COULDN'T HAVE
CHILDREN AND SHE BASED THAT SHE
BATES LAUGHING HEALTH
COMPLICATIONS FROM HER SURGERY.
HEATER DOCTOR STATED THAT SHE
HAD BEEN BUTCHERED BY THE
PROCEDURE. MARY PASSED AWAY IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT ATTORNEYS
CONTINUE TO SHARE HER STORY AND
EFFORT TO BRING AWARENESS JUST.
THAT SHE ENTERED. WELL THE BIOS
BUT THE YOUNGER GIRL A LARGE
SPANISH AND THE CURRENT FAMILY.
WELL IF YOU HAD A DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITY AND AGE SIXTEEN
SHE'D STERILIZED LISTING ON THE
STATE HOME. WELL YOU DOCTORS
YOU'RE FOR HER IF CLOTHES IN
THE SHOP. AND RECOMMEND HER FOR.
WELL THE SURGERY IS NOT AS- IT
FEW DAYS BEFORE SEVENTEENTH
BIRTHDAY WELL HE DIED HER STAY.
PROCEED IN THE WORDS OF BRODY
GREAT COAT I WANTED THERE TO BE
A RAPPER THAT THIS. AT SIXTEEN
YEARS OLD DIED BECAUSE OF A
GOVERNMENT POLICY. A POLICY
THAT WHOLE PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T
HAVE THE EDUCATION OR THE
FINANCIAL WHEREWITHAL TO DO
ANYTHING THIS IS WHAT YOU DO
WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEONE WITH A
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY. BOB
HOW EUGENICS LAWS WERE FOR
REPEALED IN NINETEEN. NINE THE
STATE CONTINUE TO STERILIZATION
ABUSES AND RECENTLY AS TWENTY
TEN. IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
WOMEN WERE STERILIZED EIGHT
PRESENCE WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT
AND SOMETIMES EVEN WITHOUT
THEIR KNOWLEDGE. TODAY
CALIFORNIA HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DENOUNCE FORTY STERILIZATION
FOR WHAT THEY WERE A FLAGRANT
HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSE. AT A TIME
WHEN THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND BRING TO THE FOREFRONT DEEP
SEATED RACIAL AND DISABILITY
BASED HOW CAN I. THIS BILL
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE KNOWLEDGE IF
THE CREATURES REPRODUCTIVE HARM.
THERE ARE ONLY AN ESTIMATED
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
SURVIVORS FROM EUGENICS
STERILIZATION THAT ARE STILL
ALIVE TODAY. IF WE DON'T ACT
QUICKLY NEED INDIVIDUALS LIKE
THE NINETEEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE BEFORE THEM WILL
DIE WITHOUT ANY FORM OF THAT.
NOW MORE THAN EVER THE STATE
NEED TO COMMIT TO ADDRESSING
ITS LEGACY OF EUGENICS AND
OPERATION BOLDLY COMMIT TO
ENSURING THAT IT WILL NOT
HAPPEN AGAIN. FOR THESE REASONS
THE DISABILITY RIGHTS EDUCATION
AND DEFENSE ON RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IDLE ON EIGHTY THIRTY
THIRTY KILL. THANK YOU Q. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. NAME IN ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO WILL BEGIN FIRST
WITH MARGOT GEORGE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE STRUCTURE LINE IS
OPEN. MARCO GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY FIFTY TWO. THANK
YOU LINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT ONE
TWO EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GEN
FLORI ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
FIFTY FOUR ONE FIVE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ROBERT LEE RALPH THEN
ON THE POLICY CONSULTANT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WOMEN PRISONERS WE ARE PROUD
CALL SPONSOR. AB THIRTY FIFTY
TWO IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE THIRTEEN ONE ONE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. QUICK
RESPONSES WHICH CHIRLA THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
AYE CONSTRUCTS SUPPORT. THANK
YOU CHRIS. LINE ONE TWENTY FIVE
ONE TWO FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ARE YOU READY WE ARE WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA LINES FOR YOU THAT
COMMUNITY JUSTICE INSTRUCTS
APART. THANK YOU. I IN ONE
SIXTY TWO ONE SIX TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS JIM WHEN
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION TO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND ONE HUNDRED SIXTY ONE
ONE SIX ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE SIX GO AHEAD THANK YOU
YEAH SURE ARE NOT HERE
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TERMS FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NAUSEA. LINE ONE OH SEVEN ONE
ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY
GREGORY COULD I WOULD MEAN SHE
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE FORTY THREE
FOUR THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE BARD BUT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE FIFTY ONE FIVE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
TO ANDERSON WITH THE ARK IN UCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SIXTY ONE SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I MEAN ELFSTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR THE
FOR THE MEASURE IS STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FINAL ONE
OLD THREE ONE ZERO THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI SHANNON HOW THE
DIRECTOR OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA AND TRANSPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE THIRTY SIX ONE
THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MONTH AND THEN THERE ARE
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WOMEN I STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN ONE
THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS CYNTHIA CHANDLER I'M AN
ATTORNEY AND THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF JUSTICE NOW I LIVE
THE EFFORTS TO EXPOSE MORE
CONTEMPORARY ABUSES INSIDE THE
WOMEN'S PRISON THAN IT WAS MY
JOB TO TELL KELLY DEALING ALONG
WITH DOZENS OF OTHER WOMEN AT
THAT THEY WERE STERILIZED
WITHOUT THEIR KNOWLEDGE OR
CONTENT. I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE ONE
FOUR EIGHT ONE FOUR EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME AND LET THEM KNOW THAT YES
THEY MAIL IT CALIFORNIA LATINA
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
COSPONSORED OF EIGHTY TAKE. AND
CONTEMPLATE. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE FOUR TO ONE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK AMONG THE
LOCOMOTIVES- BUT THE SHOE STORE
YEARS FREEDOM COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
HERE ON BEHALF OF PLUMBING
CORRECTIVE WOMEN ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE FIFTY THREE
ONE FIVE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS KELLY SAVAGE
FROM CALIFORNIA COLLECTION
FILLING THE PRISONERS- IN
STRONG SUPPORT AS A FORMER
INCARCERATED PERSON WHO HAD TO
SUPPORT A LOT AND THE
INDIVIDUAL HAVING BACK FROM
PROCEDURES AND DEALING WITH THE
HARSH TREATMENT THAT LUCY
REALLY AT THAT TIME- I CHOSE
NOT TO GET MEDICAL ATTENTION
BECAUSE OF THE CONTRACTOR. I AM
NOT BALLOT STATE. THANK YOU
THEY YOU. WIND THIRTY FOR ONE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
COURTNEY HANSEN WITH
CALIFORNIANS UNITED-
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET AND VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE FIFTY ONE
ONE FIVE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IT IS EVOLVING A QUE EL ON
BEHALF OF THE YOUNG WOMEN'S
FREEDOM CENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THE CO. THEY GIVE. ONE
SIXTY THREE ONE SIX THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ABBY OUR
MARRIAGE WITH A LATINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU.
ONE FIFTY SIX ONE FIVE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. KATIE HAPPENS
FIRST BETTER GOOD GENETICS AND
SOCIETY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. ONE THREE
EIGHT WORK ON THE LINE ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JENNY CAN FROM
LEGAL AID AT WORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FIFTY TWO.
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY NINE ONE
THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALL. YOU MAY YOU MAY BEGIN LINE
ONE THIRTY EIGHT AS WELL. YEAH
LOW WEAPONS IN THE MIDDLE
SERVICE IN AN EDUCATOR-
ADVOCATING A STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL ENCOURAGING YOU TO DO
THE SAME THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE NINETEEN ONE ONE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JULIANA WHEN REPRESENTING ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE ONE
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE
FORTY FIVE LINE ONE FOUR FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL OUR ONLINE
ONE FORTY FIVE ARE YOU THERE.
YES THE LOUDER HE MANAGED
DEFECTIVE DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
THAT THE NECESSARY PRODUCT OF
JUST HOW COLD BONTA THE FELLOW
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND THE THAT
PROTECT YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND ONE FORTY THREE
ONE FOUR THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU THIS IS RACHEL
CO WITH ACCESS WOMEN'S HEALTH
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE FIFTY TWO
ONE FIVE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE END OF THE LAND AND MARK
PLANNED PARENTHOOD OF THE
PACIFIC SOUTHWEST AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE ONE FOUR
ZERO. GOOD MORNING THERE AREN'T
MANY LIVES IT IS NOT WORKING-
ON THE WALK AT THE PARK ON THE
BELL MOBILITY LONG WITH THE
FORTY. THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DAN ECHO O'DONNELL ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE EIGHT ZERO ONE EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CARE YES.
HI MY NAME IS CARLENE CARTER
I'M WITH THE I. ONE IF WE CAN
CENTER AND ON STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE EIGHT SIX
ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAPTION SURE ABOUT HALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY
TWO FIVE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHAT WILL COME BACK TO LINE
FIFTY TWO LINE ONE NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES YEAH MY NAME IS
THAT THEY WOULD GET IT I'M HERE
REPRESENTING ACCESS WOMAN HELP
JUSTICE AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT. Q. FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN FIVE TWO. HELLO THIS IS
ANTHONY DE MARTINO WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE EIGHT NINE
ONE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS ABLE GRAY FAN BUT WHAT
COORDINATOR FOR THE SYSTEM
WORKED IN COALITION INSTRUCT
THE COURT. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
EIGHTY FOUR ONE EIGHT FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME
IS THE TRAVIS WITH INITIATE
THAT THOSE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AB TWO MORE LINES IN
Q. AT THIS TIME LINE FORTY ONE
FOUR LINE FOR ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS AS FUNDING
AS THE NUMBERS STATE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR CUT FIFTY AND
WHERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ASKED ABOUT. THANK YOU THE
FINAL LINE IN QUEUES ONE NINE
SIX ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING RICHARD
WITH CALIFORNIA COALITION WOMAN
FROM HER AND I AM STRONG OR OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. FOR THE
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. I HAVE NONE BUT I'M
GOING TO ASK IS THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION MIGHT
KNOW SAY NONE BUT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE DON'T MAKE A
MISTAKE. MODERATE DO YOU HAVE
ANY. ONE IN OPPOSITION. TO HOLD
THE POSITION OF OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. NO ONE IN Q. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT HAVE
QUESTIONS. YOU HAVE QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REBEKAH POWER
QUE AND HAS A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR. IT'S ACTUALLY A COMMENT
BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL BACK I
KNOW THIS IS A BILL WE SAW LAST
YEAR AND I WHEN I THINK I THINK
IT'S KELLY WITH THE WITNESS ON
THE PHONE IF I GOT HER NAME
RIGHT- I KNOW WE HEARD THIS
LAST YEAR IN PERSON AND IT WAS
REALLY AN INCREDIBLY POWERFUL
TO HEAR THE STORIES OF THESE
WOMEN. AND AS A STRONG PRO
CHOICE WOMAN YOU KNOW YOU ARE-
THESE WOMEN WERE DENIED THE
CHOICE TO HAVE CHILDREN AND
BEING PRO CHOICE MEANS THAT WE
PROVIDE A RUN A CHOICE TO
MATTER WHAT THAT CHOICES SO- I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
ADVOCACY DESPITE THE DIFFICULTY
IN GETTING THIS THROUGH AND-
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT AGAIN
TODAY. THANK. IS THERE A MOTION
AND. THERE'S A MOTION AND
SECOND IN YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS AND
TO ALL THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
pMEMBER YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT-
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM AND BEING
PRO CHOICE MEANS CHOICE. AND
THE FACT THAT- BOTH MEN AND
WOMEN IN OUR PRISON SYSTEM WERE
DENIED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BECOME MOTHERS OR TO BE ABLE TO
FATHER CHILDREN. IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT THE STATE NEEDS-TO RECONCILE WITH AND SO- THAT
WE'RE BRINGING THIS BLL BACK
AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF WHAT IT WHAT IT MEANS WHAT
IT STANDS FOR. AND TO THE TO
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE- BY THE WITNESSES OVER THE
PHONE BY THIS MONTH BY MISS
MYERS EVEN THROUGH COLD IT WE%
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT JUSTICE
NEEDS TO BE DONE. AND THAT EVEN
WHILE WE RECONCILE THAT COOL
BUT HAS ACTUALLY HIGHLIGHTED.
SOME OF THE INCREDIBLE
INJUSTICES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHEN IT COMES TO
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND THE
RIGHTS TO ACCESS AND RESOURCES.
THIS IS STILL A PRIORITY TO OUR
STATE. AND SO AGAIN GIVEN GIVEN
THOSE- THOSE CHOICES OR LACK OF
CHOICES FOR SOME. THIS IS WHY
THIS BILL MATTERS THIS IS WHY
SB THIRTY TWO IS SIGNIFICANT IN
THIS MOMENT IN OUR IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY. AND ALTHOUGH
NO MONETARY COMPENSATION CAN
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED THE
SUFFERING. CREATED TO BY. THE
SURVIVORS OF STERILIZATION. IT
IS A MATERIAL ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
OF THIS WRONGDOING ACROSS THE
STATE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST HERE I THOUGHT. AND SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU AS CHAIR
LOOKING FOR THE COMMITTEES A
WHOLE I THINK IN MY LETTER. TO
OUT ABOUT WHAT BILLS WE DID SET
IT WAS A VERY DIFFICULT.
DECISION ONE IT IS THE REASONS
WE DID SET SOME BILLS. WAS UP
FINANCIAL VIABILITY. AND SO I
ASKED DIFFERENT MEMBERS TO TALK
TO THE- I DID BUDGET COMMITTEE
BUT SO. YOU DID THAT. YOU DID
THE WORK. AND IN MORE POURED
YOU ALSO ENCOURAGE- TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS UP ON THE
BUDGET SIDE NOT ONLY ON THE
LEGISLATIVE SIDE. WHICH ONE ARE
YOU WAY UP TO PASS THE CHAIR OF
BUDGET SUB FIVE WHICH I SIT ON.
AND OTHER MEMBERS HERE SIT ON-
TO TRY TO GET FUNDING FOR THIS
AND YOU ARE ENCOURAGED TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THAT AND THAT'S
WHY IT. IT CAME TO THIS
COMMITTEE THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HEARING IT NOW. BECAUSE YOU DID
THE HARD WORK IS GOING TO BE
EVEN HARDER. UP TRYING TO MAKE
SURE IN JUST REALLY DIFFICULT
TIME OF RECESSION- THAT YOU
WERE COURAGE BY PEOPLE IN THE
SPENDING SIDE THE BUDGET SIDE.
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT-
WHAT'S GOING TO THANK YOU FOR
DOING ALL THAT HARD WORK BUT
MOST IMPORTANT- OBVIOUSLY
DISTURBED. TO DO. THE AVERAGE
THE CHAIR IS WRECKED. I'VE BUT
AGAIN I WANT THANK YOU FOR
DOING BUDGET WORK- THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
RED SECTOR CALDERON ON AB
THIRTY FIFTY TWO CARILLO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER LACKEY
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAND
BARKING HAD I DEEP. DEEP I
KAMLAGER. CARDIO CARDIO I
SANTIAGO. WICKS WICKS I. THAT
MEASURE GETS OUT SIX ZERO GREAT
GRADUATION THANK YOU. MISS
CERVANTES AB TWENTY D. EIGHT OH
A DISMISSAL OF CONVICTIONS
PROTECTIVE ORDERS. WELCOME BACK
THANK YOU YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TODAY ON
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT OH
EIGHT I WANT TO THANK YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE WITH THIS BILL THIS
BILL IS AN EMBODIMENT OF THIS
LEGISLATURE'S ONGOING BELIEVE
THAT SURVIVORS SHOULD BE
PROVIDED WITH PROTECTIONS FOR
FURTHER HARM AT THE HANDS OF
THEIR ASSAILANTS. UNDER
EXISTING LAW THE DEFENDANT MUST
BE ELIGIBLE TO SEEK TO HAVE THE
CASE AGAINST THEM DISMISSED
AFTER SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETING
PROBATION ONCE THE CASE AGAINST
THEM IS DISMISSED THE LAW SAYS
THAT THE DEFENDANT IS RELEASED
FROM PENALTIES AND DISABILITIES
RESULTING FROM THE OFFENSE
HOWEVER EXISTING LAW ALSO
PROVIDES SEVERAL EXCEPTIONS TO
THAT PRINCIPLE INCLUDING
POSSESSION OF A FIREARM AND
HOLDING ELECTED OFFICE. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND ELEVEN THIS
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED OUR
CRIMINAL COURTS WITH THE
ABILITY TO ISSUE PROTECTIVE
ORDERS TERMS UP TO TEN YEARS
FOR CERTAIN CRIMES INCLUDING
PLASTIC VIOLENCE AND STALKING
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
CONVICTION IS A FELONY OR
MISDEMEANOR. HOWEVER IT IS
CLEAR WHETHER PROTECT ORDER.
UNDER THE LAW REMAIN IN PLACE
AFTER DEFENDED HAS A CASE
AGAINST THEM DISMISSED AFTER
COMPLETING PROBATION. AS A
RESULT OF THIS AMBIGUITY IN THE
LOS SEVERAL JUDGES IN LA COUNTY
HAVE HAD ISSUES HAVE HAD TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE WHEN
DECIDING WHETHER JUST TO
DISMISS THE CASE AGAINST THE
DEFENDANT WHO HAS COMPLETED
PROBATION. AB TWENTY OH EIGHT
PROVIDES A BALANCED APPROACH
THAT ALLOWS FOR THE CRIMINAL
CASE AGAINST THE ASSAILANT TO
BE DISMISSED SO THEY CAN SEEK
REHABILITATION OPTIONS LIKE
APPLYING FOR JOBS WAS STILL
PROVIDING THE SURVIVOR WITH THE
PROTECTIONS THAT THEY BOTH
NEED. AND THEY RIGHTFULLY
DESERVE. FOR THESE REASONS
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FREE AYE VOTE ON ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT OH EIGHT. WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. IS LESLIE CLAIMED ON
BEHALF OF OUR SPONSOR LOS
ANGELES DISTRICT ATTORNEY
JACKIE LACEY. AND PALE SEEN HA
ON BEHALF OF THE PEACE OFFICE-
PEACE OVER VIOLENCE. THANK YOU.
MISSED MODERATOR COULD YOU HAVE
OUR SUPPORT WITNESSES NOW
TESTIFY. AB TWENTY EIGHT OH
EIGHT CERVANTES. HELLO HELLO.
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW.
OKAY THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
LESS INCLINED YES IF IT HAD
THAT THE OF THE FAMILY VIOLENCE
DIVISION OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE. WE RE THE PROUD
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY EIGHT OH
EIGHT. PROTECT THE BORDERS ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TOOL USED
IN THE PROTECTION OF VICTIMS OF
CRIME PARTICULARLY IN CASES
INVOLVING DOMESTIC VIOLENCEAND
TALKING. TO THE INTRINSIC
ONGOING NATURE OF THE
RELATIONSHIP. IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHETHER THE INCIDENT AMOUNTS TO
A MISDEMEANOR OR A FELONY ANY
ACT OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CAN
QUICKLY ESCALATED INTO A
VIOLENT FELONY INCLUDING ACT OF
GUN VIOLENCE. I HAVE CERTAINLY
SEEN THAT HAPPEN IN MY TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OF EXPERIENCE. THE
CAPTAIN ORDERED IT BECOMES THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO KEEP
THEIR ABUSERS AWAY. PROTECTIVE
ORDER CAN LITERALLY BE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH. THE BILL WE ARE
PROPOSING IS NOT ADD ANY MORE
RESTRICTIONS IT'S SIMPLY
CLARIFIED A VAGUENESS INTO LAW
AS IT IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
COURT ALREADY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY AND THE PRESIDENT IF
THE FINAL PROTECTIVE ORDERS
UPON CONVICTION IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. STOPPING AT THE BY
TECH CRIME THAT ARE VALID FOR
UP TO TEN YEARS IN BOTH FELONY
AND MISDEMEANOR CASES. ALTHOUGH
THE TEN YEAR PROTECTIVE ORDER
IS MOST OFTEN OBTAINED IN
FELONY CASES THERE ARE SOME
MISDEMEANOR CASES WHERE I CAN
YOUR PROTECTIVE ORDER HAS BEEN
<c.red>SSUED. BASED ON THE</c>
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE CASE CASES
INVOLVING MULTIPLE INCIDENTS OF
ABUSE PRIOR HISTORY OF ABUSE.
OR INJURIES THAT ARE QUITE YET
AGAIN DON'T QUITE BY THE LEVEL
OF THE FELONY CHARGE.
IMPORTANTLY QUIRK HAVE THE
JURISDICTION TO MODIFY OR
TERMINATE THOSE PROTECTIVE
ORDER WITHIN THE TENURE OF
THEIR INSURANCE. AND NOTHING
NFL CHANGES THAT. CURRENTLY
WHEN A DEFENDANT MOVED TO HAVE
THEIR CASE THICKNESS UNDER
PENAL CODE SECTION TWELVE OH
THREE POINT FOUR OR TWELVE A
THREE POINT FOUR EIGHT NOTHING
IN THE SECOND ADDRESSED THE
HOUSE SUPPORT SHOULD HANDLE THE
ISSUE OF THE UNEXPIRED
PROTECTIVE ORDER. DID HE NEED
DIFFERENT BILL CLARIFIES THAT
WANT TO COURT GRANTS DISMISSAL
UNDER TWELVE A THREE POINT FOUR
AND TWELVE A THREE POINT FOR A-
PROTECTIVE ORDER PRESUMPTIVELY
REMAIN VALID UNTIL ITS
EXPIRATION DATE. FOR THE
PROTECTION OF THE VICTIM WELL
IT COULD WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
GIVING THE PORTS THE DISCRETION
TO MODIFY OR TERMINATE THE
ORDER. IT PRESENT INFORMATION.
I THANK ACTION. IF YOU ARRIVE
IN. INDIVIDUAL JUDGE ON YOUR
DEFIED TO HAND THAT IF YOU. IT
IS EVEN A THAT I. MANY JUDGES
WILL APPROVED PROTECTIVE ORDER
ROOM IN A- MANY THE A YOU HAVE
NOT THE FACT ALL BUT THE
PROTECTIVE ORDER REMAIN IN FOR
IF. LEADING AND WITHOUT IN THAT
HERE FOR MAKE BE. TO A
PROTECTIVE ORDER. IN OTHER
INSTANCES COURT MAY FEEL THEY
MUST GIVE MISSED THE EXISTING.
ORDER IF THEY DISMISSED THE
CASE. AB TWENTY EIGHT OH EIGHT
GIVE THE COURT GUIDANCE ON IT
THE STORY AND PUT THE DEFENDANT
ON NOTICE THAT HE OR SHE IS
STILL SUBJECT TO THE ORDER
UNLESS AND UNTIL THE COURT
TERMINATE OR MODIFY THE ORDER.
IT FURTHER GET THAT BIG THEM
PEACE OF MIND NO THE PROTECTIVE
ORDER IS IN QUITE. ANY
SUGGESTION THAT A VICTIM COULD
SIMPLY GET A SEVERAL
RESTRAINING ORDER. IF THEY
REALLY WANTED WANTED LOT.
NAVIGATING THE COURT SYSTEM IS
DON INCOME MOST LAY PEOPLE. IT
FOURTH OF THE VICTIM I HAVE TO
RE LIVE THE ATROCITIES THEY'VE
ALREADY EXPERIENCE. BOB HOPING
AND PRAYING THE JUDGE WILL
TRANSPORT. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
AS EXPRESSED ME BY DOMESTIC
SURVIVOR. HERE THAT GOING BACK
TO COURT YEARS LATER WELL AS
SHE PUT IT HOPE THE HORNET'S
NEST AND REFOCUS THE ABUSER ON
THE VICTIM. AB TWENTY EIGHT OH
EIGHT HELP ENSURE THAT THE LATE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT BEHIND
TENURE PROTECTIVE ORDER LAWS
ISN'T PUT IN JEOPARDY BY
ADDRESSING THE BIGNESS
CURRENTLY FOUND IN TWELVE OH
THREE POINT FOUR AND TWELVE OH
THREE POINT FOUR EIGHT. WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. THANK YOU
THANK CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I AM BIOS AND-
MANAGING ATTORNEY AT THE SERVER
VIOLINS ARE NONPROFIT BASED IN
LOS ANGELES THAT'S UP SURVIVORS
OF INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE I'M
BE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWO
EIGHT ZERO EIGHT. STOP LIST IN
NINETEEN THIRTY IT'S A SECTION
IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE STALKING
AND NEWT BUT PREVENTION YOU'VE
GOTTEN PREVENTION CENTER WHERE
WE PROVIDE MY DAD TO DISABILITY
SERVICE INCLUDING COURT
ADVOCACY I WOULDN'T BE SERVICES
CASE MANAGEMENT COUNSELING AND
LEGAL SERVICES SHE MADE. YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE WITH DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS AND
COMMUNITY. AFFECTED BY SUCH
CRIME. I THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROTECTION GRANTED BY REACHING
ORDER. LEAVING EARLY CAN
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS THE MEDICAL
MUSIC. THE MEDICAL PROJECT
ORDER IS NOT INTENDED TO HELP
THESE VICTIMS DURING THE TIME.
PROTECTION OBVIOUSLY THE
CRUCIAL ROLE IN CREATING SAFE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE MEDICAL AND
SURVIVORS. AND WITNESSES THEIR
OFFICE AND MOST OF THE CASES
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
PROTECTION ORDER ARE OFTEN
CONSIDERED OTHER CRITICAL OF
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM TO. SAFETY
I ALSO DOMESTIC RESTRAINING
ORDER IN CIVIL SCHOOL. ALL THEY
ARE CONSIDERED LIFE TOOL FOR
WHICH OF ABUSE DOMESTIC ONE
INTRODUCTION ORDERS TO THE
COURT COMES BUT THE PROBLEM UP
OWN. NOT ONLY CAN THE PROCESS
BE OFF TOO OFTEN CAN BE
COMPLICATED INTIMIDATING FOR
SOME DANGEROUS BUT THE ONLY
LAST ONE AT AMOUNT OF TIME.
WHAT OFTEN DO ENHANCE SAFETY BY
WALKING THE DEER OFFICE TO GET
A CRUDE PROTECTIVE ORDER
STARTING A HERE TO ENSURE. YOUR
MORE I'M TO PROTECT. I'VE BEEN
LACKEY NAVIGATING SYSTEM THE
LOOP BUT WHEN YOU OKAY
RESTRAINING HA. MORE THAN HALF
OF ALL FEMALE HOMICIDE VICTIMS
ARE KILLED BY IN AN DEMAND OF
FAULKNER. ACCORDING TO WHAT
TWENTY REPORT FROM CDC. YOU
READY HAVE FOUND THAT THE SO.
IS OFTEN PRECURSOR TO AND TO
MAKE UP OUR HOMES. MAKING
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS WOULD
AFFECT OF THE MONTH WANTED TO
HE ELATION. FOR SOME VICTIMS
WHAT EVEN INTIMATE AS HOW THEY
TO UP IN A COURT IN ARTICULATE
WHAT HOW TODAY. AND WHY HEAD OF
STATE AS ELIGIBLE THEIR STYLE
NUCLEAR. AND HAVING TO COME TO
PRAY AGAIN AGAIN. THE WHOLE
PROCESS VERY DIFFICULT IN A TOM.
SPENT IF YOU ARE YOUR OWN. THIS
IS LIKE TO THE PROJECT ORDER
SUCH A- HOWEVER IF PRODUCTION
IS OF EIGHT ON THE RICHTER WHAT
TO OF THEM. UNDER EXISTING AS
MENTIONED. DEFENDER SOMETIME A
LITTLE BIT HAVE THE AGAIN THEM
TO. I COMPLETE OF THE PROBATE.
THAT THE LAW THEM. TO BE
RELEASED AN OLD AND ITS ABILITY.
BUT HE NEED THE CALIFORNIA COB
GORE WITHOUT. WHERE THERE
PREDICTABLE MEANS PLEASE ALL A
BUT DEPENDENT HOT HOT HEAT
AGAINST DISMISSED. LISTENING
THAT A SURVIVOR FACE THE
BROUGHT THAT THE NORMALLY BE
SEEN. BY PREDICTIVE ORDER THE
HOT AGAINST TO THE AND-
COMPLETED. AND HAD GET THE-
SURVIVOR SHOULD BE ABLE TO RELY
ON PROTECTIVE ORDER THE SIX
PEOPLE IN PLACE THAT IF. THE
GUY OF THE- DISPOSITION THAT
MANAGEMENT. EIGHT DO A DEAL
EIGHT WOULD RESOLVE THE I'M TO
GIVE AND PROTECT SURVIVOR BY.
THAT COMPETING PROBATION AND
HAVING THE CASE AGAIN THEM.
DOES NOT RELIEVE THEM. FROM
HAVING TO COME. WITH AN EX
PROJECT OF ORDER. ARE BUT I DO
KNOW OF THE SAME. IT IS
ESSENTIAL TO A THAT ONE
SURVIVOR I NOT LEAST WITH THE
ADDED UP. ANOTHER RESTRAINING
ORDER BUT THE PRODUCTION ORDER
HOW GROW. HOLDS JUDGE MAY AT
THE TIME. WHAT DO YOU DO YOU UP
THESE OTHER VIOLENT DIED IN
CHAU SUPPORT. OFFICE SPECULATED
ARE WHAT. ONE TWENTY FIVE ONE
FIVE. ONE WAY TO SHARE THE LOVE.
YOU. BUT THAT THERE OUT.
HEARING AID BACK AND NOW FAMILY
AND THEY SAY THAT THE CALL.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE. ONE OR TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ZERO TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BOAT THAT'S RIGHT
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
CHURCH LOCATION. FOR Q. WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE ALL FIVE ONE OH
FIVE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHRISTINE WORKED WITH CREDIT
ALLIANCE AND ARE AN EXTRA
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE ONE
EIGHT EIGHT I'M SORRY IT'S ONE.
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE ONE
EIGHT ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN A
KELLY ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
ENANTIOMER AT THE COURT. THANK
YOU. LINE THIRTY FIVE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD JOHN LEVEL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
AND UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
NARCOTIC ASSOCIATION. AND THE
COALITION OF PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS SUPPORT SERVICES ALL
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
MISTER LEVEL. LINE TWO OH FIVE
TWO ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS MAX ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WE KEEP ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE TWO OH SIX TWO ZERO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS RANDY.
HOW THEY HAVE PRO POOR ACT
HELLO SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
PERRY OUT ONE. WE HAVE ONE LINE
IN Q. IF THERE ARE OTHERS IT'S
ONE THAN ZERO LINE ONE TWENTY
FIVE WEEKS AGO AHEAD. LINE ONE
TWO FIVE IS YOUR LINE ON ME.
MACINNES NUMBER. WHEN YOU'RE
GOOD. TRANSPORTATION AND- THANK
YOU. YOU KNOW A LINES IN Q.
THIS TIME. NOW ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OP. A I HAVE KEPT
THE SURE AND MARK BUT AMMAR JOE
PUBLIC CALIFORNIA PHONE
DEFENDERS SO. ONLINE OKAY
CONTINUE. THANK FOR TO ON OF
THE CAL PUBLIC TO SYSTEM. ALL.
THE THING AUTHOR AND WORK BUT
IT'S ON THE AND WE'RE WELCOME
BUT THEY'RE JUST. ALL WE SHOULD
DISCUSS. GREEN ONE EIGHT PART
BOTH SIDE THE IN INTO HAVE LONG
RELIED THE NON THAT ONE
PROPOSED STILL CRITICAL COULD
NO LONGER MODEL THE TERM TO PUT
AND THE INDIVIDUAL HAD PAID
THEIR DEBT. TO DID YOU FINISH
YOUR DID YOU GET CUT OFF. MARK.
CASES THAT WOULD WARRANT A TEN
YEAR PROTECT THE BORDER ARE IN
OUR EXT AND THEREFORE THOUSAND
OF US ON A LITTLE MORE MEMBERS
ARE STANDING MONEY. AB EIGHT OH
EIGHT EIGHT IS NOT TO. BECAUSE
IT HIGHWAY AND THAT A COURT
DISH THE CAN. IN IN PROBATE
EARLY IF THE PROBATIONER HAD
VIOLATED A RESTRAINING ORDER IN
THE CASE. AND THE COURT COULD
CONVERT A CRIMINAL RESTRAINING
ORDER TO A CIVIL RESTRAINING
ORDER AT THE TIME IT MODIFIES
OR DISMISS KOBE. IF CIVIC STILL
WISH TO BE PRETTY. THE A NOTE.
OF THE WE FOR THE DISMISS. AND
THE CAN OF ON BEHALF OF THE IN
ASKED IT BE CONVERTED TO SO
RESTRAINING. THIS ALREADY IN
CASE AND UNPAID RESTED.
ALTHOUGH ORDER ARE ARE IN FOR
CIVIL. MANY COURTS HAVE
MONITORED AND CALLED REST
THROUGH. IN PROBATION EARLY
COURT OFF CONTAIN DURING RESTED
IN IT FOR CHEN. THERE IS NO.
THAT THE COURT COULD NOT
CONVERT EIGHT CRIMINAL WE STRAY
ORDER AND A SIMPLE ORDER IF
THAT WERE POINT TO IT. AB TWO
EIGHT AWAIT NO WAY MONEY AND
SCARES LOCAL GREASE. IN THE
MIDST OF THE PAN. AND WE IN A
CRISIS. IN MANY COUNTIES.
ORDERS A ROUTINE ISSUED IN
EVERY SHOT. PROSTITUTE BAY. AND
BATTERY QUE. SHOULD SHIP. THEY
ASSUME THAT THE BORDER NO GROUP
WHEN KOBE AS PRODUCT WE- ASK
FOR YOUR NO BOAT AND EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK MISTER GEORGE. I THERE
ANY OTHER WAY. AND OPPOSITION
NOW AN ORGAN. MODERATOR GOOD
MORNING AT THE CARE AND AT
NUMBER. CAN CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN. I AT THIS IS KATHY SURE
BUT THE ACLU CALIFORNIA I
BELIEVE I'M SIGNED UP OFFER
SUCH TO CATCH. AS WELL WE WERE
METHOD A WAIT OH EIGHT I DO
JOINED IN COMMON OF MISTER.
CALIFORNIA HAS READ THE
BENEFITS OF A BY SIR ATTEND TO
PUT THE PAP BEHIND NUMBER MOVE
ON WITH THEIR BY A LOT OF THE
AND THEY HAVE THEIR CONVICTION
BUT ON. AB TWENTY EIGHT AWAIT
WOULDN'T STAY IN THE LIMITED.
OF CASES WORK ON THEY- HE
INDIVIDUAL WHO ARE. PACKED
ABOARD. UNDER THAT YOU'RE- OF
THE CRIME COURT A PERIOD OF UP
TO TEN YEAR. TO ALLOW THE ORDER
TO READ ENOUGH. THAT THE CASE
WITH IN WHICH THE. AWAY FROM AN
INDIVIDUAL NEIGHBOR FRIENDS OR
FAMILY MEMBERS MAY POSE A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO THAT
PERSON'S ABILITY TO RE
INTEGRATE INTO THE COMMUNITY
WHICH IS THE PURPOSE. OF
ALLOWING- THAT PERSON TO HAVE.
THEIR CONNECTION TO THIS MAN.
AT THE GEORGE MAY THERE IS A
BET WAY WILL COME THE AND OF
THIS. BY HAVING THE CRIMINAL
COURT TO. BURKE BUT CRIMINAL
INTO A CIVIL OR TO ALLOW THE
PROTECT FOR THE VICTIM EMAIN
IN A- AT. BLOG WRECK THAT SOME
IN AFFECT CAP START OVER FREE
THE CONTROL CRIMINAL. EIGHT
EIGHT A WOULD DENY MANY THE
THAT. WE WERE. ASK FOR YOUR NO
ABOUT. THANK YOU. AT THE- ANY
OTHER WITNESSES OPPOSITION. FOR
OTHER IN OUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ON YOUR TELEPHONE Q. NINE
ONE TWO FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
NINE ONE FIVE ARE YOU WHEN I'M
ON DISABILITY. THE ISRAELI VIA
WITH SEE WHAT JAY INSTRUCTS IN
SO UP AS- THANK YOU. I AM A
FOUR EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. D'AMICO O'DONNELL ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPUS PUBLIC NOT
ENOUGH TO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
AGAIN IF THERE ARE OTHER ME
PRESS ONE AND THEN. NO OTHERS
IN Q. AT THIS TIME SIR. THANK
YOU. WELL NOW TAKE QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN MEMBERS.
COLOR DOES NO. YOUR QUESTION
COMING OKAY. THANK YOU RIGHT. I.
I'M MIKE MIKE OF YET YES. I
WANTED YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FOR AND IT'S SOUNDED LIKE
I FROM SOME OF WITNESSES AND
THEN ALL FOR. UP WHAT WOULD IN
THE AND NOW THAT THERE COULD BE
BE OFFERED FOR A MAN AND I WAS
HOPE THAT MAYBE YOU CAN ADDRESS
YOUR CALL SOME OF THE- THAT
WERE RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION.
I THINK THE- SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE CONCERNING IS THE
ABILITY FOR A JUDGE TO
ESSENTIALLY RE OPEN A CASE. AND
THE METAL AROUND AND ACTUALLY
CHANGE THE TERMS. AND THERE
COULD BE CONVERGENCE TO BOTH
CIVIL JUDGMENTS AND CIVIL
ORDERS WHICH IN FACT YOU KNOW
EVEN AFTER- I'M A CASES CLOSE
WOULD STAY WITH THE DEFENDANT
FOR TEN YEARS ON TOP OF THE
FACT THAT- A JUDGE WOULD HAVE
THE DISCRETION TO REVOKE
PROBATION. SO I AM HOPING THAT
MAYBE YOU CAN ADDRESS OME OF
THOSE CONCERNS- AS THEY ARE
ONES THAT I ALSO THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THIS. ABOUT
THIS YOU MAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND THINK YOU TO
COME MEMBERS I DO WANT TO JUST
RESTATE THAT AB TWENTY EIGHT OH
EIGHT SIX TO CLARIFY THE OUR
CURRENT EXISTING LAW- IT WHEN
IT COMES TO THE VAGUENESS OF
THE EXISTING LAW. SO SURVIVORS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO RELY ON THE
PROTECTIVE ORDER THEY
SUCCESSFULLY PUT IN PLACE
AGAINST THEIR ASSAILANT
REGARDLESS OF THE DISPOSITION
OF THE ASSAILANTS PUNISHMENT.
NOW AS IT RELATES TO YOUR
CONCERNS WE HAVE WE DID RECEIVE
LAY OPPOSITION A COUPLE DAYS
AGO ONE WHICH WE WERE WILLING
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
GET TO A POINT WHERE WE COULD
COME TOGETHER. AS WHAT I TRY TO
DO AND ANY BILLS- THEY COME
BEFORE THIS BODY. AT WHEN IT
COMES TO THE TEN YEAR
PROTECTIVE ORDER AND AS YOU SAY
YOU ASKED THE QUESTION THE
CRIMINAL TO CIVIL. RESTRAINING
ORDER TO CONVERT THAT I WOULD
ACTUALLY. YOU KNOW I DON'T HAVE
A DIRECT RESPONSE AT THE MOMENT
BUT I KNOW THAT THE FOLKS ON
THE LINE TO BE ON THE LINE
THEY- HAVE THE EXPERIENCE AND
THEY WERE SHARING WITH ME THAT
THAT IS NOT THE CASE THAT THAT
CANNOT BE DONE HOWEVER. I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT- I KNOW THAT THEY
CAN THEMSELVES BUT GIVEN. I
KNOW THE TIME THAT WE HAVE I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY TO GET BACK TO
YOU. AS YOU. HAVE REQUESTED ON
THIS MATTER- BUT AGAIN WE ARE
JUST LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN
CONTINUE TO PROTECT SURVIVORS-
IN CASE THAT YOU KNOW. THIS IS
JUST MESSED A CASE IS DISMISSED.
JUDGES EXISTING LAW WHEN UNDER
EXISTING LAW JUDGES MAY DENY
MOTIONS TO DISMISS THE CASE
AGAINST THE SAILING ON ORDERED
TO LEAVE THE PROTECTIVE. I
ORDER IN PLACE RIGHT NOW SO
THIS WILL PREVENT AN ASSAILANT
FROM AXIS SEEN MANY GOVERNMENT
SERVICES- AND IN ANY CASE EVEN
APPLYING FOR A JOB SO INSTEAD
OF FORCING A JUDGE TO MAKE THAT
DIFFICULT DECISION. WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE CHORDS WE LEAVE
IT TO THE COURTS TO PROTECT- TO
KEEP THE PROTECTIVE ORDER IN
PLACE WHILE ALSO DISMISSING THE
CASE AGAINST THE ASSAILANT SO
THIS IS TRYING TO FIND THIS
MIDDLE GROUND. THEY WILL WORK
YOU KNOW TO PROTECT OF COURSE-
THE SURVIVOR BUT ALSO LOOKING
OUT YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE RIGHT NOW SO AGAIN I AM-MORE THAN HAPPY TO HAVE A
SEPARATE CONVERSATION SHOULD
THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD- TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN. PERHAPS
COME TO. A MIDDLE GROUND WITH
THE OPPOSITION. THAT IS WHAT I
AM WILLING TO DO. OKAY WE HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMITTEE.
THE CARD COMMENT THAT THE I'VE
GREATER FOR THE VICTIM FOR THAT
THIS BILL TAKE. EFFORT THE
WOMEN AGAIN THE PROBLEMATIC
PEOPLE AND- HARDLY SUPPORTED
AND MUCH OF FOR THIS THANK YOU.
IN AND I WANT THANK YOU TO FOR
IT FOR I'D- OTHERS WHO WORK
ABOUT THE OTHER SIDE BUT ALSO
WANT TO MAKE IT TO COPY. THAT
WE LOOK AT THIS AND MAKE IT
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR VICTIMS.
TO BE ABLE TO GET SOME SOME
PROTECTIONS AND SO I THINK
THAT'S WHAT MR LACKEY IS
TALKING ABOUT- WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME PROTECTING OTHERS
THAT THIS BILL DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING ELSE SO. THE FACT THAT
YOU ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH
THE OTHER SIDE MAKES IT MAKES
IS REALLY ENCOURAGING AND- BUT
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
DON'T BECOME TOO BUREAUCRATIC
BUT TO LEGAL OR TO WHATEVER. AT
AND IT MAKES IT EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT FOR VICTIMS TO BE
PROTECTED I THINK WE ALL SHARE
KIND OF THE SAME THING SO WITH
THAT THAT THE CHURCH RECOMMEND
AYE VOTE. REALLY BECAUSE OF HOW
WILLING YOU ARE TO. TO WORK
WITH THE OTHER SIDE. MAY CALL
THE ROLL. AND AB TWENTY EIGHT
OH EIGHT CERVANTES THE MOTION
IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER CHEN
SIR I LACKEY LACKEY AYE
BARRICADE HAN DEEP DEEP I
KAMLAGER. CAN'T. FOR MORE.
KAMLAGER VOTER AT THIS TO
CARILLO CAVIAR I SENT. WE THAT
BILLS ON CALL ONE MORE BILLS ON
WE- BUT THREE OTHER MEMBER. THE
WILL BE HERE SOON. NOW WE HAVE
UP NUMBER SEVEN MISTER THAT
WOULD BE FAR UNSAFE HAND GUNS.
GOOD MORNING MR IN CALI SEPT
YEAR AND OF TWO EIGHT FORTY.
THIS BILL WILL ASSIST LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SOLVING GUN
RELATED CRIMES AND REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF ACCIDENTAL GUN DEATHS
AND INJURIES IN OUR STATE. IN
CALIFORNIA AS THIS COMMITTEE
KNOWS MANY GUN CRIMES GO
UNSOLVED BECAUSE NO MATCHES
MADE BETWEEN EVIDENCE AT THE
SCENE AND A SUSPECT. IN FACT NO
REST FOR MADE IT IN HALF OF ALL
HOMICIDES. MY CRISTINA BEING IS
A CRIME SOLVING TOOL IMPRINTS A
UNIQUE STAMP ON A BULLET CASING
THROUGH THE FIRING PIN ALLOWING
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DEFINITIVELY
LINK. BULLET CASINGS TO A GUN.
THIRTEEN YEARS AGO OUR
LEGISLATURE PASSED A LAW
REQUIRING NEW FIREARMS TO
INCLUDE THIS FORENSIC MICRO
STAMPING TECHNOLOGY. ARE BILL
TODAY WOULD EASE COMPLIANCE FOR
MANUFACTURERS BY REQUIRING NEW
FIREARMS MY CRISTINA IN ONLY
ONE PLACE ON THE INTERIOR OF A
FIREARM AS OPPOSED TO TWO
PLACES. AS REQUIRED IN THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN LAW. IN ADDITION
THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE THAT ANY
NEW FIREARM SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
WILL FINALLY HAPPY CHAMBER LOAD
INDICATOR TO SIGNIFY WHEN A
FIREARM IS LOADED. AS WELL AS A
MAGAZINE DISCONNECT MECHANISM
TO PREVENT A GUN FROM FIRING
WHEN A DETACHABLE MAGAZINE IS
REMOVED. THESE ARE CONSUMER
SAFETY PROTECTIONS CRITICAL FOR
PREVENTING ACCIDENTAL SHOOTINGS.
FOR EACH NEW COMPLIANT HANDGUN
MODEL THAT'S INTRODUCED THIS
BILL WOULD DIRECT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO REMOVE THREE
PREVIOUSLY GRANDFATHER HANDGUN
MODELS FROM THE ROSTER OF GUNS
ALLOWED TO BE SOLD IN OUR STATE.
IN THE MIDST OF THIS PANDEMIC
GUN VIOLENCE UNFORTUNATELY
STILL PERSISTS ON THE STREETS
WITH VIOLENT CRIMES IN HOMES
WITH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
SUICIDES. AND TWO ACCIDENTS
FROM IMPROPERLY STORED GUNS.
THIS BILL WILL EQUIP LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WITH THE
TOOLS THEY REQUIRE TO QUICKLY
SOFT ON CRIME IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AS WELL AS REDUCE
ACCIDENTAL GUN DEATHS AND
INJURIES. WITHOUT A LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO A WITNESSES WE
HAVE HOPEFULLY ON THE LINE- THE
DA OF ALAMEDA COUNTY NANCY A
MAILING. AND THE PRESIDENT OF
BRADY CALIFORNIA MEDI SCOTT.
THANK YOU OF. THE OPEN PRO FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WATER
READER MORNING. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MADDIE SCOTT I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF CAL
UNITED AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE AND
MANY FAMILIES AND BY GUN CHOIR
I AM UNLESS. WHO LOST MY
YOUNGER SON GEORGE HE'S GOT A
TWENTY FOUR AND FATHER TO YOUNG
BOY TO GUN VIOLENCE ON JULY
THIRD NINETEEN SIX. ISSUE FOR
THE REST AND LET GO ONE LATER
BECAUSE THERE WASN'T ENOUGH
EVER. TO CONNECT TO THE USED IN
MY SON DEATH. CURRENTLY THERE%
ARE OVER TWO. UNFOLLOW COMMON
FROM FATAL SHOOT AT THAT BUT
THE ALONG. FROM ABOUT MOTHER
FATHER THAN FOR ALL THE ONE TO
GUN. SOME LAW ONE TWO A EVEN
THREE CHILL TO GO ON VIOLENCE
AND THEIR CASES REMAIN ON CALL.
GET CRIMINAL SUCH AS KILLERS
DOMESTIC ABUSERS GANG BANGERS
WHILE PREDICT CETERA CAUGHT
WITH THIS NEW MARK WITH. THE
TECHNOLOGY. CATCHING ON
CRIMINAL BEFORE THEY DO MORE
HARM. WE'LL SAVE COUNTLESS
LIVES IN A THAN FIVE YOU THE
GUN VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC IN OUR
STATE AND OUR NATION. CLEAN OUR
URGE YOU TO PASS AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN. BECAUSE ALL
LIVES MATTER. ALL LIVES MATTER.
ALL LIVES MATTER LET'S STOP THE
KILLING AND START THE HEALING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
MAGICALLY OUT IT. NEXT D. EIGHT
NANCY MALLON. I RECEIVED A TEXT
SAYING THAT SHE IS APPARENTLY
ON HOLD SO HOPEFULLY THE
OPERATOR CAN LETTER THROUGH THE
WHOLE MODERATOR COULD YOU THE
MODERATE. COULD YOU PLEASE LET
THE STEAM. DISTRIBUTOR THE FROM
ALAMEDA. ONE MOMENT I SEE
YOU'RE NOW. THE MALIBU'S GO AND
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I AM THE OF
THE O'MALLEY THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND CO SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT BECAUSE THIS BILL WILL
STRENGTHEN THE UNPAID CAN GOOD
ACTORS WHICH IS CRITICAL TO
PUBLIC SAFETY IN CALIFORNIA. AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU JUST
DESCRIBE THE BILL WILL ALIGN
FIREARMS MANUFACTURING
REQUIREMENT AT AND UPDATE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S UNSAFE HANDGUN ACT.
BOTH OF THESE BILLS IN THE PAST
ABOUT THE BILL IN THE PAST WAS
PASSED WITH THE SUPPORT OF ALL
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AS STATE AS
STATED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
NEWLY DEVELOPED SEMI AUTOMATIC
PISTOL MODELS WILL ETCH MICHAEL
STAMPING CHARACTERS ON ONE
PLACE RATHER THAN TO ON THE
INTERIOR OF THE FIREARM.
BECAUSE MICHAEL STAMPING
CREATES A UNIQUE ARRAY OF
CHARACTERS. THAT WILL LINK THE
SPENT TALENT CARTRIDGE CASING
TO A PARTICULAR FIREARM AND
MONTROSE MO WILL HAVE THE TOOLS
TO CONNECT BENT CARTRIDGES FROM
CRIME SCENES TO THE FIRE I'M
FROM WHICH THE BULLET WAS
FIRED. MY CHRISTIANITY WILL
IDENTIFY THE MAKE MODEL AND
SERIAL NUMBER OF THE FIREARM
WHICH WILL ALLOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO LINK NOT ONLY TO
THAT PARTICULAR CRIME BUT TO
MULTIPLE CRIME SCENE. AS WE
HAVE SEEN. THIS BILL MAKES
COMMONSENSE CHANGES TO ENHANCE
TOOLS THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS.
TO IDENTIFIES SHOOTER AND QUIRK
AND INVOLVED IN A CRIME. OUR
RESEARCH AND NATIONAL RICHARD
RICHARD TELLS US THAT MOST
FIREARMS USED IN CRIMES OR SOLO
ON. WHICH MAKES IT DIFFICULT TO
SOLVE CRIME. HELLO MY OFFICE IS
DONE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
RESEARCH ON GUNS AND GUN
pVIOLENCE. WE LOOK AT EIGHT
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO CASES IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN. THAT WAS
ONLY A PORTION OF THE GUN
INVOLVED CASES. HAPPEN THOSE
CASES ARE REGISTERED TO PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA BUT THE OTHER
HALF WERE NOT. AND WE HAD TO
RUN EACH CASE DONE BY GUN IN
ORDER TO AID IN SOLVING THE
CRIME. THIS IS NOT PRACTICAL
AND IT'S NOT EFFICIENT BUT WITH
MICRO STAFFING. THAT WE WILL
HAVE A BETTER OPPORTUNITY FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT EFFORT DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS. TO IDENTIFY THE
CRIMINALS WHO COMMITTED THE
CRIME TO APPREHEND THEM AND
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE. MICHAEL
STOPPING BULLETS WILL. WILL
IMPROVE THE DATABASE THAT CAN
REGISTERTHE MIKE FOR STAMP OF
A FIREARM FOR ALL THE FOR CRIME
SOLVING RATHER THAN HAVING TO
DO. CASE BY CASE DONE BY DONE
MY OFFICE IS DEDICATED TO
COMBATING THE EPIDEMIC OF GUN
VIOLENCE THAT PLAGUED THEIR
COMMUNITIES DROP COUNTY THE
STATE AND THE NATION. AND THE
FIRE RELATED CRIMES HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON VICTIMS
ON FAMILIES AND COMMUNITY AS A
WHOLE. AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN DIRECTLY ADVANCES PUBLIC
SAFETY AND- WE NOTE THE
DEVASTATION OF GUN VIOLENCE IN
OUR COMMUNITY. I'LL BE HAPPY
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICEWE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU. NOW
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES. IN
SUPPORT NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
WELL FIRST A LINE OF TWO TO
FOUR TO TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI JEANNIE MINOR ON
BEHALF OF THE DIFFERENCE LAW
CENTER TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL COMMENTS IN QUEUE
LINE TWO TWO SIX TO TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JIM
WOOD BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
SIX FOUR SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS ACTUALLY AIRED
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ON BEHALF OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE YOUR
BIRTH PARENTS HOUSE SUPPORT
ABOUT. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
NINETEEN TWO ONE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IRISH SHARP NEVER
AGAIN CA STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
TWENTY ONE TWO TO ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MR KERRY MEMBERS WILL
BE AT THE LEAST SHOP ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES CITY ATTORNEY
MIKE YOUR AUTHOR OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN LEGISLATION AND
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
ONE FIFTY SEVEN ONE FIVE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JULIA LAND- I AM LOOKING
ORGANIZATION MARCH ON LAST YEAR
MY FOUR YEAROLD GREAT NEPHEW
MAY BOND JACKSON GOT A HOLD OF
A HANDGUN IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
SHOT HIMSELF IN THE FOREHEAD- I
HAVE LOST FIVE. THE NEPHEWS
BETWEEN THE AGES OF FOURTEEN.
AND EIGHTEEN TO GUN VIOLENCE IN
THE CITY OF OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. LINE TWO
TWO TWO TWO TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOU GAVE YOUR
FIRST YEAR ON BEHALF OF
UTILIZED IN OAKLAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
LINE TWO TWENTY SEVEN TWO TWO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS DENTAL ECONOMY DIRECTOR OF
STATE AFFAIRS FOR THE COALITION%
TO STOP GUN VIOLENCE BUT HE HAS
TO BE A FROM WORKING MICROSTATE
BEEN MORE THAN A DECADE AND
SUPPORTED THE PERSONAL UNSAFE
HAD GONE ACT IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN WHEN WE ARE FULLY
SUPPORT. OF THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU. FILE COMMENTING QS
FROM TWO TWENTY THREE TWO TWO
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
REBECCA TWO FIFTY WELL ON
BEHALF OF THE VIOLENCE
PREVENTION COALITION OF ORANGE
COUNTY AND STRONG SUPPORT ABOUT.
THANK YOU. NOW ARE THERE OTHER
COMMENTS THAT THE- THANK YOU
START MEDICARE NOW. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES AN OPPOSITION I
HAVE ROY GRIFFITH SEE OUR PA
AND KATHY LYNCH FROM SPORTSMAN
LOBBY. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN IF KATHY WINS CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES SIR CAN. GOOD
MORNING- I'M REPRESENTING THAT
CALIFORNIA FOURTEENTH WHAT THE
OUTDOORS WORKING COALITION
INSOFAR CLUB INTERNATIONAL IN
OPPOSITION TODAY. WELL MICHAEL
STAMPING IS IN THE ON STATE
HANDGUN ACTED HAS NO FACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP TO HAND GUN SAFETY
IT IS A MERE PHYSICAL
CHARACTERISTICS. IT SEEMS THAT
THE LOGICAL THAT ADDING UP SEMI
AUTOMATIC WITH MICHAEL CAMPING
WOULD REQUIRE THREE HANDGUNS TO
BE REMOVED THE BILL REQUIRES
THAT HAND GOT SHALL BE REMOVED
IN REVERSE ORDER WHICH DOESN'T
APPEAR TO BE BASED ON ANY
SPECIFIC RATIONALE. DOJ WEBSITE
INDICATES THAT ARE A HUNDRED
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
HANDGUNS ON THE LEFT. BUT THE
PROBABLY LET'S LISTING DOES NOT
SHOW WHICH CAN GO WOULD BE
REMOVED FROM THE WEST FIRST.
AND NOT THE MANUFACTURE COULD
BE REMOVING EITHER A COMPETITOR
OR THEMSELVES FROM THE LEFT WHY
WOULD ANY BUSINESS DO THAT. CAN
THE AUTHOR INDICATE FROM THE
CURRENT LAN. WOULD HAND GUNS
WOULD BE REMOVED WILL THIS BE
TRANSPARENT TO THE PUBLIC OR
WILL THE PUBLIC LEARNED ABOUT
IT WHEN THEY TRIED TO PURCHASE
A HANDGUN. IT WILL MAKE THE
DETERMINATION THAT THE DATA SO
CURRENTLY EXIST IN THE DLJ THEM
IT. BILL BY THAT WISHING AT TO
ONE RATIO OF REMOVAL LIMIT
ACCESS TO SAFE AND GUN TO THE
PUBLIC FUNDS. UP LIKE. WHAT FOR
THE BACHELOR. START THAT MIKE
STAMP IS. AND RELY A- BUT THERE
TO GET BETWEEN HAVING THE- TO
EDGE CHARACTERS ON THE TIP OF A
FIRE PIN. AND WEATHER SO DO I
AS WELL AN UPPER DECK AND BY.
AND WHETHER IT TO ONE EDGING
IT'S STILL NOT WORKABLE. THE
ADDITION OF MICHAEL STAMPING TO
A CURRENTLY LISTED AS BILL
WOULD MAKE THE PISTOL THEIR NEW
MODEL THAT WOULD HAVE TO
UNDERGO NEW SAFETY TESTING
INCREASING COSTS TO CONSUMERS.
IT SEEMS THAT MEASURE COULD
INCREASE LITIGATION POTENTIAL
SINCE THE CRITERIA TO REMOVE. A
HANDGUN OF ARBITRARY BUT WOULD
CREATE A PUBLIC PERCEPTION THAT
THE HANDGUN HAS THE UNFOUNDED
STIGMA OF BEING UNSAFE. IF IT
WAS REMOVED. IN CLOSING THE
BILL DOESN'T HAVE ANY THE PLAN
BENEFIT TO CAN. AND THE NUMBER
ONE ISSUE RATE BY FORTUNATE
CONSUMERS IF THE DESIRE TO SEE
A MORE EXPANSIVE LEFT RATHER
THAN A DIMINISHING OFFERING.
WHICH WILL BE THE END RESULT A
BABY TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN.
WE URGE A NO VOTE ON THE BILL
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
AND I WISH EVERYONE WELL DURING
THE CHALLENGING TIME. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT. SORRY ANY WITNESSES.
IN OPPOSITION NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. GERMAN YOUR
HEARING YES. THIS IS YOUR GROUP
OF THE NUMBERS ON SPEAKING ON
THE OUT THE CALIFORNIA. SORRY
BUT NOT GO AHEAD I'M SORRY.
ALSO MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ORDER
BECAUSE WE CANNOT BE OUT OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIVAL DISASSOCIATION
OUR MEMBERS ROCK CALIFORNIA I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN. AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN WILL
REVISE THE CRITERIA FUND STATE
HAND GUNS BY REQUIRING THE
MICHAEL STAMP TO BE IMPRINTED
ON ONE PLACEMENT HANG AND
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOR EVERYONE ADDED FOR
THREE TO BE REMOVED. LOW J.
MAINTAIN THE ROSTER'S. HANDGUNS
FOR CALIFORNIA HANG ON IS NOT
ON THAT ROSTER CANNOT BE
PURCHASED FROM A LICENSED
DEALER. TOOK PLACE ON THE
ROSTER HEARING AND MUST BE
SUBMITTED TO THE DOJ FOR
TESTING AND SATISFY CERTAIN
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS. CLEARLY
LESS THAN EIGHT HUNDRED GUNS ON
THIS LIST A DECREASE FROM A
HIGH OF FOURTEEN HUNDRED. WE
ALL KNOW IN TWO DOLLARS SEVEN
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER SIGNED
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE THAT
REQUIRED SEMI AUTOMATIC PISTOL
TO BE QUICK BUT MICHAEL
STAMPING TECHNOLOGY. THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE PROVIDED
THIS REQUIREMENT BECOME
EFFECTIVE WHEN THE DOJ
CERTIFIES. TECHNOLOGY USED TO
CREATE A MICHAEL STAMPED
IMPRINT. IS AVAILABLE FOR MORE
THAN ONE MANUFACTURER NOT
ENCUMBERED BY ANY PATHWAYS
DIRECTIONS. THIS CERTIFICATION
DID NOT HAPPEN UNTIL TWENTY
THIRTEEN. THIS TECHNOLOGY IS A
MICROSD AMPLE ARRAY OF
CHARACTERS THAT IDENTIFY MAKE
MODEL AND SERIAL NUMBER OF THE
PISTOL. AND CURRENT CALIFORNIA
LAW REQUIRES MEAN PRINTED ON
TWO OR MORE PLACES ON THE INTER
SERVICE OR INTERNAL WORKING
PARTS OF PISTOL. AND THAT THEY
ARE TRANSFERRED. BY THE CARD
FROM CARTRIDGE THAT FAR ONE IS
FOR. GEN RICHARD ONLY THIRTEEN
MENU ATTEMPTED TO INFORM THE
TECHNOLOGY TO BASIC YET
DRAMATIC INCONSISTENCIES THAT
SPEAK TO MICHAEL STAMPEDE
INTENDED PURPOSE. FORENSIC
SCIENCE CONFIRM THAT THE MARKS
LEFT BY THE INTERNAL COMPONENTS
OF THE GUN ARE ALTERED AFTER
NORMAL USE AND WHICH CAN BE
RENDERED THE MICHAEL STAMP ON
RELIABLE. NOT TO MENTION A
CRIMINAL OF THE FILE COULD
EASILY. DEFEAT THE MICHAEL
STAMP ITSELF. IMPORTANCIA IS
THE TECHNOLOGY WERE VIABLE THE
PRICE OF PRODUCTION WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE COST
TO FARMS CONSTRUED CONCERN
WITH. THE GUARANTEE THAT THE
CORRECT PARTS FOR EXAMPLE
FIRING PINS AND SLIDES WITH
EXACTLY MATCHES CHERYL NUMBER
OF THE HANDGUN FRAME DURING
MANUFACTURING PROCESS IS OUR
PRIMARY CONCERN. WELL THEN THE
SIMPLE COST OF APPLYING THE
MICHAEL STAMP TECHNOLOGY.
FURTHER AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN LOSE THREE FIREARMS FROM
THE ROSTER THAT ARE NOT IN
COMPLYING WITH KURT MICHAEL
STAMP REQUIREMENTS FOR EACH ONE
NEW FARM ARE ADDED TO THE
ROSTER. THIS RECORD WAS JUST
NOT BOUGHT OUT. THE ASPECT OF
TWENTY FORTY SEVEN WILL FURTHER
COMPOUND THE SITUATION BY
REMOVING THESE THREE TIME
TESTED AND DESIRED FIREARMS
FROM THE ROSTER BY THE RELEASE
DATE WHICH ISN'T DO NOT AT ALL
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THE QUALITY
OR INTENDED APPLICATION THE
FARM THIS ONLY PULL THE REDUCED
AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE
WHILE RELIABLE HANDGUNS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE MICHAEL
STANDING RECORD ALONE HINDERS
MARKET FORCES ANDLIMITS DOT
POLAND TECHNOLOGICALLY SUPERIOR
FIREARM TO CALIFORNIANS.
REMOVAL FARMS FURTHER
DEVASTATED THE FREE MARKETPLACE
FOR QUALITY PRODUCTS RISE TO
THE TOP. YOUR OVER PRICE MARKET
PRODUCTS FAILED TO SAVE YOUR
CALIFORNIANS IS AT THE VERY
FOUNDATION OF OUR ORGANIZATION
AND HAS BEEN. CONSISTENT GOAL
TO WORK WITH FOR COMMON SENSE
SOLUTIONS REGARDING THE ISSUE
OF CRIME AND FARM OWNERSHIP.
THIS CAN BE DONE- EVER WITHOUT
SACRIFICING CALIFORNIANS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS ON
ABILITY A LAW ABIDNG CITIZENS
PROTECT THEIR FAMILIES AND
OPERATE A LAWFUL BUSINESS AND
PROVIDE FIREARMS ARE SAFE
AFFORDABLE PRICE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. FOR THE FOREGOING
REASONS THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
PISTOL SO SHE SHE STANDS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO TWENTY
FORTY SEVEN AND URGES YOUR
NOBLE ON THIS BAD PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SIR. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION. ODD NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. OF BEST MODERATOR
THANK YOU. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN THEY'RE ALL WILL GO
FIRST THE LINE OF TWO TWO ZERO
TWO TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
I HAVE TO BEG YOUR FORGIVENESS-
BUT THE TECHNICAL GLITCH I
THINK HAVE GOTTEN IN THE WRONG
COMMENT SECTION. THE FLOOR AND
LEAVE AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF WOMEN AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE
AND I WAS CALLING TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT. OF AB TWO
EIGHT FOUR SEVEN I WANT TO
REITERATE AGAIN THAT WOMEN
AGAINST GUN BAN BY ONE OF. THE
PORT AB. TWO TWO EIGHT FOUR
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
NOTED. ARE THERE ANY OTHERS NOT
ONLINE ONE EIGHT. THERE ARE A
FEEL GOOD ONLINE ONE EIGHT FIVE
ONE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS MICHAEL
FINLEY AND THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION WHERE THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION PROMOTES GUN
MANUFACTURERS RANGES AS WELL AS
RETAILERS. WERE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS WEEK'S MEDIC
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THAT LAYS OUT
OUR CASES AS WELL AS THE
STUDIES THAT SHOW WHY THIS
ISN'T VIABLE. COSTLY AND THE
TECHNOLOGY DOESN'T EXIST
CURRENTLY AND WE- WE HOPE THAT
EVERYBODY VOTES AGAINST THIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
SIR. I AM FORTY FOUR FOUR FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD YOUR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD THE
AND READ WITH NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION HERE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TODAY. A LITTLE BIT
IRONIC THAT AT THE SAME TIME
WERE. LETTING WITH MICROCEPHALY
REQUIREMENTS FOR EXEMPTING FOR-
FOR AGENCIES SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING BOARD
PUBLIC FELT THAT. IMPORTANT
DIVISION BIG CETERAIN ANOTHER
BUILDING WHEN OUR COMPETITOR
BUT THAT ONE OPPOSITION THANK.
YOU'RE WELCOME THANK YOU. LINE
SIXTY FIVE LINE SIX FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER MEMBER CAN'T
CREDIT ANY GOVERNMENT'S
CALIFORNIA EXPRESSING STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL- IN
PREVIOUS TESTIMONY WE'VE WE
POINTED OUT ALL OF THE
DIFFICULTIES AND THE
INCONSISTENCIES WITH THIS
TECHNOLOGY SO WE AREN'T STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SAM. BLIND. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE TWO TWO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THERE ARE MANY
CHAIRPERSON FOR THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO SHE OPIATE CHAPTER
AND IN OUR MEMBERS STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN Q. OKAY IT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS. YOU MAY CLOSE
MASSACHUSETTS THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION OF
THIS COMMITTEE- LET ME JUST
TAKE A MOMENT AND THANK- THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN- THE GIFFORD
CENTER ALL OF THE GUN SAFETY
ADVOCATES INCLUDING MANY SCOTT
WHO TESTIFIED TODAY AND- ALL OF
THOSE FAMILY MEMBERS OF VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS OF GUN VIOLENCE
ALSO A TAKE A MOMENT AND THANK
OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE YOUR
TO SERRA AND HIS DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL- AS WELL AS OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS LED BY-
DA O'MALLEY FROM ALAMEDA
COUNTY- THIS IS A BILL THAT
WILL EQUIP LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WITH THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO QUICKLY SOLVE. THE GUN
CRIMES THAT WE NEED SOLVED IN
OUR COMMUNITIES IT WILL ALSO
HELP TO REDUCE ACCIDENTAL
DEATHS AND INJURIES DUE TO
FIREARMS- WITH THE SAFETY
FEATURES THAT WE DISCUSSED AND-
AND I WOULD SUBMIT THIS IS A
VERY COMMON SENSE GUN PROPOSAL
AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT. THEIR SECOND. BUT AND
I WANT THANK YOU YOU YOU YOU TO
HAVE DONE SOMETHING I RARELY
SEE. YOU'VE GOT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. IN TO DO HARM TO
JUSTICE. TO COME OUT TO COME IN
AND HELP YOU IMPLEMENT THIS-
JUST IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT
ESPECIALLY WITH THE- DIFFICULTY
OF BUDGETS AND EVEN IN GOOD
TIMES WE HAD BUDGETS- BEING
ABLE TO SUPPORT A LOT OF WHAT
TO DO J. WANTS TO DO. WHAT TO
DO- THE FACT THAT YOU'VE GOT
THAT BY AND EARLY IS. REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW SO I
COMMEND YOU ON. ON BEING ABLE
TO DO THAT THAT FOR ME THAT'S A
HUGE CONSIDERATION
IMPLEMENTATION. WHICH I THINK
IS WHAT THE OPPOSITION WAS
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT NOT
ONLY. OF BEING ABLE TO DO IT TO
MAKE SURE IT'S DONE CORRECTLY
AND SO IT IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU
WANT TO WORK WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. TO ENSURE THAT THE
INVITATION PART- DOES NOT HE-
THAT WE NEED DONE TO GET THIS
DONE. TO MAKE EVERYTHING SAFE
SO THE CHURCH RECOMMEND AND I
VOTE THANK YOU WE REALLY DID
WORK HARD TO MAKE SURE THIS
DOES WORK FOR DOJ AS WELL AS
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND I. ALSO
WANT TO VERY MUCH- THANK THE
ORIGINAL AUTHOR OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN BILL- THE
CURRENT CITY ATTORNEY OF MY
CURE CREWMEMBER THIS BODY UP
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND WORKING
WITH US AS WELL. THANK YOU YOU
MAY CALL THE ROLL. ON AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN BY CHIU THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
NO LACKEY NOPE BAUER-KAHAN.
DEEP KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I KALLIO
DARIO I SANTIAGO. WICKS THAT
MEASURES ON COLONIES TO
MEASURES ON CALL. THANK YOU.
NOW WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER NINE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL. THAT'S
ANOTHER FIREARMS GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER CORRECT. AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY BEGIN
GREAT STATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TODAY 2% AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTEEN A BILL THAT WILL HELP
TO SAVE LIVES BY STRENGTHENING
AND CLARIFYING CALIFORNIA LAW
REGARDING GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS. MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTEEN WILL HELP TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA HONORS AND
ENFORCES LAWFUL G. VIEIRA WAS
THAT ARE ISSUED IN OTHER STATES
SO THAT THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
DEEMED A THREAT TO THEMSELVES
OR OTHERS CANNOT EASILY OBTAIN
FIREARMS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NOW A G. R. O. S.
JUDICIAL ORDER THAT ALLOWS LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO TEMPORARY REAL
TEMPORARILY REMOVE FIREARMS.
FROM AN INDIVIDUAL WHO POSES AN
IMMINENT RISK OF HARM TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS. WHEN USED
TO THEIR FULL POTENTIAL JEEP
HEROES ARE POWERFUL TOOL THAT
CAN PREVENT MASS SHOOTINGS AND
SUICIDES AND SAVE LIVES. LAST
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED AND GOVERNOR
NEW SOME SIGNED INTO LAW AB ONE
SIX FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES. WHICH PROHIBITS
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA FROM
PURCHASING OR POSSESSING
FIREARMS. IF THEY'RE SUBJECT TO
RESTRAINING ORDER IN ANOTHER
STATE FOR ACTS INCLUDING
HARASSMENT WORKPLACE VIOLENCE
SCHOOL VIOLENCE AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IF THE OUT OF STATE
ORDER INCLUDES A FARM
PROHIBITION. AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTEEN BUILT ON THAT PRIOR
LEGISLATON AND THE FEDERAL
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN ACT BY
EXTENDING THAT VERY SAME
PROHIBITION TO INDIVIDUALS ARE
SUBJECT TO AN OUT OF STATE TV
ARE OUT. THIS EXTENSION IS A
MODEST AND PRACTICAL TEP THAT
WILL ENSURE CONSISTENCY AND
CLARITY IN THE LAW AND HELP
KEEP CALIFORNIANS SAFE.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE GUNS AND
GUN VIOLENCE TOO OFTEN CROSS
STATE LINES. INDEED LAST YEAR'S
MATCH SHOOTING AT THE GILROY
GARLIC FESTIVAL WAS A PAINFUL
REMINDER THAT INTERSTATE
COOPERATION ON GUN VIOLENCE IS
ESSENTIAL TO SAVING LIVES. THIS
BILL SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION
GROUPS INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SERVICE
ASSOCIATION. THE DIFFERENCE
LAWCENTER THE BRADY CAMPAIGN
MOMS DEMAND ACTION AND MARK FOR
OUR LIVES. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION ARE TIFFANY
MATTHEWS LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION. AND
ALEXANDER WALKER GRIFFIN
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR MARK FOR
A LIVES THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. OF MISTER
MODERATOR WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
FOR UP TO WITNESSES. AND YOUR
LIFE TO OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MACINNES ON HALF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBER AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL FOR THE CHANCE
TO PROVE THAT AND THE POOR AND
AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN. WELL
CALIFORNIA HAS RECOGNIZED OTHER
FORMS A PROTECTIVE ORDER IS.
LIKE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS FROM OTHER
STATE. IT IS NOT PROVIDED
AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE TV ARE
ISSUED BY OTHER STATE. HEROES
ARE IMPORTANT TOOL IN REDUCING
GUN VIOLENCE. BY ALLOWING THE
TEMPORARY REMOVAL OF FIREARMS
FROM AN INDIVIDUAL WHERE THEIR
STUFF LIKE EVIDENCE THAT SUCH
PERSON MAY BE A DANGER TO
HIMSELF OR OTHERS. NO REASON IN%
AN INDIVIDUAL SUBJECT TO AN OUT
OF STATE TV ARE- OR SIMILAR
ORDER SHOULD HAVE A GUN IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL WOULD
IMPOSE CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
FIVE YEAR PROHIBITION ON
POSSESSION OF FIREARMS OR
AMMUNITION ON ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO VIOLATE THE VISION.
COMMONSENSE PUBLIC SAFETY
LEGISLATION THAT RIGHT
INCREASED CONTACTS AND THE
CALIFORNIA BEGAN GUN VIOLENCE.
WELL ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
CURRENTLY ARE GRAPPLING WITH
THE CODE IN NINETEEN CRISIS THE
EFFORT TO REDUCE TE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY
EMERGENCY OF GUN VIOLENCE
REMAINS A TOP PRIORITY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU.
ALEXANDER WALKER GRIFFIN. I
THINK HE WAS GOING TO DO THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY. YEAH OKAY.
HOW DO YOU DO MODERATOR HOW DO
YOU DO THE- WELL. UP THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SO NUMBER GABRIEL FOR THE
CHANCE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN. I AM
PROUD TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF MARK FOR
A LOT OF CALIFORNIA. IN
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION RESTRAINING ORDERS
ARE AN IMPORTANT TOOL TO HELP
PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE ARE
COMMITTEES TODAY AT LEAST
SIXTEEN STATES HAVE SIMILAR
LAWS MINI MALL AFTER OUR BILL.
ADOPTED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
HOWEVER SOMEONE BECOMES
PROHIBITED IN ANOTHER STATE AS
A RESULT OF THAT STATE'S GB
ARLES THEY STILL MAY BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE EFFORTS AS FIREARMS IN
CALIFORNIA EVEN WITH THAT
RESTRICTION IN PLACE. THIS BILL
WOULD ADDRESS THAT ISSUE BUT
MAKE IT AN OFFENSE TO POSSESS A
FIREARM. IN VIOLATION OF A
PROTECTIVE ORDER ISSUED BY
ANOTHER STATE. BY PROVIDING A
FIVE YEAR BAN ON PURCHASING OR
POSSESSING FIREARMS OR
AMMUNITION IN VIOLATION OF.
THAT OUT OF STATE ORDER THIS
BILL WOULD SUPPORT THE STEPS
THE STATE IS ALREADY TAKEN TO
PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE. AND
INCREASED PUBLIC SAFETY. THIS
BILL CAN BE THE REASON A SPOUSE
DOESN'T BECOME A VICTIM OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. OR TEAM LOSE
THEIR LIFE IN A SENSELESS
SHOOTING WE STRONGLYSUPPORT
THIS LEGISLATION. I THINK IT'S
ONLY NUMBER DAY BEFORE HIS
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
NAME AN ORGANIZATION. WE HAVE
SOMEONE HERE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. THE MORNING ABOUT
COMARCAS REPRESENTING BRADY
UNITED AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. A
MODERATE DO YOU HAVE ANYONE
ONLINE. WE HAVE A NUMBER CUED
UP TAKE YOU OUT WE WERE LINE TO
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS TRISTEN
BROWN CALIFORNIA YOUR TEACHERS
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU WILL GO
TO BUYING TO THIRTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR KAREN MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH LOWER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AND REPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MY SEVENTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
CLIFF YOU KNOW I'M A SURVIVOR
WITH SAN FRANCISCO MOMS DEMAND
ACTION TO HONOR MY SON TOO MANY
LOG STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND NEXT TWO POINT TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ENGINE MINOR ON BEHALF OF THE
DIFFERENT LAW CENTER TO PREVENT
GUN. VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT EIGHT.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
EIGHTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. IN A
KELLY ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY
OF VALUE CORD. THANK YOU. WHAT
LINE TO THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SYLVIA SO WE SHOT ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES CITY
ATTORNEY MIKE YOUR IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING ARE
RATHER AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIZABETH
ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WHY TO ELEVEN
YOU ARE OPEN. HI SANDRA
REPRESENTING BONTA MAN ACTION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BUILDING ON JULY MONO TO. AS
CHAIR RIGHT SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S LOCATION.
THANK YOU. TWO TWENTY TWO YOU
ARE NOW OPEN. TWO TWENTY TWO IS
YOUR PHONE MUTED. ONE MORE
CHANCE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO
TWENTY TWO. YES THIS IS GABRIEL
WITH YOU TO LIVE IN OAKLAND AND
STRONG SUPPORT. AND WE WERE
LINE SIXTY THREE. MY NAME IS
KAREN BUT MODEL I'M FROM WEST
SACRAMENTO IN A VOLUNTEER WITH
YELLOW COUNTY OF MOMS DEMAND
ACTION. IF ME AND I'M IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEARLY
THE ORDER AND THE RIDER IN
MONTHLY AND ACTION VOLUNTEER
FROM LOS ANGELES DONALD BEFORE.
ONE SEVEN THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR OPEN. HI THIS
IS THE FOURTH MAN FROM MARIN
MOMS DEMAND ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT. WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE ZERO FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
CHRISTINE WARD FROM CRIME
VICTIMS ALLIANCE WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CELL
THANK YOU. TWO THIRTY SEVEN YOU
ARE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THIS IS JIM LIMBURG ON
BEHALF OF THE FRENCH COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. TWO THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHERIN
RIGHTLY ON BEHALF OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE COUNCIL IS
PLEASED WITH FORTY SPONSORED
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
REQUIRING TEMPORARY G. B. R. O.
TO BE FILED WITH THE COURT
WITHIN THREE DAYS OF INSURANCE
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND WITHOUT THE WORKING
WITH US ON THIS AS WELL AS- THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. AND LINE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
NINETY FIVE CAN YOU HEAR. HI I
THINK THEY TOOK THEMSELVES ARE
THE QUEUE THERE ARE NO OTHER
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
WITH THIS. IN OPPOSITION I HAVE
THAT FEATURE IS THE TELEPHONE.
FIVE FIVE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
KATHY SHARP FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WE RESPECTFULLY MUST
OPPOSE AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN-
I WANT TO START BY THANKING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL AND HIS
STAFF FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH US ON OUR CONCERNS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THEM ON
AMENDMENTS. ARE CONCERNED WITH
THIS BILL ARE TWO FOLD FOR SOME
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUBJECT TO A
DVR- IN ANOTHER STATE MAY NOT
HAVE NOTICED THAT THEY REMAIN
SUBJECT TO THE RESTRICTIONS
ABOUT ORDER EVEN AFTER MOVING
TO CALIFORNIA SUCH AN
INDIVIDUAL COULD BELIEVE HIM OR
HERSELF BE ABLE TO LAWFULLY BUT
THAT THE FIREARM- ONLY TO
BECOME SUBJECT TO CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION FOR DOING. WELL
SECOND STATE VERY WIDE ACT THE
PROCEDURE THE STANDARDS FOR
ISSUANCE OF A GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER. MANY STATE
FELL OUT IF YOU WANT TO SUCH AN
ORDER USING A PREPONDERANCE OF
THE EVIDENCE STANDARD. THE
PROCEDURE DONE OTHER STATE MAY
NOT BE SUFFICIENT TO PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF THOSE- SUCH AS
THOSE WHO DO NOT SPEAK ENGLISH
OR FOR OTHER REASONS HAD
DIFFICULTY UNDERSTANDING WHAT
IS AT STAKE AND PROTECTING
THEIR RIGHTS IN COURT.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT IMPOSE
CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR
VIOLATION OF AN ORDER THAT
NEVER WOULD HAVE BEEN ISSUED AT
THE PROCEEDINGS HAD TAKEN PLACE
CALIFORNIA. AT THE THEREFORE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NOBLE.
THANK YOU. AND ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
NAME AN ORGANIZATION MISTER
MODERATOR. THE BILL. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS STAR AND SKEWS ME
ONE NINE ZERO ONE AND ZERO
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THEY TOOK
THEMSELVES OUT TO KEEP UP NOT A
CAME TAX SORRY ONE SECOND
PLEASE. WITH. TAKE IT ONLINE
NUMBER TO GET OFF A MUTE. THERE
WITH THE OPERATOR ONE SECOND
PLEASE OKAY. AND WE'LL GO TO
ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
FIFTY FOUR. JANUARY TERRACE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SIR.
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
CUED UP AT THIS TIME. THEN WILL
BRING YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FOR MANY THE
MEMBERS. MISS COM AUGER. YEAH I
WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR.
CONTACTING ME ABOUT THIS BILL
AND I'M FOR TALKING WITH ME
ABOUT IT AND I HOPE IN YOUR
CLOTHES YOU CAN ADDRESS. SOME
OF THE COMMENTS THAT- WERE
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION- AS I
MENTIONED TO THE AUTHOR I AM I
AM GOING TO GIVE A COURTESY AYE
VOTE- TODAY AND COMMITTEE BUT
HOPING THAT THE AUTHOR CAN WORK
WITH. THE OPPOSITION ON SOME OF
THE AMENDMENT SPECIFICALLY
THOSE THAT SPEAK TO THE FACT
THAT THERE IS A REQUIREMENT TO
PROMPTLY ACT THIS INFORMATION
INTO THE DOJ DATABASE BUT
THERE'S NOT THE SAME
CONSIDERATION GIVEN TO TAKING
IT OFF WHEN THEY'VE EXPIRED. WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO HAVE
DATABASES CHOCK FULL OF FOLKS
WHO HAVE REHABILITATED WHO
HAVE- SERVED THEIR TIME AND
DONE WHAT THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO
DO. AND ARE STILL- IN THE
SYSTEM IT SAYS MUCH ABOUT
ENFORCEMENT AS IT IS ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND JUST
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE ARE
NUANCES TO OUR OWES ACROSS
STATE LINES AND HOPING THAT
THAT'S ALSO GIVEN SOME
CONSIDERATION. I JUST WANT TO
SAY ON THE OUTSIDE THAT WHILE%
WE CONTINUE TO ALWAYS HAVE GONE
BILLS BECAUSE WE WANT TO
PROTECT. VICTIMS WHO ARE
SPOUSES AND WHO ARE PARTNERS
AND WHO ARE. JUST UNWITTING
FOLKS I HOPE THAT WE'RE GIVING
THE SAME CONSIDERATION FOR
FOLKS WHO ARE JOGGING IN THEIR
OWN NEIGHBORHOODS AND DON'T
DESERVE TO YOU LOSE THEIR
LIVES. AND IF WE CAN COME TO A
SPACE WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT
BILLS ARE ALSO PROTECT THOSE
KINDS OF FOLKS. I THINK WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD AND HAVING A SAFER
COMMUNITY FOR ALL OF US THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. YOU MAY
CLOSE MISS TO BE RIPPED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN
TO THE COMMITTEE AND ALSO TO-
MY CLICK FROM LOS ANGELES THANK
YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR VOTING
FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS
I'LL JUST TAKE A MOMENT- TO
ADDRESS SOME OF YOUR CONCERNS
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP BY THE
OPPOSITION AND I KNOW OTHERS
I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH. A
SPECIFICALLY IN THE DUE PROCESS
ISSUE SO- IN RESPONSE TO THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE YOU KNOW THEY
HAD TWO MAIN CONCERNS ONE
ABOUT- ONE OF THEM HAD TO DO
WITH THE DATABASES- JUST I
THINK THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES THIS BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS
THE DATABASE IF YOU AT ALL
THAT'S ALREADY CODIFIED IN
CURRENT STATUTE. THERE'S A
PROVISION THAT WAS ADDED TO
THIS BILL THE TO THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL REFERENCED THAT
REQUIRES FOR TEMPORARY
EMERGENCY RESTRAINING ORDERS
THAT THOSE BE FILED WITH THE
COURT WITHIN THREE DAYS AND NOT
ACTUALLY STRENGTHENED DUE
PROCESS PROTECTION FOR- FOR GUN
OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS A TIMELY
HEARING ON WHETHER OR NOT THERE
SHOULD BE A CONTINUING TV ARE
OUT SO I THINK THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT OF CONFUSION THERE. ARE
BILL DOESN'T TOUCH THE DATABASE
ISSUE IT SOUNDS TO ME FROM THAT
LETTER LIKE THERE MIGHT BE
SOME- OR THE EFFORTS TO LOOK
INTO THAT AND TO TRY TO CLEAN
UP THOSE DATABASES BUT THIS
BILL DOESN'T DOESN'T TOUCH THAT
ISSUE- THE SECOND OBJECTION HAS
TO DO WITH CROSS REFERENCING
OUT OF STATE PROCEDURES- IT'S A
WELL TAKEN POINT- YOU KNOW
THERE CERTAINLY ARE DIFFERENCES
FROM STATE TO STATE- AND I'M
COMMITTED TO IN PARTICULAR
WORKING WITH THE ACLU TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT I'M YOU KNOW I SPENT
SIGNIFICANT TIME IS AN
ATTORNEY. I PRIOR TO COMING TO
THE LEGISLATURE ON CASES
UPHOLDING DUE PROCESS RIGHTS I
THINK DUE PROCESS PROTECTIONS
ARE CENTRAL LOOK FOR TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS- I WILL MENTION
AGAIN THIS BILL BUILT ON AB ONE
SIXTY FOUR WHICH WAS UNANIMOUS
PASSED THE LEGISLATURE THIS I
REMEMBER THE COMMITTEE FOR THAT
I'LL TWICE AND I DID THIS THING
WHICH LOOKED AT YOU KNOW REALLY
ENFORCE OUT OF STATE BORDERS
IT'S ACTUALLY HARD YOU'LL NOT
IN THE- HOUSE UNDER. THE LAW
THE VINYL IS WOMEN SO THIS IS
OUR SOMETHING THAT ARE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS REQUIRED
TO DO UNDER FEDERAL LAWS TO
GIVE FULL FAITH AND CREDIT TO
THOSE OUT OF STATE I GDR ROSE
AND IN SOME WAYS HAVE A
DIFFERENT STANDARD HERE WOULD
CREATE A PERVERSE INCENTIVE AND
WHERE YOU HAVE THE STRONGEST
PROTECTIONS. FOR THE MOST DAY.
PEOPLE FOR THE FOLKS WHO OF
OTHER IN OTHER STATES HAVE.
DETERMINED TO BE. AN IMMINENT
READ. OF LIKELY HARM TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS SO. VERY
EAGER TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS- YOU KNOW WE HAD
ASKED. THE OPPOSITION ABOUT WHY
THEY WERE NOT IN OPPOSITION TO
AB ONE SIX FOUR AND WE'RE
OPPOSITION TO THIS WE HAVEN'T
HEARD A RESPONSE YET SO I'M-
I'M CURIOUS TO HEAR FROM THEM
ABOUT. WHY THEY'RE TAKING A
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO A BILL
THAT. YOU KNOW THE OLD WAS
UNANIMOUSLY ENDORSED BY BY THE
LEGISLATURE LASTYEAR. GET
APPOINTED MAKERS THAT THE
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENTS
DON'T CHANGE FROM STATE TO
STATE. RIGHT THE DUE PROCESS
CLAUSE OF THE FIFTH AND
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT. PRESCRIBE
EXACTLY WHAT IS- ALLOWED AND
NOT ALLOWED. AND YOU KNOW IF
THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ADEQUACY OF PROCESS AND OTHER
STATES THEN I THINK THAT THE
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE THERE'S
FOR THE A SO YOU'RE OTHERS TO
BRING SUIT CHALLENGING THOSE
PURPOSE. CHALLENGING THE
SUFFICIENCY. OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS
AVAILABLE NO STATE SO- I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF. OF IT YOU
KNOW. POINTS HERE TO CONSIDER
AND I JUST WANTED TO ADD A
LITTLE BIT OF. THAT CONTEXT.
THE FINAL THING. I DON'T KNOW
IF THE OPPOSITION IN THE BASING
THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT TO PROCESS
MISS THE PART THAT WE HAVE
DIFFERENT TRADITIONAL COUNCIL.
BUT THIS BILL ACTUALLY AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE STRENGTHENS
DUE PROCESS PROTECTIONS FOR GUN
OWNERS ARE CALIFORNIA. REQUIRES
UNIFORMITY AND CONSISTENCY
REQUIRES. THAT YOU THAT IT THAT
ATTEMPT EMERGENCY G. VERO BE
FILED WITH THE COURT WITHIN
THREE DAYS. MAKING SURE THAT
THERE IS A HEARING- AND THAT
THAT PERSON HAS NOTICE AND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD SO I
WOULD ARGUE FOR FOLKS ARE
WORRIED ABOUT DUE PROCESS- THIS
IS THE STRONG VOTING FOR THIS
BILL AS A WAY TO ACTUALLY
INCREASE DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS FOR CALIFORNIANS
FOR THE RESIDENTS. OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE CONSTITUENTS
THAT WE SERVE- SO WITH THAT
AGAIN BAD. YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD
AGREE THAT THERE ARE SOME SOME
THINGS TO THINK ABOUT HERE ANY
OPPOSITION- TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY- THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THEM TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS. AND YOU KNOW
BECAUSE THESE ARE PROCEDURAL
ISSUES I THINK THERE ARE THINGS
THAT WE CAN PROBABLY ADDRESS
PRETTY EASILY LEGISLATIVE LATE.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE'S A
REASON WE CAN'T DO BOTH HAVE
ADEQUATE DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS. AND ALSO- PROTECT
FOLKS FROM FROM FROM GUN
VIOLENCE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE WHO. YOU KNOW WHO ARE
POSSESS A- ARE POTENTIALLY REAL
REST TO THEMSELVES AND OTHERS.
ARE NOT ARE NOT THREATENING
THEMSELVES ARE OR FOLKS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I THINK
WE CAN HAVE BOTH. EAGER TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME TO EXPLORE. AND
RESPECT. DRIVE OUT. THANK YOU
AND- IT SOUNDS LIKE NOT ONLY
WELL VERSED TO DETER YOU
WILLING TO GO THROUGH ALL THE-
DEEP DOWN DIE THAT YOU NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS GETS DONE
SO THE CHURCH RECOMMEND AND I
VOTE. I'M READY TO NERD OUT
WITH THEM ON. IT YES YOU ARE.
CALL THE ROLL AND AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTEEN GABRIEL THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JOHN SIR
HI LACKEY ARE LACKEY AYE
BARRICADE HAND. DEEP DEEP I
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I CARILLO
CARILLO I THANK SANTIAGO. WICKS
DOUBLE GETS OUT FIVE ZERO
GRADUATION SHOULD BUILD UP
THANK YOU MR TRUMP. NOW MR
GIPSON. A. B. TWO SIX FIVE FIVE
INVASION OF PRIVACY FIRST
RESPONDERS. ARE YOU READY TO
BEGIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
PRESENT. TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WE BILL
TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE WHICH
SEEKS TO PROHIBIT FIRST
RESPONDERS OR AND ON THE JOB
FROM TAKING PERSONAL PHOTOS OF
A DECEASED PERSON'S A PERSON'S
AFTER JANUARY TWENTY SIX. THE
TRAGIC HELICOPTER CRASH THAT
KILLED MISTER KOBE BRYANT HIS
DAUGHTER GIGI THIRTEEN YEARS OF
AGE AND SEVEN OTHERS FIRST
RESPONDERS SHARED PHOTOGRAPHS
IMAGES OF THAT HORRIFIC. CRASH
THE NATIONAL TRANSPORTATION
SAFETY BOARD AND THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY CORONER'S OFFICE
WERE THE ONLY AGENCIES THAT
WERE SUPPOSED TO BE TAKING
PHOTOGRAPHS OF A SCENE OF THAT
MAGNITUDE. CURRENT LAW
GENERALLY SUPPORT A REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF PRIVACY FOR DECEASED
PERSONS HAVING PHOTOS THAT ARE
TAKEN OF THE BY THE CORNER
DURING AN AUTOPSY. AND ANYONE
WHO VIEWS THE PHOTOS WITH THE
INTENT OF INVASION OF PRIVACY
OF A DECEASED INDIVIDUALS A
PERSON'S PRIVACY- MAY BE FACED
WITH A MISDEMEANOR. BUT CURRENT
LAW DOES NOT PROHIBIT FIRST
RESPONDERS FROM CAPTURING THESE
IMAGES OF DECEASED PERSONS OF
ANY PURPOSE WITH THE ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGY OF CELL PHONES. THE
IMAGES OF DECEASED PERSONS CAN
BE CAPTURED SET AND RESET
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF TIMES
WITH THE JAZZ IN JUST MINUTES
OF THE IMAGES BEING CAPTURED
THIS ACT IS EXTREMELY AND I ONE
UNDERSCORE EXTREMELY SENSITIVE.
INSENSITIVE AND CAN NEGATIVELY
AFFECT GRIEVING FAMILIES AND
LOVED ONES WHO MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN. AWARE THAT THEIR LOVED
pRESPONDERS ARE TRUSTED TO
SECURE AND PRESERVE SCENES OF
GREAT DISASTER AND DEATH THE
DIGNITY OF THE DECEASED MUST BE
PROTECTED AS WELL AS THE
PRIVACY OF THEIR LOVE ONES.
TAKEN ACCOUNTABILITY AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY FIVE IS A
COLLABORATION I WANT TO
UNDERSCORE COLLABORATION WITH
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT TO ENSURE
THAT THESE OCCURRENCES NEVER
HAPPEN AGAIN IN THE FUTURE. AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE SIX TO
MAKE IT A MISDEMEANOR FOR FIRST
RESPONDED TO TAKE A PHOTO OF A
DECEASED PERSON OR PERSONS FOR
ANY PURPOSE. OUTSIDE OF THEIR
DUTIES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
THIS MISDEMEANORS CARRIES A
FIGHT UP TO FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PERVIOLATIONS UP TO
ONE YEAR IN G. COUNTY JAIL OR
BOTH. IT IS CRITICAL THAT THOSE
WHO ARE TASKED WITH RESPONDING
TO THE SCENE OF AN ACCIDENT OR
CRIME DO NOT ABUSE DO NOT ABUSE
THEIR POSITION FOR PERSONAL
PLEASURE. JOINING ME JOIN WITH
ME IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX
IS THE SHERIFF OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
MISTER ALEX. THANK YOU SORRY
THIS ITEM BASS LINE VOTE MISTER
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE LET
ON OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF ALEX VILLAIN A WAIVER.
BY PHONE. GO AHEAD SIR. AND IF
I CAN FIND HIS LINE OKAY. ALEX
I THINK YOUR LINE IS OPEN JUST
GO AHEAD AND ON MUTE YOUR AND
SIR. WHATEVER COUNTY NUMBER
PROUD SPONSOR TO AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FIVE. AS PEACE OFFICERS
WE ARE EXPECTED BY THOSE WE
SERVE TO SHOW PROFESSIONALISM
IN ALL OF OUR DAY TO DAY
INTERACTIONS WITH THE PUBLIC.
THIS PROFESSIONALISM IS MOST
IMPORTANT WHEN WE ARE ENTRUSTED
WITH THE PERSON MOST PRIVATE
INFORMATION DURING TIMES OF
TRAGEDY. WE ARE TRYING TO DO
ACT DISCREETLY WHEN HANDLING
INFORMATION THAT IS NOT MEANT
FOR PUBLIC VIEW OR
DISSEMINATION. WE ARE IN POWER
TO SECURE SCENES OF GREAT
DEVASTATION INCLUDING DEATH
THEY WERE GIVEN THE AUTHORITY
TO LIMIT THE PUBLIC'S ACCESS TO
THESE SCENES. TO VIOLATE THE
STRUCK BY TAKING PHOTOS FOR NO
LAWFUL PURPOSE. IS A TERRIBLE
VIOLATION OF PUBLIC TRUST AND
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT PROVIDE A
REMEDY TO DETER THIS BEHAVIOR.
THE OPPOSITION WILL TELL YOU
THIS BEHAVIOR CAN BE CONTROLLED
BY HAVING A POLICY IN PLACE. IN
FACT MOST AGENCIES IF NOT ALL
ALREADY HAVE A POLICY IN PLACE
THAT ADDRESSES BEHAVIOR TO SOME
DEGREE HOWEVER INTERNET
STRAIGHT OF POLICY DOES NOT
ALLOW A PERSONAL LIKE TRYING TO
DIVIDE TO BE SEIZED THE
LAWFULLY. UNFORTUNATELY THE
THREAT OF A POSITIVE VIOLATION
IS NOT STRONG ENOUGH TO DETER
THIS FROM HAPPENING AGAIN. IF
ENACTED I HIGHLY DOUBT THIS LAW
WILL BE USED VERY OFTEN AS THE
VAST MAJORITY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WOULD NOT
TAKE A PICTURE IN THE FIRST
PLACE. BUT THERE WILL BE THAT
MOMENT WHEN THE TEMPTATION
MIGHT JUST BE TOO OVERWHELMING
FOR THE OFFICER ON THE SCENE.
MAKING IT A CRIME I GIVE THAT
OFFICER MOMENT OF PAUSE. IN
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH WITH THIS BILL IN
WILL ALSO PROVIDE US WITH AN
ENFORCEMENT TOOL. THANK YOU AND
I ASK. FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SHARE A BILL IN THE WAY THE-
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
IN SUPPORT NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AT THIS TIME YES
LIKE TO OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND TO SHOW US YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANNA KELLY ON
BEHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY
EMMALINE SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THE FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE ZERO FIVE. CHRISTINE WARD
WITH CRIME VICTIMS ALLIANCE WE
ARE ALSO IN THE POINT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND THERE'S ONE
MORE THAT IS JUST QUEUING UP
ONE MOMENT. HELLO. I AM WE WILL
I TWO FOUR SEVEN TWO FOUR SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES UP FOR THE OPPOSITION
SO ALL WE TELL THEM THANKS.
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
CUED UP. THANK YOU THEN-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I HAVE
RANDY PERRY FOR PORAC BY PHONE.
YOUR PHONE IS MUTED SIR PLEASE
GO ON UNIT. WE LOOK FOR IS LINE.
I DON'T SEE ANY RANDY LISTED.
OR MAYBE IT'S A. ABOUT IT ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES. IN
OPPOSITION IT YES WE HAVE
SOMEONE IN THE AUDIENCE OF. THE
NAME IDENTIFICATION AND THEN
YOU CAN TESTIFY YES SIR A GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
NOT SO I REALLY BE HAPPY
ASSOCIATION FOR LOS ANGELES
DEPUTY SHERIFFS IN A LOS
ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE
LEAGUE. HOT HERE TODAY NOT
EXACTLY IN FULL OPPOSITION I
WANT EXPRESSED TO THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSOR. HOW WE DO SHARE
COMMON GOALS HERE WE DO NOT-
OBVIOUSLY EVER WANT TO SEE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS EVER HAPPEN
AGAIN. AND WE SHARE THE CONCERN
WE SHARE THE GOAL OF PUTTING
INTO PLACE SOMETHING TO PREVENT
IT FROM HAPPENING AGAIN. OTHER
AT THE SAME TIME WE REPRESENT.
THOUSANDS OF OTHER RANK AND
FILE POLICE OFFICERS AND DEPUTY
SHERIFFS ON MYSELF IN LOS
ANGELES- AND ACROSS THE STATE-
IT'S IMPERATIVE WE WORK WE WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BILL IS NARROW THE BILL. IS
CLEAR AND SCOPE- AND FOCUSED ON
THOSE WHO MALICIOUSLY INTEND TO
VIOLATE THE CRIME. THE LAST WE
WANT IS FOR SOMEBODY TO
MISUNDERSTAND THE RULES- OR
HAVE. SOMETHING YOU'LL GET
CAUGHT UP IN A SITUATION WHERE
THEY BY THIS CRIME
UNINTENTIONALLY. CHARGED WITH A
MISDEMEANOR FOR IT BOB. BUT
LET'S NOT INTENSE I WOULD HOPE
TO WORK GOING FORWARD- AND ALL
THE EXPERTISE OF ON THE GROUND.
THE YOU. YOU ARE THERE ANY WITH
AND OPERA. MODERATOR PLEASE
PRESS ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO FOR TO SHOW YOUR
OPPOSITION. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWO FORTY
SEVEN CAN YOU HEAR. YES READY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
SHERMAN RESTORING JOURNAL
BROKERS LIKE CHIPS LOCATION-
LIKE APPLE COMMENTS OF OUR
COLLEAGUE MR SIDELINED- WE HAVE
HERE IS- CONCERNS WITH THIS
BILL LIKE TO- TRY TO WORK WITH
THE CHAIR AND THE AUTHOR- WE
THINK RIGHT NOW IS THE BILL AS
DRAFTED AT ALL AND THE-
DEPARTMENT POLICY CAN MATT OUT
WHATEVER DISCIPLINE. BE SURE OF
FOR- THE HEAD OF THE- LONGER
AGENCY BUT THEY CAN PRETTY MUCH
DO WHAT THEY WANT AS FAR AS
PUNISHMENT GOES AND- I THINK
IT'S BEST LOOKED AT THAT LEVEL
WE DON'T THINK THAT TURNING
COPS IN THE CRIMINALS FOR
TAKING A PICTURE- IS THE BEST
APPROACH ALTHOUGH WE COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND- THE HARM THAT- SUCH
PICTURES CAN CAUSE FAMILY OR
LOVED ONES WERE- VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT- OVERREACH HERE. AND THE
PRIVACY OF OFFICERS AND- THEIR
PHONES AND THE CONCERN THAT WE
HAVE WITH. OFFICERS HAVING
THEIR PHONES TAKE IN AND SEARCH
BY MANAGEMENT OF BECAUSE THEY
THINK THERE THERE MIGHT BE
SOMETHING IN THE APPROPRIATE-
THOSE- AND- I THINK WE STILL
HAVE. A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
COMPLY TO OFFICERS AND WE THINK
THIS BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM
GOES TOO FAR. AND SO. WE MUST-
THAT REMAIN- IN A VERY STRONG
POSITION CONCERNED AND
PROBABLY- IF THE BILL IS NOT
AMENDED FURTHER THAN WILL
PROBABLY HAVE TO MOVE. TO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. OR BETWEEN A
FINAL MINUTE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. TWEET ANALYTICAL LINE TO
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSION LEVINE ABOUT THE SEE
THE SAMBERG YOU KNOW COUNTY
SHERIFF'S EMPLOYEES BENEFITS
ASSOCIATION. LINE MY COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION WITH THE PRIOR-
WITNESSES TESTIMONY- IN
PARTICULAR MR STYLING WITH A
LAST LOOK FORWARD TO WORK WITH
THE OFFER- CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU. NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS CUED
UP GEN THANK YOU. IT WILL BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. CONCERNS. YES MISSED
CAREER. THANK YOU HAVE A
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR OF
LISTENING TO THE TESTIMONY.
THIS DOES YOUR DOES YOUR BILL
ACTUALLY ALLOW. POTENTIALLY
MANAGEMENT TO REVIEW AND
OFFICERS PERSONAL PHONE NO
CONTEXT NO IT HAS TO BE UNDER
THIS UNDER THIS- THE WORDING OF
THIS VIDEO YOU HAVE TO ACTUALLY
TO WARRANT FROM A JUDGE AND
THERE HAS TO BE REASONABLE
SUSPICION IN FACT THAT SOMEONE
HAS DONE SOMETHING LIKE THIS TO
RISE THAT PARTICULAR LEVEL SO
YOU HAVE TO PROVE TO A JUDGE
THAT A PERSON. WHO'S A FIRST
RESPONDER LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
WHATEVER- HAS RISEN TO A
CERTAIN LEVEL THAT THAT PERSON
HAS PHOTOGRAPHS- ON THEIR PHONE
IN ORDER FOR THE PHONE TO BE
ACTUALLY SEIZED AND EVEN THEN
IT'S NEARLY AS WHERE THEY FIND
SOMETHING ELSE THAT IS NOT
GERMANE TO THE WARRANT THEY
CAN'T USE IT. THEY ONLY GO
THERE FOR THIS REASON. SO OKAY
SO I WOULD IMAGINE THAT THAT
HAS TO GO THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES INTERNAL-
INVESTIGATIONS WITH THEIR OWN
INTERNAL UNITS IN ORDER FURTHER
FOR IT TO GET TO THAT LEVEL
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY- I JUST I
ONE ALSO JUST SAY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL I KNOW THAT
IT'S- A BIT CONTROVERSIAL
WITHIN LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THEMSELVES AND- THANK MY SHARE
OF THE END OF. GUARDING THE
OFFICER WHO TOOK THE PHOTOS WHO
WAS AT A BAR SHOWING OF TO A
DATE- THE PHOTOS OF THE KOBE
BRYANT HELICOPTER CRASH- WHICH
IS AN UNFORTUNATE I THINK FIND
A PRIVILEGE FOR THAT OFFICER-
THAT AND I WAS A BARTENDE WHO
OVERSAW IT FOR HER THE
CONVERSATION AND REPORTED IT-
AND SO I JUST I THINK THE
ENTIRE INCIDENT- IS VERY
UNFORTUNATE AND- LOOKS POORLY.
IN THE SITUATION SO I HOPE THAT
YOU DO COME TO A RESOLUTION
WAS- THOSE ARE IN OPPOSITION
BECAUSE WE WANT I THINK ALL OF
US WOULD WANT TO FEEL SOME KIND
OF SAFETY AND SECURITY AND
PRIVACY. BOTH FOR CIVILIANS BUT
ALSO FOR THE OFFICERS WHO
RESTORE LIVES EVERY DAY AND WHO
TRY TO DO THE GOOD WORK THAT
THEY DO. THEY'D FIND A MIDDLE
GROUND BETWEEN SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION AND OBVIOUSLY THE
SUPPORTS ABOUT SOME OF THE
LANGUAGES CLEARED UP AND- AND
THIS GETS THE SUPPORT IT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMMENTS
CARILLO AND I WAS SURE. THAT
THOSE WHO HAVE SPOKEN- WHERE
THEY'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF THEIR
NOT AT FULL OF POLLS I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM
AND ADDRESSING THE CONSTRUCTION
SIRENS. AND CERTAINLY THIS TWO
THAT TRANSPIRED LED TO THIS
BILL BEING- DRAFTED IT IS NOT
DIRECTED AT THE INDIVIDUAL IS
DIRECTED AT THE SITUATION- THAT
IT WE FIND OURSELVES IT COULD
BE A LOT ONE OF MINE. AND I AND
YOU KNOWFINE OUT ABOUT ON
SOCIAL MEDIA I'VE HAD NO SUCH.
WERE LOCAL BUT NOW ABOUT THEIR
LOVE ONE PASSING THROUGH SO
MEDIA TO CARE THE- AND OF THAT
NATURE AND I WOULD SAY. IT IS
INSENSITIVE FOR YOU AS A LOT OF
ONE TO FIND OUT YOUR HUSBAND.
CHORE OR WHATEVER PASSED AWAY
BE. YOU CAN BE PROP NOTRE BUT
ALL MAKING SURE THAT NEVER
AGAIN AND I THINK THAT'S THE
AUTOMATION AND THAT'S THE
LEADERSHIP AND I WANT TO THANK
THIS YEAR ONE STAN UP AND- OF
THIS HAPPENING IN A PART OF THE
STATE. UP IN A LARGE TO SAY I
WANT TO LED. THAT MAKE SURE
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN AND
I'M WILLING TO WORK AGAIN
ABSOLUTELY WITH OUT THOSE WERE
IN THE MIDDLE. THOSE ARE NOT
CREATE A FOR A FULL OP YOU KNOW.
THERE'S ROOM NOW LOOK FOR TO
WORKING THOSE INTO THAT IN.
THANK YOU. IT'S A DIFFICULT OF.
COM YEAH IT IS. THANK YOU I TO
QUESTION TO FRANK. WHICH I HOPE
CAN AND THE FOR ONE A DOES. THE
BILL MAKE IT THIS. I ABOUT THE-
THAT ARE YOU. THAT MAY. THESE A-
IS THERE TO. MAY BETWEEN
PERSONAL DEVICE SOA WORK.
BECAUSE I KNOW SOME FOR
RESPONDER. YOU KNOW A WORK
PHONE BUT THEY ALSO HAVE A
PERSONAL DOES MATTER. WHICH THE
USE TO CAPTURE THE M. WHEN IN A
SECOND. TO THIS GO. IS BELL
FOCUS. SOLELY CAPTURING THE
IMAGE OF A PER OR DOES IT ALSO
IN PERHAPS THE PAY THE BILL THE
VA ARE GONNA AIR AT IN WITH
THIS INCIDENT AND- HER. WELL
THEN TAKE THE SECOND FOR THIS
FOCUS ON THAT DOES AND THIS IS
IN THIS WITH THE ENDS INSTANT A
TOOK PLACE ON JANUARY TWENTY
SAY. IS A MODEST IS WAS
KNOWLEDGE THE TO SEE BUT THE
WRECKAGE AS WELL AND AGAIN
THAT'S HORRIFIC ITSELF SO IF
YOU ARE NOT. PART OF THE-
INVESTIGATE- THE BEST A GETTING
TEAM SAYS THE CORNERS OFFERS
AND ALSO DETECTIVE YOUR
PROHIBIT IS YOUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO OF COURSE MAINTAIN THE CRIME
SCENE- AND THEN THERE'S A
DETECTIVES AND CORNERS WHO
WOULD DO THEIR JOB AND SO THIS
WOULD MAKE SURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOT PART OF
THAT INVESTIGATE TORY TEAM-
OFFER HERE FROM TAKING SUCH
PICTURES- YOUR SECOND QUESTION.
IT'S SPECFICALLY TALKS ABOUT
PHOTOGRAPHS- AND THAT'S VERY
BROAD- THREE CAN BE USED AS
WITH A- CAMPER OR YOUR CELL
PHONE AND THIS DAY AND AGE.
PEOPLE MORE SLEEP YOU THEIR
CELLPHONES AND A DOZEN MAKE
JUST TWENTY A THE ISSUE PAUL OR
A PER FALL. A PHONE AS BONUS IS
USING THIS A MATTER IT BE
SEIZED UNDER THIS. A LAW AND
ALL INDIVIDUALS CAN FINE. TO AS
A RESULT OF IT. THANK YOU I
WANTED TO AT THIS OF MY- IN
HOPES THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OP. I THE AS- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY THE CHALLENGING TO
YOU THAT YOU KNOW SORT OF A-
HONDA THE LACK OF FOR. WAS
JAILED AND I THINK WE DON'T
WANT TO SEE BOTH I DON'T NEED
TO BE IN A IN ESPECIALLY NOW
DURING THIS TIME OF CLOTHING
WHAT HAVE AFTER. AND YOU I
RECOGNIZE THAT IT IS ALL N. TO
SUPPORT IN A PEOPLE'S PRIDE.
WHEN THESE KIND OF ACT HAPPENED
WOULD THAT THERE IS A WAY FOR
THE TO DISK OF PRICE AND POLICY
OF SUPPORTING THE NEED FOR A
PHONE TO HAVE FOR. AND I SEE
STUFF LAST ALL OVER THE T. OR
SO MEDIA. THE EXTENDED NOT JUST
TO YOU KNOW CELEB BUT ALSO TO
AB AND- PEOPLE BECAUSE KNOWS
OFTEN THIS IS HOW. TO THE FOLKS
THAT LIVE. YOU KNOW UNDER THE
MAR AND THE SHADOW OF OUR. SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FOR AND HOPE THAT CAN WORK
WITH THE APP. ON ADDRESS
THEY'RE GOING. THANK YOU ARE MY
AND I WE BE WORKING. IN THE
QUESTION SOME A QUICK. YEAH I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAVE OF ALL
I DON'T THEY ANYBODY IN THIS IS
ISSUE TRYING TO COULD THIS. IT
WAS ACT. ENGAGE AND I THINK
REAL WHAT. WHAT THE OP ISA
NORMAL GOING TO BE NOT FORTY
TODAY WERE OUR JOE THAT CURRENT
TO MY QUESTIONS BUT TO BE
CLARIFIED ON WE NEED A VERY
CLEAR. THE NARAL PRO AS TO. WHY
WE'RE ADDRESSING. AND THE IN
THE COURSE FORWARD. SO EVERY
KNOWS. APPROACH WHAT'S IN A FOR
THIS WAS IN A PRO. BUT WHAT
LEVEL OF UP AS- HAS TO BE TO
AND I DON'T IN ANYWAY IT SHOULD
BE TOLERATE. BUT TO THE COURSE
AS IS REALLY WERE WE NEED TO
HAVE A VERY FOR TO. SO I'LL BE
CURRENTLY NOT FORTY TO AND SEE
HOW THIS. COOPERATION COULD
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS AND I WOULD ARE YOUR AND
WE WILL AGAIN OUR SURE THIS
THIS COMMITTEE IN THE CHAIR
THAT MY TO WORK THOSE WHO ARE
IN OFFICE. THOSE WHO HAVE
ADDRESSED CONCERN AND I LOOKED
TO RECEIVING CALLS ENDORSED WE
CAN COME UP OFFICE. RECEIVING
CALLS RISEN CALLS AND-
COLLABORATIVE. TO TRY TO REACH
MAY THE- AS RULERS AS A RESULT
OF THIS PARTICULAR VIA. AGAIN
WHETHER IT'S MISTER BRYANT AND
THOSE WHO LOST THEIR LIVES ON
JUNE I WAS GIVEN A J. TWENTY
SIX. A WEATHER'S YES. A NOR IN.
JUST A CITIZEN OF THIS STATE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
KIND OF BEHAVIOR NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN. WE SHOULD NEVER HAVE TO
FIND OUT- BY WAY OF SOCIAL
MEDIA THAT I LOVE ONE- HAS
PERISH EITHER AN ACCIDENT OR
WHATEVER THE SITUATION MAY BE.
AND CERTAINLY- THE BRIDE FAMILY
AND THE OTHERS WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES- PHOTOGRAPHS OFF LIMITS
DURING THIS VERY DIFFICULT
TIME- THAT PEOPLE THAT THEY
FACED AND THIS IS AN ATTEMPT AT
MAKING SURE THESE. KINDS OF
ACTIONS NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN AND
SO. AGAIN MISTER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTED FOR A GOOD
TIME. BIGGEST AT YOUR- THAT'S
MY CLOSING SIR THANK RIGHT
THANK. OFFER OUR ONE A THANK
THE AUTHOR JUST. AND THE- ALL
OF THEM THEIR LEADER ON THIS
ISSUE. OBVIOUS THERE IS NO
EXCUSE FOR THE WELL NO
OF THIS BILL. BUT I DO WANT TO
MAKE SOMETHING VERY CLEAR- I'VE
HAD DISCUSSIONS DOLLAR WOULD
ALTER BUT WITH EVERYONE.
INVOLVED THE SHERIFF A LEAD TO
ELLIE PPL OTHER AGENCIES. AND I
CAN TELL YOU. IN ALL OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS BOTH SIDES AGREE
THAT THIS WAS WRONG THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO ONE ANYBODY IN MY
EAR SHOT NO ONE ON EITHER SIDE
WHERE THEY HAVE CONCERNS ARE
NOT. BELIEVES THAT THIS BUT
THIS PERSON DID WAS
APPROPRIATE. AT EACH SIDE
WANTED TO STOP FOREVER SELECT
THIS JUST MAKE THAT VERY CLEAR
BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND THE
PUBLIC WANTED TO STOP. MY
INTEREST IN SEEING THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD- IS REALLY TO STOP
THIS ABUSE OF PRIVACY. AND IS
REALLY UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT
FROM FROM EVER EVER HAPPENING
AGAIN. AS A MEMBER OF LABOR I
ALSO KNOW. EIGHT YEARS FIGHT
BETWEEN MANAGEMENT AND
EMPLOYEES AND I'VE I'VE HEARD
THERE'S BEEN SOME VERY
STRENUOUS. REALLY HARD FOUGHT
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS AND THAT
WHICH DOES PROBABLY MORE UP
WHAT MANAGEMENT WANTS AND WHAT.
NOW WHAT THE EMPLOYEES WANT-
UGH AT THE END OF THE DAY OF.
AS YOU KNOW MISTER GIBSON AND
PROBABLY EVERYBODY ELSE KNOWS
THIS IS A COMMITTEE THAT
DOESN'T WANT TO NOT ONLY OVER
INCARCERATE. BUT GIVE PENALTIES
OUT THERE LOOK TOO STRENUOUS
AND WITH THAT IN MIND WHEN THE
EARLY DISCUSSIONS. ABOUT DOING
FELONIES CAME TO THIS COMMITTEE
OR AT LEAST CAME TO MY YOUR
SHOT THAT WAS REALLY A NO
STARTER. IS NOT ENOUGH BUT WHEN
IT DOES YOU KNOW STARTED
BECAUSE IT WAS SOMEONE AT WAR
BRANCH WHERE YOU'RE- SWORN FOR
NON SWORN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE.
WEEK WHATEVER THE CRIME IS OR
WHETHER THE INFRACTION IS THAT
IS WHATEVER WE DO IS PENALTIES
IT IS APPROPRIATE. AND THAT IS
NOT TOO HARSH. BUT IT'S ENOUGH
TO STOP THE ACTIVITY. AND SO
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW
AND I WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR- AND EVEN TO SPONSOR FOR
REALLY TRYING TO WORK. WITH THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO COME
UP WITH SOMETHING COULD THIS IS
IN SOME WAYS. IS ABOUT WE TALK
ABOUT REHABILITATION. DOES WHAT
WE TALK ABOUT EVERY DAY IN THIS
COMMITTEE ABOUT. HOW DO WE
TRAIN INDIVIDUALS SO THAT THEY
NEVER DO THAT ACT AGAIN. AGAIN
TODAY AND I WOULD I WANT TO
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION IS SOUNDS
LIKE YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM. ADD TO
INCLUDE TRAINING AND OTHER
MEASURES THAT WILL HELP STOP
THIS BEHAVIOR. IN THE FUTURE. I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE. THAT
AS WE MOVE FOR NEXT YEAR. WE
ALSO WANT TO LOOK AT THE
VICTIMS AND I WOULD BUT I PLAN
TO WORK WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACQUI IRWIN ON AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY TWO TO LOOK AT THE
IMPACT OF VICTIMS HAVE WITH.
THIS TYPE OF ACTIVITY AND WHAT
CAN BE SHOWN AND SO THIS
DISCUSSION WILL WOULD NOT
HOPEFULLY THIS ONE WITH A LOT
FOR THE LONG WE CAN GET
SOMETHING DONE HERE AND THEN WE
CAN DO A MUCH BROADER LOOK AT
HOW. VICTIMS PEOPLE WHOSE
PICTURES ARE BEING SHOWN HOW WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT IMPACT IS
MITIGATED AS MUCH AS WE CAN. OF
WHAT I'M NOT INTERESTED IN
SEEING IS A CONTINUATION AGAIN
OF THE OVERLY HARSH PUNITIVE
PURELY PUNITIVE LOCK THEM UP
AND THROW AWAY THE KEY APPROACH
THAT WE WORK SO HARD TO AND DO
IN THIS COMMITTEE. I CAN TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY. AND A
CURSE YOU OFFER TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION ON
A SOLUTION- I'M GONNA HOLD OFF
FOR ONE THREE THIS BILL TODAY
BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO SIGNING
ON ONCE. ALL OF THE OUTSTANDING
ISSUES ARE RESOLVED. I WITH
THAT I WILL BE VOTING FOR THE
BILL TODAY WHICH ALSO ENJOYS
AND I RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. I NEED A
MOTION AND THIS. HAS BEEN BOTH
AS WE IN SO. OF MAY TAKE THE
ROLE. I'M AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
FIVE GIPSON THE MOTION IS PASS
TO THE UPPER COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER ON CHEN SIR I NOT BODY
LACKEY NOT BOW BARRICADE. DE
DEEP I KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I.
KALLIO I SAN DIEGO. SAN DIEGO I
WICKS. DOUBLES OUT FIVE ZERO
THAT THOSE OF FIVE. GIVE NOW I
THINK WE CAN SINCE YOU'RE HERE
WE'RE GONNA RE AT ONE FIFTEEN
BUT COME UP COME TO MISSOURI
COME. OF THE BILL OF OKAY. COMO
DOWN THE SURLY WHEN AB TWENTY
FOR THIRTY TWO FIREARM GUN
VIOLENCE ORDER. AND THEY MAKE
YOU MAY BE CORRECT BUT YOU HAVE
SOME YOU HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
TALK YES- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR A COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
THE TO ASSIST LON SPENT ONE
FILING EIGHT GB ARE IT'S STILL
COURT. AB TWO FIVE TWO AS DAYS
TO THOSE WHO ARE A TO BE
NOTIFIED AND MOTION TO EXTEND
FIREARM PROHIBIT PRO THIS FOR
THOSE WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS. CALIFORNIA TO TURNING
SO SHE AND THE VENTURA COUNTY
TO TURN YOUR CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL. JUST ATTORNEY'S OF
THE STATE ARE WILLING TO STEP
UP AND ASSIST LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AND FILING FOR AND
DEFENDING G. V. R. OWES IN
COURT. HOWEVER AS A RESULT OF
THEIR LIMITED JURISDICTION IN
CIVIL CASES. THEY HAVE BEEN
PRICKLY YOU PRECLUDED FROM
JOINING CITY ATTORNEY CENTS
COUNTY COUNCILS AND
REPRESENTING LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THESE PETITIONS. CURRENT RATES
OF TV ARE OWES USE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA RIVER REMAIN LOW
THIS WILL HELP INCREASE THEIR
USE AND REMOVE GUNS FROM
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS THAT DO
NOT NEED TO END IN A GUN
RELATED DEATH. AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO WILL ADD THOUSANDS
OF THESE TO FIGHT AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE IN CALIFORNIA. I AM
PLEASED TO BE JOINED TODAY IN
SUPPORT BY PHONE VENTURA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY GREG TOTTEN.
AND MICHAEL MOORE SAID. MICHAEL
MOORE SAID IS THE FATHER OF
CRISTINA MORISSETTE WHO WAS
KILLED IN THE BORDERLINE OF
MASS SHOOTING AND MY DISTRICT.
THE A TITAN. YOU THE REFEREE
WITNESSES. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME. MISTER CHAIRMAN YES I GET
HERE WHO ARE YOU. GREG TOTTEN I
AM THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF
CENTRE COUNTY IN A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO. I WANT TO THANK
YOUR CHIEF. THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK YOUR CHIEF COUNSEL FOR
HIS EXCELLENT ANALYSIS AND
ASSISTANCE ON THIS IMPORTANT
PROPOSAL WITH THE LANGUAGE. AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY TWO FOR
PROVED WILL ENHANCE OUR
COLLECTIVE ABILITY TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE BY AUTHORIZING
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S ALONG WITH
CITY ATTORNEYS AND COUNTY
COUNCIL. TO ASSIST LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CLEAN THE ISSUE
ONCE OVER NEW WILL OF GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS. IN
THIS WILL OCCUR MOST FREQUENTLY
IN TWO DISTINCT SITUATIONS
FIRST FOR FIRE ARM WAS SEIZED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT. IN AN
INCIDENT INVOLVING VIOLENCE OR
THREATEN VIOLENCE IN THE RETURN
OF THE WEAPON WOULD LIKELY IN
DANGER THE VICTIM. MOST
FREQUENTLY THE CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE GONNA INVOLVE CRIMES OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. BUT THEY
COULD ALSO INCLUDE. THE
VIOLENCE OR ACTS OF VIOLENCE
THAT OCCUR IN THE WORKPLACE OR
IN OUR SCHOOLS. SECOND
SITUATION OCCUR WERE FOR SEE OF
ARM. ATTAINING TO CHECK HER
HEALTH. AND AGAIN RICH OF THE
FOR REPRESENTS DANGER TO THAT
PERSON TO OTHERS. EXISTING OR
ALL. DISTRICT TO LITIGATE
SIMILAR GONE FOR FIFTY ISSUES
AND CIVIL COURT. WHEN A PERSON
IS A DENTAL AS A DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OTHERS AND IS PLACED
ON A MENTAL WHOLE PULLED. AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY TWO IS A
VERY MEASURED- EXTENSION OF
THAT RESPONSIBILITY THE STATE
REQUIRE. YOUR AND CONVINCE OF
THOSE DANGERS AND RISKS AND THE
APPROVED OF A SECURE COURT.
BORDERLINE SHOOTING IN COUNTY
MY DEAREST. AS WELL AS NUMEROUS
MAN SHOOTING ACROSS THE NAY.
PETER LEE WERE THAT FIRE ARE IN
THE HANDS OF POTENTIALLY VIA
PERSON. OR THOSE WITH MENTAL
ISSUES CAN PRESENTED GRAY DAY
TO OUR- WELL I'M NOT SUGGESTING
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE PREVENTED
THE BORDERLINE SHOOTING WAR
TWELVE INNOCENT PEOPLE LOST
THEIR LIVES I BELIEVE VERY
STRONGLY IT WILL HELP US
PREVENT OTHER SHOOTING SHOOTING
TO THE FUTURE. THEREFORE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NECK. MR
MORE SET. TO CLARIFY AND MET MY
MOORE SAID IF ON THE LINE BUT
LINE IS NOW OPEN YOU MAY PRESS
STAR AND THEN ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE A LINE HERE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. MISTER MOORE SAID IS
THAT YOU SEE ON THE SLIDE. YEAH
CASES. YOU MAY CONTINUE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITIES MY VOICE IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY TWO MY NAME IS
MICHAEL MOORE SAT. AND MY
DAUGHTER CHRISTINA. I WAS
WORKING AS A HOSTESS FOR LINE
BORING POWER OAKS WHEN A YOUNG
MAN MARK IN WITH THE IN
BRUTALLY HER. SHE WAS OF ELEVEN
WHO DIED ON THE FLOOR OF THE
BAR NIGHT. AND VENTURE COUNTY
THAT THE SEARCH RUN HE WAS
STUCK THE NEXT MORNING IN THE
HOSPITAL. AFTER SHOOTING STARS
HE WAS KILLER TO HIS OWN.
INSTEAD OF FACE BUT NEW DONE. I
LOOK AT KNOW I AM I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE CORE OF THE WHICH TO
OUR INTO AT THE LINE WOULD NOT
THIS IS. BEEN A- IF THE
LANGUAGE IN AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY HAD BEEN. LAW AT THE
TIME IT MAY. GOT CUT OFF
SEVERANCE. WHERE I'M SORRY YOU
HEAR ME NOW. OKAY I JUST SAYING
THAT- I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COURTS OF EVENTS WHICH LED TO
THE INCIDENT BORDERLINE BUT NOT
NECESSARY NO ALTERNATIVE FOR
LANGUAGE OF AB FIVE THIRTY TWO
THEN LAW THAT SOME. IT MAY NOT
THOSE LIVES BUT KNOW THAT THERE
WERE SO INTO WHERE SHOOTER
CROSSED THE PATH LOCALLY. AND
THOSE EIGHT DID NOT THE TO ACT
FOR THERE'S THEY DID A THAT
TIME I DON'T BLAME THE NO ONE
IN THIRTY TAKE THE MEASURE THAT
WOULD HAVE STOPPED MARCH NAY.
JUST WHY I BELIEVE WE MUST TAKE
TO OPEN UP FOR LOCAL. TO EXIT
THE FLOOR MATTER OF OUR
INTEREST STATE I BELIEVE THAT
THIS BUDGET AND GETTING THE
ATTORNEYS ARE THE TO RID A GUN
RESTRAIN A CERTAIN HELP WITH
THE SAY IN MY OF OTHER. LIST
SOMEONE CLOSE. THANK YOU IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THAN THE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WILL MOVE FIRST THE
LINE OF TWO FOUR SEVEN. TWO
FORTY SEVEN YOU MAY. GO AHEAD.
CHAIR MEMBERS FIND GERMAN WITH
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION. WE'LL GO CLIMB
TWENTY EIGHT TO EIGHT THE MAIN.
CONTINUE. THANK YOU THIS IS A
LIST OF THAT HAS BEEN A FAN
BEHALF OF THAT CENTER A COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FIVE. IT HAPPENED IN CRISTINA
WARD WITH CRIME VICTIMS
ALLIANCE AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX TWO FIVE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD WELL. I'M SORRY
TWO TWO FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN DO YOU HAVE A COMMENT.
WELL MOVE ON LINE ONE EIGHT ONE
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY LINE ONE
EIGHT ONE ARE YOU ON MUTE. AND
A KELLY ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY NANCY A VALIANT
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF THERE ARE
OTHERS YOU MAY PRESS ONE THAN
ZERO AS WELL. WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SIX TWO FIVE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEAN ON
THE WHAT THE CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NO
FURTHER COMMENT TO Q. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO
TESTIFY. BUT PAPER I HAD RORY
GRIFFIN SEE OUR PA IT NOT YOUR
HERNANDEZ C. A. C. J. MODERATOR
RE ABLE TO FIND A. I FOUND
MISTER GRIFFIN MISTER GRIFFIN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
SIR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FOR A
GROUP OF ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
OUR OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY TWO. TWENTY
BY THIRTY TWO WHAT AMEND THE
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS
PROCEDURE CREATED BY ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE FOURTEEN. SURE BE
ABLE TO KERN GUN VIOLENCE
BETWEEN OUR PROCEDURES BECAUSE
THEY PROVIDE A MECHANISM FOR
INDIVIDUAL LOSE THEIR RIGHT TO
KEEP AND BEAR ARMS. DUE PROCESS
OF LAW. AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
TWO WILL FURTHER COMPOUND THIS
PROBLEM BY AUTHORIZING A
DISTRICT ATTORNEY COUNTY
COUNCIL. CITY ATTORNEY TO FILE
A PETITION ON BEHALF OF
ABORTION OFFICER. THE QUESTION
ISSUE INTO RENEWAL OF THESE
ORDERS. AND TO PRESENT TO AN
OFFICE DURING SUBSEQUENT COURT
PROCEEDINGS RELATED TO THE
ISSUANCE RENEWAL THEIR ORDER.
UNDER CURRENT LAW IMMEDIATE
FAMILY MEMBERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS CAN USE
THE GUN VIOLENCE RESTORING
ORDER PETITION TO AN INDIVIDUAL
STRIP BUT THERE ARE A MARCH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THIS WAS
EXTENDED BY STANLEY BILL SIXTY
ONE WHICH IS ALLOWS AN EMPLOYER
COWORKER. EMPLOYER A SECONDARY
SCHOOL THAT THAT PERSON IS A
TWO LAST SIX MONTHS TO. FOR A
BONTA OR- BY SHOULD STAND
INCREASE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
PETITION FOR GUN BANS
RESTRAINING ORDERS. AB SIXTY
ONE ALREADY OPEN THE SYSTEM TO
FURTHER ABUSE A DISGRUNTLED
COWORKER UNHAPPY EMPLOYER
CONTROL INTO BASHER COULD
PETITION DENY POLLUTION OF
THESE RIGHTS TO BEAR ARMS. MR
LAW REQUIRES. LICENSED
PSYCHOTHERAPIST TO REPORT IN
IDENTITY A PERSON TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A REQUIRES LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THE TO NOTIFY THE
TO OF JUSTICE BUT THEN TO FOUR
HOURS OF RECEIVING THE REPORT
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY TWO WOULD
ALLOW THE CYCLE THERE WAS TWO
INSTEAD NOTED BY THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF SUCH THAT WE
REQUIRE. THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
WHEN RECEIVING A REPORT OF SUCH
A THREAT TO NOTIFY THE
DEPARTMENT. IT'S JUST I'M
ALREADY ALLOWS FOR THE EXPIRY
PROCEDURES AND INDIVIDUALS
RIGHTS WOULD BE. RESTRICTED
WERE NOT EVEN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTEST
ALLEGATIONS FOR UP TO TWENTY
ONE DAYS. AFTER THE ORIGINAL
ISSUES ORIGINAL ORDER. EVEN IF
THE COURT FINDS IN FAVOR THE
PERSON'S RIGHTS RESTRICTED TO
ME TAKE THAT INDIVIDUAL SEVERAL
MONTHS TO HAVE THEIR FARMS
RETURN. THE CURRENT PROCEDURES
WHEN YOU LOOK BACK JUST A
LITTLE OVER THREE YEARS AGO
THIS EXPANSION. OF AUTHORIZED
PETITIONERS YEAH OUTLINED IN AB
SIXTY ONE DOESN'T GO INTO
EFFECT UNTIL SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY. THERE IS NO EVIDENCE IS
EXTENDED ADDITIONALEXPANSION
FOR THE GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS PRUDENT.
EVEN MENTAL HEALTH WORKERS
THEMSELVES HAVE TESTIFIED
AGAINST THIS AFTERNOON PASS
ATTEMPTS WHEN THEY WERE
INCLUDED. IN ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX NINETY
SEVEN. THE SAY GIVE
CALIFORNIA'S IS A VERY FUND OUT
FEDERATION OF OUR ORGANIZATION
AND IT'S CONSISTENT GOAL TO
WORK TOWARDS CONSCIENCE
SOLUTIONS REGARDING ISSUES OF
CRIME. AND FARM OWNERSHIP THIS
CANNOT THIS CAN BE DONE HOWEVER
WITHOUT SACRIFICING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AND
ABILITY OF. LAW BIASES TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. FOR THE FOREGOING
REASONS THE GERMAN WE'RE
JOURNAL VOTING CALIFORNIA RIFLE
PISTOL SESSION OPPOSES AB.
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY TWO THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU SIR. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
IT. THANK RESEARCHER IS IT NOT
STILL HERNANDEZ IS ON THE PHONE
LINE IN YOUR BUT DO NOT HAVE AN
OPEN MIND YOU MAY PRESS STAR
AND THEN. ZERO ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. MR HERNANDEZ'S YOUR
LINE. YOU MAY CONTINUE BUT
YOU'LL YOU'LL NEED TO SPEAK UP.
THANK YOU I DID NOT SEVEN AND
IS ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TERMS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
LEGISLATION. OUR PRIMARILY
CONCERNED THAT THE BILL FURTHER
BLURS THE LINE BETWEEN THE BILL
PROSECUTORS NOT OF LONG. OVER
THE YEARS- THE CLOSE KNIT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
PROSECUTORS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
WITHIN THE PRECEDING DURING TO
EFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT OF UNLAWFUL
ACTIVITY BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
LAUREN AT THE PROSECUTOR
CERTAINLY THE FILE CHARGES. I
IN REALITY YOU CAN VIEW. OUR
HAVE CREATED THE REAL PERCEIVED
DISTRAUGHT OF PROSECUTOR. THIS
BILL WOULD ESSENTIALLY CREATING
QUALIFYING TURN CLIENT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE A
VIRTUAL LOCK PORTION OFFICER.
HAVE THE AFFECTED FURTHER THE
WILL LOOK PROSECUTORS. AND ALSO
CREATE CONFLICT LEGAL ENOUGH
QUESTIONS WITH THIS WITH A-
UNDER LAW YOU HAVE TO YOU
TURNING THE COUNTY COUNCIL
REPRESENTING MOM FORTUNATE
BECAUSE THEY ARE PACKED YOU
TURN FOR THE EMPLOYER. I. AND
PUT IT BE ON POINT AND YOU'RE
NOT A NOTHING ON RELATIONSHIPS
KEEP IN MIND THAT THIS BILL
GUILTY BE THE WHO ARE YET IN
THE JUNIOR PROCESS. THERE'S NOT
BEEN THE CASE BROUGHT AGAINST
THEM AND SO THE COULD BE A IN
THE MISSION PATCHES MORE.
HOUSING A LOT OF PROBLEM ALI WE
ARE. HAVE TO IN MIND THAT THERE
POTENTIAL BETTER LONG COURSE
NOT CERTAIN RECORD BY. THE TIME.
BACK SUBJECT NOW. BUT THAT ALSO
COMPLICATE THE THAT YOU BE TO
ABLE AND LONG. OUR COMPLETE
REASON WE FEEL THAT THE LEGAL
AND ETHICAL THAT WERE ANY
MINUTE BENNETT I HAVE THE A
PLACE AS WELL THOSE CAN DO A
POSTER ON. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER. A WITNESSES IN OP
NAME AN ORGAN. MR MARGARITA.
CARE IT THAT AS AN ON PLEASE
PRESS ONE THE ZERO WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF TO TWENTY TWO TWO FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THERE ARE ANY OTHERS
YOU MAY ALSO QUEUE UP. TWO TWO
FIVE- THEY'RE WALKING BACK ONE
MOMENT. YOUR LINES OPEN THE I
MANDA CHAIRPERSON SOUTH
SACRAMENTO CA ARE PRETTY
CHAPTER IN IN ALL RIGHT MEMBERS
TRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SIR.
YOU THERE ARE NO OTHERS AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU UP WITH THE
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS KAMLAGER THE- I WANNA.
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR- YOUR
CONTINUED PASSION ON THIS ISSUE
AND I BELIEVE THAT AT SOME
POINT. WE WILL FIND SOME COMMON
GROUND- I WANT TO SAY THAT I AM
UNABLE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AT
THIS TIME IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
I WOULD TOTALLY BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT A BILL THAT DEALS
SOLELY WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH
ASPECTS OF THIS BUT I HAVE SOME
GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT SORT OF.
EXPANDING THE ALREADY BLOATED
AUTHORITY OF DA'S OFFICES- AND
PROSECUTORS AND WOULD WISH
THAT. THERE COULD BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR. MAYBE MORE
COLLABORATIVE APPROACHES TO
TRYING TO SEEK GDR ROSE THAT
WOULD INCLUDE NOT JUST D. A.'S-
OR CA'S BUT ALSO YOU KNOW. THE
IMPACT OF COMMUNITIES. PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND OR- DEFENSE
COUNSEL. I JUST I DO HAVE
CONCERNS- MANY FOLKS THAT IT
GOOD WORKING HARD WORKING GOOD
PEOPLE IN THE D. A.'S AND THE
SEA IS OFFICES AND ALSO IN
COUNTY COUNCILS. I'M KIND OF
RELATE AN UNDERSTANDING THAT'S
REALLY REQUIRED THAT I THINK IS
REALLY REQUIRED WHEN YOU'RE
MOVING INTO- THE DIRECTION OF
THIS KIND OF- THIS EFFORT. AND
SO MAYBE THERE'S A WAY TO THINK
ABOUT THAT AND- SOMETHING
THAT'S MORE RESTORE IN
COLLABORATIVE- AND WOULD
CERTAINLY BE SUPPORTIVE OF
SOMETHING LIKE THAT- AND I WANT
TO MAINTAIN THAT I DO SUPPORT
THE ASPECT OF THIS THAT DEAL
WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING MICHAEL MOORE SET. TO
TESTIFIED- I WANNA THANK YOU
SIR FOR- YOUR AND YOUR
TESTIMONY. THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
VETERAN YOU MAY CHRIS LIKELY
ASK FOR YOUR I'VE OF. THANK YOU
INDEED THE CHAIRS OF
RECOMMENDING AYE BOAT AND IN
TOLL FREE TAKE THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE AND IN IN
CONSIDERATION AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD AND LISTENING TO.
REALLY HOW TO MAKE THE BILL OF
BETTER FOR EVERYONE. AND SO THE
CHAIRS RECOMMENDED I. BILL'S
BEEN PROPERLY MOVE IS BIG
PROPERTY MOVED IN SECOND. ON AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY TWO- WHEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
ARE LACKEY I BAUER-KAHAN. DEEP
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER NO GARCIA
GARCIA HI SAN DIEGO SAN DIEGO
HI WICKS. THAT VOTE IS FOR WHEN
THAT MEASURES ON CALL IT NEEDS
ONE. VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE IT
AND APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS TO
THIS CALL LONGER THAT IS. AND
NOW WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A FORTY
FIVE MINUTE. BREAK AT TWO
O'CLOCK WHICH IS PROBABLY LESS
THAN FORTY BUT A LOOK AT ME
LIKE I WON A LITTLE MORE TIME.
YES. THE CITY OF SO DO WHAT WE
STAND IN RECESS I NEED TO.
WE'RE GONNA STAND RECESS TILL
TWO O'CLOCK.
THE BACK IN ORDER
WAIT FOR COM LAW THE DOVE.
INTERESTED COMMITTEE TO COME
HERE SO WE CAN BEGIN. AB
NINETEEN FIFTY PROBATION LENGTH
OF TERMS NUMBER SIXTEEN
KAMLAGER DOVE. THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YEAH. YEAH.
HI. ALL.
WE HAVE A QUORUM IS
COLORED UP WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MAKE YOUR VISITATION AB
NINETEEN FIFTY. HAVE YOU. YES
WE DID WE DID. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IS EVERYTHING ALRIGHT.
OKAY EVER AGAIN MY BAD. MY BAD
I AM HERE TO PRESENTS. AB
NINETEEN FIFTY WHICH SETS A
MAXIMUM PROBATION PERIOD OF ONE
YEAR FOR MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES
AND TWO YEARS FOR A FELONY
OFFENSES IN EIGHTEEN FORTY ONE.
JOHN I GUESS THIS CONCEIVED OF
A NATION OF PROBATION AS AN
INFORMAL INDIVIDUALIZED SYSTEM
THAT WAS HEAVILY FOCUSED ON
REHABILITATION. THAT VISION HAS
METASTASIZED INTO A HUMAN
WAREHOUSING SYSTEM. AND
STRUCTURE THAT ATTEMPTS TO A
LIST OF COMPLIANCE FROM
INDIVIDUALS PRIMARILY THROUGH
THE IMPOSITION OF FINES FINES
FEES AND CONDITIONS THAT OFTEN
CANNOT BE MATT. THIS WEB IN
WHICH PROBATIONERS FIND
THEMSELVES IS UNDER FUNDED AND
FINANCIAL BURDENS LEVIED ON TOP
OF NUMEROUS CONDITIONS OVER AN
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME HAVE
BECOME A RECIPE FOR DISASTER.
DEFAULTING PROBATION OFFICERS
INTO ADMINISTRATIVE COLLECTION
AGENTS RATHERTHAN ENGAGE
REHABILITATIVE EXTENSIONS OF
COURTS AND COUNTIES. PROBATION
IS THE MOST TO LEE USE FORM OF
CORRECTIONAL CONTROL IN THIS
STATE CALIFORNIA'S ADULT
SUPERVISION POPULATION IS ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
IT IS ONE OF THE LARGEST OF ANY
STATE IN THE NATION MORE THAN
TWICE THE SIZE OF OUR PRISON
POPULATION ALMOST FOUR TIMES
LARGER THAN OUR JAIL POPULAR.
AND SIX ONE. OUR POPULATION. IT
IS ALSO THE BIGGEST. IN PRISON.
FOR PROBATIONERS THIS PERIOD OF
SUPERVISION COMES WITH STRICT
MANDATES. A SENTENCE OF
PROBATION REQUIRES THE PERSON
UNDER SUPERVISION TO REPORT ON
A REGULAR SCHEDULE AND IT HERE
TO A NUMBER OF CONDITIONS LIKE
BEING DRUG FREE. I'M AT A
CERTAIN TIME ATTENDING SESSIONS
NOT IN THE FRONT SEAT OF A
VEHICLE OR EVEN GETTING
PREGNANT. THE AVERAGE NUMBER OF
CONDITIONS IS ABOUT FIFTY OR A
PROBATIONER INVITE IT YEAH
CONDITIONS ALONG WITH THE LAW
OR ORDER AND SO. RESULT IN
ORDER. CONDITIONS THERE ARE THE
GREATER THE LIKELIHOOD IS THAT
SOME WILL BE VIOLATED AND THEN
THERE ARE THE FINES AND FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH BEING A
PROBATION. THE FEES FOR SOMEONE
ON PROBATION IS MORE THAN
THIRTY SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
PROBATIONERS ARE REQUIRED TO
PAY FOR COURT. AND PROBATION
SUPERVISION COSTS BOOKING LAB
AND URINALYSIS FEES ANGER
MANAGEMENT CLASSES X. AT
AROUND. CONSIDER THAT PEOPLE ON
PROBATION WILL LIKELY EARN A
LOW INCOME OR BE UNEMPLOYED
BECAUSE THEY ARE ON VACATION.
AND THAT FAILURE TO FATE PAY
THESE FINES AND FEES WHILE ON
PROBATION ULTIMATELY RESULT IN
A VIOLATION. SO FATIGUE AND
FAILURE BECOME A PART OF THIS
WEB AND AS A RESULT A LARGE
PORTION OF PEOPLE ON PROBATION
VIOLATE THEIR TERM REQUIREMENTS
AND END UP INCARCERATED. 20% OF
PRISON ADMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE THE RESULT OF SUPERVISED
PROBATION VIOLATIONS ACCOUNTING
FOR PART OF THE ESTIMATED TWO
BILLION WITH A B. DOLLARS SPENT
ANNUALLY BY THE STATE CAR THREE
PEOPLE FOR THE SUPERVISION
VIOLATIONS. IN TWENTY EIGHT IN
A PERCENT OF PEOPLE
INCARCERATED IN CALIFORNIA
PRISON WERE BEHIND BARS FOR
SUPERVISED PROBATION VIOLATIONS
MOST OF WHICH WERE TECHNICAL IN
OF SUPERVISING SOMEONE ON
PROBATION IS TWELVE DOLLARS. OR
ABOUT FORTY FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS A YEAR. CALIFORNIA
PROBATION DEPARTMENT SUPERVISES
THE LARGEST POPULATION YET THEY
RECEIVE THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
FUNDING COMPARED TO OTHER
SUPERVISION DEPARTMENTS HANSOL
THE FINES AND FEES WHICH BECOME
ON COLLECTIBLE. THIS IS A BAD
BUSINESS MODEL FOR ALL OF US
STATES COUNTIES PROBATIONERS
AND TAXPAYERS. WE NEED A
PROBATION SYSTEM FOR THE COST
OF THE PROGRAMS DO NOT EXCEED
THE ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENSES
WHICH CAN HAPPEN WHEN YOU HAVE
FEWER PEOPLE ON PROBATION.
PROBATION OFFICERS WITH LIGHTER
CASE LOADS ARE BETTER ABLE TO
DO THEIR JOB SMALL CASE FRONT.
WITH THE SERVER. SIGN FOR SIX
OTHER FOR FAIR IS WHERE WE
SHOULD BE HEADED ESPECIALLY NOW.
THERE WOULD BE FEWER
PROBATIONERS TO CLOG UP THE
COURTS. THE TIME OF PROSECUTORS
AND PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND MORE
TIME AND RESOURCES COULD BE
SPENT ON HIGH RISK HIGH NEED
PROBATIONERS. THE OPPONENTS SAY
THAT THIS IS ONE SIZE FITS ALL
BUT THE CURRENT MODEL IS ONE
SIZE FITS ALL. THREE FIVE EIGHT
YEAR TERMS VIOLATIONS THAT LAND
YOU IN JAIL OR PRISON ARE BACK
TO SQUARE ONE WHERE YOU HAVE TO
START THE CLOCK ALL OVER AGAIN.
WITH NO REAL INCENTIVE TO
SUCCEED. IS ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY DOES REDUCE
TIME ON PROBATION BASED ON THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY OPPOSE ALL
STUDIES AND MODELS PRACTICE IN
THIS STATE SUCH AS CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY US CANNOT A STUDY OF
THIS COUNTIES PRACTICES REVEAL
THAT JUDGES ISSUED A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF SENTENCES
IN THE TWENTY FOUR MONTH RANGE
OR LOWER. PROBATIONERS WAS
SHORTER TERMS HAVE LOWER
RECIDIVISM RATES THE COUNTY
RELIED HEAVILY AMONG OTHER
THINGS ON RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS
AND CONTRACTED SERVICES TO THE
LEVER NEEDED TREATMENT TO THOSE
IN GREATEST NEED. RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT PROBATION SERVICE
SUCH AS MENTAL HEALTH CARE AN
ADDICTION TREATMENT ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE DURING THE FIRST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF SUPERVISION.
RESEARCH ALSO INDICATES THAT
PROVIDING INCREASED SUPERVISION
AND SERVICES EARLIER REDUCES AN
INDIVIDUAL'S LIKELIHOOD TO
RESERVE EIGHT. AND I MIGHT ADD
THAT IN TWO YEARS YOU CAN DO A
LOT YOU CAN BECOME AN AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROLLER YOU CAN
COULD BECOME AN AVIONICS
TECHNICIAN YOU CAN BECOME A
NUCLEAR MEDICAL TECHNICIAN ALL
OF THOSE CAN HAPPEN IN TWO
YEARS. I THINK I AGREE THAT YOU
WANT PEOPLE OFFER PROBATION AND
YOU DON'T WANT THEM TO GET BACK
ON. BUT LAST TIME DOESN'T MEAN
LESS MEANINGFUL OR LESS
MEMORABLE OR EVEN EASY. AB
NINETEEN FIFTY IS NOT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL. DEPARTMENTS WITH
DESIGN PROGRAMS WITH MORE
EFFECTIVE TERMS OF SUPERVISION
AN INDIVIDUALIZED TREATMENT
SERVICES. CORD STILL AND WOULD
CONTINUE TO GET PROGRESS
REPORTS ON PROBATIONERS JUDGES
WOULD ALSO STILL HAVE THE
LATITUDE TO REVOKE PROBATION IF
A PROBATIONER IS GROSSLY OUT OF
COMPLIANCE RESTITUTION WOODS WE
DO. ALL ADDS IS THE CASE TODAY.
CALVET NINETEEN IS FORCED US TO
ACCEPT THE NEW NORMAL IN REGARD
TO OUR JOBS SOCIAL LIVES AND
MORE. I CHALLENGED US TO
ENVISION A NEW NORMAL WHERE
JUSTICE IS BASED ON RESEARCH
FACTS AND FIGURES. AND WHAT IS
ARE DESIGNED FOR A FIFTH. AND
SUCCESS. A NEW NORMAL WHERE
SUPERVISION IS NOT ABOUT HOW
LONG SOMEONE'S TERM IS BUT HOW
MEANINGFUL THE TERM IS. THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA AGREED WITH THIS IN
FACT IN JANUARY WHEN THEY
ISSUED A PRESS RELEASE IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S NOW
WITHDRAWN PROBATION REFORM
TRAILER BILL. SAYING INVESTING
IN EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES ON
THE FRONT TEN AND ALIGNING
SUPERVISION AND SERVICES WITH A
PERSON'S RISK AND NEEDS RATHER
THAN SIMPLY THEIR OFFENSE. WILL
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY AND GIVE
PEOPLE A BETTER CHANCE OF
STAYING CRIME FREE FOR THE LONG
TERM. THIS GROUP NOW OPPOSES
THIS BILL ALTHOUGH WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION ON
A NUMBER OF SENSIBLE AMENDMENTS
THAT WILL ADDRESS SOME OF THEIR
CONCERNS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON AB. NINETEEN
FIFTY TO HELP MOVE US ALONG IN
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS WHICH IN
FACT WERE JUST HAPPENING A
MINUTE AGO. HERE WITH ME IN
SUPPORT IS MAN WHO RUNS YOU OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE. AS WELL AS
DAVID MUHAMMAD OF THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM. THANK. YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK. YOU THANK
YOU. AND I'LL SECOND IT. WE CAN
NOW HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO DEFENDER
AND TO FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM. MISTER MODERATOR CAN
YOU PASS THE MEN. THANK YOU
THOSE LINES ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS MY NAME
IS BELOW ROGER. AND I BE
ELECTED PUBLIC DEFENDER
SEPARATE. I'M USED TO BE
SPEAKING TO YOU TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NIKE FIFTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. KAMLAGER AB
NINETEEN FIFTY RECOGNIZE THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO PROBATION
SUPERVISION LESS REALLY CAN BE
MORE IT IS MORE. BUT DEFENDERS
WE FREQUENTLY THE FORMER CLIENT
OF OURS. WE APART LONG AND HARD
ALONG SIDE GERM FRIEDMAN HI GO
BACK INTO THAT THAT THE SIMPLY
DUE TO THE TECHNICAL
POPULATION. PROBATION CAN. THE
TECHNICAL. INCLUDE ANYTHING
FROM THAT TO GET. BLOCKED UP TO
MORE THAN ONE FIGHT TOLD ME
THEY TRIED TO REACH A PROBATION
OFFICER WITH VOICE MAIL WAS
FULL. TO UNPAID CARTONS. OKAY
THE IT'S KIND OF NET WHAT THE
END UP MAKING SOMETHING THAT IN
THEORY IS SUPPOSED TO BE ALL
ACTUALLY CARPAL. ROCKETS YEAH I
BRING NUMBERS ILLUSTRATE A TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN JET THE
CENTER OF THE COUNCIL OF STATE
GOVERNMENTS STUDY OF 67% 67%
JAIL AND PRISON ADMISSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN WE'RE DUE TO
TECHNICAL VIOLATION. PAROLE AND
PROBATION VIOLATION END UP
COSTING THE STATE APPROXIMATELY
TWO BILLION ANNUAL. THIS IS A
HUGE CONTRIBUTOR YOUR TO THE
VERY QUOTE JAIL CHURN UNQUOTE
PROBLEM THAT IT BECOME A MUCH
MORE WELL KNOWN ISSUE SIR DUE
TO THE CORONAVIRUS. THE NEED
FOR REDUCING NET WIDENING JAIL
CHURN HAS BECOME EVEN MORE CUTE
DURING THE END OF IT. ANY
UNNECESSARY PRODUCT THAT THE
PEOPLE. OPEN PRESENTS INCREASES
THE LIKELIHOOD OF THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS AMONGST LAW
ENFORCEMENT. BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY A LOT. IT'S A GREAT
TIME IN JAIL AND PRISON EVEN
MORE DANGEROUS AND FOR MANY
THAT LOOK. IT INCLUDES THE
FIRST PERSON CODED NINETEEN
RYKER'S ISLAND. NEW YORK CITY
JAIL. HIS NAME WAS MICHAEL TYPE
HE WAS FIFTY THREE YEARS OLD
AND WITHIN JAILBREAK TECHNICAL
VIOLATION CALL FAILING TO SHOW
UP FOR PAROLE ME. PROBATION
ALSO OFFICE THEN THE WAY PEOPLE
LOOK FOR WITH THEIR LIVES. IN
ORDER TO QUALIFY RECORD
EXPUNGED MUST'VE SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETED PROBATION. SO MAKING
A PROBATION CAN PREVENT SOMEONE
FROM BE BEING ABLE TO CLEAR
THEIR CRIMINAL RECORD WHICH IN
TURN BLOCKED THEM OUT OF JOBS
AND HELPING IMPACTING THEM AND
CRITICALLY CRITICALLY THEIR
FAMILIES THAT'S LEADING TO
GENERAL SMALL IMPACTS ON OTHERS.
A CHILL OF THE ONE ON PROBATION.
FURTHER BEING DENIED EMPLOYMENT
OR STABLE HOUSING ARE
INDICATORS LIKELY TO LEAD FOLKS
BACK INTO AN INTEGUMENT BUT THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM. AND
FREQUENTLY RESULT IN
HOMELESSNESS. LONGER PROBATION
PERIOD I'M JUST NOT GOOD PUBLIC
POLICY IF THE EVIDENCE SHOWED
MALL MALL WAS. DIFFERENT STORY
BUT- IT SHOWS THE OPPOSITE
ELECTED SO THERE'S NO MORE
FEELING MORE SATISFYING TO
PUBLIC DEFENDER THAT TO SEE
SOMEONE GO THROUGH A COMPLETE
PROBATION SUCCESSFULLY AND THEN
GET A CLEAN PLATE CERTIFICATE
AND GET THE JOB WE WANT THAT
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER. GOOD
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY. FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL AND GENERATION FALL
WHICH REALLY ALL THE EVIDENCE
NOT DOING SO AS COSTLY BOTH IN
DOLLARSAND ENJOY THAT FOR ALL
THESE REASONS. CHARLIE URGE
YOUR I BOUGHT THE NINETEEN
FIFTY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THE. DAVID MUHAMMAD.
ROUND IF YOU DON'T FIND THAT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE PRESS
STAR AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. HELLO YES GO AHEAD OKAY
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR JONES SAWYER AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAVID
MUHAMMAD AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM I'M ALSO THE PROPERTY
PROBATION OFFICER IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY FORMER DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER PROBATION IN NEW
YORK CITY. THE DAY AND DEBATE
TEAM FIFTY. BRING MUCH NEEDED
RELIEF TO PROBATION OFFICERS
HANDED ALIGNED WITH EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES. PROBATION IS
BY FAR THE LARGEST PORTION OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
THE COUNTRY WHICH IS ALSO TRUE
IN CALIFORNIA. ACCORDING TO THE
MOST RECENT DATA THERE ARE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
ADULTS UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE CALIFORNIA. FROM
WHAT WE CAN GLEAN THERE ABOUT
TWO TO THREE TIMES THAT AMOUNT
ON MISDEMEANOR PROBATION KNOWN
AS CORPORATION. BUT ALL THAT
DATA IS NOT AVAILABLE. FOR
ADULTS THE SUPERVISION COUNTY
PROBATION APARTMENTS HAVE THE
LET THE PROBATION VARIES FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY MOST OF THREE
YEARS BUT SEVERAL COUNTIES AS
LONG AS FIVE. FOR MISDEMEANOR
PROBATION THE TERMS ARE USUALLY
THREE YEARS BUT THERE IS NO
ACTIVE SUPERVISION. AB NINETEEN
FIFTY PROPOSES A MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT WAY TO
OPERATE PROBATION. AB NINETEEN
FIFTY PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
FRONTLINE WORKERS AND SEVERAL
LARGE TO MID SIZED COUNTIES
PROBATION OFFICERS HAVE
CASELOADS UPWARDS OF ONE
HUNDRED AND SOME OF. IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO QUALITY WORK WITH
SIXTY PEOPLE LET ALONE ONE
HUNDRED. ABNINETEEN FIFTY
MAKES THE SAME LIMITS ON
PROBATION AS THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED IN HIS BUDGET THIS
JANUARY. I AGREE WITH MY FORMER
COLLEAGUES OF THE CHIP
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT PROPOSAL AND
SAID THAT IT REFLECTED QUOTE
RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES WORKING
WITH INDIVIDUALS USING
APPROPRIATE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS WITHIN THE FOUR. YEARS
OF THE PROBATION TERM IS THE-
PAINS TO HATE. DO A HAND ON. IN
THE MAY READ THE GUY HAS BEEN A
COUPLE ROLE TERMS TO TWO YEARS
FOR MOST PAROLEESIN ADDITION
TO PROVIDING EARNED EARLY
DISCHARGE GIVING THEM SHORTER
TERMS ON PAROLE. FOR POPULATION
IN GENERAL AT HIGHER RISK THAN
PEOPLE ON PROBATION. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE HARVARD
KENNEDY SCHOOL'S EXECUTIVE
SESSION ON COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS WHICH INCLUDED
SEVERAL CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS RECOMMENDED REDUCING
SUPERVISION TERMS TO BETWEEN
ONE AND TWO YEARS WITH
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITY TO TERM
TIME TO EARN TIME OFF OF
PROBATION. IN APRIL ARNOLD ON
VACATION AND PEW CHARITABLE
TRUSTS RELEASED A POLICY
FRAMEWORK WITH OVER FIFTY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION. WHICH
INCLUDES REDUCING THE SIZE OF
PROBATION AND FOCUSING
SUPERVISION ON THE INITIAL
PERIOD WHEN MOST THE ARRESTS
OCCUR. A PREVIOUS STUDY BY PEW
REVEALED THAT AFTER EIGHTEEN
MONTHS OF SUPERVISION THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT SOMEOE MORE
SEDATE SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES
AND THEREFORE SUPERVISION
SHOULD BE FRONT LOADED TO THE
FIRST TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS
AND FOCUSED ON THOSE ASSESSED
AT HIGHER RISK. AB NINETEEN
FIFTY WOMEN'S BEST PRACTICES
AND REPRESENTED A WIN WIN. IT
REDUCES THE IT'S LOADS OF
OVERWORKED PROBATION OFFICERS
FOCUSES ATTENTION FOR THE RIGHT
TIME OF SUPERVISION AND A
FAIRER TO THE PEOPLE ON
SUPERVISION FOR THESE REASONS I
THANK YOU AND URGE A ES VOTE
ON A. B. NINETEEN FIFTY. GOOD
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF MR MODERATE. NAME IN
OUR ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU IF
YOU AREN'T SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME WELL
FIRST ONLINE TO NINETY TWO. THE
LINE IS OPEN. TWO NINE TWO WERE
YOU ON MUTE FROM YOUR OWN
DEVICE. MAMA BYE BYE EIGHT OF
THAT BOOK AHEAD. SORRY CAN WIN
GAME ALIVE FOR POINT MEN OF
COLOR ACT POLICY LINK IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE THREE
OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN THREE
HUNDRED FIVE. DATAQUEST ROMERO
AT THE CEILING. IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. LOCAL NINE
TO NINETY ONE TWO NINE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SENATOR FIRST
MARKED UP THE CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT. RIGHT. LINE
THREE TWELVE THREE ONE TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ISRAEL VIA WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
YOUTH THE COMMUNITY JUSTICE
INSTRUCTABLE. THANK YOU THREE
TWENTY THREE TWO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SORRY LINE THREE
TWENTY ARE YOU THERE. WILL MOVE
ON TO LINE TWO EIGHTY FIVE LINE
TWO EIGHT FIVE THE OPEN. FIND
YOUR LOCAL SOCIAL WORKERS THE
CLERK. THANK YOU. LINE ONE OH
SEVEN ONE ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAPTION AND AGREE THAT
WOULD INITIATE JUSTICE AND
TRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
THREE EIGHTEEN THREE ONE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT.
MOVING A THREE OH FOUR THREE
HUNDRED FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHT GREAT THANK Y.
COORDINATOR POLITICAL WORK IN
COLLEGE NOW AND STOP THE CORE.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN TWO EIGHT SEVEN HER LINE
MANNER BUT THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NINE TWO NINE EIGHT TO NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
QUITE AGAIN IT WOULD BE ALMOST
A THREE TO INSTRUCT PORT. THANK
YOU. LINE THREE NINETEEN THREE
ONE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE THREE NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WILL MOVE TO LINE TWO
SIXTY EIGHT TWO SIX EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU. ALL OF
US AND THEN MARCH ON IN THE
FAMILY PROJECT AND I STAND
BEFORE. THANK YOU. NINE TWO
SEVEN SEVEN TO SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IS IN YOUR
BRIEF THEIR FORMER ALLIANCE AND
WE HAVE WITH THE PORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NATIONAL GUARD LINE
TO NINETY FOUR TWO NINE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO NINETY
FOUR ARE YOU ON MUTE ON YOUR
DEVICE. AS REMINDER IF THERE
ARE OTHERS IN SUPPORT ME PRESS
ONE ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE TO
FOR. THREE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE FOURTEEN DO YOU HAVE A
POSITION. THE WORKER- GEORGE
AND I HAVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. OUR LAST COMMON IN Q. IS.
TO NINETY THREE TWO NINE THREE.
A LOCAL MOTEL WITH THE YOUNG
WOMAN FREEDOM CENTER AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL LINE. TWO
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
TO NINE FOUR. BECAUSE I WAS
WITH INITIATE THE LOCAL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND FINALLY IN LINE
THREE NINETEEN THREE ONE NINE
GO AHEAD. BETTER CLEAN WITH THE
AMERICAN CONSERVATIVE UNION
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT THE
PRINCIPLE. THANK YOU. NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. AND THERE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION. I
HAVE GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN BUT- THIS DETERMINER
MEMBERS- LARRY MORSE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FIFTY
WHICH WOULD DRAMATICALLY SURE
THE PROBATION PERIOD IN ALL
CASES IN WHICH PROBATION IS
IMPOSED. LIMITING PROBATION TO
TWO YEARS IN ALL CRIMINAL CASES
IS A NECESSARY COURT ALREADY
HAVE THE POWER TO CHOOSE AN
INITIAL READ OF PROBATION THAT
IS APPROPRIATE FOR A PARTICULAR
CASE AND- TO TERMINATE THAT.
FOR PROBATION COMPLETES ALL
TERMS AND CONDITIONS BILL CODE
SECTION TWELVE OH TWO POINT
SEVEN SAYS THE SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC SHALL BE A PRIMARY GOAL
THROUGH THE ENFORCEMENT OF
COURT ORDERED CONDITIONS OF
PROBATION. THIS BILL WOULD
STRIP AWAY FROM JUDGE. THOSE
MOST FAMILIAR WITH THE FACTS
AND CIRCUMSTANCES OF A GIVEN
CASE THE POWER TO DECIDE THE
APPROPRIATE LIKE THE PROBATION
BASED ON THE MOST RELEVANT
FACTORS. THIS IS A DEFENSE YOUR
VENDOR. THREE WHO SHOULD THE
OFFENDER OF THE CRIME VICTIM
AND THE TYPE OF WE HAVE. PRO
THE COURT ORDER THIS BILL
WOULD STEM. REPLACE THE COURT
INFO DISK IN. WITH A ONE SIZE
FITS APPROACH IN WHICH EVERY
FELON ON PROBATION WOULD BE
RELIEVED FROM HIS OR HER COURT
ORDERED OBLIGATIONS AFTER TWO
YEARS. WHAT ABOUT HOUSE BOUND
ELDERLY VICTIMS OF FINANCIAL
CRIMES FOR EXAMPLE WHO LOST
THEIR LIFE SAVINGS AS A RESULT
OF THE CRIMINAL ACTS OF AN
OFFENDER. WHAT DOES THIS BILL
TELL THEM REGARDING THE
RESTITUTION SORRY TWO YEARS ARE
UP AND THIS BILL WILL COURT NO
LONGER HAS ANY JURISDICTION TO
HELP YOU RECOVER WHAT WAS
STOLEN FROM YOU. YOU CAN OF
COURSE. BUT IS DO THROUGH CIVIL
JUDGMENT PROCESS. OR CONSIDER A
PERSON WHO HAS RACKED UP FOR DO
YOU AYE CONVICTIONS IN LESS
THAN TEN YEARS. AND IS
SENTENCED FOR ABOUT. UNDER
EXISTING LAW A JOB. LIAM POSES
FIVE YEARS FELONY PROBATION. AS
THE TERM AND CONDITION OF THAT
PROBATION THE DEFENDANT IS TO
INSTALL AND MAINTAIN AN
INTERLOCKING MISSION DEVICE
WHICH PRESENT PREVENTS HIM FROM
STARTING IS CAR WITHOUT FIRST
READING INTO THE DEVICE- THE
HAS THE ALCOHOL IN HIS SYSTEM.
HIS BROTHER ORDER NO MEASURABLE
AMOUNT OF ALCOHOL THIS IS THE
MALL DRIVE. UNDER THIS BILL.
AFTER JUST TWO YEARS. DESPITE
OF THE HISTORY OF DRIVING WHILE
INTOXICATED HE WOULD. BE TO
CONNECT. THE VICE AND DRY
WITHOUT THE WHOLE IT IS SYSTEM
WITHOUT CONSEQUENCE. HOW DOES
THAT. I WOULD. THOSE WELL GO TO.
THAT THIS OF THE PUBLIC BE THE-
GOAL. WE ALSO WERE TAKE ISSUE
WITH THE INFO SO IN THE- THAT
SAYS 8% OF CALIFORNIA'S PRISON
POPULATION IS INCARCERATED FOR
VIOLATING COMPARATIVELY MINOR
PROBATION- CONDITIONS IS
MISSING DRUG APPOINTMENT OR
SOCIAL SOCIALIZING WITH A
FRIEND WHO HAS A CRIMINAL
RECORD. WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
DON'T BELIEVE THERE ARE RATHER
CREDIBLE. DOUBLE THE NOT. ABOUT
MEMBERS ON PROBATION BEING
SPENT INSTANCE PRISON WHEN A
DRUG TREATMENT APPOINTMENT WAS
WITH THE- THERE MAY BE CASES
LIKE THE EXAM I SAW IN THE A
PERSON ON FELLOW PROBATION FOR
THE WHY IS THAT TO PRISON BY A
JUDGE OF REMOVING AN- ICE.
ABOUT THIS. ONLY 3% OF STATE
POPULAR IS IN CARS FOR FILE OF
PROBATION AND WITH RESPECT TO
SEE EVIDENCE THAT QUITE VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ASSAULTS
AND I CRIMES AND THE PUBLIC AT
LARGE THE LAW ON THE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS OF PROBATION PUT.
HARPER IN TERMS OF YOURS. THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE CRIME THAT
WAS COULD AND THE PERSON WHO
COMMITS IT BREAKS OF OUR
RESPONSE TO FIND VICTIMS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE RESPECTFULLY
APPS WILL MOBILE. LIKE THANK
YOU MISTER MORRIS. DANIELLE
SANCHEZ JUST PROBATION OFFICERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU I
CHAIR NUMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS A CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
DETECT THE NINETEEN AT THE END
OF CURRENTLY WRITTEN I DO WANT
TO EXTEND OUR APPRECIATION- AN
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- COME LONGER.
CAPTION WITH HER OFFICE PGD FOR
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT A VERY-STRONG COMMITMENT TO COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
WHICH WE- ABSOLUTELY SHARE-
PROBATION IS INCREDIBLY
DEDICATED TO A HELP BUT GET.
INDIVIDUALIZED READABILITY.
TREATY YOUR PATHWAYS- IN
PROMOTING PUBLIC SAFETY IN OUR
COMMUNITY- AND AS I THINK WITH
THE EARLIER. POP CERTAINLY DOES
RIGHT NINE. SEARCH AND- OUR-
ISSUE THAT WORKING WITH THE YOU.
THANKS PACKED AT THE THANK YOU
FOR PROVIDING AND SUPPORTS
WITHIN THOSE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
THEIR PROBATION TERM REALLY IS
THAT'S CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR
AND REDUCE THREE EXPENSE I
WOULD JUST ADD HERE THAT I KNOW
A LOT OF RESEARCH ON THAT IT'S
BROKEN ABOUT. NASH REALLY THAT
KIND OF ENCOURAGES COMMITTEE-
AND THE LEGISLATURE AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- CHANGES TO THE
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM TO REALLY
LOOK AT ALL OF THE ADVANCEMENTS
AND WHERE CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
LEADING THE WAY FOR MANY MANY
YEARS. HOW BY ABOUT THE PROGRAM
THE SERVICE IN THE FIRST FEW
YEARS SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT WITH
CAPTAIN TWO THOUSAND NINE AND
REALLY PROVIDED THE FIRST EVER
FUNDS TO LOCAL PROBATION
BUILDUP INFRASTRUCTURE. ALL AT
THE SUPERVISION STRATEGIES AND
REALLY COLLECTED OUR SYSTEMS
RELYING ON INCARCERATION AND
KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF PRISON- WITH
THAT PICKED SEVENTY EIGHT
FUNDING. THREE ENTRANCE. IS A-
FUNCTION THE SUPERVISION
PRACTICES THAT AT THAT ADDRESS
YOU KNOW. WILL POINT TO REDUCE
SET AND AGAIN WITH THE OFFICE
GOAL OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY AS
WELL I WOULD NEVER GONNA. FORTY
WE SB SEVENTY EIGHT HELP REDUCE
PRISON BY. BY MORE THAN 30%
AFTER THE FACT YEAR OF
EMPLOYMENT SHE- AND THE
PRESIDENT. BY MORE THAN SIX
THOUSAND INMATES AND THE FIRST
YEAR ADDITIONALLY THE EIGHT
REDUCE. OUR STATE CORRECTIONAL
EXPENDITURES BY OVER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS SPENT ON
EDUCATION AND THAT CERTAINLY I
THINK IT CAN HIGHLIGHT THAT
AGAIN CALIFORNIA REALLY HAN
LEADING THE WAY IN KEEPING
PEOPLE- OUT OF INCARCERATION
AND THIRTY BETTER IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND AGAIN I A HIGH
LIKE THIS- AS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THE SERVICES OF SUPPORTS
WITHIN THOSE FIRST TWO YEARS IS
REALLY CRITICAL. ACTUALLY
AFFECT THAT SHE- THEN THE BELL.
SO WHERE THEY WORK. SHOULD THE
TERM YOU REALLY BE ALIGNED THE
COMPREHENSIVE THE- TO ENHANCE
THIRTY AND PROGRAMS. DURING HIS
FIRST YEARS AJ ENSURE THAT
PROBATION. ARE RECEIVING WHAT
THE TO ACHIEVE HELP YOUR
CATHOLIC PATHWAYS AND REDUCE
RECIDIVISM- SO AGAIN IT'S
REALLY THAT CAPACITY IN THOSE
FIRST TWO YEARS IN THERE. THE
EXISTING FUNDING. CURRENTLY THE
UPDATED IN STABLE. TO ADDRESS
THIS IN A- WAY TO- SUPPORT OUR
CLIENT. SO WE I THINK WE
CERTAINLY SURE THAT FOCUS ON
EARLY AND EFFECTIVE INVESTMENT-
AND LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
DISCUSSION IN MEDICAID
UNINTENDED COM AT IMPACT AND
SO- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THOSE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR IN THIS
COMMITTEE THAT FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE I RESPECT. THAT
CURRENTLY DRAFTED TODAY. THANK
YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OF
NAMING ORGANIZATION WE HAVE
SOMEONE IN THE GALLERY RIGHT
NOW TO A GUEST DO YOU WANT TO
WAIT YES YES. THE CHAIRMAN
HUBBARD TO RECALL ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE COLUSA PROVISION
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY PROBATION OFFICERS. IN
OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I
COULD THIRTY SECONDS I DON'T
KNOW IT'S AGAINST THE RULES
BUT- I WHAT I DO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HER EFFORTS AND
I WANNA I WANNA SAY THAT WE'RE
IN A GREEN. THE I THINK THE ONE
YOU'RE MISDEMEANOR MARKS THE
ONE YEAR MAX ON MISDEMEANORS IS
PERFECTLY ACCEPTABLE IMPROPER
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE. OUR
CONCERN IS TO CONSERVE NUMBER
ONE IS. THE FUNDING. SB SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH WHICH IS
THE TRANSFER OF MONEY FROM
STATE TO LOCAL. THAT THAT MONEY
IS CONTINGENT UPON SUCCESSFUL
NOT ONLY PROVISION OF A
REHABILITATION EFFORTS.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY
REHABILITATION EFFORTS WILL
TAKE LONGER TO YEARS AND IF WE
DON'T COMPLETE THOSE WE'RE
GONNA LOSE THAT MUCH SO THAT
THAT'S A THAT'S ONE CONCERT.
THE SECOND CONCERN QUITE
FRANKLY IS SUCCESS. MANY CRIMES
ARE PROBABLY NOT SUITED FOR TWO
YEARS PROBATION. VIOLENT
CRIMES. SEX CRIMES DRUG
ADDICTIONS. AND MISTER LUCKY
I'M SURE YOU RECALL PROP THIRTY
SIX. WHICH WAS. PROPOSED AS A
GREAT SOLUTION TO A DRUG
PROBLEM. SO I DID A LOT OF PROP
THIRTY SIX CASES WHEN I WAS IN
PRIVATE PRACTICE FOR CAN LOOK
BEFORE I CAN SACRAMENTO. AND
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH PROP
THIRTY SIX WAS. THAT THERE WAS
REALLY NO INCENTIVE. TO DO WITH
REHABILITATION IN EARNEST THE
ONLY INCENTIVE WITH SIGNATURE
CARD SIGNED. YOU GET FOR YOUR
TIME. AND OUR CONCERN IS THAT.
A PROGRAM LIKE THIS WHERE YOU
WHERE YOU SAY. THE MAXIMUM TIME
ON PROBATION IS TWO YEARS. HILL
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE INFORMATION
TO GET THROUGH THE TWO YEARS.
AND NOT TO BE SERVICE OF A REAL
REFLECTION EFFORT AND THAT'S
REALLY OUR OUR CONCERN IS THE-
WE- PROGRAM SB SIX. IF YOU PUT
IF YOU PUT A CAP BUT TO. SOME
SORT WILL NOT BE REHABILITATED.
BUT BILL RICH THE LINE. AND WE
WILL BE. TYPES OF CRIMES WERE
OPEN TO THE CONVERSATION WE
APPRECIATE THE LET THEM. MISSED
CALL LOGGERS. EFFORTS IN THAT
RESPECT AND WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
WE CAN RESOLVE THIS IN A WAY
THAT MAKES SENSE FOR THE
PUBLIC. AND FOR THE VICTIMS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. YES MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MATTHEW SO I
REALLY TO BE HALF THE LOS
ANGELES PROBATION OFFICERS
UNION ASK ME LOCAL SIX EIGHTY
FIVE AGAIN JUST JUST TO BE
BRIEF ALL ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MISTER TRIGO AND SCOPE OF- WE
JUST REALLY NEED TO MAKE SRE
WE MAINTAIN SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
TAILOR SOMEBODY'S PROBATION
PLANS FOR PEOPLE- THAT WE WANT
TO BE SUCCESSFUL- FROM FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND NOW GO. TO MISTER MODERATOR
ANY OTHER. IN A- THANK YOU
ESTATE IF YOU'RE FOR IT IS
OPPOSITION- TWEENER WE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO WE DO HAVE A LINE
MIND TO EIGHTY THREE TO EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MARK RIGHT I PROBABLY SERVICE
PRESIDENT OF LAUGHING OKAY
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. REPRESENT
INFORMATION HEATH OFFICERS IN
SANTA CLARA. I'M ALSO A TWENTY
EIGHT YEAR VETERAN PROBATION
ASK BANDED OFF THE OF THE
PROPOSED. AT THIS TIME.
ALTHOUGH ONE PROBABLY PERIOD
FOR MANY ME TO. IT MANY OTHER
CRY EVERYDAY IN A OF ONE
PROBATION CHOIR. A HIGHER LEVEL
THREE AND TO BE. APPLE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CONVICTION CHOIR RATED.
SURVIVOR. UNDER DOCTOR REQUIRE
YEARS OF THERAPY LASTLY YOU
LIVE WITH FIRE REQUIRING
FIFTEEN TREAT PROGRAM.
PROBATION OFFICERS LET THE CITY
THE WITH EXCEPT CANDICE. BACK
TO THE COMMUNITY INCLUDING
APPLY AND TO. PRIOR TO
RECURRING TO TREAT PROGRAM THAT
ARE REQUIRED BY LAW. A ONE YEAR
PROBATION PERIOD IS NOT FOR
FIFTY TIME FOR OFFENDERS TO GO
TREATMENT BECAUSE- THAT ARE NOT
THE TO CHANGE BEHAVIOR AND
VICTIM AND SAY YOU. COURAGE YOU
TO CONSIDER THANK YOU YOUR
EUROVISION TYPE CASES THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
OKAY THANK YOU. WHAT
ORGANIZATION YOU BELONG TO.
WHAT I WHAT I WOULD CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OKAY THANK YOU. THANK.
NO FURTHER COMMENT IN Q. ON THE
PHONE. OKAY THANK YOU THEY WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS. YES THIS
IS NOT THE ORDER. ONE OF THANK
YOU MISTER KAMLAGER ON THE
OTHER FOR THIS- LEGISLATION
AND- WANT TO RE ITERATE THAT I
DO SUPPORT TODAY BUT IF E
COULD JUST CONTINUE TAKE A LOOK
AT SOME OF THOSE SOME OF THOSE
ARE THE KINDS THAT MAY REQUIRE.
ON JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE. I
TIME TO REHABILITATE THE
PROBATION. PARTNER THE THINGS
HIT MY LIPS. BUT REQUIRES A BIT
MORE TO THE PRO PROBATION
PROCESS I WOULD APPRECIATE THAT
CONVERSATION TO CONTINUE. BUT I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ENGAGING
IN AND THAT HARD WORK SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YES I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
FOR ALL YOUR WORK THAT YOU DO
IN THE SPACE AND BROADER
COLONEL JUSTICE REFORM EFFORTS
AND VERY HAPPY TO BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL AND WOULD LIKE TO ADD
MY NAME'S ACOSTA. GIVE ANY
OTHER COMMENT. YOU MAY CLOSE
MISS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS- I WANT TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE COMMENTS IF I MAY AND
THE CLOSING AND I WANT TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO- FOR
HIS SUPPORT AND FOR HIS-
REQUEST THAT I COMMIT TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION I DO
WANT TO ASK THAT- IN TALKING
WITH THE OPPOSITE GENDER- AND
OF THE- NEGOTIATION. AMENDMENTS
BEEN TALKING ABOUT DO INCLUDE
SORT OF EXTENDING TIME FOR
THOSE- WHO HAVE COMMITTED A
PURELY FINANCIAL CRIME- THERE
I'M OPEN TO AMENDMENTS THAT-
I'LL OFFER ADDITIONAL TIME OR
STATUS QUO TIME FOR THOSE ONLY
OFFENDERS. A PENAL CODE SIX SIX
SEVEN POINT FIVE WHICH ARE THE
MOST EGREGIOUS I THINK THOSE
ARE THAT OF CONCERNS REYES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO. I
FULLY SUPPORT WHAT THE
OPPOSITION SAID ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT WE HAVE TO
FIGHT FOR FUNDING- ESPECIALLY
NOW AND WHILE THIS IS A POLICY
BILL AND NOT A FISCAL BILL I
ENCOURAGE ALL OF US TO WRAP OUR
HEADS AROUND AN ARMS AROUND THE
FIGHT FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
PROBATION FOR. DEPARTMENT BASED
ON SUCCESSFUL MODEL THAT THEY
HAVEN'T AS IT RELATES TO
TREATMENT AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES- THERE WAS COMMENT BY
OPPOSITE. THAT SAID YOU WOULD
GET OFF A PROBATION ALL YOU
HAVE WOULD HAVE LEFT WOULD BE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT WANT TO REMIND.
THE OPPOSITION IN OF US HERE
THAT CIVIL JUDGMENTS LAST FOR
TEN YEARS IN FACT CAN GO ON
FOREVER AND IT IS VERY COLD TO
GET OUT OF THAT. IT IS AS MUCH
AN ACCOUNT REMEMBER. IS GOING
THROUGHPUT. SOMEONE ASKED DO
YOU ARE TO GO IT'S STILL FAR
YEARS THAT TO ME VIOLENCE IS
STILL EXAM TODAY THREE. YOU
KNOW ULTIMATELY. AND LASTLY I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO MENTION
THAT PROBATION IS A QUALIFYING
SENTENCE YOU IN FACT HAVE TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR PROBATION. AND
THAT ELIGIBILITY COMES IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH PROBATION THE
JUDGES DEFENSE COUNSEL AND THE
PROSECUTION- AB FIFTY IS A-
IT'S ABOUT A SYMBIOTIC
RELATIONAL DESIGN WHERE THE
SYSTEM AND THE PROBATIONER WORK
BETTER AND DIFFERENTLY
ESPECIALLY NOW I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH-
THOSE WHO CURRENTLY OPPOSE
THIS- SO THAT WE CAN GET TO
pSOME RESOLUTION. AND I'M MORE
THAN PROVIDE. ABOUT HOW MANY
FOLKS ARE IN PRISON FOR
TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS I WANT TO
ADD PEOPLE HAVE MENTIONED.
CHALLENGES WITH THE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS AS IT RELATES TO BEING
ON PROBATION DJJ OFFERS A
REALLY GOOD EXAMPLE DJJ WAS
HOUSING JUVENILES THEY WERE NOT
SUCCEEDING. THE SYSTEM CHANGED
HOW IT OPERATED. IT SAID NOW
INSTEAD OF HAVING YOU DO ASK
FOR NOW GOING TO FOR EXAMPLE
HAVE YOU DRAWN. EVERY WEEK FOR
FIFTY TWO WEEKS OUT SOMETHING
DIFFERENT. SO THAT YOU ARE
BECOMING MORE IN TUNE WITH
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH YOURSELF
WITH WHY YOU WERE HERE. THIS
TIME SAID WE'RE GONNA ANTI
INVEST IN THE- BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO SEE A BETTER RESULT ON THE
AND THEY HAVE TO ACCEPT. EIGHT
OF RETURN OF IN THE- SYSTEM
LOOK AT THE PRODUCT THAT WAS
TRYING TO CREATE AND DECIDED IT
WAS GOING TO CHANGE SO THAT IT
COULD HAVE A HIGHER RATE OF
SUCCESS AND THAT IS WHAT WE
FIFTY TRYING TO DO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I.
THANK YOU AND UP. I JUST WANT.
THANK YOU FOR. FOR BEING
EXTREMELY GENEROUS. WITH YOUR
TIME AND LOOK INTO THE
OPPOSITION. AND REASON I KNOW
THAT. IS BECAUSE I'VE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION NOT ONLY WITH YOU.
BUT WHICH OPPOSITION LATE. INTO
THE EVENING LAST NIGHT. AND I
WOULD ALSO US THAT BOTH THE-
HEY MORRISON CD A AA JOIN IN
THT CONVERSATION. AND DANIEL
SANCHEZ THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS THAT WE ALL COME IN
RAPPER ARMS AROUND THIS.
BECAUSE I ALSO KNOW TO JUST
EVEN THE EARLY CONVERSATIONS
OF. YOU ARE EXTREMELY.
COMFORTABLE WITH MAKING CHANGES
THAT MAKE SENSE TO YOU I
WATCHED YOU GOT TOGETHER WITH
BOTH. YOU KNOW ASK ME LOCAL
EXPIRY FIVE ARE THE PROBATION
OFFICERS OFFICES THERE IN LA.
AND LISTENING TO SKI SCOPA
YOU'VE YOU'VE YOU'VE MADE SOME-YOU WILL NEED TO MAKE SOME
CHANGES AND SO I THINK DESERVED
IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY. FOR US
TO COME TO SOME KIND OF
CONSENSUS WE MAY NOT BE 1100%
ON BOTH SIDES. BUT IT WILL MAKE
THE SYSTEM BETTER. ARE NORMALLY
DURING HIS COALBED ECONOMIC
CRISIS- I'D WE WERE NOT
ADDRESSING A LOT OF THIS BUT
YOURS WAS BEING LOOKED AT AT BY
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF AND
THEN WE HAD THE BOTTOM SHELF.
UP TO CONTINUE PUT TO PUT ON.
UNDER PRESSURE ON- ON THE
GOVERNOR TO BRING THAT BACK SO
LIKE. OTHER BILLS THAT WE'VE
WE'VE HEARD THAT NEEDED
FINANCIAL HELP OR TO MAKE SURE
THAT BUDGET ARE THERE. OF YOU
HAD IT ON THE BACK AND- OF.
ANOTHER MEMBER THIS SUBSTITUTE
IN HERE TODAY THEY HAD SOME BY
AND FROM FROM BUDGET AND SO-
LET'S LET'S ALSO. I WANT TO
FORGET THAT WE INCLUDING. WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR
FUNDING IN PROBATION SO THEY
COULD BE SUCCESSFUL ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
BECAUSE THE LAST THING YOU WE
WANT THAT ALL OF THIS BECOMES
MOVED. BECAUSE WE GO BACKWARDS
ON THE ABILITY ATION AND WE
DON'T HELP PROBATION OR PAROLE
UP TO FILL THEIR THEIR
OBLIGATIONS BECAUSE WE UNDER
FUNDED OR WE DON'T HELP SO I
LOOK AT IT'S GOING ALONG TO
RAILS AND IF WE ALL COME
TOGETHER BOTH I DEFENDERS AND
BASS I THINK HE APOLLO MESSAGE
ALLOW LAW FOR W. OFFER MESSAGE
OF TO THE GOVERNOR AND- TO THE
LEGISLATURE. IT IS TO MOVE THIS
UP ALONG. THE SO I VOTE. AND
THAT WE ALL GET BEHIND
SOMETHING I THINK IS A- COULD
BE A JOINT EFFORT. IS
PRESSURING GET THROUGH SOME OF
THE ISSUES AND AGAIN I'M GOING
TO STRESS. TO EVERYONE INVOLVED
THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
LOS ANGELES HAS BEEN EXTREMELY
GENEROUS WITH HER TIME UP ON
THIS ISSUE AND YOU CAN TALK TO
ANYONE HAS BEEN TALKING TO A-
THAT IT'S A- IT WILL BE
BENEFICIAL. WITH THAT CALL ROLE
ON A. B. NINETEEN FIFTY COME
UNDER THE MISSION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER
LACKEY LACKEY NARROW BARRICADE
CAN BARRICADE HAD NARROWED DEEP.
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I CARILLO.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WICKS WICKS
I FOR TO THAT MEASURES ON CALL
IT NEEDS WHEN. THANK YOU. THE
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN MR LACKEY
AB. TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE. SEE
IT WOULD BE CENTRAL SAW
FORENSIC EVIDENCE TESTING ABOUT.
YEAH YEAH. YEAH. ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT-
THIS ASSEMBLY BILL. TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY ONE. THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD EFFECTIVELY END THE
BACKLOG OF UNTESTED RATE GETS
IN CALIFORNIA. AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY ONE MANDATES THE TESTING
OF EVIDENCE COLLECTED FROM
SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS PRIOR.
TO TWENTY SIXTEEN. THIS CAR
COULD BE AMONG THE MOST
DIFFICULT TO REALIZE JUDICIAL
JUSTICE. THIS COLLECTED
SENSITIVE EVIDENCE SHOULD BE
PROFILE BEFORE THE DNA DEGRADES
ANY FURTHER. RETROACTIVE DO A
TESTING IS KNOWN TO CONSOLIDATE
CRIMES ASSISTING INVESTIGATORS
TO IDENTIFY PATTERNS OF
CRIMINALITY. BUDGET OCCASION OF
SEX CRIMES IS OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE. BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
VICTIMS SURVIVORS TO BEGIN THE
RECOVERY PROCESS WITHOUT
CONSTANT FEAR OF BEING EXPOSED
TO THEIR ATTACKER. IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY STATEWIDE AUDIT
OF UNTESTED SEXUAL ASSAULT
FORENSIC EVIDENCE GETS. THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE FOUND
NEARLY FOURTEEN HUNDRED
UNTESTED RATE CAPS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE SERVICE COULD
IDENTIFY SERIAL RAPISTS AND
RESOLVE LONG LASTING SEX CRIMES.
FOLLOWING THE PUBLICATION OF
THE AUDIENCE I'M SORRY THE
AUDIT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
RELEASED REQUEST FOR
APPLICATIONS FOR THREE GRANT
PROGRAMS ALL OF WHICH ARE
INTENDED TO ADDRESS THE
BACKLOGS OF UNTESTED SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE BY OFFSETTING
THE COST. RECORD BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGES IN CRIME
LABORATORIES. TODAY I HAVE ILL
SEE NOT FROM THE JOYFUL HEART
FOUNDATION AND THE TASHA.
ALEXANDER FROM NATASHA'S
JUSTICE PROJECT CALLING IN.
THANK YOU. MISTER MODERATOR
COULD PLEASE. LET US HEAR FROM
OUR WITNESSES. SALLY QUINN
COASTLINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK. YES WE CAN. OKAY
WONDERFUL- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- MEMBERS OUT OF
THE LEGISLATURE RIGHT I AM
HONORED TO BE HERE MY NAME IS
NOT HOSTILE BANCO I ANY
SURVIVOR OF SEXUAL ASSAULT I AM
ALSO A SURVIVOR OF THE RAPE KIT
BACKLOG. I HAVE BEEN HONORED TO
TESTIFIED BEFORE THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE AND PLANET SEVERAL
OCCASIONS. THANK GOD THAT I CAN
BE THERE IN PERSON I'M VERY
GRATEFUL- WHAT IS BEING DONE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND SURVIVORS OF
THE BACKLOG I'D LIKE TO SHARE
MY STORY WITH YOU AT THIS TIME-
AS IT RELATES TO THE SPELL AND
YOU KNOW PLEASE KEEP IN MIND
THAT. WOULD BE GREAT CHECK THAT
ASSEMBLY. I'M TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER THE FOURTEEN. HUNDRED
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN OUR- AND
HAS A GREAT AT IN CALIFORNIA
EACH OF THOSE WEEKS CAN'T COULD
CONTAIN A STORY JUST LIKE MINE-
I WAS RAPED AND ROBBED AT
GUNPOINT BY AN UNKNOWN
ASSAILANT. IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE. THE RESULTS WERE
DEVASTATING I CAN'T EVEN BEGIN
TO PUT INTO WORDS THE WAY IT
AFFECTED MY LIFE. I WENT
AGAINST MY INITIAL INSTINCT
WHICH WITH TO IMMEDIATELY TAK
A SHOWER AND THAT I HAD A GREAT.
DAM FOR THE DNA EVIDENCE I HAVE
THAT SEVEN COLLECTED FROM MY
BODY. MY BODY HAD BECOME A
CRIME SCENE AND I KNEW THAT I
NEEDED TO GO TO THE VERY ARGUE
WITH HALF OF GOING TO A RATE
THAT EXAM. WATER TO EVENTUALLY
APPLE. THAT MAN THAT TOOK AWAY
SO VERY MUCH FOR MY LIFE. I
KNEW AND AGAIN THIS IS JUST MY
PERSPECTIVE IN MY STORY I
ASSUMED THAT I READ CAN'T WOULD
GO ON TO BE CAUGHT THAT WAS MY
ASSUMPTION. I DIDN'T THINK FOR
A MINUTE MY RATE WOULD CHECK
FOR NEARLY. I'M THAT. ON A
SHELF. AND AS MENTIONED BY
PENGUIN AND LACKEY EARLIER I
DID LIVING NOT CONSTANT FEAR
EVERY DAY OF MY LIFE BUT MY
RESPECT THAT AND PRACTICE I
LOOKED BEHIND THE SHOULDER
EVERYWHERE I TURNED AND I ALSO
HELD. YOU IN MY HEART IN NINETY
FOUR BECAUSE I WAS ASSUMING
THAT MY READ BREAKS IT HAD NOT
BEEN TESTED BECAUSE I ADEQUATE.
ON THAT I WOULD NOT ABLE TO.
HILLS OF MY SOUL. IN AND I'LL
BE. AND THERE THEY HAD YOU KNOW
APPREHENDED THE MAN THAT WE I
CERTAINLY NEVER FOR A MINUTE MY
IT HAD BEEN TAX. I LIVE WITH SO
MUCH GUILT I. REALLY KNEW MY
WITH GO ON TO HER OTHER HE
BEING. AND I BLAMES MY FOR AND
HUMAN BEING THAT MAN WHAT HURT
IN THE INTERIM. WHEN MY WEIGHT
WITH THE BAND PASS IT TOOK. YOU
BEFORE MY- BE IN A HER. WHICH
IS THE NATIONAL DAY. WHEN HIS
LIKE FINALLY IN THE AS WE GET.
THAT THIS MAN WAS ON I NEED WHY
CRIME THREE AND TWO MINUTE A
VIRAL OF CRIME LATEST AREN'T
SPECIAL THEY CAN TO MAKE IT A
VARIETY OF CRIMES AND- ME AND
GET IN A VARIETY. EIGHT I CAN
TELL YOU HOW I WANT TO ADVANCE.
FIND JACK THANK I. ALL TO THAT.
THAT THE MINISTER. DO NOT
RECEIVE THE JACK THIS I WOULD
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO RECEIVE. I
HAD MADE IT THE FIGHT OF MY
LIFE MAKE SURE I CAN DO
EVERYTHING IN MY POWER. TO MAKE
CERTAIN OTHER SURVIVORS MACHINE
THE JACK THAT THAT I WOULD GET
THE AND- AND I WILL CONTINUE ON
TO FIGHT FOR SURVIVORS IN
CALIFORNIA I LIKE BEEN DOING
FOR THE PAST DECADE I THINK IF
EVERY SURVIVOR IN CALIFORNIA
AND I THINK THAT ALL OF THOSE.
WAIT TO GET ALL THE FOURTEEN
ALMOST FOURTEEN THOUSAND I
PRACTICE RATE CAPS IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE I THINK EACH
ONE OF THEM IF THE PERSON LIKE
ME. IS TROUBLED I THINK
CONFERENCE HERE. WHO BLAME THEM
THAT. PORTRAYED AND I WERE TO
MAKE SURE THAT EACH BILL THREE
CAPS ARE POP. YEAH YOU KNOW
UNDER WITH MY CASE OF THE MAN
RATE ME WITH BAND HARMING OTHER-PEOPLE YOU KNOW SOMETHING COMES
IN AND- THAT IT'S REALLY A PART
OF PUBLIC SAFETY THIS IS THE
PUBLIC. IS ISSUE A IS AN ISSUE
JAPANESE WITH DRIVER BUT IT IS
ALSO A SAFETY ISSUE. AND PUBLIC
SAFETY IS NOT A LUXURY. IT A-
AT JUSTICE BE. A LUXURY EITHER.
IT SHOULD ALSO BE IN A FACULTY.
AND SURVIVOR AND I LOVED ONE.
COURT TAX HERE'S AND VOTERS WE
ALL THE ARE TWO. TO CHECK. ALL
THESE FORTY OUTAGE OF EITHER
BOX CAN'T. YEAH I NOTHING OUR
THAT IN THE OF BUT TRULY UNDER
YOU WHAT IT'S LIKE TO HAVE AND
I PROFIT RIGHT. AND I. THAT
EVERYONE ON THE ASSEMBLY. WILL
TRY TO IMAGINE THAT LIKE. FOR
THE SURVIVORS OUT THERE WHO TO
THE PRACTICEHAVING A KIDDING
THAT. AND THEN PERHAPS. REPORT
AFTERWARD. ANYONE ACTUALLY TO
GO THAT PROP THAT. AND HAVE A
GREAT ON. I YOU KNOW I WANT TO
PAY THE END TO WHAT YOU KNOW
MIGHT HAVE MANY YOU WALK AWAY
FROM THIS SAME. YOU KNOW THAT
REALLY TRIED BUT IN THERE SHE
BE A BY THERE SHOULD BE A YOU
KNOW THE IS REALLY. AND NEED TO
SOME ABOUT. I CAN'T EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE ENOUGH. HE WITH
SAMPLING AND LACKEY FOR FORTY
MINUTES LEGISLATION FORWARD
IT'S TIME- NECESSARY AND IT'S
IN THE INTEREST OF PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND THE LEAST WITH YOU
FOR THE SURVIVING THE FACTUAL
ABOUT WHO BEEN WAITING FOR A
VERY VERY LONG TIME PROJECT
THAT. THANK YOU AGAIN AND I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE WITH YOU
VIRTUALLY. I THANK YOU AND I
HOPE YOU'RE ALL HEALTHY AND
FACE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER. IN SUPPORT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION IS THE
MODERATE RIGHT HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THANK YOU SO MUCH- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRED JONES SAWYER
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK
YOU BUT YOU'RE LACKEY FOR
INVITING ME TO TESTIFY. IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL IT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR EIGHT
ONE MY NAME'S ULTRACONNECT AND
I'M THE POLICY IN ADVOCACY
DIRECTOR FOR THE JOYFUL HEART
FOUNDATION. TRIPLE HEART WAS
FOUNDED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR BY LAW AND ORDER SVU ACTOR
DIRECTOR AN ADVOCATE MORISCO
HARGETT K. THE TWO THOUSAND AND
TEN WE HAVE MADE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE NATION'S
BACKLOG. UNTESTED RAKE IT OUR
TOP ADVOCACY PRIORITY. IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO A HEART LUNCH
THE NATIONAL CAMPAIGN TO ENACT
COMPREHENSIVE RICKETT REFORM
LAWS IN ALL FIFTY STATES AND WE
HAVE HAD THE HONOR TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ON A NUMBER.
TWENTY EIGHT. OR ORIGINAL
SPONSOR EIGHT THREE ONE ONE
EIGHT WHICH REQUIRED STATE
INVENTORY UNTESTED RATE CAPS.
THIS INVENTORY RELEASED IN
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY. SOUND MORE
THAN THIRTEEN THOUSAND UNTESTED
RICKETS ACROSS THE STATE
HOWEVER THIS INVENTORY WAS
INCOMPLETE AND ONLY A HUNDRED
AND NINETY SIX LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES RESPONDED OUT OF MORE
THAN SIX HUNDRED. AND IT DID
NOT INCLUDE ACCOUNT OF CAT THE
CAT SITTING AT MEDICAL
FACILITIES. UNFORTUNATELY WE
ARE LIKELY LOOKING AT MUCH MORE
THAN HIRTEEN THOUSAND KIDS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
LAST YEAR WEWORKED A SENATOR
LEYVA AND OUR PARTNERS TO GET
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET FOR THE TESTING OF BACK
LIKE GREAT KIDS. AND THESE
FUNDS ARE NOW AVAILABLE THROUGH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS- AT THE
SOME. OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
LACKEY- EXPLAINED. AND ALTHOUGH
SB TWENTY TWO LAST YEAR
MANDATED THE TESTING OF ALL
BREAK IT'S MOVING FORWARD FROM
TWENTY SIXTEEN THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO MANDATE TO TEST
KIT THAT HAVE BEEN SITTING
BACKLOGGED FOR DECADES WITHIN
LAW ENFORCEMENT CUT THE MEDICAL
FACILITIES OUR CRIME LAB IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AB TWENTY
FOUR. BY REQUIRING POSITION AND
TESTING OF RATE CAPS FROM
BEFORE JANUARY TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND MANDATE TESTING OF THOSE
KEPT BY JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AT THE VERY IMPORTANT
COMMITTEE KNOW WHAT COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY I'VE LEARNED
FROM TESTING KIT. VALUABLE
RESEARCH BATES FINDINGS THAT
MAKE THE CASE FOR TESTING EVERY
RIGHT CAN'T CONNECTED TO A
REPORTED CRIME. FOR EXAMPLE
RESEARCH OUT OF THE BEGUN
CENTER CASE WESTERN UNIVERSITY
IN OHIO. FOUND THAT SEXUAL
OFFENDERS ARE FAR MORE COMMON
THAN PREVIOUSLY BELIEVED AND
THEY COMMIT ALL KINDS OF CRIME.
ATTACH A SPOKE OF. BURGLARY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CANNABIS AND
HOMICIDE AND THEY BUDGET THAT
THEY'RE NOT SPECIALIST. IN
DETROIT. ELEVEN THOUSAND MORE
THAN ELEVEN THOUSAND RATE CAPS
WERE TESTED. AND AS OF TODAY
THE TESTING HAS FOUND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE RAPIST
WHO ARE LINKED TO CRIMES AND
FORTY STATE IN WASHINGTON DC.
THE LECTURE ONE RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU'RE GONNA BE ON
THE TIME AND I HAVE A SAYING
HERE THEY'LL HAVE. A MONTH THAT
DON'T YOU GET OKAY LIKE FIVE
MINUTES YOU'RE UP TO EIGHT. AND
THIS MIGHT BE ONE OF THOSE
TIMES WHERE YOU WANT TO TALK
PASSED THE YES. OKAY SORRY I
DIDN'T REALIZE IT HAD BEEN
EIGHT MINUTES ALREADY THAT WHAT
IT'S LIKE IT'S BILL ANYWAY. GO
AHEAD FINISH UP I WOULD JUST
IMPORTANT FOR THIS COMMITTEE TO
PASS AB TWO TWO FOUR EIGHT ONE
AND WITH THAT YOU WOULD SEND A
MESSAGE TO THE RECORD THAT WHAT
HAPPENS THAT MATTERS. THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES ENDS
SUPPORT NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO THE QUEUE UP ON THE
TELEPHONE FIRST OVER LINE THREE
THIRTY SIX THREE THREE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKER CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE THREE THIRTY TO THREE
THREE TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR KAREN MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MUCH WE'RE HERE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CRIME LAB
DIRECTORS- WHILE WE ARE NOT IN
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATION WE
DO WANT TO THANK. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY AND HIS STAFF WE
HAVE BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
THAT THE LAST FEW MONTHS TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS I WOULD
JUST WANT TO PUBLICLY RECOGNIZE
THAT BIRD AND THANK THEM AWFUL
I CANNOT START IN ADDRESSING
THOSE IN AT CURRENT LANGUAGE. I
WITH THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY NEW
CHORE ON THE BALLOT THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU. LINE THREE
THIRTY THREE THREE THREE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
TIME WHERE A TOP ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
THREE FOUR THREE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND ON
BEHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY
O'MALLEY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE THREE THIRTEEN THREE ONE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. RYAN
SHERMAN WITH RIVERSIDE CHURCH
LOCATION COURT. THANK YOU. NO
FOR THE LANDING GEAR. THIS IS
BEEN A SURPRISING DAY MUST BE
COVERT NINETEEN. HI ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OR ANY
WHEN I. GO AHEAD. MARCO GEORGE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS CREATION. HI
MY GO SET UP TO SURE AND THE-
ON SECOND SEC LOVE. AND I ALSO
TO THANK THE ALL. FOR THE
CONGRESS REGARDING OUR CONCERNS.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY ONE BECAUSE IT
MICHAEL MANAGES THE LIMITED
RESOURCES THE CRIME LAB TO THE
DETRIMENT OF CURRENT
PROSECUTIONS AND IN INDIVIDUAL
AWAITING TRIAL AND THOSE WHO
WOULD BE EXONERATED POINT B.
AND THEY AND THERE. IS COMPLETE
ALL THE CHOIRS THAT OLD SEXUAL
ASSAULT CASE. BE ANALYZED IN
THE DO YOU TEST TO REGARD OF
WHETHER IT'S FRIEDMAN THAT'S
JUST TO. THE CASE OR THE DISK
HAS ALREADY GUILTY. OR WHETHER
THEY STILL LAW IT SO THAT DNA
CAN BE ADDED INTO LISTA AND
DATABASE. THE LIMITED RESOURCES
OF CRIME LABS ARE NOT
HYPOTHETICAL. I REPRESENTED A
MAN LET'S CALL HIM TONY WHO WAS
CHARGED WITH. ARMED ROBBERY
WITH THE GUN AT THE CONVENIENCE
STORE. THE STORE VIDEO DEPICTED
SOMEONE WHO LOOKED REMARKABLY
LIKE TONY WHO DROPPED IF
BASEBALL CAPTIVE SHE FLED THE
STORE. MY CLIENT TONY SAID HE
DIDN'T DO IT SO WE ASK THE
PROSECUTION TO TEST THE CAP FOR
DNA. THE CRIME LAB WAS BACKED
UP WITH DNA REQUEST THE
PROSECUTOR TOLD US. SO TONY
STRATTON COUNTY JAIL. FOR OVER
EIGHT MONTHS UNTIL FINALLY THE
CRIME THAT GOT TO BE A THROUGH
TO TEST THE CAP FOR DNA. THE
CASE WAS DISMISSED AFTER THE
DNA RESULTS CAME BACK
EXONERATING TELL ME. AND IN A
CERTAIN HAS SPENT ALMOST A YEAR
IN COUNTY JAIL FOR A CRIME HE
DIDN'T COMMIT. PASSAGE AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE WOULD
MEAN THAT I'D OTHER INNOCENT
INDIVIDUAL WHICH SHIP WAITING
AND JAILED FOR DNA TESTING. LAB
TESTING AS WE'VE SEEN IN THIS
PANDEMIC IS NOT THE NUMBER
LIMITED RESOURCES. CRIME LABS
NEED TO BE ABLE TO PRY TO
PRIORITIZE YOUR WORK WITH
GUIDANCE FROM PROSECUTORS. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY OTHER. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. DAVID ORGANIZATION
IN A PRESS ONE AND THEN THEIR
OWN YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
THANK YOU KNOW MINDING YOUR AT
THIS TIME. DID NOT BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS THERE
TO ANYONE FOR COMMENT ARE.
MISSED REBEKAH POWER QUE HAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL AM I
COULDN'T LET THOSE COMMENTS
STAND IN OPPOSITION WITHOUT
SAYING SOMETHING BECAUSE
ALTHOUGH I UNDERSTAND WHO I
WOULD NEED TO BE MINDFUL
DEFENDANTS IN CREATING A JUST A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
LISTENING TO NATASHA'S STORY OF
PERMITTING A DECADE. TO GET HER
TEST DONE MAKES THE YEAR THAT
THAT DEFENDANT WAITED PALE IN
COMPARISON AND THERE ARE SO
MANY LIKE HER AND LIKE MOST
WOMEN. THAT HAVE EITHER
EXPERIENCED SEXUAL ASSAULTS OR
WE KNOW SOMEONE WHO HAS AND
THOSE WOMEN DESERVE JUSTICE AND
THAT MEANS THEIR KIDS TESTED.
SO I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND I'M HAPPY SPORTS NIGHT.
THANK YOU. IT ANY OTHER
COMMENT. MR LACKEY YOU MAY
CLOSE. I JUST LIKE TO CLOSE BY
SAYING THAT THE- THIS
LEGISLATION EMPHASIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROVIDING. THESE
VICTIMS VICTIMS SURVIVORS WITH
PEACE OF MIND AND I WOULD-
CERTAINLY OFFER YOU AN HONOR
THEM WITH YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. OF YES YOU HAVE BY MY
SUPPORT AYE EVERYWHERE I THINK
WE GOT HERE WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THESE RAPE KITS. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WE'VE GIVEN
MONEY TO IT WE HAD LEGISLATION
TO HELP MOVE ALONG- SO ANYTHING
TO GET THIS DONE BEFORE WE
LEAVE IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
WOULD BE. GREAT. I WISH WE
DIDN'T HAVE TO WORK ON THIS FOR
EVERY ALMOST EVERY TWO YEARS
CYCLE BUT IT SEEMS TO BE THAT
WAY EVERY NOT INTO TO WE GET IT
RIGHT AND SO- IT CHOSE
RECOMMENDED I GO. THE BILL'S
BEEN PROBABLY MOVED IN SECOND
IN ON AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE
LACKEY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER HI JOHN SO YOU'RE
AYE LACKEY. ARE LACKEY AYE
BARRICADE CAN. FIRE QUE HANNAH
I DEEP. DEEP I KAMLAGER. LEO
CORREA II SANTIAGO. WICKS THAT
MEASURES OUT FIVE ZERO. THANK
YOU NOW. I BELIEVE MR MCCARTY
IS STUCK BUT HOWEVER WE HAVE
THE GREAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MISTER MERRETT SUCI WITH AB.
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO FIREARMS
DEALERS CONDUCT OF BUSINESS.
UNFORTUNATELY MISTER MCCARTY
STUCKY COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW SO
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE THIS OUT
OF ORDER. YEAH IN FACT WE WERE
IN THE SAME COMMITTEE THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE. ON
EDUCATION FINANCE SO- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR FOR-
ALLOW ME TO PRESENT TO AB TWO
THREE SIX TWO- WHICH IS A BILL
THAT WILL GIVE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JSTICE.
AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE CIVIL FINES
ON GUN DEALERS WHO DO NOT
COMPLY WITH OUR GUN SAFETY
LAWS. DURING THIS PANDEMIC WE
HAVE SEEN A DRAMATIC SPIKE IN
GUN SALES WITH CROWDS LINING UP
TO PURCHASE GUNS FROM GUN
DEALERS. ACCORDING TO THE US
BUREAU OF ALCOHOL TOBACCO AND
FIREARMS GUN DEALERS ARE A
LEADING SOURCE OF GUNS ON THE
BLACK MARKET A RESPONSIBLE FOR
NEARLY HALF OF THE TOTAL PER OF
TRAFFIC FIRE ARMS UNCOVERED IN
A TF INVEST. ANY OF THESE TRAP
GUNS ARE USED IN CRIMES WITH A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF GUN
HOMICIDE VICTIMS BEING YOUNG
BLACK MEN. THIS BILL WILL GIVE
THE STATE DOJ BUREAU OF FIRE
ARMS THE IMPORTANT TOOL TO
IMPOSE PROGRESSIVE DISCIPLINE
WITH THE PRIMARY GOAL TO SEE
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR GUN SAFETY
LAWS THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
THE BRADY CAMPAIGN UNITED
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE. AND
SUPPORTED BY ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAVEA PESETA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE- WE HAVE
REBEKAH MARCUS- WHAT THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN- VIA TELECONFERENCE AS
WELL AS ASHLEY AYERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE- TO SPEAK IN BEHALF OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU UP. MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU. THE BILL.
THEIR SECOND. AND I DO HAVE
REBEKAH MARKETS FOR THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN ON THE PHONE AND
ACTUALLY AIRS DO JAKE ON THE
PHONE. AS WE AFTERNOON THIS IS
REBECCA MARKET. REPRESENTING
THE BRADY UNITED AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE AND BRADY UNITED
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE CALIFORNIA
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO THIS MEASURE
WOULD IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY AND
BRING INCREASED ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY TO GUN SALES
IN CALIFORNIA BY AUTHORIZING
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DEFINING YOU'RE
RESPONSIBLE DEALERS TO BREAK
THE LAW CURRENT LAW ONLY GIVES
CAL THE O. J. ONE TOOL AGAINST
GUN DEALER VIOLATE LAW.
REVOCATION UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S
PROCESS OFTEN FOLLOWS YEARS OF
IGNORED WARNINGS GERMAN FACTORS
ABOUT REPEAT VIOLATION AND IT
CAN PASS THAT CAN LEAD TO
MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS OF COSTLY
APPEAL AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
TWO WOULD PROVIDE THE STATE AN
ALTERNATIVE ENABLE CAL THE OJ
TO FIND DEALERS FOR VIOLATIONS
RATHER THAN ALL. NOTHING
REVOCATION. I PART OF A COMPANY
APPROACH TO GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION THERE MUST BE A
FOCUS ON THE UPSTREAM SOURCE OF
GUN CRIME GUNS INFILTRATING
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
AND IN PARTICULAR IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IF YOU GOT
APPLE DEALERS WILL CLEAN GAUGE
AND A LEGAL OR IRRESPONSIBLE
BEHAVIOR BY SELLING OR
TRANSFERRING GUNS THAT THEY
KNOW WILL BE TRAFFICKED INTO
AREAS OF HIGH CRIME. FURTHER
THEY PROFIT OFF OF THIS
BEHAVIOR AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
ECONOMIC SYSTEM THAT
CONTRIBUTES TO SYSTEMIC POVERTY
AND CONTINUED STRUCTURAL
VIOLENCE. THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT THESE
COMMUNITY. AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO WOULD BRING ABOUT
RESPONSIBLE AND REASONABLE
PENALTIES AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR GUN DEALERS THAT VIOLATE
THE LAW WE ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT.
THANK YOU VERY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ON BEHALF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR IT COULD YOU
FOR OFFERING AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO THIS BILL HAS BEEN
FEDERAL GRANT THE DEPARTMENT
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE CITATION
AGAINST NON COMPLIANT FIREARMS
DEALERS LIKE HOLDERS IN ORDER
TO OPERATE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DEALERS MICHAEL
BOULDERS MUST HAVE A FEDERAL
FIREARMS LICENSE A LICENSE
ISSUED BY THE LOCAL COUNTY OR
JURISDICTION AND IF THE TICKET
AVAILABILITY ISSUED BY THE
DEPARTMENT AND THEY HAVE ALL
THREE OF THE THINGS THEY'RE
INCLUDED ON THE ENGAGEMENT. DAY
MAINTAIN CENTRAL IOWA ALLOWING.
GREATER BUSINESS. IT MAKES ON
SITE ON HANEY INSPECTION OF
DEALERS MY FROM. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THEIR COME. WITH HOW.
FIREARMS STILL REPRESENTATIVES
WERE DEALER RECORD IN JUNE THAT
COMPLYING WITH REQUIREMENTS DO
RECORD AND TENSIONER. THE BILL
MAKING SECURITY CRIME AND CIVIL
OUR WAITING PERIOD REQUIREMENT.
IF IN THE ARE I THINK WATER IT
OUT COMPLY INDIA DAY AND WOULD
BE WORK CORRECTIVE ALL OF THE
TECH MAYBE. MAYBE PERFORMED IN
ORDER TO ENSURE CORRECTIVE
ACTION HAS BEEN TAKEN. NOT
EVERY INSTANCEOF NON COMPLIANT
WARRANT FROM LOCATION JUST
CURRENTLY THE ONLY A STORY THAT
THE DEPARTMENT HAS. ADDED BUT
LACKS. AUTHORITY TO IN. THE
PRIMARY ACTION FOR EXAMPLE THE
MIGHT HOLDERS ARE REQUIRED TO
UPDATE STATE THE FINANCE THE
BACK OF WITH THE CORRECT FONT
AND BY BYE BYE STATUE AS AND-
CAN. FROM YEAR TO YEAR REPEAT
MILEY FOR IN ON FIVE BUT
WEREN'T SOME OF PAIN THAT OF.
I. REMOVAL. I BUT- REVOCATION
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR THE- ALL OLD
RESULT IN A- OF THE- UNLOCKING
FOR. TO AFTER AND HOW HANDED.
WHEN INFRACTION ME MINOR. AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY TWO GRANT
PART MENTALLY TO IMPOSE AND OR
HOLD THE MY FOR HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE A RECORD WE PANEL
AND MINOR WITH ARE OVER. BRING
THEM MONITOR FINES INDIAN
AGAINST DEALER LIKE RECORDER
AFTER THE FAILED TO TAKE
CORRECTIVE ACTION AFTER. SEEING
A WARNING FOR. YOU CAN. OR A
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO A CALM
MEASURE PROVIDED WITH TOOLS TO
ENSURE BY COMPLIANCE WITH FIRE
A MONTH THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER. SPEAKER AND SOME.
THURMOND ORGANIZATION. PRESS
ONE ZERO FOR THE PHONE LINES TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT. NOBODY'S
KILLING UP ON THE PHONE AT THIS
TIME J. BUT THEN WE'LL MOVE ON
TO OPPOSITION- SPEAKING. ON
BEHALF OF OPPOSITION. I HAVE
ROY RIFFITH US SEE OUR PA AND
SEND IT AS A GUN OWNERS. WHAT
GERMAN YES. THIS IS THE HOLD
SIR THANK YOU FOR COMING HAPPY
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION OUR MEMBERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
UNDEREXPOSURE STRONG OPPOSITION
TO ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO THIS BILL COMMENCING
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WOULD AUTHORIZE CALIFORNIA
BARBARA JUSTICE TO IMPOSE. FIND
FARM DEALER. NOT EXCEEDING ONE
OR PAPERWORK WHILE. AND SO FINE
NOT EXCEEDING THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER VIOLATION LICENSEE
RECEIVE WRITTEN NOTIFICATION
FROM DOJ REGARDING A VIOLATION
AND TAKE CORRECTIVE ACTION. FOR
DOJ DETERMINES A LICENSEE
COMMITTED THE VIOLATION
KNOWINGLY OR GROSS NEGLIGENCE.
THE DECISION TO START NATIONAL
DORY ON THE DEPARTMENT. WE
DIDN'T NEEDLESS PUNITIVE
MEASURES AGAINST FARM DEALERS
WHO HAVE MADE AN INSIGNIFICANT
MISTAKES HIM FROM A LACK OF
RESPONSE FROM DOJ. EXISTING
LAWS ALREADY REGULATE SLIGHT
FARM DEALERS AND PROVIDE A
LICENSEE IS SUBJECT TO
FORFEITURE. BREACHES OF BIG
CORPORATIONS THE LAW IN OTHER
WORDS THE OJ ALREADY UP TO
FORTY TO TERMINATE NON
COMPLIANT FIRE DEALERS. IN THE
OJ IS NOW STRAIGHT UP RECORD ON
HOW TO. HANDLE LAW ABIDING.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE NATION'S
OF FARM. WHETHER POTATO INTO
WHO WANTS TO READ YOUR A GUY OR
TO BUY OF. THE LETTER LAWS
DESCRIBED AS- DOJ HAS BEEN ON
WHICH TO MANY FOR WITH THE
GIRLS THAT RECORD OF SALE. AND
THE APPS AREN'T GREAT PERSON
SINCE. ONLY ON THE BILL TO
PROVIDE. CHANGING REGULATORY
INFORMATION ALONG FAR DEALERS
BUT THE SIGNIFICANT MISTER MARK
IN A- THE- BY. YET ANOTHER
REASON WHY ATTY DOJ WORK. AND
TURN THEM INTO SEVERAL FAR
COLLECT IS A VERY BAD I. IT
WOULD BE PREMATURE TO GRAB THE
JANISH. PENALIZED DEALERS. WHEN
THEY THEMSELVES ABOUT ACTUALLY
ADDRESSING EXISTING.
OPERATIONAL PRO. TO THIS DAY.
OWN RECORDS AFTER MEAN IN THAT
BOX. STILL READING. WORLD WAR
ST STE. BUT DO J. OFFICERS ON
BY. OF BUSINESS ALONG ABIDING.
BUT INSTEAD OUT AND GET DANGERS
ARE HOLLISTER. RIGHT NOW SMALL
BUSINESS AND CAL ARE STRUGGLING
TO STAY ALIVE HIS IS NOT THE
TIME TO PILE UNNECESSARY FIND
UPON THEM AND CERTAINLY NOT IN
THE INTEREST OF RECOVERY
MISSION. ST YOU CALMLY. OKAY I
JUST CHALLENGES IN BALTIMORE.
NOT AS A ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHICH
IS THIS TRY CALLING TO SOME IN
THE IN AND OUT ON ON QUESTION
THAT OR DO YOU GO. THE STATE
CALLED DOES THE- FOUNDATION OF
ORGANIZATION IS BEEN OUR
CONSTANT GOAL TO WORK TOWARDS
COMMONSENSE SOLUTIONS REGARDING
NATIONS ACROSS OUR OWNERSHIP.
THIS CAN BE DONE HOWEVER
WITHOUT BY SHEER ACOSTA. RIDES
WALMART IS A PROTECT THEMSELVES
AND OWN AND OPERATE A- THIS IS
A BAD PIECE OF LUGGAGE THE KEY
CALM AND INTO SEVENTEEN WE SAW.
THE SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE SAW AB TEN SIXTY
FOUR IT WAS WRONG AND FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND IT'S WRONG NOW
THANK YOU SIR FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR VOTE
ON A. B. TWENTY THREE SO TWO.
THANK YOU. SANDERS THANK YOU
RIGHT. ALL SAM YOU'RE NEXT.
MISTER MODERATOR. CAN YOU GET
EVERY DID YOU FIND THEM. SIX
FAMILIES YOU ARE YOU ON WITH US.
PLEASE PRESS STAR ZERO AND I
CAN JUST OPEN YOUR LINE SAM A
FEW. I DO NOT SEE IT HIS NAME
HONOR. OKAY I THINK I FOUND HIM
ONE MOMENT. YES I'M TRYING TO
GET ONLINE PART IN DESIGNING IT
AND CANNOT BE. YES IT IS OKAY
THEY GOT. OKAY WELCOME MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK YES YOU CAN WELCOME
HELLO OKAY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SAMPRAS REPRESENTING GOVERNOR'S
CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE TO ECHO-
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE VOICED
BY MY COLLEAGUES- RIGHT GRIP
BUT- THERE ARE THERE ARE. SOME
SOME REALITIES UP THERE IN
CALIFORNIA IF YOU DO CHECK THE
BATF RECORDS YOU WILL FIND THE
CALIFORNIA IS NOT ONE OF THE
STATES WHERE YOU HAVE THE
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF. GUNS
COMING FROM GUN DEALERS AND
GOING BEING USED IN IN CRIME
GUN DEALERSIN CALIFORNIA ARE
SOME OF THE CLEANEST ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. THAT IS NOT EVEN
ARGUABLE- A POSITION ON NUMBER
TWO. THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
CALLS FOR THOSE DEALERS THAT
HAVE REPEATEDLY- BROKEN THE LAW
NOT FOLLOW THE LAW NOT FOLLOW
THE INSTRUCTIONS. AND FOR THOSE
DEALERS THEY IT'S OKAY TO
REMOVE THEIR LICENSE THAT IS
ALL RIGHT WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW
IS WE'RE SETTING UP A SYSTEM OF
FIND SOMEBODY'S. YOU KNOW
THERE'S GOING TO BE CONCERNED
SAID WELL THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS
MONEY WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO SET
SOME QUARTERS OKAY EVERY
INSPECTOR GOES OUT MAKE SURE
THAT YOU FIND SOME MINOR
WHATEVER KIND OF VIOLATION. IN
ORDER TO LET THE APPLYING AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO
DO OUR WORK AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE FACT THAT. THE
GUN DEALERS AND THE GUN BUYING
PUBLIC IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HAS REALLY NO
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. YOUR
CALL. YOU YOU GET A BUSY LINE
YOUR NO ANSWERS OR YOU LEAVE A
MESSAGE AND NOBODY RETURNS A
CALL. IN ORDER TO REQUEST
INFORMATION ON THE GUN LAWS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO NOW
WE ARE BEING ASKED AS DEALERS.
TO SUPPORT A MEASURE THAT WILL
ALLOW DOJ TO FIND US. WHEN WE
ARE GOING TO THEM TO ASK THEM.
WHAT IT IS THAT WE NEED TO DO
IN ORDER TO BEGIN COMPLIANCE
THAT IS COMPLETELY NOT FAIR.
AND YOU KNOW THIS THIS APPEARS
TO BE NOTHING MORE THAN A FUND
RAISING EFFORT. FOR THESE
REASONS- A GUN CALIFORNIA IS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
SIR. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AN OPPOSITION- MISTER
MODERATOR. IN ORDER DRAFT ONE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. NOW
WE HAVE A COUPLE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT. AN OPERATOR ONE SECOND
PLEASE.
AND IF. FIRST ONE IS
FROM DâN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DâN
CAN YOU HEAR. WHEN.
I'M SORRY
THERE'S A NEW OPERATIONS TAKING
OVER- PLEASE DâN GO AHEAD SIR
CAN YOU HARRIS. I CAN HEAR YOU
CAN HEAR MY CAR ON. MISTER
CHAIRMAN GREATLY DON'T QUITE
COMMON SEARCH I REPEATED. GROUP
REPEATED WE DIDN'T HEAR. GOOD
SO COULD YOU PLEASE REPEAT THAT.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD
THE AND READ WITH AFFLECK WILL
DIE BY NATIONAL RIFLE.
OPPOSITION TODAY ALL ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
GRANTED THE MISTER GRIFFITH-
WHILE THE NRA HAS SUPPORTED AN
INCREMENTAL APPROACH THAT
INCLUDED FINE ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL IN OTHER PLACES- WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT A SIMILAR
APPROACH HERE IN CALIFORNIA
UPDATE ON THE RECORD AS WAS
GENERATED BY MR PARTISAN
GRIFFITH REGARDING DOT'S TRACK
RECORD ON THE ANSWERING
QUESTIONS. AS WELL AS CONCERNS
WITH WHERE TO FIND MONEY DOES
FLOW AND COULD THAT- INCLUDES
AGGRESSIVE PORTAL PROGRESSIVE
ENFORCEMENT AS WE'VE SEEN
THINGS AS WAS MENTIONED BY THE
PROPONENTS OF THE CHANGE. THAT
TIME CHANGED SEVERAL TIMES OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS IT COULD
BE. A SIGN THAT. CHANGE THREE
TIMES IN THE LAST BECAUSE TO
THE LONG FOR RESULT IN THOUSAND
ALL FINE TO SMALL THIS THAT
COULD OF THE- KEEPING OUR GOAL
OPEN AT. DURING TIMES WITHOUT
WERE OPPOSITE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT AND. WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD THREE FORTY THREE. THAT
THE NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS WE
REPRESENT- A LOT OF THE
RETAILERS AS WELL AS
MANUFACTURERS AND SHOOTING
RANGES AND STATUS WALLS
EVERYWHERE IN THEUNITED
STATES. WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL ONE
THING THAT I'D LIKE TO ON ECHO
THAT THE OTHER FOLKS IT ECHOED-
IN OPPOSITION HERE. IS THIS
WOULD OPEN UP A LITTLE
VIOLATIONS- Q. LITTLE SMALL
VIOLATIONS TO POTENTIAL
MONETARY VIOLATIONS AND GET DE
OKAY THAT OPPORTUNITY TO FIND
HER FOLKS. ON AS DâN READ WITH
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
MENTIONED EARLIER THE WARNING
LABEL COULD ACCOMPANY ALL FIRE
ARMS FOR INSTANCE HAVE BEEN
CHANGED THREE TIMES OVER THE
PAST YEAR AND A HALF. IF YOU
FOR INSTANCE UNDER THIS BILL
HAD THE OLD WARNING LABEL FROM
LAST YEAR AND DIDN'T USE THAT
OVER. OBJECT TO THE LINES THERE
ARE A MULTITUDE OF ALL.
TESTIMONY THAT UNDERLYING SOME
OF THESE OTHER EXAMPLES AS
WELL. BUT TO THE MYRIAD OF
REASONS- AND SMALL POTENTIAL
VIOLATIONS WE ARE OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU SIR. I
KNOW OTHER PARTICIPANTS CUED UP
AT THIS TIME GAY WILL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. AND
YOU BRING IT BACK TO YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI AND IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS. SOME ISSUES ESPECIALLY
DOJ AS WE KNOW BEING ABLE TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT. THIS THIS
THIS NEW POLICY CERTAINLY SO-
THE BILL- IN ADDITION TO
AUTHORIZING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO BE ABLE TO- TO HAVE
THE AUTHORITY AND THE
DISCRETION- IMPOSE A FINE- IT
ALSO CALLS FOR ADOPTING
REGULATIONS- AND AS WELL AS TO
PROVIDE AND AN APPEAL PROCESS.
SO INDIVIDUALS THAT- OUR OUR
FIND WOULD HAPPEN TO- AN
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAL ANNIE-
HEARING OR UNFAIR- FINES BUT- I
THINK AS THE REPRESENTATIVE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE-
INDICATED- THIS IS A TOOL-
LIKE. SIMILAR TO WHAT THE- THE-
A. B. C. BOARD THE ALCOHOL-
BORDEAUX SIMILAR POSSESSES
MANY- PUBLIC ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO IMPOSE- WHAT ARE CALLED
ADMINISTRATIVE FINES. WE ALL OF
PUNISHING THE- THE NON
COMPLIANT BUT TO SEE COMPLIANCE
AND SO YOU KNOW I THE
ALTERNATIVE AS THE DOJ
REPRESENTATIVE INDICATED IS TO
REVOKE A LICENSE AND I AM SURE
THE GUN OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA
GUN OWNERS OF AMERICA WOULD.
OPPOSED ATTEMPTS T. COMPLIANCE
BY HAVING THEIR THEIR LICENSE
THREATEN TO BE REVOKED AND SO
THIS IS TO PROVIDE. A MIDDLE
GROUND PROVIDE DISCRETION FOR-
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO BE
ABLE TO ENFORCE. OUR GUN SAFETY
LAWS WHICH IS YOU KNOW GO
BEYOND. MERE PAPERWORK
VIOLATIONS IN THE FOR EXAMPLE
FROM THE LETTER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THEY
INDICATE TO YOU KNOW DEALER
RECORDS- MAKING SURE THAT THAT-
LAW ENFORCEMENT WELL THIS IS
THE OJ AS OUR RECORDS IN TERMS
OF WHO AND WHEN- THESE GOOD
SALES TAKE PLACE WAIT PERIOD
CHOIR THIS MAY. IT THOSE THAT
HAVE A GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDES- YOU KNOW THAT THEIR
RECORDS- YOU KNOW YOU TO BE TO
TRACK WHO GUNS ARE BEING SOLD
TO- WHETHER THE WAITING PERIODS
ARE ARE ARE BEING COMPLIED WITH
IN TERMS OF. ANYONE CONVICTED
OF THE OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
TWO TO MAKE SURE THAT THE OUT
AWAITING COMPLIED. THESE ARE.
TO GUN SAFETY LAWS THAT- THIS
COMMITTEE- WORKS HARD TO- TO-
VAN AND TO REVIEW AND TO PASS-
IN ORDER TO- REDUCE GUN
VIOLENCE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL- THAT- YOU KNOW.
WE SEE TO THAT THAT I AM
OPPOSED TO- BY TWO THE
CALIFORNIA PART JUSTICE TO USE
IN THEIR PROPER DISCRETION. TO
ENFORCE COMPLIANCE AND SAVE. ON
CALIFORNIA RIFLE ASSOCIATION
GUN OWNERS AND EVEN THE ARRAY-
HAVE A VALID POINT ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT DOJ I MEAN FOR
US YOU KNOW YOU PAYMENT CAME IN
WITH ME IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
WE ALL HAVE CONCERNED WHETHER
NOT. THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE CAN
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT SOMETHING-
MUCH LESS THEM OVER PRESCRIBING
OR OVER. PENALIZING PEOPLE TO
PAD THEIR THEIR BUDGETS THEY'RE
HAVING TROUBLE JUST TRYING TO
KEEP UP WITH THE WORKLOAD MUCH
LESS GOING OVERBOARD AND TRIED
IT WANTED THINGS THAT HELPS YOU
AND HELPS ME GET ME SOME. THAT
GO LEASE BE ABLE TO GET IT DONE.
SHE HAD DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
SIGNING ON THAT'S WHY YOU'RE TO
TAKE A DATE THEY ARE INTO THEY
WANT BE INCOME. IN IN YOUR LAW
THEY WERE TO MAKE SURE YOU GET
IT GETS DONE I WOULD URGE YOU
TO MAKE. THAT WE SOME SOME
MECCA. PLACE EVEN THOUGH I
DON'T THINK IT. SURE THAT. LIKE
IN YOUR SMALLEST NOT YOUR SMALL
CITY IN THE LAW OF SMALL SOME
SMALL SO THEY USED AS A WAY OF
OR BUDGETS DURING DOWNTURN THE
ECONOMY SO WE DON'T WANT TO
OVER REGULATE JUST. BUILD UP A
BUDGETS BECAUSE- I'M SURE THE
DOJ. AND IS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S WILL ALL BE X. SOME.
DRAMATIC CUT INTO BUDGET AND SO
IF YOU COULD. PROVIDE SOME
COMFORT IS BEING FOR I'VE AM IN.
SO OF IT TODAY COULD NOT HOLD
BACK FOR WINNING TO FLOW
BECAUSE THE FLOOR BUT- COULD
YOU SEE HAD THAT BUDGET FOR THE
GOAL. OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS TO MAKE SURE. THE OF
JOE JUDGE WITH ONLY GIVE IT
DONE BUT IT IT DONE CORRECTLY
AND WE DON'T HARM ANY. IN THIS
IF THERE TO LEAVE THINGS THAT
THEY NEED TO BE DOING. I MAKE A
SURE THEY HAVE A- THERE THE
POST WHAT NEEDS TO BE. AND THAT
WE DO HER ARM A SMALL BIT SPACE
HEATER. DOING THE- BIT INTO. IF
ANY WOULD PROBABLY SHOULD BE.
OF SO THEY CAN STAY IN BUSINESS
SO WITH THAT RECOMMENDING AYE
VOTE. YOU MAY CALL. I'M AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY MORE CHEAT
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE A PRO
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JOHN
YOUR EYES. LACKEY NO
BAUER-KAHAN DEEP. DEEP NOW
KAMLAGER CARRY YOUR CARILLO ICE
AND THE ARE SENT DOWN I WISH.
THREE TO THAT MEASURES ON AT
NEW TO VOTE THANK YOU THANK
VERY MUCH. MISTER PATTERSON A-
THREE ZERO THREE ANIMAL. AND.
THANK MR WOULD I COMMON DATE ME
WITH. MOVING THE MASK WHILE I
PRESENT OKAY HOW FAR THE OF
NEST SWITCH. THAT'S OKAY DON'T
KNOW WHAT THIS MADE HAVE BEEN.
HAVE A HARD TIME GETTING IN
HERE WELL. WE CAN GET YOU A
MESSAGE BRIEF I. YEAH I'VE GOT
THOUGHT OF MY- CC A COUPLE
HOLES IN BUT THAT YOU KNOW THE
PIZZA PER NOT DOESN'T WORK. TO
POST A PUBLIC NOTICE. OF THE
ROOSTERS AE OTHER FIGHTING
ANIMALS USED IN ILLEGAL FIGHTS-
IT ON AN ONLINE SOURCE RATHER
THAN SOLELY WITH HARD COPY
NEWSPAPERS. ILLEGAL ANIMAL
FIGHTING IS A HIGHLY AGGRESSIVE
GAMBLING SPORT DIAPER PROBABLY
ALL FAMILIAR WITH THE- ****
FIGHTS IN THE DOG FIGHTS THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS IT'S A
SPECIALTY. PERVASIVE IN IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. AND OUR
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT HAS AN
AWFUL LOT OF ENFORCEMENT WORK.
AND THEY HAVE BROUGHT THIS TO
OUR ATTENTION AND THE SHARES
ARE GOING TO COMMENT ON WHY
THEY THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
BUT- WE HAVE PEOPLE ON THE STE
IT ACTUALLY TRAVEL. FOR THESE
BITING SEASONS- STARTS IN
FEBRUARY LAST UNTIL- THE
TEMPERATURES GET A LITTLE
WARMER GENTLE CALIFORNIA. SO
HERE'S THE IT THE PROBLEM IS
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT APPEARS AT
THESE FIGHTS IT IS COMMON FOR
ATTENDEES TO FLEE. TO AVOID
ARREST THEY MANY TIMES LEAVE
THAT BIRDS OR OTHER ANIMALS
BEHIND. THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
TAKES POSSESSION OF THE ANIMALS
AND FILES A PETITION WITH THE
COURT TO HUMANELY EUTHANIZE
THEM. BEFORE DOING SO CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES A PUBLIC NOTICE OF
DESTRUCTION OF THE ANIMALS TO
BE POSTED IN A HARD COPY
NEWSPAPER. MOVED AND SECONDED
YES IT WITH ARCH I JUST ASK FOR.
YOUR CALL THAT BACK TO MAKE
SURE YOU DON'T TALK PASSED THE
I'D YEAH YOU'RE RIGHT I LEARNED
THAT. IN TWENTY TWELVE. UP WITH
THAT I'M GOING TO I'M GOING TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT APPRECIATE
THAT. THE MOTION AND THE SECOND
SIMPLY STATED THIS IS GOING TO
PROVIDE LOTS OF OTHER OPTIONS
AT A FRACTION OF THE PRICE TAG
IN ORDER TO GET THE WORD OUT
MOVE US INTO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY AND- ALLOW OUR CHAIRS
DEPARTMENTS- TO. ANNOUNCE THESE
THINGS OF A FORMALLY AND
APPROPRIATELY THOUGH IN THE
DIGITAL AGE AND WITH THAT I ASK
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE OR ARE YOU HAVE A WITNESS
OUR STATE SHE LIVES SUPPORT. I
AM- A WITNESS FOR THE
OPPOSITION- OKAY SO- SHARK
LUCIA OH YEAH I'M SORRY WE SHOW.
YOU GIVE IT A TRY GET
EVERYTHING ON AT THE MOVE SHE
LOOKED I KNOW I KNOW IT IS TO
SHOP. I GOT I GOT TO FOR NOT
EMOTIONALLY. MUCH BETTER MUCH
SHORT TERM YOU SEE H. ELLIE ARE
AS THE PHONETIC WHEN THEY GET
ON DEAL TELL US HOW TO HEAR OUT.
ALL OKAY TELEVISION BOTH GREAT.
HELLO OCEAN AND REVENUE HELLO
HI MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. WE
CANNOT BRICKS THERE YOU GO WE
CAN SEE YOU NOW THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON SHOW MUCH LOWER ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION I TO WILL
NOT BELABOR THE POINT I DO WANT
TO SAY THAT WE ARE SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL AND WE WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
FOSTERING DISPEL AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. ALL ARE THERE ANY
OTHER. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFYING ONE ZERO. MY
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE THREE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
LIKE. NINE THREE FORTY EIGHT.
RIGHT ONE ZERO AGAIN. I'M I'M
TESTING IN OPPOSITION. BY CAN
YOU FOLKS HERE MAPS. YES ARE
YOU IN SUPPORT. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN JONES SAWYER
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE MONEY AND
REPRESENTS KINGS AND THE CHIEF
OF ELDORADO COUNTY ANIMAL
SERVICES OF SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON BILL
KALAU OTHER MEDICAL PUBLICATION
FOR NOTIFICATION I'LL BE BRIEF.
AND SHE HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN
LARGE SCALE COCKFIGHTING
OPERATIONS WITH THE EXECUTION
OF SEARCH WARRANTS AND CEDAR.
FIGHTING BURKE. HAS ALSO
PROVIDED MUTUAL LAKE OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND ANIMAL
WELL AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE INCLUDING NAPA HUMBOLDT
TRANSFORM COUNTY. OPERATING
SYSTEM REQUIREMENT CALIFORNIA I
BELIEVE THIS BILL FACILITATE
REGIONAL NOTIFICATION IN
MULTIPLE MEDIA OUTLETS AS
OUTLINED THE BILL WAS STILL
KEEPING A LINE. THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS OF THE EXISTING
LAW AND ALLOW PROPER
DISPOSITION OF THESE FIGHTING
ANIMALS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO TESTIFY IN RESPECTFULLY.
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL.
YOUR THAN YOU. THE ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF. YEAH PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO HIGH IF YOU'D
LIKE TO. THE PUBLIC. NOBODY
ELSE Q. UP AT THE TIME NOW WILL
HAVE IN OPPOSITION HELLO MISTER
MODERATOR. I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN A RESTAURANT ZERO YOU WOULD
LIKE TO BE A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION JIM IT WORKS THE
CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPERS
ASSOCIATION AND KATHY SURE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA. WHERE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JIMMY WORK FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. WELL WE ARE OPPOSED
TO AB. THIRTY THIRTY FIVE.
BEACH PUBLIC NOTICES ARE
INTENDED TO REACH- TARGETED
AUDIENCES IN COMMUNITIES SO
THAT WHEN AN ANIMAL- AND ITS
OWNER- HAVE BEEN SEPARATED FOR
WHATEVER REASON- ANY OWNER IS
ON THE TABLE. THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES UNABLE TO
REACH THE OWNER TO INFORM THEM
THAT THE ANIMALS ABOUT TO BE
DESTROYED OF IT CAN INFORM
OTHERS IN THE COMMUNITY HE MAY
KNOW WHO THE OWNER IS SO THAT-
THEY CAN BE INFORMED- ABOUT THE
ABILITY TO- GET THEIR GET THEIR
ANIMAL. AND DO FACT MISS OF
THESE NOTICES REALLY IS
UNPARALLELED- THROUGH THE USE
OF NEWSPAPERS BECAUSE
NEWSPAPERS ARE PUSHED INTO THE
COMMUNITY SO THAT WHEN SOMEONE
PICKS UP A NEWSPAPER WHERE THEY
LOOK TO FIND NEWS AND
INFORMATION ABOUT LOCAL
COMMUNITY. EVENTS AND
OCCURRENCES- THEY HAVE A
SERENDIPITOUS EXPERIENCE AS
THEY ARE GOING TO THE USE OF
THE NEWSPAPER AND AFFECTED
WHICH STOP ALONG THE RANGE THAT
THEY MEAN INTEND TO LOOK FOR.
FIFTIES ARE ONLY POSTED ON
WINE- OR THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA
THAT SAME- SERENDIPITOUS.
AFFECT DOES NOT TAKE PLACE.
PEOPLE WHO GO TO PAY FOR GO FOR
A SPECIFIC PURPOSE AND ONCE
THEY HAVE OBTAINED THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR- THEY LEAVE THAT
WEBSITE- VERY FEW PEOPLE GO TO
GOVERNMENT WEBSITES TO OBTAIN.
GENERAL INFORMATION NOT TO
MENTION THE FACT THAT WEBSITE
ARE NOT SECURE WHEN A PUBLIC
NOTICE IS PUBLISHED IN A
NEWSPAPER OF GENERAL
CIRCULATION. IT IS PRINTED ON-
A NEW STRENGTH AND YOU CAN FIND
THAT ANYWHERE BUT IF IT'S
ONLINE THINGS HAPPEN WEBSITES
CAN BE HACKED- THEY CAN BE-
POWER CAN GO DOWN- THERE
INSTANCES WHERE- THEY ARE EVEN
HELD FOR RANSOM- UNTIL- IT IS
PAID AND- WITH. THAT
INFORMATION CAN THEN BE
RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC- AS FAR
AS THE INVOICE THAT WAS USED TO
JUSTIFY THIS BILL- MY
UNDERSTANDING AND TALKING WITH
THE PUBLISHER OF THE NEWSPAPER.
IS THAT THAT AD WAS NEVER
PUBLISHED AND- SO. WHILE IT MAY
APPEAR TO BE EXCESSIVE IN COST-
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT WITH
SEVERAL- THAT WAS NEVER PAID-
AND PUBLISHED. ALSO WANT TO
SHOULD THAT BE TYPES OF NOTICES
AFFECT COMMUNITIES ALL OVER THE
STATE NOT JUST IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SO THESE NOTICES THAT
ARE PUBLISHED IN NEWSPAPERS
LIKE LOPPING YOUR OWN OR OTHER
COMMUNITY BASED PUBLICATIONS-
WOULD ALSO BE AFFECTED BY THIS
AND- NOT A- YOU. HAVING NOTICES
POSTED ON WINE IN ADDITION TO
THE REQUIREMENT THAT THEY BE
PUBLISHED IN A NEWSPAPER OF
GENERAL CIRCULATION IN FACT
SEEN PEERING HAS ITS OWN
WEBSITE WHERE WE UPLOAD NOTED
IS FROM ALL OF OUR MEMBERS
PUBLICATIONS JUST FOR THAT
PURPOSE. BUT OUR OBJECTION IS
THAT THIS IS GOING TO CREATE A
SITUATION WHERE THOSE NOTICES
ARE PUBLISHED IN LIEU OF THAT
PUBLISHED NOTICE IN A
NEWSPAPER. AND UP FOR THAT WE
CAN- WE ARE URGING YOU TO VOTE
NO ON THIS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR. AND MEASURE ACLU YEAH.
THANK YOU YES THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA- WE RESPECTFULLY
ALSO MUST OPPOSE. EIGHTY THIRTY
THIRTY FIVE. SB THIRTY THIRTY
FIVE LOOSENS THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR PUBLICATION OF NOTICED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN. IN
CONNECTION WITH ILLEGAL
COCKFIGHTING OPERATIONS ARE
GOING TO BE DESTROYED THE
APPLICATION IN THIS BILL IS A
VERY SPECIFIC ONE BUT THE
PRINCIPLE. INVOLVED ARE BROADLY
APPLICABLES AND IMPORTANT WHEN
THE GOVERNMENT SEIZES PROPERTY
AND INTENDS TO DESTROY IT OR
FOR THAT PERMANENTLY IT MUST
GIVE NOTICE IN A WAY. THAT IS.
THAT CAN EFFECTIVELY REACH
THOSE WITH AN INTEREST IN THE
PROPERTY THERE ARE NUMEROUS
PROVISIONS OF LAW THAT SET OUT
GET THAT IN DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES SET OUT THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR HEALTH SUCH
NOTICE MUST BEPROVIDED.
REQUIREMENTS ARE INTENDED TO
ENSURE THAT NOTICES NOTED THAT
PUBLISHED IN AN INDEPENDENT
FORM BUT THE FACT OF NOTICE CAN
BE INDEPENDENTLY VERIFIED THAT
THERE IS A RECORD OF THE NOTICE
AND THAT THE NOTICES. WILL TO
EVER WANT AND THAT IT IS GIVEN
IN A WAY THAT MAXIMIZES LET IT
INTO A PARTY WILL YET.
NEWSPAPER NOTICES THE IT'S
REQUIREMENTS THERE MAY BE OTHER
WAYS TO MEET THEM AS WELL BUT
ALLOWING NOTICE TO BE PUBLISHED
ON QUOTE A SOCIAL MEDIA OUTLET
BELONGING PEOPLE ON. YOUR
COUNTY OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ENTITY OR LONG ARGUMENT IN. ON
SURELY NOT. WITH CAPTION IT
WILL BECOME A STEP MATTER
LAUNCH A TO ARE OR- VERY AND
NOTIFY THE FATE FEED NO ONE
WILL BE REDUCED FOR THIS
PURPOSE AND AIRPORT BUT NO ONE.
THIS MAY NOT SEEM LIKE IT
MATTERS MUCH ONE. ABOUT THESE
PRISONERS. BUT IF THE STANDARD
FOR PUBLICATION IS CHANGED IN
THIS WAY HERE WE WILL SEE
PROPOSAL IT CHANGED ELSEWHERE
WHEN MUCH MORE THEY BE AT STAKE
AND WHAT YOU DO TODAY MADE THE-
MODEL FOR. JAMES AND- WE URGE
YOU NOT TO CHANGE REQUIREMENTS
WITHOUT CAREFUL THOUGHT. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NOBLE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. NAME
AN ORGANIZATION MODERATOR AN
ESN OF ON THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU ARE NOT POSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AND NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
THANK YOU ARE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES
MA'AM CARILLO. THANK YOU MISTER
PATTERSON- I ACTUALLY THINK
YOUR BILL IS. VERY ON POINT-
AND- IN TUNE WITH THE WAY IN
WHICH A LOT OF CONSUMERS
RECEIVE THEIR NEWS RECEIVE
THEIR MEDIA AND I'M TOTALLY AN
ONBOARD AND SUPPORTING IT I DO
WANT TO CLARIFY SOME OF THE-
COMMENTS ARE MADE OVER THE
PHONE. IS THIS- WHAT
ADVERTISING ON A NINE MONTH
ONLINE NEWSPAPER SAY LIKE. THE
LA TIMES ONLINE ORDER SHALL BE
NEON ONLINE WHICH WAS BROUGHT
UP OVER THE PHONE OR THROUGH
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT SOCIAL
MEDIA IS THAT DOES NOT REPLACE
OR THAT IN ADDITION TO. THE
NEWSPAPER ADVERTISEMENT THE
ANALOGY REST. AB DIP
SPECIFICALLY. THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO UPDATE THE CODE. BY
ALLOWING LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
POST THE SAME CONTENT IS
REQUIRED IN A HARD COPY
NEWSPAPER ON THESE OTHER
OUTLETS WEBSITES- AGENCIES
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES ITS AFTER
ANY INCLUDING NEWSPAPER
WEBSITES. THE BUT WE HAVE THE
ACT THE ADVENT OF THE INTERNET
AND- IT IS CLEAR THAT THE
PUBLIC NO LONGER RELIES SOLELY
ON PRINT. NEWSPAPERS TO LOOK
FOR LOST POSSESSIONS LEARN
ABOUT LOCAL NEWS AT ITS ADDRESS
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
ALLOWING LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO PUBLISH NOTICES
ONLINE THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM
THE AFFORDABILITY I WANT TO GET
TO THE COST YOU IN A SEC THE
AFFORDABILITY. OF DOING THIS IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES TARGETING
MORE SPECIFICALLY AND FURTHER
INCREASING ACCESS AND AWARENESS
WITH THE CURRENT CODE AGENCY
SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD TO
DIVERSIFY AND TO RUN- WITHOUT.
PAYING FOR THIS MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS AND I MUSTSAY
WITH VERY LITTLE OR NO RESULTS
IN OTHER WORDS. THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS REQUIRED TO PUBLISH.
ARE IN OF PRINT NEWSPAPER IN
WHICH THERE'S A MASSIVE AMOUNT
OF OTHER NOTICES- IT LEGAL
NOTICES AT CENTER IF YOU TALK
TO THE SHERIFF'S THEY WILL SAY
THEY SPEND ALL KINDS OF MONEY
AND THEY GET LITTLE OR NO RISK.
AND THEY BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
MORE TARGETED WAYS BUT IT COMES
DOWN TO A PRICE TAG THAT. A
IT'S SO THAT THEIR OPPOSITION
REFERENCE THIS EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLAR- PRICE TAG FOR ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN LINES
OF SMALL TYPE FOR THREE DAYS.
THE END THE GENTLEMAN WAS
CORRECTED THEY DID THEY DIDN'T
PAY IT WHY BECAUSE THE BIRDS IN
QUESTION ALL DIED. BEFORE THEY
PUBLISHED THE AT. AND SO THEY
WITHDREW THE AT. THIS IS A STE.
S. SAMPLING OF THE KIND OF
QUOTATION- THAT THE NEWSPAPERS
PROVIDE ADDITIONALLY I HAVE
GONE AND WE FOUND A COULD
GOTTEN QUOTES AS EARLY AS TODAY
FROM THREE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
NEWSPAPERS RANGING FROM FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO ELEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS. REQUIRING LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO POST IN HARD
COPY NEWSPAPERS IS NOT ONLY
OUTDATED BUT IT IS VERY VERY
EXPENSIVE. AGAIN ELEVEN
SOMETHING LIKE TO EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS THE FRESNO BEE
ELEVENTH DOLLARS I THINK IN THE
LAW THEN THE LA AREA WHEN THE
LA NEWSPAPERS. TURN IT IN THIS
IS. APPLES AND APPLES. A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN LINE
OF SMALL TYPE FOR THREE DAYS
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
FRESNO ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
THE END OF THE CENTER
CALIFORNIA IMAGINE- THE
AFFORDABILITY OF BEING ABLE TO-
TAYLOR AND USE THAT THAT- THE
INTERNET. MEDIA LOOK. CURRENT
LAW AND THE OPPOSITION SUGGESTS
THAT YEAH THERE MAY BE SOME
PRECEDENT IN HERE I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT AND I'M NOT
PUSHING IT BUT LET ME SAY THIS.
CURRENT LAW SETS UP AN OUTDATED
MONOPOLY FOR HARD COPY
NEWSPAPERS AS A RESULT THEY CAN
CHARGE MONOPOLY RATES BECAUSE
THERE IS NO. OTHER OPTION THIS
BILL PROVIDES AT NUMEROUS
OPTIONS INCLUDING THE WEBSITES
OF THESE NEWSPAPERS AND SO WITH
THAT I'M I'M ASKING. FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ODD. THE BED SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS- POLICE AUTHORITIES
CAN DO WHAT THEY WANT IF THEY
WANT TO SPEND. ELEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN LINES FOR THREE DAYS.
OKAY FINE BUT- WE'RE GIVING
THEM THE OPTION. TO GO AND DO
THIS A DIFFERENT WAY AND IT
WOULD BE JUST AS- ACCEPTABLE
WITH RESPECT TO OFFICIAL
NOTIFICATION. AND I VENTURE TO
DISAGREE WITH THE NOTION THAT-
ONLY THE NEWSPAPERS CAN
ARCHIVE. THAT'S JUST THAT'S
JUST THE TECHNOLOGICAL LEAD
INCORRECT BUT THE FUNDAMENTAL
PLACE WHERE THIS IS ARCHIVED IS
WITH THE COURTS. THAT REQUIRE
THE NOTIFICATION ANYBODY
ANYTIME CAN CAN GO FIND THIS AT
THE COURT IT'S ARE ARCHIVED
THERE AS WELL SO FOR THESE
REASONS I THINK THIS IS
APPROPRIATE- MODERNIZATION
MOVING INTO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY IN HE DIGITAL AGE AND
PROVIDES FOR MUCH LESS AMOUNTS
OF MONEY FOR MUCH. TARGETED AND
SPECIFIED. I INFORMATION THAT
HAS AYE MUCH HIGHER LIKELIHOOD
OF REACHING THOSE WHO NEED TO
HEAR IT BECAUSE IT'S
DIVERSIFIED IN DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES AND IS AFFORDABLE FOR
THOSE REASONS I'M ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. YOU COULD
YOU COULD. BUT SO YOU MAY ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. YOU MAKE BAD
CONSIDER MY CLOTHES OKAY SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS ALSO MIGHT. INVOLVEMENT IN
A NEWSPAPERS AND PUBLICATIONS-
WAS AS DIRECTOR REAL ESTATE TO
SEE BELLI. I WE WOULD HAVE TO
NOTICE WHENEVER WE HAD AN
AUCTION OF CITY PROPERTY. AND I
JUST REMEMBER. THAT STAFF
WITHIN GOVERNMENT WITHIN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES WHAT ONLY
ADVERTISE INTHE LA TIMES AND
WHEN I PUSH TO HAVE IT OUT
ADVERTISING LOPPING YOUR OWN
REALLY SET NO. THE BILL TOKIO
NEWS FILIPINO TOWN IN ETHNIC
NEWSPAPERS THEY REFUSE TO. AND
THEY SAID THOSE INDIVIDUALS
READ DAILY TIMES AND NOT THE
OTHER WAY AROUND. AND IT WOULD
NOT. GIVE MONEY TO THE SMALLER
PUBLICATIONS IT USED TO DRIVE
ME CRAZY. I FORCED HIM TO AND
I'M PRETTY SURE AFTER I BLESSED
THE ONLY- ADVERTISING. IN THE
LA TIMES IN A LARGER PAPERS IN
A HAVE NOT GONE BACK. TO THAT
AND SO PERSONAL. I'VE ALWAYS
BELIEVED DICK THIS IS BACK WHEN
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE INTERNET
WHEN WE DIDN'T HAVE YOU KNOW. A
WEBSITE FACEBOOKAND SOCIAL
MEDIA THIS THIS IS MY IDEA WAS
TO GET THE WORD OUT TO AS MANY
NEWSPAPER. AFFILIATES
ESPECIALLY IN AREAS THAT DON'T
NORMALLY GET A CHANCE TO BUY OR
TO GO TO AN AUCTION FOR CITY
PROPERTY. AND SO- BUT IT. THE
BILL THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
REACH AS MANY. FOLKS AS
POSSIBLE IS REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME. AND IT'S
REALLY WOULD THINK SHOULD BE
REALLY IMPORTANT TO EVERYONE.
THAT WE ALL TRY TO TALK TO
EVERYBODY ON EVERY MEDIA- AND
INCLUDING DAILY TIMES HAS THEIR
OWN. WAY OF POSTING THINGS
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW I GET MY
NEWS I DON'T GET A HARD COPY
PAPER ANYMORE. IT'S ON DISTINCT
NOW AND THAT'S HOW I READ MY
NEWS- EVERY DAY I HAVE A
SUBSCRIPTION I PAY MONEY I KNOW
I PAID MONEY BECAUSE I WRITE
THE CHECK. IT SO IT IS LONGEST
BEGINS PEOPLE FLEXIBILITY. AND
I'M HOPING THAT YOU'RE YOUR
TIME UP. THE ABILITY TO GET TO
AS MANY DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PEOPLE. NOT JUST ONE SEGMENT OF
THE POPULATION AS POSSIBLE. WE
WANT TO MAKE A MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT AND IF SOMEONE WANTS
TO GO AHEAD AND ADVERTISE. AND
PAY. WHATEVER THAT AMOUNT IS
WAS EIGHT THOUSAND LIVE IT UP I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE LA TIMES IS
CHARGING NOW. THAT BIG THEY CAN
USE THAT VALLEY PD SHERIFF'S
OFFICE OR JUST GOVERNMENT.
DEPARTMENT WANT TO BE ABLE TO
USE THAT SO WITH THAT WOULD
RECOMMEND I'VE OPEN IT WOULD
MAKE SURE. IT IT ALLOWS
EVERYONE AN OPPORTUNITY DELUDE
USE ALL OF THE MEDIUMS- IN IN
GOING FORWARD I HAVE STAFF
DOUBLE CHECK TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT IS THE CASE. DO WE GET A-
VERY MOTION SO CALLED FOR THE-
ON A. B. THIRTY THIRTY FIVE
PATTERSON THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED JONES SAWYER BY JOHN SIR
HI LACKEY LACKEY AYE BARRICADE
HAN. DEEP DEEP I KAMLAGER
CARDIO CARDIO AYE SANTIAGO SAN
DIEGO I LEX THAT MEASURE GETS
OUT FIVE ZERO THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED. MISS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ELOISE RADIUS
YOU HAVE AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN AND A. B. TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX. IT WOULD BE
CONVICTIONS EXPUNGEMENT INMATE.
HAND CREWS AND VICTIMS OF CRIME.
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN WHICH
PROVIDES AN EXPEDITED
EXPUNGEMENT OUT FOR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY PARTICIPATED IT AS
INCARCERATED FIREFIGHTERS. IN A
CONSERVATION CAP PROGRAM UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
OF THE BELL. CITY SEE OUR
INCORPORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
AND THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT JOINTLY OPERATE
FORTY THREE CONSERVATION CAMPS
OR FIRE CAMPS IN TWENTY SEVEN
COUNTIES. THIS FIRE CAMP
SUPPORT LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AS A
RESPONSE. SEE SUCH AS FIRES
FLOW. AND OTHER NATURAL OR
MANMADE DISASTERS. ALL
INCARCERATED FIRE CAMP WORKERS
RECEIVE THE SAME ENTRY LEVEL
TRAINING THE CALIFORNIA-
SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS RECEIVE.
IN ADDITION TO ONGOING TRAINING
FROM CAL FIRE HELL FIRE WHILE
THEY REMAIN IN THE PROGRAM.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE VETTED
AND MUST FIRST EARNED THEIR
RIGHT TO WORK IN A CONSERVATION
CAMP. BY EXHIBITING NON VIOLENT
BEHAVIOR AND CONFORMING TO ALL
RULES. IN ADDITION ONLY THOSE
WITH THE MINIMUM BECAUSE THEY
USE CUSTODY TATUS ARE ELIGIBLE
TO VOLUNTEER FOR ASSIGNMENT IN
CONSERVATION CAMPS. AS NOTED IN
ALICE'S SOME CONVICTION
OFFENSES SUCH AS SEXUAL
OFFENSES ARE SEN AND THE
HISTORY OF ESCAPE WITH FORCE OR
VIOLENCE. AUTOMATICALLY MAKE
VISUAL INELIGIBLE FOR
CONSERVATION CAMPUS SIMON EVEN
IF THE INDIVIDUAL HOLDS A
MINIMUM CUSTODY STATUS. MEMBERS
WE HAVE OVER TWO THOUSAND CAR
FOR INCARCERATED PEOPLE
ANNUALLY IN CALIFORNIA WORKING
ALONGSIDE OUR FIREFIGHTERS
FIRST RESPONDERS AND OTHERS
PUTTING THEMSELVES IN GRAVE
DANGER TO PROTECT ONE PLANS AND-
FIVE. WE ALL KNOW THESE
WILDFIRES WE'VE ALL SEEN THE
DEVASTATING RESULTS IN
COMMUNITIES LIKE PARADISE IN
DOUBT A TREMENDOUS SACRIFICE OF
PERSONAL SAFETY OR VOLUNTEER TO
VOLUNTEER TO FIGHT THESE DEADLY
BUYERS. TO KEEP OUR FAMILIES
OUR OMES ARE WILDLIFE IN OUR
FOR SAFE. WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
REDUCING THE IMPACT OF DAMAGES
ON OUR ECONOMY AS CALIFORNIA
SAVES APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
MILLIONS OF HOURS FROM OUR
FIRST RATED FIREFIGHTERS.
HOWEVER EVEN WITH OUR THEIR
SACRIFICES THEIR TRAINING THEIR
DEDICATION OF THE LOWER LEVEL
RISK STATUS. MANY WILL
PARTICIPATE IN THE FIRE CAMPS
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE TO FIND
PERMANENT AND STABLE EMPLOYMENT
ONCE RELEASED. THIS IS DUE TO
THE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS THAT
HISTORICALLY BEEN PLACED ON
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS HINDERING THEIR OFF
THEIR ABILITY TO SEE CAN
ACQUIRE EMPLOYMENT. OR EVEN THE
EDUCATION NECESSARY TO START
CAREER AND CONTRIBUTE TO
SOCIETY. IT IS A GRAVE
INJUSTICE OF OUR LEGAL SYSTEM
THAT WE DEEM INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS. FIT TO FIGHT FIRES
FOR LITTLE OR NO PAY WHILE
THEY'RE IN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
BUT WHEN THEY'RE RELEASED THEY
MUST FACE INCREDIBLE CHALLENGES
BEFORE THEY EARN AN HONEST
LIVING. HERE TO TESTIFY. OR
VIRTUALLY TO TESTIFY. ON ON
BEHALF OF THIS BILL ARE
FERNANDO CARREIRA REPRESENTING
A R. C. ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION. IT FORMALLY
INCARCERATED YOUTH WHO FOUGHT
FIRES AND AFTER HIS RELEASE WAS
HIRED. AND IS NOW A CREW TO
LEADER AT THE BUTTE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS.
AND CAVING TENTO CLINICAL
PROFESSOR OF LAW AT DIRECTOR OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE CLINIC AT
UC IRVINE SCHOOL. THANK YOU.
TOMORROW CAN YOU PATCH QUE
TENTO AND FERNANDO HIGHER IN.
WE HAVE A LINE TWO NINE ONE
CALL HAD. AT THE- I'M SORRY I'M
JUST FOR ME TO NOT THE MAIN
WITNESS HELLO MISTER CHAIR
MANDO GUERRERO IS OUR FIRST
WITNESS FERNANDO FERRER CAN
CATCH ONE MOMENT. WE HAVE A NEW
MODERATOR. FISHKILL HEERLEN ON.
I DON'T SEE MISTER CAROLINE.
IDC MISSED TENTO CAKE TO ENTER.
I AM HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
YOU CAN BEGIN BY LINING UP AND
GO BACK. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS KATIE
TENDO AND I'M A CLINICAL
PROFESSOR OF LAW AND DIRECTOR
OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE CLINIC
AT UC IRVINE SCHOOL OF LAW. I
REPRESENT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE.
CONNECTION I AM VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THE BIG BEARS AND HURDLES
FORMALLY IN. ALL STATE WHEN
SEEKING OF ON FROM PAST
MISTAKES. IN THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN PROVIDING FORMERLY
INCARCERATED IN VISUAL WAY.
THEIR CONVICTION. HOWEVER
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CONVICTED
OF FELONIES STILL FACE AN
ENORMOUS BARRIERS IN GETTING
THIS RELIEF AND OFTEN HAVE
DIFFICULTIES FINDING MANY
EMPLOYMENT. UNDER THE LAW MANY
INDIVIDUALS COMMIT A FELONY AND
ARE SENTENCED TO A TERM IN
COUNTY JAIL ARE NOT ELIGIBLE TO
EXPAND THEIR CONVICTIONS UNTIL
ONE TWO YEARS AFTER THE RELEASE
FROM CUSTODY. THE PROGRAM MY
CAMP OR DEMONSTRATE OTHER
REMARK READ. LIKE SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETING RESIDENTIAL DRUG
TREATMENT. BUT THESE ARE THE
HURDLES FACED BY INDIVIDUALS
WHO SERVE THEIR TIMING COUNTY
JAIL MOST INDIVIDUAL TO SERVE
THEIR SENTENCE IN STATE PRISON
EVEN IF THE SHORT TERM. TWO
YEARS. NO MATTER THE EXTENT
REHABILITATION THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE NEVER ABLE TO
SEEK AN EXPUNGEMENT UNDER
INDIVIDUALS MUSCLE THE MINIMUM
OF SEVEN YEARS AND THEN THEY
ARE ONLY ABLE TO APPLY FOR A
CERTIFICATE OF REHABILITATION A
LIMITED FORM OF RELIEF THAT
DOES NOT. THE CONNECTION FOR
SOMETHING PURPOSES. IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO KNOW THAT EVEN
ONCE INDIVIDUALS ARE ELIGIBLE
TO APPLY FOR AN EXPUNGEMENT-
CERTIFICATE REHABILITATION. IT
IS NOT CERTAIN BY ANY MEANS
THAT THE COURT WILL GRANT IT.
CRIMINAL COURTS ARE HIGHLY
LOCALIZED THE DECISION IS IN
THE HANDS OF AN INDIVIDUAL
JUDGE AND THE OPINION OF THE-
PROSECUTOR IS OFTEN VERY AND
SHALL. REQUEST FOR EXPUNGEMENT
AND CERTIFICATES OF
REHABILITATION ARE OFTEN DO NOT.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW AN
INDIVIDUAL EXACTLY COMPLETED
ONE OF THE FIRE CAN'T PROGRAM
TO BE ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR
PUNISHMENT UPON HIS OR HER
RELEASE FROM CUSTODY. WOULD
CREATE OPPORTUNITY IS
IMMEDIATELY RATHER THAN HAVING
THIS INDIVIDUAL WAIT YEARS
BEFORE HERE SHE COULD TRY TO
MOVE FORWARD IN A PROFESSIONAL
CAREER. THIS TIME IN ITS
CREDIT. IT IS UPON A PERSON'S
RELEASED FROM CUSTODY WHEN THEY
MOST NEED A PATHWAY TO
EMPLOYMENT. STORIES LIKE WE'LL
HOPEFULLY HEAR FROM FOR. REMIND
US IS WHY THERE IS ANY GIVE
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPROVE THEIR LIVES. BY
ALLOWING A PERSON TO APPLY FOR
AN EXPUNGEMENT WITH
DEMONSTRATED IMPRESSIVE
REHABILITATION BUT THE CATHOLIC
COMPLETING FIRE CAN'T. THIS
BILL RE WILL REDUCE TO THE
RHYTHM AND PROVIDE A CRITICAL
OPPORTUNITY THE INDIVIDUAL.
WELL IN FAMILY. AMBER STRONGLY
YOU. THANK YOU. ARE WE WERE
ABLE TO FIND MISTER HERGER. FOR
NOW I UNDERSTAND HE'S ON THE
LINE. EXAMPLE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BE SURE LARGER LINE IS UP AND
GO AHEAD. DOES HE NEED ON MUTE
ARE YOU NEED DONE MUSIC IT.
MILLION IT TELL ME WHAT IF HIS
NOTE ALIGN ITSELF AND FOR
EVERYBODY. FERNANDO I THINK YOU
NEED TO WEAR.
MAYBE MAYBE WE DO
THE OTHER ME TO AND THEN
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN GET IN AFTER
THAT SO ARE THERE ANY ME
TUESDAY MINT ORGANIZATION WE
WAIT TO HERA TO GET IN. THAT
WOULD BE YOU MISTER MODERATOR.
LINE TWO NINE ONE GO HEAD. IT
HAS SOME MARKED AT THE
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE THREE FOUR SIX
GO AHEAD. MARCO GEORGE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE REYES
SPEAKS ONE GO AHEAD. PROTECTED
AND SALAS NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. LINE THREE
THREE FIVE GO AHEAD. WE ARE
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA LINE FOR
YOU TO THE COMMUNITY DOCTOR
DESTRUCTIBLE THANK YOU. LINE
TWO SEVEN ONE GO AHEAD AT. MY
NAME THAT'S FUNDING IS ON THE
STATE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR GET
THE UPPER HAND OVER ACTUALLY IS
ONE OF MY MENTEES- AND SO WERE
IN. STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS.
THANK YOU. LINE THREE SIX ZERO
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS AB CHáVEZ
I AM WITH INITIATE THAT THERE
AND THAT SOMEONE WHO HAD A LOVE
FOR PAROLE FROM FIRE CAN'T
AFTER THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
WILD PRTIES AND I AM A STRONG.
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE OH SEVEN GO AHEAD. YES
YOU'RE GOING TO FIND OUT THAT
SHE JUSTICE ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE THREE
TWO ZERO GO AHEAD. PANIC ALARM
NAM HAPPENED CAMPAIGN COULD GO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
STRONG WORK THANK YOU. AND
THERE ARE NO MORE QUESTIONS NO
MORE COMMENTS WHAT. OKAY CAN WE
TRY SEE IF WE GET FERNANDO
ABOUT. IN THE HOTEL I AM GLAD A
LOT. SO CALLED. I DON'T I DON'T
SEE ANY FIRMANDO HAVE READ ON
THE LATEST ON PERCENT OF ROAD
NUMBER SIX MORE THAN ONE. HELLO
BUT THE LINE IS OPEN. OKAY GET
THE NEW CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS FERNANDO
GUERRA I AM TWENTY YEARS OLD
I'VE FOUGHT WITH AN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TEAM ON THE FRONT LINE.
FUNDING TO A NUMBER OF NATURAL
DISASTERS EMERGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA. SOME INCLUDE THE
THOMAS FIRE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN THE CAMPFIRE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. THE KK FIRE
NINETY THOUSAND IN NINETEEN
UPON MY RELEASE I JOIN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
RIGHT NOW SERVE AS A CREW
LEADER. AT THE BUTTE FIRE
CENTER WHICH IS JOINTLY
OPERATED BY CAL FIRE MANY OF MY
PEERS. AND I DO WANT TO JUST
LET YOU MIGHT HAVE TO STORIES.
WE ARE BROKE. GROWING UP THERE
WAS NO BALANCE IN OUR LIVES
BECAUSE WE LACK GUIDANCE. MOST
OF US DIDN'T RECEIVE POSITIVE
REINFORCEMENTS CONTROL IN IS
THE CORE. WHEN I WAS A LITTLE
KID ALL POSSIBLE. HE BUT HARD
QUALITY EXPERIENCE THE DARK
PASSED THE POVERTY I HAVE YOUNG.
AND THE LADY THE COMFORT THIS.
COOPER WITH THIS. LET ME TO BUY
TOP OF THE STREET. I REALIZED
OR JUST ABOUT TO SHEEP COULD
NOT REALLY LEADER NO GUIDANCE
WE WERE LIKE THE BLIND LEADING
THE BLIND WITH NO CLEAR PATH.
ANOTHER PRODUCT OF OUR UNSTABLE
HOMES. I DON'T NEED TO GO TO
MEDINA MUD BRING BUT I LIKE YOU
TO KNOW. THE HARD CHOOSE TO LET
LED MANY OF US TO GO DOWN THE
WRONG PATH. THANK YOU. HAVE A
MORAL COMPASS AND UNDERSTANDING
MY WRONG HELP ME FIRE MY GROUP
MY GROWTH. WHEN ALL THE RED
COULD BE DONE AND FOURTEEN I
KNEW THAT I WANTED MORE FOR
MYSELF TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND BOOK PROGRAMS
INCLUDING MANY SELF HELP GROUPS
AND- IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.%
BECAUSE MY CONSISTING GOOD
BEHAVIOR I WAS ABLE TO GO TO
PINE GROVE WHEN CARSON MEN ARE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
THE STATE AS FIREFIGHTERS.
HOWEVER GETTING ONTO FAR TOO
LONG CRISES INTENT IN A CLOSE
DIGGERS TRAINING. INCLUDING A
STANDARD HIKING UNEVEN TERRAIN
AT HIGH ALTITUDE ONE FULL FIRE
PROTECTIVE GEAR AND CARRYING
FORTY POUNDS SOMETIMES MORE IN
YOUR FIRE PACKED WITH A
CHAINSAW AND OTHER HAND TOOLS
AS WELL AS CHALLENGING OUR IN
THE CLASSROOM ON TOP OF IT. IN
MY AMBITION AND VISION FOR
CHANGE MY CAPTAIN ENCOURAGED ME
TO JOIN THE CLUB WHEN I WAS
WHEN I WAS RELEASED. JOINT
COURT HAVE HELPED ME GAIN
CONFIDENCE DEVELOP AS AN
INDIVIDUAL AND THE ROLE MODEL.
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE BACK
TO MY COMMUNITY BUT MOSTLY TO
WORK TOWARD GET PER GIVING
MYSELF AND SERVING OTHERS.
PEOPLE LIKE ME THAT COME TO SEE
DC OFTEN LACK TE GUIDANCE. WE
ALL SHARE A COMMON GOAL TO
DEVELOP AND BUILD CONFIDENCE.
TO ME IT WAS MORE THAN PHYSICAL
TRAINING SO I TOOK THE EMPTY
COURTS TO FURTHER MY NOWLEDGE
UNFORTUNATELY HOWEVER. ALTHOUGH
I'M CHANGE QUALIFIED AND
EDUCATED IN THE FIELD BECAUSE
OF THE ACTIONS THAT THEY CAN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN I CAN'T
BE REGISTERED MEAN P. EVEN NON
CERTIFIED. I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
YOU ALL BUT I'M NOT THE SAME
PERSON I WAS FIVE YEARS AGO.
IGINLA AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN WILL ALLOW ME THE ABILITY
TO APPLY FOR EXPUNGEMENT.
PEOPLE ARE QUICK TO JUDGE
SOMEONE WITH THE RECORD FOR
SOMEONE WHO MAKES MISTAKES BUT
THE UNWILLING TO LISTEN AND
HELP VALIDATE THE IN
INDIVIDUALS VOICE AND HELP THEM
GROW. THIS CYCLE MUSTANG. THERE
HAS TO BE AN UNDERSTANDING THAT
WE CAN GROW WE CAN DEVELOP I'M
NOT ALONE AND I STRONGLY FEEL
THAT HOPE IS BROUGHT TO LIGHT.
SHE I STRONGLY FEEL THAT HOLDEN
BUT LIKE SUPPORT IS
COMMUNICATING THOSE WHO BEEN
BUILDING AND REMODELING
THEMSELVES THAT THE COURT CAN
SEE THAT THEY ARE NOT ALONE WE
ARE NOT A- WE NEED YOU TO
RECOGNIZE THE FOR THE CHANGING
THE VISUAL THAT WE ARE. MEASURE
LIKE AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN
RECOGNIZED ME AND MY PEERS AND
HELP US FEEL HUMAN AGAIN AND
GIVE US THE RESOURCES TO BRING
DOWN WITH OTHER THAN RATE. THE
GROUPS LIKE AND PALESTINIAN
COALITION AND MEMBERS LIKE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY IS THAT
HAVE HELPED SPARK HOPE AND HELP
US UNDERSTAND THAT OUR VOICES
HEARD. THEY GIVE US A PLATFORM
TO SHIRK DORY SO WE CAN DO WE
CAN BRING CHANGE. I KNOW THAT A
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER ALL THE REST
OF MY LIFE SERVING OTHERS.
NUMBER OF THE CITY AFTER YOU
INVESTING. AND OTHERS LIKE ME
CLEVER RECOGNIZE THE WRONG AND
WANT TO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES. I RESPECTFULLY
URGE HI BEAU ON AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. NOW
HERE FROM. THE TIME YOU'RE
WELCOME TO ALLOW HERE FROM
OPPOSITION LARRY MORSE CD A ON
THE PHONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
LARRY MORSE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE FORTY SEVEN. MAC LOOKED OF
RECENT CRIMINAL JUSTICE
MEASURES LIKE AB ONE OH NINE
AND PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN THE
CURRENT POPULATION OF INMATES
IN OUR STATE PRISONS GENERALLY
EXCLUDES LOW OF OLD LOW
OFFENDERS. WHILE WE RECOGNIZE
THE RISKS OF CLOSE THE
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA AND
THEN TO USE ALL AVAILABLE
RESOURCES- INCLUDING PERSONS
SERVING FELL OF THE SENTENCES
TO COMBAT WHILE BOB. IT THE
PIRATE. WE BELIEVE SO SWEET
ROOM BUT MEANT OR DISMAY AS A
COMPASS TO NAVY TWENTY ONE
FORTY SEVEN WHAT ESSENTIALLY
WIPE THE SLATE CLEAN FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE COMMITTED CRIMES OF
VIOLENCE THAT RESULTED IN
LENGTHY PRISON SENTENCES. IN
THE BILL. WE ARE. WELL PRO. SO
YOUR ELIGIBILITY IT APPEARS THE
IN BASIC FROM ELLA FOR THE
EXPUNGEMENT REAL FUNDED BILL
WOULD BE THOSE CONVICTED AND
SENT TO NINE CENTS IS OURS OR
VIOLENT BECAUSE- MEANS THE CAN
OF VIOLENT ASSAULTED CRIMES
LIKE ROCK. SO GREAT BOND INJURY
CARJACKINGS AND MORE WOULD BY
VIRTUE OF PARTICIPATINGIN FIRE
CAMPS HAVE THEIR RECORDS WIPED
CLEAN DO WE REALLY WANT TO GO
SO IS EXPLODING THE RECORD OF A
PERSON CONVICTED OF ORDINARY
ACTS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR
PERSONAL USE OF A FIREARM TO
COMMIT ROBBERY AMONG THE CRIME.
ELIGIBLE AND WHAT STATE TO
THOSE WITH A BIG. RAIMES THAT
IS FOR THE STATE IS CONCERNED
THE CARD THEM FOR ALL ALL AND
PURPOSES NEVER HAPPENED. WE
BELIEVE SUCH RELIEF SHOULD BE
LIMITED TO THOSE WHO RECEIVE
LOCAL SENTENCES EITHER FELONY
PROBATION OR ELEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT SENTENCES NOT STATE
PRISON SENTENCES MOREOVER
PRISON INMATES TO SUPPORT IT
PARTICIPATING IN WILDLIFE
PREVENTION AND CONTAINMENT
ALREADY RECEIVED SIGNIFICANT
AND IMPORTANT INCENTIVES AND
BENEFITS SUCH AS TWO FOUR ONE
CONTACT CREDITS. WITH OFFICIALS
AT CD EARLIER TODAY WE STILL
DON'T HAVE A DEFINITIVE IDEA OF
WHO IS AND ISN'T ELIGIBLE TO
OBTAIN THE RELIEF OFFERED BY
THIS BILL. YOU KNOW YOU THAT IT
IS CRITICAL AND WE BELIEVE THE
PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW TIED
RHYMES THAT ARE BEING PUNISHED
FROM RECORDS. AT A MINIMUM WE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
AUTHOR TO CONSIDER AMENDING THE
BILL TO LIMIT THE GIFT OF
EXPUNGEMENT FOR A CRIME THAT
RESULTED IN THE STATE PRISON
SENTENCE. THE NON SERIOUS AND
NON VIOLENT DRUG. WOULD BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
TO CLEARLY DEFINE THOSE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE BENEFITS
OFFERED IN THIS BILL. CDA
SUPPORTS REMOVING BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING FOR
FELONS RE ENTERING OUR
COMMUNITIES HOWEVER EXPLORE
EXPOSING THE CONVICTIONS OF
THOSE CONVICTED OF VIOLENT
ASSAULT DESCRIBES. IS SIMPLY A
BRIDGE TOO FAR AND WE WOULD ASK
pYOU MISTER MORRIS ARE THERE ANY
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION- MISSED.
MISTER MODERATOR NAME IN
ORGANIZADA THE LINE TWO EIGHTY
ONE GO AHEAD. YOU LINE IT UP
INTO A ONE. ALL RIGHT. THIS
COURT TO. NINE THREE FIVE EIGHT
ZERO GO AHEAD. CAN YOU AGREE
TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND I
APOLOGIZE WORDS ACTUALLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I WAS
PUSHED OVER TO THE OPPOSE
COLUMN ACCIDENTALLY. THANK YOU.
LINE. THREE FIVE EIGHT FIVE.
YES THIS IS PASSAGE MKC
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF COAL AND
SENIOR PASTOR OF NEW LIFE
CHRISTIAN CHURCH IN THE CITY OF
FONTANA WE CELEBRATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RARE AND IN WE ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY SEVEN IN RESPONSIBLE READ
THEM AND RESTORE ORDER PAYING
TO. KEEP THANK YOU I KNOW NINE
THREE FIVE FOUR KH<c.red>HELLO</c>
THIS IS TOM DOLAN ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ENGLAND
CONGREGATIONS UNITED COULD
CHANGE. OUR CONGREGATION
STRONGLY BELIEVE IN THE POWER
OF REDEMPTION. WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL WILL HELP US WE HAD A
GREAT MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY AND FOR
THAT REASON WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. COULD SO MAKE SURE
WE GET THE LINE FOR. PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN OPPOSITION. QUITE
IMPRESSIVE ONE ZERO TWO A POWER.
I KNOW COMMITTEE I'M SORRY OKAY
DO YOU WANT TO FINISH OFF THE
ONES IN SUPPORT THAT MAY NOT
HAVE GOTTEN HIM BEFORE. THOSE
WHO SUPPORT PLEASE ONE ZERO
AHEAD. I CARELESSLY THAT CAN'T
BE DIMARTINO WITH CALIFORNIANS
ARE SEEKING JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE HOLD ON
JUST A MOMENT. NINE THREE SEVEN
THREE GO AHEAD. THREE SEVEN
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. APRIL
GREAT THEN STATEWIDE
COORDINATOR FOR THIS IS TO WORK
WITH THE COALITION I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TWO
ONE FOUR SEVEN. THANK YOU. LINE
THREE SEVEN FOUR GO AHEAD.
THREE SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES HI THIS IS KATHY SURE
ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA STRUCK SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NORMAL COMMENTING TO
GUIDE THANK YOU ARE NOW BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS. LIST
POWER QUE. NEEDS THANK YOU
SHARE. IN THIS CONVERSATION
THAT AND OTHER QUESTIONS WE ARE
ASKING OPPOSITION. RIGHT I
WOULD BE HEALTH NOW I MY SON
WOULD YOU DRESS THE
OPPOSITION'S AND REQUESTS THAT
WE TAKE OUT. MASON VIOLENT
OFFENDERS FROM THIS EXCEPTION.
I WILL CERTAINLY- WITH THEM I
AM OPEN TO THE DISCUSSION OKAY.
AND THEN CAN I ASK I THINK THE
NAME OF YOUR WITNESS AGAIN I'M
SORRY FERNANDO CARREIRA. AND SO
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WERE YEAR
AND SUPPORT WANT TO ANSWER THIS
BUT I GUESS SO MY FOR
CLARIFICATION HAVING READ BOTH
CURRENT EXPANSION LAW AND THIS
IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
REAL EXPANSION OF THIS IS THOSE
FOLKS WHO ARE IS PROVIDING
EXPANSION OPPORTUNITIES TO
THOSE FOLKS THAT ARE AND
IMPRISONED IN OUR STATE.
FACILITIES RIGHT RIGHT YES AND
I CAN I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
PROFESSOR KATIE TEN TELL. THE
ANSWER IS YES OKAY I'M HERE.
PROFESSOR TENTO THIS. YES I
THINK THE EXPANSION IS IN TWO
KEY WAYS- THE MOST IMPORTANT IN
MY MND IS THE TINY IN. MEANING
THAT. INDIVIDUAL TO ACCEPT THE
COMPLETE- FIRE CAN'T CAN
PETITION FOR EXPUNGEMENT
IMMEDIATELY UPON RELEASE FROM
CUSTODY AS OPPOSED TO A WAITING
PERIOD- AND THEN YES IT ALSO
EXPANDS- THE EXPUNGEMENT RELIEF
FOR THOSE INCARCERATED IN STATE
PRISON WHO THEN DO FIRE CAMP
FROM. PRESIDENT NOW DID YOU-
AND I APOLOGIZE I WAS IN-
ANOTHER. HEARING I AND I COULD
SEE MAY HAVE ADDRESS THIS BUT
THAT ANALYSIS TALKS ABOUT SORT
OF THE VAGUENESS OF THE
DEFINITION OF SUCCESSFUL
PARTICIPATION. YEAH BUT HE- WE
TALK A LITTLE ABOUT THAT WHAT
THAT MEANS IT'S A LITTLE
UNCLEAR TO ME AS WELL. THE
PRESENT CDC ARE PROVIDES THE
CERTIFICATES I THINK THAT. IT'S
AN AREA THOUGH THE DOES NEED TO
WILL NEED TO WORK WITH C. C. R.
ADD TO THAT THE KEY. DOES WELL
TO A PRIVATE PROPER CRITERIA.
FOR THAT SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION
I THINK THE ANALYSIS IS FAIR IN
ASKING THAT THAT BE FAIR
FURTHER CLARIFIED SO WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY BE WORKING ON THAT.
I THINK YOU SO I THINK I MEAN.
I REALLY RESPECT WHAT. YOU'RE
TRYING TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER ****
AND I THINK THAT IT IS ALWAYS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO GIVE
OPPORTUNITY FOR RE INTEGRATION
I THINK THAT'S WHAT EXPUNGEMENT
THIS FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
SHOWN THAT THEY CAN.
SUCCESSFULLY HE AND- THEN AND
SUCCEED IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
I GUESS- MY CONCERN LIES THE
IDEA THAT THESE. VIOLENT OF
THERE IS WHO WILL. EAST AND
THEN I'M LEVY TO GET X. WHAT
ANY BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THIS
WOULD PROVIDE IF ONE HAD DONE.
AND SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED FIRE
CAN'T WHILE INSIDE AND SO. ON
IT REALLY IS THIS. VERY FOLKS
CAN OUT AND SO. I THINK I. OFF
TODAY FOR IT. THE OPPOSITION
AND HOPEFULLY WE GET HOPE WHERE
AND WE'RE GETTING THIS OP TO
PEOPLE WHO I'M CAN TRULY THRIVE
WHEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY SO I
THINK IF. TO RESPOND. YOU CAN
DO IT IN YOUR CLOSER IS ANY YES
MISS KOREA. FIRST I WANT TO
THANK BE- OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SENATOR NINO FOR INTRODUCING
THIS BILL WHEN I WORKED. AUTHOR
TO BILL LAST YEAR IS THAT
PROVIDE PATHWAY FOR
INCARCERATED OR FORMALLY
INCARCERATED FIREFIGHTERS. TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY IN A
PATHWAY FOR. EMPLOYMENT THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS AND UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE
OF THE CURRENT SITUATION THAT
WE'RE LIVING IN WITH COAL BED
AND POTENTIAL FUNDS TO FUND
THIS PROGRAM WE MAY HAVE TO BE
LOOKING AT ALTERNATIVE- OPTIONS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD EVEN THOUGH.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CURRENT CERTAINLY INVEST IN BE
SKILLED TRAINED AND DEVELOPMENT
ARE. FOLKS WORK SIDE OUR
TRADITIONAL FIREFIGHTERS- FOR
WHAT IS CONSIDERED THE NEW
NORMAL IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
THE WILD FIRE PREVENTION AND WE
CERTAINLY NEED TO DO A LOT OF
WORK AROUND THAT AT. THAT ARE
GOVERNOR. CAN AND TO FIGURE.
HOW WE DO THAT IN A LOT OF THAT
IS CHEN SO IF WE AS A STATE AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS IS INVESTING IN THE
TRAINING OF INDIVIDUALS TO-
BECOME BECOME PART OF THE CAMP
THE DOES THIS PART OF THE
REQUIREMENTS IS THAT THEY ARE
ACTUALLY AND NON VIOLENT.
OFFENDERS A LOT OF THIS TO BE A
WOMAN THAT THEY- DON'T HAVE THE
SEVERE CRIMES IS ACTUALLY ISN'T.
THE CONVERSATION BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO MEET A MINIMUM
REQUIREMENT OF NON CRIMES. TO
BE PART OF THE- PROGRAM TO
BEGIN WITH WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS. BECAUSE THERE'S
ALREADY A- EXTENSIVE LIST OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WANT TO BE A
PART OF THIS PROGRAM AND SO THE
REQUIREMENT TO JOHN. OR THE
POLICY. ACTUALLY QUITE HIGH IN
ADDITION TO THAT THE THIS
PROGRAM SAVES THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ABOUT ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR- WITH-
THE WORK THAT THEY DO WHICH
PAYS VERY LITTLE AND THERE'S
BEEN NATIONALLY. FIVE THESE
FIRE. IN THIS PART CAMP GET
PAID ABOUT I THINK IT WAS LIKE
A DOLLAR FIFTY A DAY SOMETHING
LIKE THAT- AND I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO CONSIDER HOW WE USE THE
INVESTMENT IN PEOPLE. AS A WAY
TO PROVIDE OPPORTUNITY AND
RESOURCES ONCE- FOLKS ARE OUT
SO I THINK THE QUESTIONS THAT
ARE- THAT HAVE ARISEN TO VALID
IN TERMS OF. TRYING TO- CREATE
LANGUAGE AND- ASSURANCE. THAT
PEOPLE CAN BE SAFE I THINK AT
THE END OF THE DAY THERE'S A
LOT OF PUBLIC SAFETY- QUESTIONS
THAT SHOULD BE ADDRESSED. BUT I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
I WANT TO APPLAUD. THE YOUNG
AND- FERNANDO FROM BUTTE COUNTY
HERE- REALLY GREAT THINGS ABOUT
BUTTE COUNTY AND LOOK FORWARD
TO VISIT ONE DAY BUT FOR THE
WORK. HE'S DONE TO ENSURE THAT
HE'S MOVING FORWARD AS A YOUNG
MAN HE'S TWENTY YEARS OLD AND
WAS ABLE TO ARTICULATE HIS
PERSON. THIS IS THE STORIES ARE
SO IMPORTANT WE HEAR THEM.
BECAUSE IT'S A YOUNG MAN TWENTY
YEARS OLD HAVING ALREADY BEEN
PRESS SYSTEM AND FOUND ALL TURN
INTO FOR HIS LIFE. AND NOW
TRYING TO DO. SOMETHING GOOD
AND- OF WELL YOU. HAVEN'T HIS
COMMUNITY I THINK IT'S A- FOR
US TO RECOGNIZE. AND ONE LAST
THING I DO WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT
OUT TO. A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE
AND- SOMEBODY THAT. LEAD TO
PROGRAM AT HOME V<c.cyan></c>
INDUSTRIES AND MY COMMUNITY
HECTOR. COOL MANY YEARS AGO.
OFTEN THE SAME SITUATION AS A
YOUNG MAN CAUGHT UP ON THE EAST
SIDE OF LA THE DISTRICT THAT I
NOW REPRESENT. HAVING GONE TO
PRISON HAVING GONE TO ME. A
FIREFIGHTER CAMP TRAINING AND
HAD. ME PERSONALLY. WORKING OUT
OF. YOUR THAT HE WOULD LOVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT WORK.
THE BECAUSE THESE LAWS WERE IN
A PLACE THERE WASN'T ANYONE
ADVOCATING FOR HIM AT THAT
TIME. HE WILL BE ABLE. SO I'M
GLAD THAT THERE IS- AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT NOW AND
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES
AND TO GIVE PEOPLE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO GOOD WORK
WHEN. THEY'RE OUT THANK YOU.
THANK THE- YOUR QUESTION. YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
EXPUNGEMENT SURVEIL BILL NOW.
AND THOSE WITH FELONY
CONVICTIONS ARE REQUIRED TO
WAIT MUCH LONGER SO I COULD BE
AS AS A PROFESSOR MAKE MENTION
TO GIVE YOU SEVEN YEARS. THIS
PROVIDES THAT OPPORTUNITY WE'RE
LOOKING AT REHABILITATION IF
DURING THEIR TIME IN PRISON
THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO WORK
THEY WERE SELECTED BECAUSE OF
THEIR BEHAVIOR ALREADY. THEY
WERE SELECTED BECAUSE OF THE
THEY WERE IN. THE LOWEST
CLASSIFICATION OF INMATES AS
THE AS HAS BEEN NOTED. LOWER
LEVEL- VIOENCE. NON VIOLENT
CRIMES. THEY WERE SELECTED-
BECAUSE OF THIS AND THAT DURING
THEIR TIME WORKING ON THESE
FIRE CREWS ARE UNDER
SUPERVISION THE ENTIRE TIME AND
THIS AT TIMES IS CONSIDERED
PART OF THE REHABILITATION
PROGRAM. AND WITH THAT I DO ASK
THAT WE AS WE MOVE FORWARD-
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD THE
PRACTICE OF REHABILITATION. THE
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN IS
INSTILLING HOLE IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM GIVING
INDIVIDUALS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROPERLY INTEGRATE INTO SOCIETY
AND ALLOWING THEM TO GET THE
SIX FUNDS MEANT ON AN EXPEDITED
BASIS RATHER THAN WAITING THAT.
FOR SEVEN YEARS. RESPECT ASK
FOR YOUR I'VE- THANK YOU INTO I
CHAIR. SOME OF THE COULD OF THE
CALIFORNIA AGREE SIR THIRTY
SOCIAIS AND I. A LOT OF IT
WOULD GO THE WAY SO IF WE TALK
TO CDC ARE AND AT WHAT ARE
REQUIRE FOR YOU THE BEING. IN
THIS I THINK YOU WERE I THINK
THE PUBLIC. AND EVEN THE DA
OFFICE WILL GET SOME COMFORT
KNOWING THAT IT'S A HIGH. THEY
JUST DON'T TAKE ANY AND IN THAT
WAY REALLY DO INTO THAT. SO
THAT YOU SEE THAT IS THE BEST
OF THE BEST BETTER IN CDC Y.
TWO LET'S LOOK AT THE CRIMES
INVOLVED AND IF THERE'S A WAY
TO A- IT TO GIVE SOME KIND OF.
FEELING THAT WE'RE MOVING IN
DOWN MOVE YOUR RIGHT DIRECTION.
WE DON'T HAVE WE DON'T ALL
DON'T HAVE A MISTAKE BECAUSE I
AS YOU KNOW. ALL IT TAKES JUST
ONE PER GOING TO THIS TO SET A
BACK. TEN TWENTY YEARS SO. WE
DO HAVE TO MAKE. THE ROOM. AS
AS WE CANCER ONE PEOPLE OF BACK
AT WHAT WE'VE DONE. OF WHO WE
ALLOWED. DON'T KNOW THE WE MADE
IT. THE MOST DIFFICULT NO
STRANGE PROCESS DECK COULD BE
AND THE SUCCESS RATE IS
UNBELIEVABLY HIGH AND IF SOME
DOES. NOT TO MEET THOSE. THERE
THERE YOU IT'S NOT. IT'S AN
ABERRATION AND SO I I'M WE TO
WORK WITH YOU LES MORSE AND-
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS. TO MAYBE
TRY TO FOR A SWEET SPOT AND
HOPEFULLY MISTER MOORE SO ALSO
WILL UP TO MEET WITH THE- ZOOM
WHATEVER BUT THE NEW THE NEW
NORMAL OF I'M WILLING TO WORK
YOU AS WE MOVE THIS CAN BE. AND
BEFORE IT GETS. TO THE FLOOR
AND WORK FOR YOU BEFORE IT GETS
A DISCLOSE APPROACH WITH GETS
TO A THAT. WE'VE READ REFINED
IT. IF THE IN AND I THINK ONCE
WE START THERE AND MAYBE EVEN
ADD SOME MORE REQUIREMENTS
WORKING WITH CDC ARE. WE MAY BE
ABLE TO SCORE ABOUT. SOME FOLKS
THERE REALLY SHOULD BE. OKAY
GREAT SO THE JURORS RECOMMEND
AYE BOAT WITH THE UNDERSTAND IT
WE STILL NEED TO DO SOME WORK.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED ON AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN RAY AS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JOHN
SO YOUR EYES LACKEY NO LACKEY
NOW BARRICADE CAN. DEREK HE HAD
NOT VOTING DEEP. KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I CAN RIO CARILLO I
SANTIAGO. WICKS. THE VOTE IS
THE ONE THAT MEASURES ON CALL
NEEDS TO. THANK YOU. DO NEXT
WHAT VERY GOOD THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX THE
CLEANUP BILL TO EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTEEN WHICH WILL
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT POLICY FOR UNDOCUMENTED
VICTIMS OF CRIMES. PACIFIC GLEE
WHEN THEY ST CLAIR FOR
CERTIFICATION BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATING
AGENCIES OTHER YOU VISA AND
TV'S- FORMS. A U. VISAS GRANTED
TO VICTIMS OF A CRIME OR THEIR
LOVED ONES. WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED KNOW FULLY
COOPERATE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO ASSIST IN THE PROSECUTION OF
A CRIMINAL CASE. SOME LANE THE
TV IS A LOT OF DOUBLE VICTIMS
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING TO
TEMPORARILY REMAIN AND WORK IN
THE UNITED. SIGNED INTO LAW
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTEEN WHICH
UPDATE AT THE TIMELINE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
CERTIFICATION AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE PROPER DOCUMENTATION.
TO THE VICTIM OF A CRIME OR THE
REPRESENTATIVES FOR THE
PURPOSES OF OBTAINING YOUR
VIEWS AND TV'S A CERTIFICATION.
HOWEVER MANY IMMIGRATION
PRACTITIONERS OF EXPRESS THE
INCONSISTENCY OF CERTIFICATIONS
FROM CERTIFYING AGENCIES HAS
DEMONSTRATED THE NEED TO
FURTHER CLARIFY STATE STATUTE.
IN ORDER TO CREATE A UNIFORM
STATE POLICY TO FURTHER
PROTECTED VICTIMS THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THE ROLE OF POLICE
DEPARTMENTS GOVERNED BY LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARDS POLICE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES AND THAT
IS CERTIFIED CERTIFYING AGENCY
MUST COMPLETE A FORM. IF A
VICTIM MEETS ALL ELIGIBILITY
HERE TO TEST AND SUPPORTERS
BILL IS CHRISTOPHER'S SONGES
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH STATE LAW.
A MISTER. MISTER SANCHEZ FROM
CHIRLA. I MISSED DUROCHER BUT-
SORRY CRISTINA MEANING THAT'S
RIGHT- BUT MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ARE RESPONSIBLE CHAIR OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS- I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS
BRIEF IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
WE'RE PROBABLY SPONSORED BE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
SIX TO FURTHER CLARIFY THE LONG
RESPONSIBILITY YOU ALONG FOR
TWENTY AGENCIES AVE TO DO AND
THE UV STEP PROCESS OUR STUDY
THAT HAVE BEEN SHOWN ON THE-
CERTIFYING. IN THE LONG COURSE
FROM LACK KNOWLEDGE OR PROP
UNDERSTANDING OF THE LAW IN THE
YOU GET THE PRODUCT THEREFORE.
WE SEEK TO HAVE A- CLEAR
FINALLY WHICH TO ENSURE THAT
ALL THE AGENCIES ARE OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES. OUGHT TO. THE
U. S. I. AT THE AGENCY WHICH
ABOUT AGENCY THAT UP OR DENIED.
CAN TO APPROVE APPLICATION THAT
HAVE BEEN BOB HAD BEEN IN THE
PAST THAT WERE FROM. YEARS OP
PRIOR BEFORE THE- THE- THE
VICTIM HAD COME FORWARD AND
REQUEST CERTIFICATION THEREFORE
WE'RE ASKING THAT THE ROLE OF
OUR DENIAL STAY WITHIN THE
HANDS OF THAT FEDERAL AGENCIES.
WITHIN THE CURRENT OUR LEGAL
SYSTEM. LAST WEEK I LIKE THE
STATE BY BY STRENGTHENING
UNIFORM POLICY IS NEEDED NOW
MORE THAN EVER OF MANY. ARE AS
WE ARE AWARE BUT UNFORTUNATELY
AUDIO CHILDREN PLEASE ORDER COP
CAR AND PEOPLE FOR. IRONMAN OF
THE VIOLENCE ARE MUCH BIGGER DO
NOT HAVE A CHOICE. A CRIME
MAYBE COMMITTED. TO WHAT CITY
THEY RAN ON YOUR SECTION THE
REGION. ON THE MISSION OF THE-
FOR. THIS FOR THESE REASONS
WORK PARK THERE MEASURE. YOUR
AND YOUR OUTLOOK BILL THERE'S-
YEAH YOU OTHER ANY OTHER. IT'S
A SECOND. IS DOES NOT SPORT THE
SECOND PERSON. YEAH BUT THEY
WILL IT UP FOR NAMING
ORGANIZATION FOR ANYONE ELSE IN
SO. FOR PRESS ONE ZERO NOW ONE
ZERO AND GOING TO THREE FORCE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS MARCO TO
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MARGARET. LINE THREE
TO FOUR BY. CAN'T CLOSE OUT ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. HERE LINE THREE EIGHTY
ZERO CRIED. HI RAIL OF ERA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE THREE
TWO ZERO BY. DIANA TOWARD I'M
NOT A MAP AND EVERYTHING'S GOT
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. LINE THREE FIVE EIGHT
ZERO BY. JANUARY KARAGANDA
CAPITA CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE. THREE THREE
FIVE ONE. RIGHT HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LINE THAT COMMUNITY
TRUST OR. YEAH MORE COMMON
ISSUES GO. THANK YOU. WE NEED A.
HELLO. THERE'S NO ONE NO ONE
NOW. SHE. THE NEW. OF SORRY
STARTED LOOPY APPEAR. NOW HERE
FROM OPPOSITION I HAVE COREY
SELVES ALONG A BY PHONE. MISTER
MODERATOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS COREY SOWS ELLO
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WEEK
KNOWLEDGE VICTIM COOPERATION
CAN BE EXTREMELY VALUABLE WHEN
INVESTIGATING CRIMINAL OFFENSES
THAT SAID EXISTING ON THIS
MATTER REQUIRES SPECIFIED
OFFICIALS TO SIGN THESE
REQUESTED IN THE REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION THAT EFFECTIVELY
STATE FOR THE VICTIMS
COOPERATIVE OR IS LIKELY TO
COOPER. UNTIL HE OR SHE IS
COOPERATIVE LIMITING LAW
ENFORCEMENT DISCRETION. OUR
CONCERN HERE THOUGH IS THAT IF
THE CASE IS CLOSED FOR THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS HAS RUN.
THE NEED FOR AN OFFICIAL TO
MAKE A CERTIFICATION ABOUT
VICTIM COOPERATION SEEMS MOOT.
SURE WE DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY IF
THE CASE HAS BEEN CLOSED- THERE
NEEDS TO BE CLARITY ABOUT
SIGNING A CERTIFICATION GIVEN
THE TEMPORARY NATURE OF RELIEF-
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
OR TWENTY SIX THANK YOU. THAT
CAN THIS IS ALSO A- BUT MANY
PEOPLE ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION.
MODERATOR LEVEL. SHE GOT IN
PRESS ONE ZERO TOLL CALLS. ONE
ZERO. HE NOT NO ONE IS KILLING.
OKAY IT WILL BRING IT BACK OFF
I DON'T WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTION ABOUT MISTER.
LACKEY LACKEY OUR VICE CHAIR
HAS A QUESTION. BEEN HERE FOR
ALMOST EIGHT HOURS OKAY. AND
WAS A JUST A QUICK QUESTION DO
YOU HAVE ANY IDEA OF- ABOUT HOW
MANY TV'S IS ARE YOU BE SAYS-
APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN DENIED
BECAUSE OF THE PROSECUTION
PROCEEDINGS WERE ALREADY CLOSED.
I DON'T. THIS CAN PROVIDE THAT
CHRISTOPHER. MISTER LACKEY
UNFORTUNATELY- WE DON'T HAVE AN
EXACT NUMBER HOWEVER WE SHOULD
HAVE THAT NUMBER BECAUSE IN
CURRENT STATE STATUTE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SHOULD BE
PROVIDING THE OUR REPORT
ANNUALLY TO THE LEGISLATURE
STATING THE NOT OVER YOU
HOWEVER OUR FIVE SENSES THAT
YOU'VE BEEN IMPLEMENTED LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES HAVE NOT
BEEN PROVIDING- THIS REPORT-
AND SOME HAVE HOWEVER THE IT'S
BEEN SIGNIFICANT IN A NUMBER OF
LAW MOM PERSONALLY JUST BE.
PROVIDING NOT SO SHOULD- ANY TO
THINK THAT YOU BUT
UNFORTUNATELY DON'T HAVE A
CLEAR NUMBER RIGHT NOW. OKAY
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU MAY
CLOSE THIS RARE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. I DO YOU CAN
WORK OUT WITH YOURSELVES ALONE.
BECAUSE HE'S VERY FAIR MINDED
HE'S OPEN MINDED I THINK YOU'LL
BE ABLE TO TALK TO HIS CLIENTS
AND OTHERS- ABOUT THEIR
CONCERNS AND SO LET'S MOVE
FORWARD. AND ACTUALLY GET TO
START I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT SPACE FOR IMMIGRANT
POPULATION AND JUST FOR
CALIFORNIA IS A WHOLE. SO I
ALSO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD BECAUSE WE NEED TO
HAVE TO DISCUSSION. THANK YOU
ON AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX
RAISE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
JONES SAWYER JOHN SO YOU'RE AYE
LACKEY. OUR LACKEY AYE
BARRICADE HAN BARRACK HE HAD
AYE DEEP. DEEP I KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I CAN BE YOUR CARILLO
I SANTIAGO WICKS THAT MEASURE
GETS OUT SIX ZERO SIX ZERO AND
I'M STARTING TO WEAR ON MISTER
LACKEY SWITCHED TO WORKING.
YOUR BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU AND
WHILE THE STATE IN SIX HOURS
EIGHT HOURS. MISTER MARK STONE
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. AT
AB. TWENTY FIVE TWELVE. YOU ARE
NOT PLEASE DO NOT PLEASE RECORD.
AND THE DEATH PENALTY PERSONS
HOW WITH AN INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY. IN DATE I DO HAVE A
PREFERENCE WE GO WITH TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE IT'S YOUR
CHOICE ALL RIGHT SIR WITH AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE SO THE
SEALING OF JUVENILE RECORDS IS
AN IMPORTANT FACTOR IN REDUCING
RECIDIVISM. AND OPENING DOORS
TO JOBS EDUCATION AND GETTING
ON WITH THEIR LIVES. HE IS YOU
KNOW I'VE DONE A NUMBER OF
BILLS AROUND RECORD CEILING
THIS ONE AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE CLOSES THE GAP IN THE
RECORD CEILING STATUTES IT'S
SIX TO PROTECT YOUTH WHO
PARTICIPATED DIVERSION PROGRAMS
FROM THE NEGATIVE COLLATERAL
THE COMES FROM INVOLVEMENT IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WHEN A YOUTH COMPLETED VERSION
PROGRAM IN OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT THE
PROGRAM SERVICE PROVIDER BOTH
REQUIRED TO SEE OTHER RECORDS.
OVER LAW ENFORCEMENT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IS NOT AND
THAT MEANS EVEN IF THE YOUTH IS
THAT EVERYTHING NECESSARY TO
COMPLETE THE DIVERSION PROGRAM.
AND HAVE THAT PROMISE THAT WE
HAVE GIVEN THEM. OF A STILL
RECORD. THEY STILL HAVE THAT
RECORD WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AS
WE CONTINUE TO DIVERT KIDS AWAY
FROM THE JUSTICE SYSTEMS WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE'RE
HOLDING UP OUR BARGAIN. THAT WE
MAKE WITH THESE KIDS AND SEE
ALL THOSE RECORDS THIS BILL
CLOSE THE GAP AND I
RESPECTFULLY MEMBERS ASK FOR
YOUR- VOTE. I HAVE A COUPLE OF
WITH THIS JUST GALA. DARIA
LARA'S IDA. THANK YOU ARE. THE
TO OPEN A DOOR LIKE ON THE
PHONE I BELIEVE. YES COULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE BOTH OF
THE WITNESSES IN BROADHEAD. IN
FAVOR. BY TABLE PRESS ONE ZERO
NOW ONE ZERO. GO TO LINE THREE
FOUR SIX GO AHEAD. THIS IS MARK
AT LARGE. ON BEHALF OF CPD A
WE'RE OF ME TOO AND SUPPORT. SO
JESSICA LANGE JESSICA ELLIS AND
DARK DARIA LARS OUT A LETTER IS
EITHER THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
TESTIFY. ON THE CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. GO JUST GOOD HELLO- HI
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
REGARDING AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. MY NAME IS JESSICA ELLIS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF AND NOW
HE'S- WE FOUNDED THE EVERY
CHILD RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
CENTER WILL KEEP IN A LEADER AN
INNOVATOR INEFFECTIVE EVIDENCE
BE YOUTH EVERSION IT'S A
CRITICAL POINT OF FAIRNESS THAT
WE UPDATE THIS LAW TO INCLUDE
RECORDS REVEALING FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO WERE DIVERTED. AT
THE POINT OF ARREST. SHOULD A
SHOPLIFTING CHARGE WHEN YOU
WERE A CURE FOLLOWING FOURTEEN
YEAR OLD HOLD YOU BACK FROM A
CAREER IN FINANCE WHEN YOU'RE
ALMOST THIRTY. DID HAPPEN TO
ONE OF OUR YOUNG LADIES HO
AFTER GETTING HER ACCOUNTING
DEGREE. WITH BEING BLOCKED FROM
GETTING HER CPA LICENSE. WHY
SHOULD SHE HAVE TO TAKE EXTRA
STEPS TO PETITION THE COURT FOR
FEELING WHEN WE RIGHTFULLY MADE
THAT AUTOMATIC FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
DIVERTED BY PROBATION AND THE
COURTS. IT UNDERMINES THE GREAT
WORK. AND LAW ENFORCEMENT HAVE
DONE KIM GRACEIMPROVED
OUTCOMES FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
ACHIEVED THROUGH QUALITY
COMMUNITY DIVERSION.
ADDITIONALLY BLACK AND BROWN
USED ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE POLICE CALLED ON BEHAVIOR
THAT FOR OTHERS THE COUNSELING
ADDITIONALLY ARGUES ARE MORE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE UP
CHARGING WITH FURIOUS LABELING
CONSEQUENCES. ONE OF OUR
STUDENTS A TWELVE YEAR OLD BOY
WHO IS BLACK WE CHARGED WITH
SEXUAL ASSAULT. TURNED OUT HE
WAS WORKING AT THE SCHOOL DANCE.
WITHOUT FEELING THE LABOR
SEXUAL THOUGHT CONSOLIDATE
CHALLENGES VERY SERIOUS DAMAGE.
PEOPLE ASSUME IF THERE IS NO
CONVICTION THERE IS NO RECORD
TO BE DISCOVERED WE'VE HAD
PEOPLE IN THEIR LATE TWENTIES
AND THIRTIES COME BACK THE
REQUESTED RECORD FROM THEIR
TIME OR DIVERSION PROGRAM WHEN
THEY WERE TWELVE BECAUSE THERE
IMMIGRATION APPLICATION WITH
UNDER INVESTIGATION. THESE DAYS
AS YOU KNOW THE IMPACT OF AN
ARREST SOMEONE IMMIGRATION
STATUS IS DEVASTATING. YOUTH
EVER IN HEAVEN. IMPACT ON
LOWERING CRIME AND IMPROVING
LIFE PROSPECTS FOR YOU BUT THIS
GAP IN THE LEGISLATION
THREATENS THE IMPACT OF THAT
WORK. ARREST RECORDS ARE
HARMFUL AND FOLLOW PEOPLE FOR
DECADES IN LATER
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO OUR GOAL
OF HAVING ALL USED. GIRL WAS
THE CONTRIBUTING CITIZENS. IT'S
A NO BRAINER WE'VE ALREADY
GRANTED THIS PROTECTION NOW WE
JUST NEED TO FIX THIS OVERSIGHT
AND COVER ALL THE USED. TO
COVER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION ON THE- THANK YOU
DARIA. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DARIA THE
READ THE DATE I'M FROM THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
ONE OF THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BATTLE I'M JUST AVAILABLE HERE
FOR AG ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE BUILDING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND NOW WE'RE
HERE. FOR ANY ME TO. MODERATOR
OPEN UP THE LINE FOR THOSE ARE
IN SUPPORT NAME IN AN
ORGANIZATION. LINE. THREE SEVEN
FOUR NINE. HAPPY SURE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THE LINE
LINE. THREE EIGHT THREE FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE PENA ON
BEHALF OF THE PACIFIC GIVEN
I'LL DEFENDER CENTER WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE THREE EIGHT FIVE
GUARD. GOOD AFTERNOON MRS
KENWYN DEAN WITH THE ALLIANCE
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR AT
POLICY LINK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE EIGHT
SEVEN CLASS. GOOD AFTERNOON
DOMINIQUE LOCAL CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA PROUD
COULD SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. LINE THREE NINE TWO
BY. THANK YOU JIM WHEN BURKE ON
BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE LINE
THREE NINE ZERO GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS A MONITORING DíAS OF
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THIS BILL. THREE EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE THREE EIGHT EIGHT. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS THE RETIREMENT
WITH INITIATOR IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE THREE FIVE EIGHT ZERO
BY. JANUARY TERRACE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TERMS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU LINE LINE THREE TWO
ZERO CLIENT. DâN CORRECT ARE
NOT ALL ON BEHALF OF THE TABLE
THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LARA LINE
THREE THREE FIVE BECAUSE I.
GOOD IDEA WHAT CALIFORNIA LINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE. TWO
NINE NINE GLIDE. GOOD AFTERNOON
LADIES HAVE GONE FROM THE RIGHT
THEN ORIGINAL CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NINE THREE SEVEN EIGHT GO AHEAD.
THIS IS MARIA GAS FROM YOU COST
CENTER WE CO SPONSOR THE FELONS
ACCORDED PASSAGE. NINE THREE
SEVEN NINE GO AHEAD. JOINT
CORRECT CHILDREN PLOT THAT ARE
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE THREE EIGHT TWO BY. THREE
EIGHT TWO LINE ON THE PHONE. IN
A MANNER WITH THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
JUNE AND THERE'S NO MORE IN
KILL. THANK YOU. THE MOBILE HOW
DOES THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION.
OPPOSITION CREATED PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW ONE ZERO THOSE ARE
WITNESSES. BUT THERE WERE
PERHAPS LUCIA WILL BE HONEST ON
THE VIDEO SCREEN FIRST AND THEN
LARRY MORSE ON THE PHONE WITH
HIM FOR. THE LEVELS. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH
LIKE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AND CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION OF
RECORDS SUPERVISORS I
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE-
I DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE AND
THANK THE AUTHOR AND DOWN HIS
STAFF AT THE BEEN VERY CORDIAL
AND LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS
AND WE DO ALL THESE THE ONE I
RECKON AS AT AUTHOR FOR ALL HIS
WORK HE IS NOT IN THIS AREA- I
DO WANT TO LIMIT MY COMMENTS
CHIU- DEBT THAT CALIFORNIA LAW
FIRMS IN THE STATION OF RECORD
SUPERVISORS HOWEVER. SINCE THE
ARE EXPLICITLY SHOWN IN THE
BILL AS WORKING WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL I TO COME UP
WITH THE FORMS AND ASK FOR ME
LATE AT PLAN ON HOW TO MEET
THIS MAN EIGHT OUT WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED WITH THAT- ACOSTA
THIS BILL- IF I MAY BORROW YOUR
OWN STATEMENT MISTER CHAIR WE
NEED A IN FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE OFTEN THESE BILLS ARE
A PUSH FOR OR WITH. ANY KIND OF.
AT THE- FOLKS ARE ON THEIR THE
ONES WHO TAKE YOUR WEEK I AM
PROUD ALL YOUR ON FOR THERE'D
ONES FOR CURRENTLY WORKING ON A
SKELETON CREW THEY NEVER
RECOVERED FROM TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT EIGHT RECESSION AND NOW
THEY'RE BEING ASKED TO DO YET
ONE MORE THING WITHOUT ANY KIND
OF FUNDING SO WE REALLY IMPLORE
YOU TO THINK ABOUT THIS MANDATE
AND I WAS GOING TO AFFECT THOSE
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN OUR- AND A
CAMPAIGNER IN A LONG FORCED
AGENCY WERE OUT TO PROCESS ALL
THIS. WORK SPECIAL. TO THE POP
OF DOING. I'LL PEPPERELL. WERE
THESE ARE VERY VERY SENSITIVE
INFORMATION OBVIOUSLY AND NOT
EVERYONE CAN DO IT- SO AGAIN WE
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE- WHEN IF. I
SUSPECT THIS BILL WILL GET OUT
OF COMMITTEE THAT YOU- ATTACH
SOME KIND OF THE FINDINGS SO
THAT THESE COSTS CAN BE
RECOVERED- AS A RIGHT NOW
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. YOU'RE WELCOME THANK
YOU. NO WE HAVE A LARRY MORSE.
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION YOUR- THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LEARN MORE
SOMEBODY HAVE TO CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED CDA HAS NO
OBJECTION TO THE GENERAL INTENT
OF THIS BILL TO PROGRAM THE
RELEASE OF INFORMATION
CONCERNING A MINOR WHO HAS
PARTICIPATED IN- COMPLETED A
DIVERSION PROGRAM. IN FACT WE
ARE. HOWEVER WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT
WOULD APPEAR TO PREVENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
PROSECUTORIAL AGENCIES FROM
EVER DISCLOSING THE SYSTEMS. OF
UNDERLYING INFORMATION
CONTAINED IN THOSE REPORTS
WHICH MAY BE CONSIDERED BRADY
MATERIAL PURSUANT TO THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT CASE BRADY
VERSUS MERRILL. THE BRADY CASE
AS YOU WELL KNOW IMPOSES A DUTY
UPON LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND
PROSECUTORIAL AGENCIES TO
DISCLOSE INFORMATION WHICH THEY
PUT OUT THAT SHOWS A PERSON
BEHAVES IN WAYS WHICH MAY
REFLECT UPON HIS OR HER.
CREDIBILITY IF THEY BECOME
WITNESSES AND A LITTLE
PROSECUTION. THE DUTIES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND PROP
HEATERS UNDER BRADY.
CONSTITUTIONALLY IMPOSED AND
CANNOT BE ABROGATED BY STATE.
WE BEAT SURPRISED TO HEAR
ATTORNEY ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING THE DEFENSE FARMS
SUPPORT THE BILL AS DRAFTED
GIVEN THE IMPEDIMENT IT WOULD
CREATE TO D. A.'S IN COMPLYING
WITH THEIR BRADY OBLIGATIONS.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES
THE BRADY CONCERNED PRESENTED
IN THIS BILL AND WE ARE HOPING
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
WOULD CONSIDER AN AMENDMENT. IN
ORDER TO MEET OUR OLD BRADY
OBLIGATIONS WITHOUT SUCH AN
AMENDMENT WE HAVE NO CHOICE BUT
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL IN ORDER TO
PROTECT A CRIMINAL DEFENDANT'S
RIGHT TO A FAIR TRIAL. AND TO
SHIELD CALIFORNIA PROSECUTORS
FROM LEGAL AND ETHICAL
CONSEQUENCES THAT WOULD FLOW
FROM FAILING TO PROVIDE BRADY
MATERIAL IN A CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION. WE HOPE THIS
AMENDMENT IS ADOPTED SO WE MAY
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION UNTIL
THAT PLAY TAKES PLACE HOWEVER
WE MUST ASK FOR A NOTEBOOK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER IN OPPOSITION MISTER
MODERATOR OPEN UP THE LINE FOR
A- NAME AN ORGANIZATION. NINE
THREE NINE THREE CLASS PLACE.
I'M SORRY I WAS NOT IN
OPPOSITION OUT THERE WAS FROM
THE PEOPLE IN THE MODEL COULD
NOT OPEN PRODUCT MANAGER THE
PUBLIC THE BALL FROM THE LIKE
THE BELL THAT'S THE THAT. YOUNG
OF AN BACK. WE'VE RANGERS
BELIEVE WHEN. THAT THE FALL AB
THE MORE YOU SO THAT YEAH YOU
SIR. FOR RICK LOOK. SB THANK
YOU BUT THE LINE THREE FIVE
GOING. HI THERE MY GAS WHICH
YOU FOR I COULDN'T MAKE THE
LINE BUT WE ARE SUPPORT OF TWO
FOUR TO FIVE THANK YOU. AND
NOTHING LIKE YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
FOR COMMENTS OR. QUESTION JUST
A QUICK ONE. I JUST WANT TO FOR
UP ON A THREE THAT WERE MADE
WITH WITH TO THE BRADY VERSUS
MARYLAND CONCERNS BY THE DA'S
OFFICE DO YOU HAVE ANY THEN
YOU'D LIKE THAT YEAH ABSOLUTELY
IT IN A LOT OF FEELING STUFF
THAT WE'VE DONE DEALS WITH
BRADY MATERIALS WERE WERE HAPPY
TO TALK ABOUT BRADY MATERIAL
WHAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THOUGH IS THAT. IF WE'RE
PUTTING IN. LANGUAGE AROUND
ALLOWING BRADY MATERIALTHAT
IT'S NOT SO BROAD THAT IT
UNDERMINES. THE INTENT OF WHAT
THE- SO YEAH WERE. FORCES BEING
DRAMATIC WERE WORKING WITH HIM
AND TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
THAT WE DO IT IN A WAY THAT IS
PRODUCTIVE DOESN'T UNDERMINE
THIS BUT DEALS WITH THE SUPREME
COURT CASE ABSOLUTELY. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU. YOU
MAY CLOSE I THANK YOU I. ASK
YOUR EYE BUT IT'S INTERESTING
THAT SOME OPPOSITE BROUGHT UP
THE ISSUE OF COST WHEN
ULTIMATELY WHEN WE DO AUTOMATIC
CEILING LIKE THIS IT'S LESS
EXPENSIVE BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
INVOLVE A- HAVING TO GO TO
COURT TO GET A- BIRD SEALED.
AND WE'RE CERTAINLY WILL FUTURE
COUNCIL AND OTHERS ON THAT THE
TIMING AND THE COST AND ALL OF
GETTING THIS DONE SO THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY A MINOR ISSUE AND
I FRANKLY HAVE. BEFORE THE KIDS
TAX THAT. THE WHO ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO GET ANOTHER FORM I
THINK OUR SYSTEM CAN HANDLE.
ANOTHER FORM AND AS RESPECT.
ABOUT JAKE AND I KNOW I WILL-
PROBABLY. FOLLOW UP WITH YOU.
ON THE BUT JUST BECAUSE WE DO
DO IT TO MAKE SURE. THAT IT CAN
BE DONE IN THAT IT UP FULL
ABSOLUTELY. I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT AND THEN THE LAWYER THING
YOU'RE IN. DELEGATES CAN WILL
SORT THAT OUT THE X. I HAVE ONE
LAWYER YELLING CONSTITUTIONAL
SOME. YEARS I GOT ANOTHER
LAWYER HERE THEN I GOT YOU SO.
WHEN YOU BETWEEN THREE LAWYERS
YOU JUST. PUT THEM IN A CORNER
AND LET HIM FIGHT IT OUT AND
SO- I THINK. YOU IN. YOU AND-
LARRY MORSE WILL BE FULLY
CAPABLE OF BEING ABLE TO.
FIGURE THIS OUT. TOGETHER I
THINK SO YES. OKAY THE- CHAIRS
BREAK ME AYE VOTE. AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE BY MR STONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JOHN SO YOU'RE AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY NOW BARRICADE
HAN BARRICADE HAND I DEEP DEEP
NOW KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I CAN BE
A HEAVY OUT I SANTIAGO. SIX THE
VOTE IS FOR TO THAT MEASURES ON
CALL IT NEEDS ONE. THANK YOU
AT. NOW WEHAVE A AB TWENTY
FIVE TWELVE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ALMOST TWENTY
YEARS AGO THE US SUPREME COURT
HELD THAT IT IS CRUEL AND
UNUSUAL PUNISHMENT TO EXECUTE A
PERSON. WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES SINCE SEVEN STATES
ATTACHED WITH THE TOP TWO SPOTS
REALLY DETERMINE. WHO IS
ACTUALLY DISABLED FOR THE
PURPOSES OF HOLDING THE
CONSTITUTION THE CARD THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE ACTED.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND AND THREE
TO DO JUST THAT BUT OVER
SEVENTEEN YEARS THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY HAS MADE VAST
ADVANCES IN THE STUDY OF
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES AND
THE SCIENCE OF BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT. THIS BILL DOES IS
BRING FORWARD. THAT SCIENCE
INTO THIS DISCUSSION OF WHO HAS
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES.
DISABILITIES CURRENTLY OF THIS.
THERE ARE PARKS WE SEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY PEOPLE WAITING
ON DEATH ROW MANY OF WHOM MAY
BE INTELLECTUALLY BOTH
ACCORDING THE CITY'S CLINICAL
STANDARDS AND THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE- AND IGNORE.
SO BUILT UP IT REQUIRES. THE
CALIFORNIA THE PROGRESS AND USE
THE STANDARD IN THE DIAGNOSTIC
AND STATISTICAL MANUAL OF
MENTAL DISORDERS DSM I'VE WHICH
IS THE CURRENT STANDARD THIS
BRINGS IT UP THAT STANDARD AND
IN ADDITION THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS THAT AB
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE. WITH
PROSECUTE. FOR A PERSON OTHER
IQ SCORE LOW. FOR A THEIR I. Q.
SCORE ADJUSTED UPWARDS BECAUSE
OF THEIR RACE OR SOCIOECONOMIC
STATUS WE KNOW THAT IQ TESTS
ARE BIASED AGAINST BLACK AND
LATINO PEOPLE. AND THAT THEY I
WOULD AND THAT MAKES THEM WELL
FOR EXECUTION WITH A- AND A
SCORE THAT IS REALLY IN THE
INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED
CATEGORY BUT BECAUSE OF THAT
ARGUMENT YOU GET REYES AND THEN
THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE THIS IS
BLATANT RACES. THAT DEVELOPED.
THE IT GENERAL IS NOT USING
THAT STANDARD ANYMORE THERE ARE
SOME PROSECUTORS IN SOME
COUNTIES THAT STILL ARE THIS
WOULD. MAKE THIS CONSISTENT
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND PROHIBIT ITS USE THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL MOVING FORWARD I
KNOW THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
MORATORIUM OUR GOVERNOR TO THE
VERY STANCE MORE TORRENT AT THE
DEATH PENALTY BUT HOWEVER WE
STILL HAVE A DEATH ROW. THERE
ARE MANY ON DEATH ROW. NOT BE
DESERVE NOT TO BE THERE BECAUSE
OF THE THEIR INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES. AND IT IS
UNCONSCIONABLE FOR CALIFORNIA
TO LEAVE THEM THERE THIS BILL
CLEAN SET UP AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTES. I HAVE A
COUPLE OF WITNESSES. TO SHOP
ATTORNEY AND LEGAL DIRECTOR OF
THE HABEAS CORPUS RESOURCE
THAT. AS A WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
AND I ASKED THE RIGHT. THANK
YOU MISTER MODERATOR COULD YOU
BRING ME SHOT ON. BY THE LINE
IS OPEN ON YOUR YOUR PHONE
PLACE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS NATION'S JOHN I'M AN
ATTORNEY AND LEGAL DIRECTOR AT
THE HABEAS CORPUS RESOURCE
CENTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
STAFF ASKED ME TO ADDRESS HOW
AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE IF
ENACTED WILL BRING CALIFORNIA'S
INTELLECTUAL. ABILITY TO. IN
COMPLIANCE- WITH UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT LAW. IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE ARE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB THREE ADDING SECTION
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX TO THE
PENAL CODE AND CODIFYING ATKINS
VERSUS VIRGINIA. SINCE THEN THE
US SUPREME COURT HAS REPEATEDLY
CLARIFIED AND EXPANDED UPON
THEIR HOLDING AN ATKINS
STRESSING OVER AND OVER THAT
STATES MUST LOOK TO THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY TO DEFINE
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY. IT'LL
CODE SECTION THIRTEEN SEVENTY
pSIX IN CONTRAST HAS BEEN
UPDATED ONLY ONE. CHANGE THE
TERM MENTALLY RETARDED TO
INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED. AB
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE BRINGS THE
STATUTE IN LINE WITH US SUPREME
COURT CASE LAW AND CURRENT
CLINICAL STANDARDS AND IT
ADDRESSES ISSUES THAT THE
COURTS AND LITIGANTS HAVE
ENCOUNTERED AND I CAN HEARINGS
OVER THE PAST EIGHTEEN YEARS.
EVERY CHANGE TO SECTION
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX PROPOSED
HERE IS ALIGNED WITH THE
AMERICAN PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION DSM FIVE AND THE
PUBLICATIONS OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION ON INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
FIRST AS A SCIENTIFIC MATTER
BEYOND THE EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY
THE DSM FIVE HAS DROPPED. OUT
UP OR INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY
AND FIND A COLLECTION. EIGHT
AND IT STILL DOESN'T WORK WELL
THANKS IN CONTRAST UPDATED ONLY
ONE. IN A- THE TARGET WILL
ACTUALLY GET PAID ALL EIGHTY
FIVE ALL THREE THANK YOU LINE
WITH YOU YOUR GREEN COURT CASE
IN CURRENT. HELLO DO WE GET OUT
IN LOS NO THOSE THE SAME YEAH I.
HELLO I AM ONE OF THE WITNESSES
FOR DAY HOST THE EXPERT WITNESS
FOR THE OPPOSITION. SORRY I
NEED TO I THINK I'M- GETTING AN
ECHO SO I WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF
MY TESTIMONY SO I THINK IS
ANGELA BACKERS FROM CD A WORK
DAY WITNESS FOR IS FINISHING UP
COULD SO COULD YOU WAIT JUST A-
FEW MORE MINUTES. IF YOU'RE NOT
SPEAK PRESENTE PUT YOUR PHONE
ON MUTE PLEASE. PUT YOUR PHONE
ON MUTE. YOU'RE NOT SPEAKING.
THE CARD. AT OKAY. MAKING YEAH.
IF YOU PLEASE CONTINUE TO SHOP.
I THINK WE'RE A LAPTOP WITH
DISCUSSING THAT THE DSM FIVE
DROP DISTRICT EIGHT AGE CUTOFF
FOR INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY AND
IT STILL DOES SO AS WELL SECOND
CLINICAL STANDARDS REQUIRE
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO
RELY ON A THROUGH SOCIAL
HISTORY RELEVANT RECORDS AND
DOCUMENTS AND MORE INTERVIEWS
IN AFFECTING INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY AB TWENTY FIVE
TWELVE BRING CALIFORNIA LAW
INTO ACCORD WITH US SUPREME
COURT PRECEDENT BY ALLOWING GET
TO HEAR AND CONSIDER ALL THE
EVIDENCE ADEQUATELY RELEVANT
ITEM BY MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. AS EXPLAINED THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THE BILL OF.
ON SECOND BECAUSE FOR MEDICAL
DIAGNOSES AND HABEAS PROCEEDING.
THIRD AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE
ADDRESSES A LACK OF ACCESS TO
EXPERT WITNESSES IN SOME CASES.
SOME CASES HAVE PROCEEDED
THROUGH A FIRST ROUND OF THINK
THEY POST CONVICTION WITH
REVIEW WITHOUT FUNDING FOR AN
ACTION DIRECTOR. WHEN THESE
CASES BLOOM BONTA FEDERAL COURT
AND A PAIN FUNDING FOR AN
EXPERT THERE THEY THEN RETURNED
TO STATE COURT FOUR YEARS OF
ADDITIONAL LITIGATION. BY
CREATING AN ALTERNATE WAY TO
MAKE A PAYMENT AFTER SHOWING
BILL WILL HELP CALIFORNIA COURT
BETTER IDENTIFY THOSE FACING
EXECUTION WHO MAY BE
INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED. THERE
IS NO DISADVANTAGE TO THE STATE
HERE THE SENATE OR PETITIONER
STILL HAS THE BURDEN OF PROOF
BUT A HEARING. AND THE FACT
FINDERS DECISION ABOUT WHETHER
A PERSON IS INTELLECTUALLY
DISABLED. ALWAYS BE BASED ON
THE EVIDENCE THE PARTIES
PRESENT AT THE HEARING. FINALLY
TO WORK IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS TO KNOW THAT RACISM
IN FACT THAT. WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
ACTION DOES THAT RATE PLAGUE
THOSE HEARINGS AS WELL. HE ATE
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE
ARGUED IN ASPEN THAT PEOPLE OF
COLOR FOR THOSE WHO GROW UP
WITH LOW SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS.
A CIRCUMSTANCE
DISPROPORTIONATELY EXPERIENCE
IN THE COUNTRY BY PEOPLE OF
COLOR SHOULD HAVE THEIR IQ
SCORES ADJUSTED UPWARD BECAUSE
THE TAP WHAT MADE FOR THEM. IT
HAD NO GROUNDING IN AND IS IN
FACT CONTRARY TO THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY STANDARDS FOR
EVALUATING INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY. ARTIFICIALLY
INFLATING A PERSON OF COLOR
THANK YOU SO THAT WE CAN
EXECUTE THEM IS ANTITHETICAL TO
THE STATE'S IDEALS AND TO THE
CONSTITUTION. INTELLECTUALLY
DISABLED PEOPLE IN THE
AGGREGATE DATA SPECIAL RISK OF
WRONGFUL EXECUTIONS AB TWENTY
FIVE TWELVE WILL BRING
CALIFORNIA LAW INTO ALIGNMENT
WITH US SUPREME COURT PRECEDENT
AND ENSURE THAT THE STATE
IDENTIFIES AND PREVENTS THE
EXECUTION OF INTELLECTUALLY
DISABLED ADULTS. AT THE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOW WOULDN'T
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. NAME IN
ORGANIZATION. LINE. THREE NINE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF POSTAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE LINE
TWO NINE ONE BECAUSE I.
QUESTION ANSWER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ANTI DEFINITELY
COALITION THE EIGHTH AMENDMENT
PROJECT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA EQUAL JUSTICEUSA
THE ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA
ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE TWO EIGHT ONE GUY.
CALIFORNIANS YOUR SAFETY AND
GET THAT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE THREE EIGHT ONE CORRECT.
IT DOESN'T NOT YOUR WORK SO ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU. LINE. THREE FOUR SIX.
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE MORE
EQ YOU MAY CONTINUE. NOW NOW
OPPOSITION I HAVE AGILE BACKERS
SODOMY A WITNESS ON THE PART OF.
MODERATOR YOU MAY BEGIN.
PRESIDENTIAL CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES SORRY FOR THE CONFUSION.
ALL RIGHT THIS IS ANGELA
BACKERS I'M A CO CHAIR OF THE
CAPITALIZATION COMMITTEE FOR
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION I HAVE BEEN A
PROSECUTOR FOR THIRTY SIX YEARS
RECENTLY RETIRED. AND I- AND
THE CHAIR OR CO CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE. THAT SETS ON THE
CAPITAL ALLOCATION- ISSUES IN
THE STATE AND YOU WERE JUST
COLDS AND THINGS THAT WERE NOT
TRUE. AND WE- ARE ASKING FOR
YOUR DIRECT OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS
YOUR GOVERNMENT WE ARE GOVERNED
BY THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT IN ATKINS VERSUS VIRGINIA.
IT IS A TWO THOUSAND TWO UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT CASE. OF
FIVE THIRTY SIX U. S. THREE OH
FOUR THAT IS THE LAW OF THE
LAND AND IT IS- INAPPROPRIATE
FOR CALIFORNIA TO TRY TO
OVERTURN. THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT THAT GIVES EVERY
BENEFIT TO THE CAPITAL
DEFENDANT WHO IS CLAIMING AN
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY. I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU TO YOU TODAY I HAVE A
FEW THINGS I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
TO YOU. AS A WITNESS ON THIS
CASE- THE- REQUIREMENT IN COURT
TO PROVE AN INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY IS THAT YOU HAVE AND
IT SHOULD BE THAT SHOULD BE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT YOU HAVE AN
EXPERT PSYCHOLOGIST WHO IS. AN
EXPERT IN THE AREA OF
ASSESSMENT TESTING AND ADAPTIVE
FUNCTIONING THERE IS NO WHERE
THAT THAT IS MENTIONED IN THIS-
PROPOSED BILL. IT IS ALSO-
VAGUE UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND
UNDER JEFF TO MURDER VICTIMS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. BECAUSE NOW
WERE THEY WANT TO HAVE THIS
BILL THAT SAYS- WELL YOU KNOW
WHAT. EVEN THOUGH THE AND
HIGHER PSYCHOLOGICAL COMMUNITY
BELIEVES THAT IF YOU HAVE AN
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY IT IS
CLEAR AND UNAMBIGUOUS AND
MANIFESTS ITSELF BEFORE THE AGE
OF EIGHTEEN. NOW THE BILL WANTS
TO HAVE A VAGUE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND UNDER A-
DEFINITION OR LACK OF
DEFINITION I SHOULD SAY VAGUE
BUT SAID. WELL WE'RE GONNA SAY
IT MAYBE TO MANIFEST ITSELF
BEFORE THE END OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL FAN. PERIOD THE
DEVELOPMENTAL PERIOD IS NOT
DEFINE SO YOU COULD HAVE A
HIRED GUN SOMEONE IS PAID TO
SAY THAT THIS PERSON IS
INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED WE'LL
TALK ABOUT. AT WHAT STAGE OF
THE PROCEEDINGS IN A MINUTE.
BUT THAT A HIRED EXPERT COMES
INTO FOR THE DEFENSE AND SAYS
WELL DURING HIS DEVELOPMENTAL
PERIOD AT AGE TWENTY NINE. IT
APPEARS TO ME THAT HE IS
INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED WHEN
THAT IS CONTRARY TO ALL. I
LOGICAL READ. SANDERS ARE YOU
HAVE THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT GUY THE- YOU HAVE THE
CLINICAL CYCLE A- TESTING AND
ADAPTIVE FUNCTIONING THAT GUIDE
THE- AND NOW YOU HAVE THIS
PROPOSED BILL THAT SAYS THE
FOLLOWING. IT NO LONGER
REQUIRES A SPECIFIC DEFINITION
OF INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY IT
CAN BE WHATEVER YOU'RE PAID
THAT. IT NO LONGER REQUIRES A
DEVELOPMENTAL PERIOD IT'S NOT
EVEN DEFINE IT JUST SAYS AT ANY
TIME BEFORE THE END OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL PERIOD WHEN THEY-
THE VAST MAJORITY OF RESPECTED
PSYCHOLOGISTS. SAY THAT WE ALL
KNOW IF SOMEBODY'S
INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED BEFORE
THEY TURN EIGHTEEN BUTTHIS NEW
LANGUAGE THAT IN HERE COULD YOU
COULD COME IN AND SAY WHAT WHEN
HE TURNED THIRTY I NOTICED
THERE WASN'T SOMETHING QUITE
RIGHT. SO IT'S COMPLETELY UNDER
FINE. AND THEN IT'S- JEFF
BECAUSE IT JUST REQUIRES A
SINGLE CONNECTION TO COME IN
AND DAY WELL I NOTICED FOR THE
VERY FIRST TIME IN HIS TWENTIES
OR THIRTIES. THAT THERE MIGHT
HAVE BEEN SOMETHING THAT WASN'T
QUITE RIGHT. THAT IS NOT
CONSISTENT WITH THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT AND IT'S
NOT CONSISTENT WITH THE- WELL
RESPECTED CLINICAL- LAW
CLINICAL I SHOULD AY. THE
TESTING THAT IS DONE AND THIS-
STATE A VERY WELL RESPECTED
TESTING. AND THEN THEY- THING
THAT WAS JUST BROUGHT UP IN
ABOUT A THAT WAS COMMENTED
ABOUT HABEAS IS OUTRAGEOUS
BECAUSE YOU'RE DEPRIVE THE
VICTIMS. AND THE VICTIMS'
FAMILY AND THEIR LOVED ONES
FROM BEING PART OF ANY
PROCEEDING. SO WHAT THEY'RE
BUILT WHAT THE SENATE THE VERY
END. THAT NOT IN PRE TRIAL
PROCEEDING NOT DURING THE
PRELIMINARY HEARING NOT DURING
THE JURY TRIAL NOT DURING THE
SENTENCING HEARING BUT TWENTY
YEARS LATER I'M GONNA BRING
SOMEONE AND DURING THE STATE
HABEAS. FOR A FEDERAL HABEAS
AND ALL THE SUDDEN FOR THE VERY
FIRST TIME I AM GOING TO SAY OH
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS PERSON'S
INTELLECTUALLY DISPLAY DISABLED
AND I. PAID A GUY TO COME IN
AND SET IT TO A LATER IT. IT
WOULD THE VICTIM. AND BRING IT
UP TO THE VERY FIRST TIME IN A
HABEAS PROCEEDING AFTER THERE'S
BEEN A CONVICTION BY A JURY
TRIAL SO WE ARE ASKING YOU FOR
ALL OF THESE REASONS TO
STRENUOUSLY OPPOSE WELL. Q. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESS IS AN
OPPOSITION NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. NO ONE IS THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT NOW. ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. DECEMBER MR LACKEY HAS
A QUESTION. YEAH I REALLY HAVE
TROUBLE WITH THE AMBIGUITY
PIECE ON THE DEFINITION I THINK
IT'S FAIR NO ONE WANTS TO. HOLD
SOMEBODY ACCOUNT HAS A TRUE
ELECTION DISABILITY. BUT I'M
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT HOW MUCH
COULD BE INTERPRETED BY THE
COURTS ARE NO WE JUST HEARD A-
VERY- POWERFUL. DESCRIPTION OF
OPPOSITION. WHEN SHE PRESENTED
ATKINS VERSUS VIRGINIA I DON'T
NOT FAMILIAR WITH WHAT THOSE
PER CAR. BUT THE CLEARLY THERE
SEEMS TO BE. THE MEMBER UNION
WHAT WHAT THIS MEANS ACT AND AN
OFFER GOES TO BE TO BROUGHT I
THINK WE DEFEAT WHAT THE
ATTENTION AS INTENTIONAL- HAS A
REAL. DISABILITY A RECORD USING
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND RIGHT FROM
TIMES OF AND I THINK THAT NOT.
TO SEE ANYWHERE. PUT TO THAT
HAS A THAT DIFFICULTY MAKING
THOSE DETERMINATIONS. HOWEVER
THERE'S IF THE IF IT GOES
BEYOND ITS INTENTION THEN IT
BECOMES A DISSERVICE AND
BECOMES QUESTIONABLE AS FAR AS
IT ARRIVING AT JUSTICES SO I'D
LIKE TO HEAR WHAT ADDRESS
ABSOLUTELY CERTAINTY ON THAT
ISSUE YEAH IT'S A IT'S A LITTLE
ASTONISHING TO HEAR THAT
TESTIMONY BECAUSE THIS IS NOT A
DOING ATKINS THIS IS BASED ON
ATKINS AMERICANS DECISION. AND
WHAT THE SUPREME COURT HAS SAID
IS THAT THE STATE'S NEED TO
KEEP UP WITH THE DEBT THAT SORT
OF DEFINITION THAT CLINICAL
CLINICAL DEFINITION OF
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE DOING SO WE
RELY ON THE CALIFORNIA STATUTE
SAID BEEN EXISTENCE FOR DECADES.
CLINICAL STANDARDS HAVE CHANGED
THAT'S WHY WORKING THIS TO THE
CURRENT STANDARD WHICH IS THE
DSM FIVE. SO THAT'S ACTUALLY
VERY CLEAR NOW THE
DEVELOPMENTAL PERIOD. IS UP TO
AGE TWENTY FIVE IT'S THIS
COMMITTEE HAS SEEN AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN WE TALK ABOUT.
THE ABOUT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
DOESN'T ADDED EIGHTEEN THAT'S
COOL THINKING AND THAT'S SPENT
OUTMODED FOR YEARS SO WE'RE
BRINGING IN LINE. THIS WHOLE
LINE OF THINKING IN THIS WHOLE
POLICY TO WORK CURRENT. MENTAL
HEALTH STANDARDS ARE AND THE
CURRENT DIAGNOSTIC AND CLINICAL
MANUAL THAT'S WHAT IT S IT'S
NOT A BIG YOU ITS NOT UNCLEAR.
WE'RE PUTTING CLARITY HERE
BECAUSE WE'RE USING THE SAME
STANDARDS THAT WE USE IN THE
DIVERSION STATUE FOR EXAMPLE OF
WHEN WE'RE DECIDING WORK WHEN
IT WHEN IT SOMEBODY IS. IT WILL
BE DIVERTED AS A AS A JUVENILE.
UP TO TWENTY FIVE IF IT'S CLEAR
THAN WITH SOMEBODY THAT HAS
AUTISM FALL UNDER THIS
DECLARATION. EIGHT YOU GET HAVE
TO GO TO THE MANUAL I'M NOT A
CLINICIAN. SO THE DSM FIVE THE
CURRENT MANUAL FOR WHAT TO FIND
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY.
CURRENT STATUTE RELIES ON THAT
pIS BRINGING UP TO CURRENT
STANDARDS THE CURRENT CLINICAL
AND DIAGNOSTIC MANUAL. THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS DOING AND THAT AND
THAT'S WHAT I MEAN THAT
TESTIMONY WAS EMOTIONAL.
MATTERS MONEY CLEARLY DON'T
LIKE THIS BILL BUT THAT'S
REALLY NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
THIS BILL IS. WE BEGIN THIS
PROCESS STRONGER AND BETTER AND
BRINGING CALIFORNIA. TO USING
CURRENT. MEDICAL SCIENCE. IN
THE AREAS OF INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES SO IT IT'S NOT
MAKING IT IT'S NOT BIG. IT'S
NOT MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT
IT'S ACTUALLY PROVIDING A LOT
OF CLARITY BASED ON CURRENT
SITES THAT'S WHAT THAT'S ALL
THIS BILL DOES IS IT TAKES THIS
THAT STANDARD. HELLO FROM THE
QUILL STANDARD AND BRINGS IT UP
TO CURRENT CLINICAL STANDARDS.
THAT'S WHAT GOT. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COM YOU MAY
CLOSE. A THIRD OF ASPIRO. BUT
IT IT IT. OBVIOUSLY THE
WITNESSES ARE BOTH SIDES ARE
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS AND
I HOPE. FOR THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF IT THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE DO A
BILL. IT GOES TO OUR- JUDICIAL
COUNCIL WOULD NEXT WANTED
THINGS THAT THEY LOOK FOR. AS
FAR AS APPROVING ARE SITTING
THROUGH A BILL SO. WE DO HAVE
SOME LAWYERS ACTUALLY LOOKING
AT THAT NIGHT AND I THINK. ALL
OF THAT WAS TAKEN IN
CONSIDERATION BEFORE WE EVEN
GOT YEAH YEAH WE'RE WE'RE NOT
CHANGING THE UNDERLYING CAUSES
THEATER I'M JUST. YEAH OKAY
THANK YOU DON'T TALK PASSED YES
OKAY SO- I KNOW YOU'RE NOT
CHANGD I NOW THE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION IS SAYING YOU YOU
ARE I'M JUST SAYING IS A THIRD
PARTY INDEPENDENT GROUP THAT
LOOKS AT THIS DID NOT FIND THAT
IS WHAT WOULD HAVE SEC CORRECT.
AND THEY'RE THERE TO MAKE SURE
WE DON'T MAKE THOSE MISTAKES.
WE DON'T- TRAMPLE OVER THE
CONSTITUTION THEY'RE THEY'RE
JUST WITH THE THEREFORE. AND
SO- THE INTELLECTUAL STANDARDS
OF FROM WHEN WE WERE YOUNG AND
GOING TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS
OBVIOUSLY IT'S CHANGED QUITE A
BIT TO NOW. AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OF THEIR A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT FELL THROUGH THE
CRACKS. THAT MADE IT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH SOME
DISABILITIES BUT THEY WORK FOR
WHATEVER REASON. FUNDING AND
OTHER THINGS AND SO- WORKER ALL
OF TO DO THAT AND SO BRINGING
THESE THINGS UP TO PRESENT DAY
STANDARDS- I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IT'S BEST. TO TAKE.
YOU GO AHEAD AND IN SOMEONE'S
LIFE. WE SHOULD. WE SHOULD BE
VERY CERTAIN. THAT WE'RE DOING
THE RIGHT. AND SO THAT THE
CHURCH RECOMMENDING AND I GO.
AND I'LL BE TWENTY FIVE TWELVE
BY MR STONE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS JONES SAWYER ON JOAN SO
YOU'RE AYE LACKEY NOT VOTING
LACKEY NOT VOTING BARRICADE
HAN. MERRICK HE HAD HI DEEP.
DEEP NO KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I CAN
DO. HAVE YOUR AYE SANTIAGO.
WICKS THE VOTE IS FOR ONE THAT
MEASURE NEEDS ONE IT'S ON A
CALL. THEY CAN. AND THEN FOR
OUR LAST PRESENTATION MR
MCCARTY AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
THREE FORTY TWO PAROLE. I HAVE
A LONG PRESENTATION BUT I'M
GONNA I'M GONNA BE QUICK THIS
MERGES TWO BILLS EVERT BEFORE
LAST COUPLE YEARS ONE ON
REINTEGRATION CREDITS THAT I
AUTHORED ONE THAT IS THE ONLY
WOMAN CARILLO AUTHORED ON
EXPAND ELIGIBILITY FOR PAROLE
THE- SUPERVISION IN THE
COMMUNITY POST RELEASE
SUPERVISION AND- CERTAINLY ASK
THAT YOU CONSIDER IT SUPPORTING
THESE BILLS ONCE AGAIN THERE IS
OPPOSITION WE'RE WORKING WITH
THEM TRYING TO FIND. A SOLUTION
WORKING A CCP AWAY AND THE
PAROLE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION I
WOULD THINK THIS IS A SMART
REFORM THOUGHT ABOUT RELEASING
INDIVIDUALS BACK THE COMMUNES
ABOUT INSURING THEIR SUCCESS
THIS FOCUSES ON IMPROVING. BEST
PRACTICE IS TO- FOCUS ON
SUCCESS NOT A PUNISHMENT AND-
WITH THAT ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THIS AFTERNOON. THANK YOU AND
YOU HAVE TO IT THIS IS TODD
HOFFMAN SENIOR PUBLIC SAFETY
CONSULTANT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FOR JUST SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND
NIKKI MARTINUS SISTER WARRIORS
FREEDOM COALITION. BOTH ARE ON
THE PHONE. AND MISTER MODERATOR
ALL HAVE THEM CALL IT. ALRIGHT
I HAVE MAKING WORKING IS HERE.
RIGHT YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NIKKI
MARTINEZ AND I'M AN ACTIVIST
WITH HISTORIANS FREEDOM
COALITION BASED CAMPAIGN GAVE
ON MARCH FOURTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN I
RETURNED HOME AFTER SERVING
TWENTY FIVE YEARS THE
CALIFORNIA PRISON SYSTEM. I
CAME BACK TO MY FAMILY AND
FRIENDS COMPLETELY DEDICATED TO
GIVING BACK AND GETTING
INVOLVED WITH MY COMMUNITY AND
BEING A ROLE MODEL DURING MY
INCARCERATION I SPEND A LOT OF
TIME AND SEAT BELT IN DEEP DEEP
REFLECTION WHICH TO ME
RECEIVING MY ASSOCIATES DEGREE
COMPLETING AND FACILITATING
NUMEROUS SELF HELP COURSES AND
TO BE ABLE TO RUN TO PRESENT
PROGRAMS. IF CHANGES IN
ACHIEVEMENT LATE THE FOUNDATION
FOR ME TO GO BEFORE THE
CALIFORNIA PAROLE BOARD TO
BOULDER OPAL DISCUSSED HOW IT
WOULD NO LONGER THE PERSON I
WAS. TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO A
CHANGE WHICH WAS SEEN BY BOTH
THE BOARD AND THE GOVERNOR WHO
GRANTED ME SUITABILITY TO COME
HOME. TODAY I WORK WITH THREE
ORGANIZATIONS ALL OF WHICH I AM
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT. ONE AS A
MENTOR FOR THE YOUTH IN THE
JUVENILE HALL WITH THE
RESILIENCE PROGRAM AT SAN
DIEGO. THE SECOND AT THE SAN
DIEGO CHAPTER LEADER FOR THE
SISTER WERE YOUR FREEDOM
COALITION. AND THE THIRD AT THE
TEACHING ARTIST AT THE OLD
GLOBE THEATRE A POSITION THAT
IS CLOSE TO MY HEART AS IT IS A
WAY OF ME MAKE YOU DIE RECHTE
DEMANDS AND HONORING THE
VICTIMS OF MY CRIME. I AM
CURRENTLY A LIFETIME ALL IN MY
FIRST YEAR AT BASS NEEDLEWORK
SO BLOCKS THAT HAVE MY READING.
CHALLENGE THE BIGGEST ONE IS
HOW THE SIX PLACES RESTRICTIONS
AND LIMITATIONS FOR PEOPLE ON A
ROLE IN A UNIFORM WAY THAT DOES
NOT ALLOW FOR MUCH FLEXIBILITY.
FOR EXAMPLE THE TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS THAT LIMIT HOW FAR
I CAN MOVE ABOUT MY COUNTY
MAKES IT HARD. TO PARTICIPATE
FULLY IN WORKING EVENTS AND TO
SEE MY FAMILY WE STILL HAVE TO
TRAVEL TO VISIT ME AS. IF I WAS
STILL INCARCERATED. WHILE I.
THE OF THE WORLD'S AS WHO COME
WITH THE- PLANTS ON HOW I WANT
TO LIVE. IT CAN BE VERY DE
MOTIVATING WHEN I INDICATED BY
A SYSTEM THAT SHOULD BE HELPING
ME TO SUCCEED. IN ADDITION TO
MY JOB I AM CURRENTLY A STUDENT
AT THE SAN DIEGO CITY COLLEGE.
WHERE I'M WRAPPING UP A FEW
UNIT SO THAT I CAN TRANSFER TO
A COLLEGE WHERE I HOPE TO. BE
EIGHT IN SOCIAL IN JUVENILE
JUSTICE. AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
TWO WILL HELP MAKE MY EDUCATION
MORE MEANINGFUL AS ONE OF THE
PROVISIONS CREATE A PROGRAM FOR
PAROLE THESE CAN ACTUALLY EARN
CREDITS TO REDUCE THEIR PERIOD
A POOL BY SUCCESSFULLY.
COMPLETING EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS. I WILL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE MY EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY
WHILE ALSO WORKING TOWARD THE
SHORTER PELO PERIOD. CASTING AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO WILL SET
OUT ON A PATH. TO NOT ONLY GIVE
BACK TO MY COMMUNITY AND
ACTUALLY BUT CHEST SIX ACTUALLY
RE INTEGRATE BACK INTO SOCIETY.
IT WOULDHELP WITH PRACTICAL
SITUATIONS LIKE BEING ABLE TO
JUST RENTS AN APARTMENT AND
BEING ABLE TO TRAVEL FREELY FOR
WORK SO I CAN FULLY PARTICIPATE
WITHOUT HAVING TO WONDER. IF
I'LL BE ABLE TO ATTEND TO
WORKING EVENT A TRAINING A
MEETING BECAUSE IT'S OUTSIDE OF
MY TRAVEL RADIUS. I FEEL AS
THOUGH I AM PROHIBITED FROM
BEING THE BEST VERSION OF
MYSELF. BECAUSE ALTHOUGH I'VE
DONE MUCH INTERNAL SELF
REFLECTION IN WORK. I'M STILL
RESTRICTED BY THE LIMITATIONS
PLACED ON THE PART BY TWO ALL.
I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE CALL YES
IN. ARE THE- ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. YES THIS
IS TOM BOTTOM. YOU MAY BEGIN
YOUR MAKE YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU THE
APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING THE TIME
DATE THE SO WHAT. IS YOUR THIS
BILL WELL MY NAME IS TOM OFTEN
I AM BUT YOU SEE YOUR PUBLIC
SAFETY ADVISED FOR CALIFORNIA'S
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE. AND
HAVE BEEN SERVING IN THAT ROLE
FOR ABOUT EIGHT YEARS OF MY
PRIOR LIFE OR WAS NO THIRTY
YEARS OF CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT. TWENTY YEARS
LINK WITH PD OFFICER THE
CAPTAIN. AND A LITTLE OVER TEN
YEARS OF WHAT SACRAMENTO PD.
CAPTIVE DEPUTY CHIEF AN INTERIM
CHIEF OF POLICE. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX I WAS
APPOINTED AS THE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA DOLE POOL
OPERATIONS. THEY HEAR
CALIFORNIANS SERVED IN THAT
CAPACITY FOR A LITTLE OVER
THREE YEARS- THAT WILL. CAUSE
ME TO- THINK VERY DIFFERENTLY
ABOUT THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM GENERALLY SPEAKING AND
HOST OF COURSE RISEN.
SUPERVISION SPECIFICALLY. BOB
AB TWENTY THREE TWO REPRESENT
OVER TO YEARS OF COLLABORATION
AND COOPERATION REPORT
POLLUTION OF GLOBAL JUSTICE
REFORM ADVOCATE. WELL MARKING.
BUT GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND IMPORTANT
LIKE WHICH DID YOU PRE ORDER
LOOK FORWARD TO BEING AND THE-
ALIKE TO REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
BUG. YEAH DOPPEL POLE AGES
ASSOCIATION. ALL OVER AT BUT
HAVE NOT BEEN AGREED ON EVERY
DETAIL IN OUR DISCUSSIONS
CONTINUE THE WILLINGNESS OF SO
MANY DEDICATED PEOPLE TO ENGAGE
IN THE COST OF THE OFFER THEIR
POINT OF VIEW AND COOPER
RECOMMENDATION SO SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED THE CONSTANT FOLKS OF
THIS LEGISLATION. WE ARE
HONORED TO BE PART OF THE- AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO IS
ROOTED IN THE UNDERSTANDING OF
THE PRINCIPAL OBJECTIVE OF
POSTCARDS REGION SIMPLE
BUSINESS ACCORDINGLY. MANAGING
KURDS EPISODE TAKE THE
SUCCESSFUL REINTEGRATION OF
PEOPLE ON FULL. AB TWENTY THREE
FOUR TWO IS ALSO CONSISTENT
WITH THE SCIENCE AND RESEARCH
THAT SUPPORTS A FINDING THAT
FAILURE ON POOL MOST OFTEN
OCCURS IN THE MEDIA WEEKS AND
MONTHS AFTER CHRISTMAS RELEASED.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUCCESS IS
IMPROVED. WHEN DETERMINATIONS
ABOUT THE LINK THE NATURE
COMMITTED SO PROVISIONAL
REFLECT EACH PERSON'S UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THE EIGHT
OR- AND ONE ALSO OF PLACES
EMPHASIS ON REWARDED POKING
TOPPLE. GOOD ACTORS THIS IN A
CRITICAL LIFE SKILLS RATHER
THAN MERELY PUNISHING THEM
COULD MISTAKES. LOSE PROVIDE A
CERTAIN NUMBER FOR. THANK
QUICKLY. THAT CAN LEAD TO AVOID
IN THE TERM OF CALL. OF AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO A BUT
AND GRAY DESPITE THAT IS TO.
THE DISCOUNT PRODUCTIVE.
ASSEMBLY HI LIKE THE TO
PERSON'S. OF AS FOR IS THE CASE
UNTIL. AND OREGON SUPERVISE
PEOPLE ALL FOR A LONGERTHAN IS
NEEDED TO HELP THEM BE
SUCCESSFUL. AB TWENTY THREE TO
FOUR TO READ WITH THE INTENTION
OF PROVIDING A VITAL ROLE ABOUT
FOUR PEOPLE ON CALL AND THE
AGENTS TO SUPERVISE THEM. SO TO
WORK WELL AND TO HAVE TO
REALISTICALLY BILL IS SHE A
SUCCESSFUL OUTCOME. FINALLY AB
TWENTY THREE BURKE WROTE TWENTY
THREE WHAT FOR TO ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A
CONCURRENT NEED TO ENSURE THE
POLL WILL DISSOLVE HOPEFULLY
STAFF AFFECTED WILL DEPORTED.
IN SUPPORT OF OUR NETWORK OF
SERVICES SO THAT THEY CAN
REALISTICALLY MEET THE
COMPLICATED NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE
IS SUPERVISED GUIDE AND MENTOR.
TO MEET THIS OBLIGATION AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO REQUIRES
THAT THE AGENT TO CALL THE
RATIO WHICH IS CURRENTLY.
FUNDED AT FIFTY THREE TO ONE.
WHY EVEN AT THAT FIGURE. WE
WOULD. FORTY DOOR. THE REALITY
OUR STREETS TODAY IS THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF MONSTERS LIKE
THESE HEARING AIDS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVER SIXTY
PEOPLE. THAT NUMBER OF SALT AS
A TOOL TO HIDE YOUR DOCTOR.
REDUCING PASSED OVER TOLD LUCAS
WAS THAT OTHER THAN THE AND
APPROVED OUT FILMS BY ENABLING
YOU TO THE TIME NEEDED TO
DEVELOP A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
FORCIBLE TRUSTING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH PEOPLE ON CORPORATE FAMILY
BROWN'S IMPORTERS AND OTHERS.
AS WELL AS MORE ACCURATELY
DETAILED LOOK THAT UP BY THE
NEEDS AND EFFECTIVELY
CONNECTING EACH PERSON WITH A
PERSONALIZED. STRATEGY OF
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS. WELL
THIS AND MANY OTHER RE. WE WILL
WHAT ARE WE TO AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY TWO AND ASK FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
ME TO USE A NAME AN
ORGANIZATION A MISTER
MODERATOR. OPEN UP THE LINE
GLAD. LET'S GO TO LINE TWO
EIGHT ONE. TWO EIGHT ONE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS ANTHONY GUARDINO
PROUD CO SPONSOR WITH TOP WINDS
THEIR SAFETY AND JUSTICE. THANK
YOU SIR. LINE THREE FIVE NINE
GO AHEAD. HELLO CANARY YES. HI
THIS IS DAVID MUHAMMAD WITH THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE FOR CALL
JUSTICE REFORM A PROPER SPONSOR
AND WE URGE A YES VOTE. THANK
YOU. LINE TWO NINE ONE BUY A
PLACE. ENTITLEMENTS FIRST
MARKED UP TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
FOUR SIX GLAD. MARCO GEORGIA
MAY HAVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE FOUR ZERO THREE
GO AHEAD. ANNIKA RIGHT ARM OUT
ON THE HAPPEN TO DAMPEN THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
COURT THANK YOU. NINE FOUR ONE
EIGHT FIVE. EACH MIKE A DOCTOR
OFF ON BEHALF WITH THE EASE
FEEL YOUR CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE FOUR ZERO EIGHT GO AHEAD
SH HI SO GREAT STATEWIDE
COORDINATOR BUT IT'S JUST THE
WAY OF FREEDOM COALITION AND
STRONG SUPPORT AND SUPER PROUD
OF THIS IS THE WORKING
COLLECTIVELY MAKE MARKING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. A LINE. THREE
FIVE ZERO. DANIEL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR. TWO NINE FOUR
ONE FOUR BY. I MEAN IT
HEALTHCARE ON BEHALF OF
BERKELEY UNDERGROUND FOLLOWING
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE FOUR ZERO SIX GOING. IN
YOUR BRIEF WHETHER FORMALIZING
ARMSTRONG FOR. NINE FOUR ONE
ZERO CORRECT. I AM QUITE TAYLOR
WITH THE L. WANTED THREE
DEFENDERS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LINE TWO LINES TWO
SEVEN ONE GUY. TWO SEVEN ONE
TWO LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS LESS
FUNDING AS ON THE STATE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR CUT FIFTY AND WE
ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU ESTEBAN. NO
WONDER CHANGE HAVE YOU MAY
CONTINUE. ED NOW WE HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION- WITNESSES- YOU MAY
OPEN UP THE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR. WHAT IMPRESSED. ONE
ZERO FRIENDLY COMMENT ONE ZERO
I THE IS MATT PLEASE WITH THE
HELP ON CORRECTIONAL PEOPLE THE
YES IS FOR THANK MEDICARE. AND
YET THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT THE PPO
REPRESENT NEARLY THIRTY
THOUSAND CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS AND PAROLE AGENTS
ACROSS THE STATE. OKAY I'M HERE
TO EXPRESS THE ASSOCIATION OF
HOLD ELECTED MENDED POSITION
FOR ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
FORTY TWO. IF YOU EIGHT THAT
THE PREVIOUS THE AUTHORS
WILLING AT THE FALLS THAT
FOSTER YOU TO DISCUSS OUR ISSUE
THEN CONTINUE WORKING TOWARD A
RESOLUTION WHICH- I THINK
YOU'RE IS ULTIMATELY A REAL
POSSIBILITY. I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS FOR THE
INCLUSION OF THE PAROLE AGENT
CASELOAD CAPS CONTAINED IN THE
BILL. I THINK THIS IS A
PROVISION THAT'LL CERTAINLY
RESULT IN MORE EFFECTIVE AND
PRODUCTIVE SUPERVISION BY OUR
POLL AGENTS WITH A MORE
MANAGEABLE CASELOAD. WHAT THE
PPO A IS NOT INHERENTLY OPPOSED
TO THE IDEA THIRD OFFENDERS
BEING GRANTED AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR EARLY DISCHARGE WE HAVE
COULD NEVER GET CONCERNS WITH A
BROAD RANGE OF OFFENDERS THAT
WOULD BE INCLUDED. SPECIFICALLY
THE INCLUSION OF GANG MEMBERS
ARE SENATE AND TOTALLY FORGET
TO LIFETIME PAROLE TERMS ARE
PROBLEMATIC. THE GANG MEMBERS
AN ARSONIST A REQUIRED REGISTER
HAVE AN ESTABLISHED HISTORY OF
VIOLENT OR DANGEROUS BEHAVIOR.
AND SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
DISCHARGE AFTER ONLY SIX
MONTHS. AND UNDER CURRENT LAW
LIKE TEMPORALLY THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR DISCARDED VIEW AND
EARLY IN ONLY FIVE YEARS FOR
SECOND DEGREE MURDER AND SEVEN
FOR FIRST DEGREE MURDER. SO
THEY SHIPPED ONLY A HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS AND THE PATIENT TO
ENSURE THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL
NOT CONTINUE VIOLENT BEHAVIOR.
WE'D LIKE TO SEE AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY TWO AMENDED TO
INCLUDE THESE INDIVIDUALS FROM
THE POSSIBILITY OF THE SIX
MONTH DISCHARGE. ADDITIONALLY
THERE SHOULD BE A REQUIREMENT
THAT POLICE SPECIFIC CRIMINAL
GENIC NEED THEIR MATT AND
ADDRESS PRIOR TO THEIR
DISCHARGE. AT THIS BILL DOES
ACTUALLY CONTAIN THIS
REQUIREMENT FOR ALL SUBSEQUENT
REVIEW PERIOD BUT THE CRIMINAL
SACRAMENTO GENIC NEEDS. ARE
ABSENT FROM THE INITIAL REVIEW.
WE ALSO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH THE RESTRICTIVE
DEFINITION OF GOOD BECAUSE- AS
WRITTEN GOOD BECAUSE MOST
PERSUASIVELY SUGGEST THAT
PERSON POSES AN UNACCEPTABLE
RISK FOR COMMITTING A SERIOUS
VIOLENT OFFENCE IF DISCHARGED.
AND THAT REQUIREMENT- THAT THE
RICH BE POSED ONLY FOR SERIOUS
OR VIOLENT OFFENSES IS
INSUFFICIENT TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC SAFETY. SAMPLE APPROACH
WITH. INDICATORS THAT THEY'RE
LIKELY TO COMMIT AN ACT OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR THOUGHT
WOULD NOT SATISFY THAT
REQUIREMENT. WE'D LIKE TO SEE
THAT GOOD BECAUSE BE BROADENED
TO ALLOW FOR CONSIDERATION OF
RISK THAT MIGHT NOT NECESSARILY
BE SERIOUS OR VIOLENT OFFENSES.
BUT STILL DEMONSTRATE THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL POSES A SUBSTANTIAL
RISK OF COMMITTING OTHER
SIGNIFICANT AND SAYS. NTT
PEELING OFF BUT CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL'S REQUIREMENT THAT A
NEW OFFENDER VIOLATION RESULT
IN A CUSTODIAL THINKING ABOUT
LEAST TEN CONSECUTIVE DAYS. FOR
THAT EVENT TO. BE SUFFICIENT TO
JUSTIFY ATTENTION. THERE
SHOULDN'T BE A CUSTODIAL
THANKING REQUIREMENT IN ORDER
TO JUSTIFY THE RETENTION
ESPECIALLY WANTED SIGNIFICANT
TEN DAYS. ONE OR MORE OFFENSES
ARE VIOLATIONS SHOULD BE
SUFFICIENT AS LONG AS THEY
INDICATE THAT THE PERSON ON PRO
PROCEEDS AND REASONABLE RISK OF
DANGER TO THE PUBLIC. AND THIS
IS ESPECIALLY TRUE IN CONTACT
OF THE ENTIRETY OF THIS BILL
WERE THE PRO WILL BE ELIGIBLE
FOR ANOTHER REVIEW IN ONLY SIX
MONTHS. IN LIGHT OF THE ISSUE
THE PPO A MUST TAKE AN OPPOSING
BUT THE MINUTE POSITION BUT WE
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR DISCUSSIONS TO
RESOLVE THE ASSOCIATION
CONCERNS. AND ALTHOUGH OUR
ISSUES WITH THE BILL AND PRINT
ARE SIGNIFICANT I THINK THERE'S
A REAL POTENTIAL PATH FORWARD
FOR OUR MEMBERS- GETTING TO A
PLATE THAT THEY COULD LIVE
WITH. BUT WE CERTAINLY HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
DISCUSSION WITH THE FAMILY
MEMBER AND STAFF. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION NAME. AND
ORGANIZATION MISTER MODERATOR.
NINE FOUR ZERO FIVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HEY I THINK I GOT PUT
ON AROUND HERE THIS IS A MEGA
MALL- WITH THE YOUNG WOMAN
FREEDOM CENTER CROWD C<c.cyan></c>
FUNCTIONS OF THE FILL. IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU MADE A MISTAKE.
YES ANYONE ONE ELSE. WE HAVE A
LINE FOUR ZERO SEVEN GOING.
THANK YOU MY APOLOGIES ALSO FOR
BEING IN THE WRONG QUEUE MY
NAME IS JEFF NOR PROFESSOR OF
ENGLISH AT SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE. WHERE I WORK WITH OUR-
POST INCARCERATED STUDENTS. NOT
RE EMERGING SCHOLARS PROGRAM
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF 23-14
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE LAST
ONE IN LINE AND TWO EIGHT EIGHT
ZERO GO AHEAD. JENNIFER ROLE ON
BEHALF OF THE CHAMBER AND YOU
KNOW COUNTY SHERIFF COMPLETE
BENEFIT ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND I WAS THE LUCKY TO. NOW
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS. COMMENTS
ARE CONCERNED. SEE SEE NONE OF.
IT'S ENCOURAGING THAT YOUR
QUESTION COM GOOD.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARDIO. THANK
YOU I'M I'M CURIOUS- IF- MR MAT
EASILY STILL ON THE LINE. I CAN
ADDRESS A QUESTION TO THE BSA.
AT THANK YOU I'M YOU YOU
MENTIONED- FORMER GANG MEMBERS
BEING- TAKEN OFF OF THIS
POTENTIAL PAROLE- BILL SO I
REPRESENT EAST LA IN A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES THAT SUFFERED FROM
A LOT OF GANG VIOLENCE IN THE
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES AND-
WE'VE SEEN IN MANY WAYS A
RETURN OF SOME OF THESE
INCARCERATED FOLKS- AND MANY
MANY RESIDENTS ARE. THEY THEY
THINK ABOUT THEIR SAFETY QUITE
A BIT AND I'M CURIOUS AS TO
WHAT YOUR- PERSPECTIVE IS WHEN
IT COMES TO. THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO PAROLE OFFICERS IN
AN EFFORT TO ADDRESS-
OPPORTUNITIES AND RESOURCES FOR
THOSE THAT ARE RETURNING BACK
ON THE STREET AND I SAY THAT TO
SAY THAT IN A TIME OF COAL IT.
WE ARE SEEING AN INCREASE OF
20% AT THINK THE GOVERNOR SAID%
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
EVEN 24% OF UNEMPLOYMENT. AND
SO FOR COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
THAT ARE IMPACTED WHAT ARE SOME
OF THE RESOURCES THAT YOU NEED.
SO THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
SAFER WELL WE'RE ALSO TRYING TO
ADDRESS- CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM. AND THE ABILITY FOR
PEOPLE TO GET TO WORK AND SO
ONE OF THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SPOKE ABOUT HAVING TO TRAVEL
LONG DISTANCES. AND SO IF THE
PAROLE OFFICER IS WITHIN A
CERTAIN REGION IN A PAROLE LEE
IS WITHIN A CERTAIN REGION
WHERE THERE IS NO WORK. WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE SUGGESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE ON HOW WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO RESOLVE. SOME
OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES THAT WE
FACE AND THAT'S REALLY ACCESS
TO A JOB. YOU HAVE BUT THAT.
AND QUITE A FEW QUESTION.
ROLLED UP IN THERE I'D I'D
START BY THING AND WITH WHAT
THE- WHAT ARE POLL FOLKS NEED.
MOST IS THAT AND I THINK SOME
OF WHICH IS ACTUALLY CONTAINED
IN THE BILL BOTH CASELOAD CAPS
WILL DEFINITELY ALLOW OUR
PATROL AGENT TO- BETTER
FACILITATE SERVICES BECAUSE
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO BETTER
MANAGE THEIR CASELOADS- RIGHT
NOW THEY'RE JUST SO OVERWHELMED
THERE'S VERY LIMITED TIME
AVAILABLE TO ACTUALLY- TO
ACTUALLY. BEEN TIME DEDICATED
TO AN INDIVIDUAL AND SPEAKING
OUT SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
SECONDLY. I KNOW THAT YOU OVER
THE LOT AT THE DECADE SERVICES
HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY. PRODUCED
AND CUT RIGHT UP IN MANY AREAS
AND SO THE ACT THAT YOU
SERVICES HAS REALLY DWINDLE-
AND SO I THINK ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR ACTUAL COMMUNITY
SERVICES. IN THAT. WOULD BE
TREMENDOUSLY HELPFUL- TO
ACTUALLY GET THE GOALIE THE
HELPFULNESS THAT NEED. AS FAR
AS THAT JOHN BEING AVAILABLE A
PARTICULAR GEOGRAPHIC REGION I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE CURRENTLY
PROPERTIES AVAILABLE NOW IN
ORDER TO BE GRANTED TRAVEL
PASSES FOR PAROLEES SO THAT
THEY CAN TRAVEL OUTSIDETHE
RESTRICTED REGION UP FOR
SOMETHING LIKE A JOB. SECONDLY
IN I DIDN'T REALLY ADDRESS THE
REINTEGRATION CREDITS PORTION
OF THIS BILL BUT IT THAT THAT
THE REINTEGRATION CREDITS
PORTION THE BILL DOES INCLUDE
PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW FOR
ADDITIONAL TRAVEL DISTANCE FOR-
SCHOOL EDUCATION AND THINGS
LIKE THAT SO I THINK THERE ARE
OTHER MECHANISMS. BUT REALLY
FUNDING. FUNDING FOR THOSE
LOCAL SERVICES INCLUDING
EMPLOYMENT SERVICE AND- WOULD
BE A TREMENDOUS HELP. FOR ALL
POLL AGENT AND FOR THE PROCEEDS
THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO SERVE.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT ACTUALLY
HELPS. WHAT WHAT THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL IT IS THAT IF THE IF
OFFICERS DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES CURRENTLY AT HAND AND
THERE IS NO INCREASE IN
BUDGETS. AND PAROLEES HAVE A
HISTORY OF GOOD BEHAVIOR FOR
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
DAYS BEING DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AS WELL AS THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS MAKES
A RECOMMENDATION THAT THEY NO
LONGER NEED TO BE ON PAROLE.
THEN WHY SHOUL THEY BE ON
PAROLE WHY DON'T WE ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THOSE RESOURCES FOR
PAROLE OFFICERS TO ACTUALLY
CONTINUE TO DO THE WORK
NECESSARY FOR THOSE THAT
CONTINUE TO BE ON PAROLE. WELL
ACTUALLY GIVING AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SOMEONE TO START A NEW LIFE
AND TO. BE JUDGED BASED ON
THEIR MOST RECENT BEHAVIOR- NOT
BY THE HAIR THAT COSTA TO BE
INCARCERATED TO BEGIN WITH I
THINK IF WE ARE TO LOOK AT.
WHAT ACTUAL. CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM LOOKS LIKE IT LOOKS LIKE
AGAIN AND I WILL MENTION THIS
BECAUSE OF MY OWN OF A
NONPROFIT THAT WE HAVE IN MY
DISTRICT HOMEBOY INDUSTRIES.
THAT NOTHING STOP SIMPLE IT
LIKE A JOB. AND THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SOMEONE TO EARN A LIVING.
EVEN THROUGH THIS CRISIS RIGHT
NOW ONE OR SEEN SO MUCH
UNEMPLOYMENT. THE ABILITY FOR
SOMEBODY TO. BE TAKEN OFF
PAROLE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
STARTING A LIFE BE RECONNECTED.
WITH THEIR FAMILY TO LIVE IN
DIGNITY. I THINK IT'S A PLACE
THAT WE ALL WANTTO GET TO AND
IT'S GOING TO BE INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT AND CHALLENGING AND
SO I THINK. MR MCCARTY I THINK
THIS BILL IS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND I HOPE THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO COME TO A
CONCLUSION AND I THINK WE ALL
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
PAROLE OFFICERS HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED. THEY NEED
TO DO THEIR JOBS. WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME WE CREATE A SOCIETY
IN WHICH- JUDGES AN INDIVIDUAL
FOR. WHO THEY CURRENTLY ARE NOT
FOR A CRIME THAT THEY COMMITTED
IN THE PAST THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY PAID FOR. AND SO I
THINK- I THINK IT'S A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS. THANK YOU I
WAS SUPER QUICK STATEMENT. THIS
BILL SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT FELON. AND
I THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE
BALANCED AS WE CONSIDER ALL
THESE NEW PROVISIONS THE
VICTIMS INVOLVED ARE GETTING NO
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. WITH
THAT YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS A
BALANCE SAYS WE HEARD FROM. I
VICE CHAIR MISTER LACKEY I
THINK THIS ATTEMPT TO STRIKE
THAT WORK WE'RE COMMITTED TO
KEEP WORKING ON THIS ISSUE- YOU
KNOW THIS IS ABOUT WHAT MAKES
THE MOST SENSE FOR CALIFORNIA
AND- WE ALL WANT THE SAME THING
PEOPLE WHO ARE RELEASED TO
SUCCEED AND NOT RE OFFEND AND
NOT HARM THEIR COMMUNITY THEIR
FAMILIES OR END UP BACK IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM SO. AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARDIO
MENTIONED THAT- HAVING THE
FOCUS ON THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE ON PAROLE TO HAVE THIS THE
FOCUS AND PEOPLE ARE DOING WELL
TO TAKE OFF THAT LIST IS JUST
COMMON SENSE- WE ALSO HAVE IT
HERE WHICH WE NEED TO WORK OUT
THROUGH THE BUDGET
CONSIDERATIONS. IS THE RATIOS
BECAUSE NO MATTER WHAT YOU
THINK PEOPLE WOULD THINK THAT
HAVING FEWER PEOPLE ON YOUR
DOCKET TO SUPERVISE IS A BETTER
THING- SO HAVING THE RATIOS GO
FROM ONE TO FORTY- SUPPOSE FROM
ONE TO FIFTY THREE IS A GOOD
THING. AND THEN LASTLY IS THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON PAROLE. HOW
THE SCARLET LETTER THAT. IT IS
WHAT IT IS IT'S IT IT HURTS
THEIR ABILITY TO. TO CERTAINLY
TRAVEL SEE LOVE ONCE BUT GET A
JOB. AND MOVE ON WITH OUR LIVES
AND IF WE REALLY WANT PEOPLE.
TO SUCCEED WE SHOULD FOCUS ON
WHAT PRO REALLY IS NOT
PUNISHMENT. IT'S HELPING PEOPLE
RE INTEGRATE BACK TO SOCIETY
AND HAVING THE SECOND PRIZE
BILL WE CAN ONLY TALK ABOUT
WHICH I THINK IS TO THEM AND
EVERYBODY COULD EMBRACE WHICH
IS. HATE AND IT WAS ON PAROLE
YOU GO TO COLLEGE FOR A YEAR.
YOU CAN REDUCE YOUR TIME. YOU
GO TO A REHAB OR TREATMENT
WE'RE GONNA REDUCE YOUR TIME ON
PAROLE THE VOLUNTEER WITH
HOMEBOY INDUSTRIES OF
SACRAMENTOFOODBANK DOING
COMMUNITY WORK. YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE YOUR TIME ONE PRO REDUCE I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
COULD ALL EMBRACE AS WELL SO
WITH THAT ASK YOUR RIVAL TODAY
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU AND I
AM ENCOURAGE. WHEN THE
OPPOSITION MR EASILY MENTIONED-
SOME GOOD POINTS IN YOUR BILL
THAT I THINK. THE CPO A- IN
OTHER GROUP ME RAY. SAW IS A
POSITIVE IN A MOVIE FOR THE
OTHER PARTS ABOUT. PROTECTING
YOU KNOW VICTIMS OF CRIME IS
BEING CONSIDERED OF THEM- IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK CCPOA.
AND OTHERS CAN WORK WITH YOU TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS THAT
ALSO AND SO WITH THAT IN A
COMMAND I HOPE. WE NEED A
SECOND. SECRETARY CALDERON ON
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO
MCCARTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER BY JON SO YOU'RE
AYE LACKEY LACKEY NO BARRICADE
CAN. BARRICADE HAND NO DEEP
DEEP NOW KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I
CAN BE YOUR- GARCIA I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I THAT VOTE IS
FORTY THREE THAT THE BILLS ON
COLONIES ONE. IN YEAH NOW YOU
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS TO COME
IN AND FINALIZE THE VOTE YES
AND MEMBER. IN A WAY FOR HIM TO
DEAL WITH IT IS IT GO GET IT
IT'S BEEN A LONG DONE AS PART.
THE CAN SECOND THERE'S BEEN
ADOPTED MR LACKEY WAS AND I
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE WAS DISPENSED WITH THAT
WENT OUT EIGHT ZERO ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB TWENTY THREE FORTY WAS
ON CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT.
WE'RE STILL PENDING FOR MISTER
SANTIAGO. ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
THIRTY FIFTY TWO BY MISS
CARILLO KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I
DOUBT BUT THAT BUILDS UP THIS
NOW SEVEN ZERO. ITEM NUMBER
FIVE I MISS CERVANTES TWENTY
SIX OR SIX WAS ON CONSENT. ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT I'M SORRY I
DON'T NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH EIGHT THAT'S THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL. BARRA CAN
BARRICADE HAND I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WHICH I. THAT MEASURE
PASSES SIX ZERO. ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN THIS MEASURE WAS ALSO ON
CALL AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN CHIU BAUER CAN BARRICADE
HAD I DEEP. DEEP NOT VOTING
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WICKS WICKS
I THAT MEASURE GETS OUT BY TWO
ONE. I DON'T NUMBER EIGHTY
TWENTY TO THIRTY SIX WAS ON
CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN GABRIEL.
BAUER-KAHAN BARRICADE HAD AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WICKS WICKS
I THAT MEASURE GETS OUT EIGHT
ZERO I DON'T NUMBER TEN AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY FOUR WAS ON
CONSENT ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE BY MR
GIPSON. BARRICADE BAUER-KAHAN
HI WICKS WICKS I THAT MEASURE
GETS OUT SEVEN ZERO. ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
TWO WHEN. BAUER-KAHAN BARRICADE
HAD AYE DEEP DEEP I WICKS WICKS
I THAT MEASURE GETS OUT SEVEN
TO ONE. ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY ONE WAS ON
CONSENT I DON'T FOURTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY ONE WITH A CONSENT
ITEM FIFTEEN AB THIRTY FORTY
THREE WAS ON CONSENT. ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FIFTY BY MISS KAMAGRA
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL DEEP.
DEEP NO GARCIA GARCIA I THAT
MEASURE GETS OUT FIVE TO THREE.
I DON'T NUMBER SEVENTEEN BY MR
LACKEY AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
ONE KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER NOT
VOTING SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HI
WICKS WICKS I THAT MEASURE GETS
OUT SEVEN TO ZERO I DON'T
NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY
THIRTY THREE BY MR LACKEY WAS
ON CONSENT ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO THIS
MEASURE. WAS ON CALL. SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I'D THAT BILL GETS
OUTSIDE TO THREE. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
TWO BY MARTUCCI THIS MEASURE
WAS ON CALL BARRICADE HAN
BARRICADE HAD HI KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER HI WICKS WICK SIDE
THAT MEASURE GETS OUT BY TWO TO.
I'M SORRY SIXTY TWO. I KNOW
NUMBER TWENTY ONE EIGHTY THIRTY
THIRTY FIVE PATTERSON.
BARRICADE HAN BARRICADE HAD I
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER HI WICKS
WICKS NOT VOTING THAT MEASURE
GETS OUT SEVEN TO ZERO I DON'T
EVER TO AB THIRTY NINETY NINE
WAS ON CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY THREE THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN BY MISTER RAY IS DEEP.
DEEP SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AYE
WICKS. WICKS I THAT MEASURE
GETS OUT FIVE TWO TWO. WE DO. I
DON'T NUMBER TWENTY FOUR AB.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX. BY MISS
RAY S. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE
WICKS WICKS I THAT MEASURE GETS
OUT EIGHT TWO ZERO. I DON'T
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE WITH ON
CONSENT TWENTY SEVEN FORTY ONE
BY MISS RUBIO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
NINE BY MISTER SANTIAGO WAS ON
CONSENT ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE BY MR STONE THIS MEASURE
WAS ON CALL. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
HI WICKS. WICKS I THAT MEASURE
GETS OUT SIXTY TWO. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE
BY MR STONE. SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO
I WICKS WICKS I THAT MEASURE
GETS OUT SIX TO ONE. WE'RE
GOING TO FINISH WITH THE FUNDS
I WITH OTHER BILLS OKAY. YOU'RE
WELCOME. ONE HUNDRED. ITEM
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT BY MISTER BONTA
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. THAT
MEASURE THAT VOTES THAT
MEASURES FINAL THAT WAS SEVEN
TO ONE. ITEM NUMBER FOUR BY
MISS CARILLO AB THIRTY FIFTY
TWO MR SANTIAGO MISTER SANTIAGO
AYE THAT MEASURES FINAL VOTE
EIGHT TWO ZERO. ITEM NUMBER
FIVE WAS ON CONSENT. ITEM
NUMBER SIX. AB TWENTY RIGHT I
MISSED CERVANTES SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI THAT MEASURE SPINAL
THOUGH IS SEVEN. TWO ZERO. AND
ALL THE REMAINING ITEMS APPEAR
TO BE. SEVEN MISTER SANTIAGO.
TAKE EVERYBODY FORTY PUBLIC
SAFETY HEARING TODAY ALL I KNOW
IS A LONG. BUT WE DID SOME GOOD
WORK THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SEMI
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED.